COMMITTEE WILL COMMENCE SOON WE
HAVE AT LEAST TWO AUTHORS HERE.
IN WAITING AND ENTERS THREE
AUTHORS HERE IN IN WAITING- WE-
NEED TO AT LEAST FIVE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO COME ON DOWN. FOR
PURPOSES OF EXPLANATION OF FOR
THOSE OF YOU WATCHING AND
LISTENING EITHER HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OR AT OTHER LOCATIONS-
TODAY IS THE LAST ISSUE. OF
REGULARLY SCHEDULED HEARING OF
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
HEARINGS GOING ON
SIMULTANEOUSLY IN BOTH IN THE
SENATE AS WELL AS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND SO THE US
SENATORS- WILL BE GONE
PERIODICALLY INCLUDING MYSELF
UP PRESENTING BILLS IN IN
PARTICULAR IN THE ASSEMBLY. SO
BY WAY OF EXPLANATION THAT'S
WHY- SOME OF YOU MAY SEE SOME
SEATS THAT ARE VACATED BUT- AT
SOME POINT TODAY WE ARE GOING
TO- LIVE CALLS ON ALL THE BILLS
SO EVERY MEMBER HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. VOTE ALL RIGHT
SO I UNDERSTAND THE SERGEANTS
ARE ROUNDING UP MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WILL COMMENCE
HOLDING OUR BREATH.
ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY SEES ME
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE IN SIXTY SECONDS.
ALL
RIGHT US SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN- IT- AT
THE VERY LEAST AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERS AND
HERE'S SOCIAL DISSING FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE CENTERS
MAY NO SIR JUST A SMALL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC DESERVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMIN
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC'S TWO
HEARING ROOMS EXTENSIVE TESTING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
SPEND A DAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT SPIN TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSAR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILS STRUCTURES OF HELL
TELECOM SERVICE SERVICE WORKS
PLEASE REFER THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATE
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THE MAYBE A SHORT
WAITING PERIOD ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTE YOU BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR LISTENING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORTHAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
JUST IN A NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. I'M
INSTITUTING TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL
PERMITTED IN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. WHICH IS TO ME TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
THE US FOUR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE. THERE MAY BE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS IN TERMS OF
WITNESSES BUT IT WILL BE FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE ALL OF
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO. THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. EACH SIDE WILL
HAVE A MAXIMUM OF TEN MINUTES
FOR ME TO WITNESSES WHO AGAIN.
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION THE
BILLS- LET'S. WE'RE GOING. TO-
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE STILL WAITING
TO MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED AS A SUB COMMITTEE WE
WILL- TAKE ROLE HERE A
MOMENTARILY. ALL RIGHT- THERE'S
SOME HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FOR
TODAY SENATOR WIENER IS NOT
HERE TODAY SO WE WELCOME
SENATOR SKINNER TO THE
COMMITTEE IN HIS ABSENCE I WANT
TO NOTE THAT PHYLUM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM HAS
BEEN PULLED AND WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY IN ADDITION FILE
I'M NUMBER TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHT SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL HAS BEEN
PULLED AND WE NOT WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY. ALSO PHYLUM NUMBER
NINETEEN FOUR SIX EIGHT AB FOUR
SIX EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND WILL.
BE HEARD TODAY- WE'RE GOING TO
GO OUT OF FILE OUR ORDER- TO
ACCOMMODATE- THE- CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE ALL FACING RIGHT NOW
WITH BUDGET COMMITTEES AS WELL
AS OTHER COMMITTEES MEETING
SIMULTANEOUSLY SO WE'RE GONNA
START WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY THREE. EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING-
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO FILE I'M
NUMBER ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS NEXT WILL TAKE UP
VIOLENCE NUMBER TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY SEVEN A. B. SEVEN FIVE
ONE AND THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN. AFTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER IRWIN'S
BILLS WILL THEN GO BACK TO FILE
ORDER INTAKE UP- STR NUMBER
SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD. WE
HAVE FORTY TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA NINE OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS PHYLUM
NUMBER FIVE AB ONE ZERO NINE
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER AROUND
BELOW FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. PHYLUM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN EIGHTY ONE TWO
TO ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA
WITH AMENDMENTS FLAT FILE AND
NUMBER THIRTY ONE A. B. EIGHT
TO NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN
FILE IN NUMBER THIRTY TWO A. B.
FOUR SEVEN ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WITH
AMENDMENTS. PHYLUM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR A. B. ONE FOUR FOUR
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
FILE I'M NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
EIGHTY THREE ONE SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON PHYLUM
NUMBER THIRTY NINE EIGHTY ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT READ THIS AND
FINALLY FILING NUMBER FORTY TWO
AB ONE TWO FOUR THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BLANCA RUBIO-
WE CAN TAKE A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. STRIKE THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TAKE A VOTE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE ALL RIGHT- LET'S
WE HAVE. WE'RE STILL MISSING
SOME MEMBERS ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE TO THE FIRST ITEM- BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AS I
MENTIONED JUST ONE MOMENT AGO.
THAT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER. FORTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER TANK
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR FOR ACCOMMODATING ME
BECAUSE WE HAVE A BUDGET
COMMITTEE COMING UP VERY VERY
SOON. EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A TIME FRAME FOR
THERMOFORM FOOD PACKAGING
MANUFACTURERS TO USE. MINIMUM
RECYCLED CONTENT INTO PLASTIC
CONTAINERS STARTING WITH 10%
THE 202420% 202730% BY TWENTY
THIRTY. THERMA FORMS ARE THE
PLASTIC CONTAINERS THAT WILL
YOU SEE IN GROCERY STORES AND
STRAWBERRIES- SALADS OR LEAFY
GREENS OR TAKE OUT CONTAINERS.
RIGHT NOW ALL APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED POUNDS OF THERMOFORM
WASTE ARE DISCARDED EACH YEAR
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT MANY PEOPLE
THINK THAT THEY GET RECYCLED
MOST OFTEN ARE MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT THEY END UP IN LANDFILL
LAST YEAR I WAS VERY PROUD TO
WORK. WITH MY COLLEAGUE THE
MEMBER- WENT ON A. B. SEVEN
NINETY THREE TO ESTABLISH A-
HISTORIC MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT FOR PAP PLASTIC
BEVERAGE BOTTLES. THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER THAT- AND IT
TURNED IT OVER TO HER TO DO A
PRESENTATION THEN WE HAVE TO
KEEP WITNESSES BOB. DAVID DUKE
WHO IS THE CEO OF OUR PLANET
EARTH AND SCOTT WILKERSON WITH.
BOND DO FRESH AMERICANS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND MY JOINT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. AV FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT IS ANOTHER BIG STEP FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
CREATING A CIRCULAR ECONOMY. IT
PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO PULL OUT
A HIGHLY RECYCLABLE MATERIAL
FROM THE WASTE STREAM. AND
THROUGH MINIMUM CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS CREATES A MARKET
FOR THE MATERIAL FURTHER THE
BILL INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF
RECYCLED P. ET WHICH IS SEEING
AN INCREASE IN DEMAND FROM
SEVERAL INDUSTRIES. WHILE THERE
REMAIN A FEW OUTSTANDING ITEMS
TO ADDRESS WE ARE CONTINUING
THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND THAT INCLUDES
THE STRAWBERRY COMMISSION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
NUMBER ONE AS I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE TO WIN THIS IS ON THE
PHONE MISTER BOB DAVID DOC. IN
SCOTT WILKERSON- ARE ARE THE
VIEW ON THE PHONE. HI THIS IS
BOB WTF I'M ON ALL RIGHT THE
DOUBLE DIP GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR- BERGEN MEMBERS- YOU KNOW
ON BOB W. THE CO FOUNDER AND
THE CEO OF THE COMPANY OUR
PLANET EARTH. AND WE ARE PROUD
TO BE THE SPONSOR OF AB FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT- THANKS TO THE
COMBINATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE CAPITAL OUR PLANET
EARTH. THE WORLD'S FIRST
COMPLETELY VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED MANUFACTURER OF
RECYCLED PET PACKAGING AND
OTHER PRODUCTS SUCH AS CHECKING
COPS. THAT ARE DERIVED FROM
POST CONSUMER PET CONTAINERS
BOTH BOTTLES AND THERMAL FORMS
AN OFFICE BUILDING THAT IS
LOCATED IN VERNON CALIFORNIA.
AT THE PRESENT TIME THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION POUNDS OF POSTING
SOME WITH SOME FORM OF
ENTERTAINERS DISCARDED IN
CALIFORNIA. EVERY YEAR AND
GROWING. EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
WILL CREATE MARKETS. AND
BECAUSE OF CONCERN CONFORM
CONTAIN. WHICH WILL DIVERT THEM
FROM LANDFILLS. THE BILL WILL
COVER DON'T WANT CONTAINERS
USED FOR FOOD AND BEVERAGES
INCLUDING ITEMS SUCH AS PRODUCE
VERY CLAM SHELL CONTAINERS
SANDWICHING FINGERS OVER TOP
SPOT. OWN TAKEOUT CONTAINERS
AND DRINKING CUPS. PURCHASERS
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF
CERTAIN RESIN TYPES IN RECYCLED
FORM THAT ARE COMPLIANT WITH
THE FDA'S REQUIREMENTS FOR FOOD
GRADE APPLICATIONS. IN ORDER TO
USE RECYCLED MATERIALS AND
DIRECT FOOD CONTACT
APPLICATIONS THEY MUST BE SAFE.
WHICH IS TYPICALLY DETERMINED
BY OBTAINING A LETTER OF NON
OBJECTION SO KNOWN AS THE NOW.
ON A- FROM THE US FDA. 84%
EIGHT ONE TO THE FOR FOOD
STAPLE CONSUMER PRICE GLASS
SUCH PEOPLE T. R. POLY PRO.
THEY'RE BY ENCOURAGING
RECYCLERS THAT DO NOT HAVETHE
FDA'S DELANO DESIGNATION TO
OBTAIN IT BECAUSE BRAND DEMAND
WILL EXIST JUSTIFY THE
INVESTMENT REQUIRED TO COLLECT
AND RECYCLE THE VARIOUS WEAPON
TYPES. TO A FOOD GRADE QUALITY.
THERE WAS AN ANTI PROVISION IN
THIS BILL. WITH ONE OF THE
PRIMARY REASONS FOR ITS
INCLUSION IS TO FOSTER
COLLECTION AND ALLOW
MANUFACTURERS TO FACILITATE THE
PURCHASE OF RECYCLED FROM A
FORM. IN ORDER TO MEET THE
RECYCLED CONTENT TARGETS. IN
ADDITION THE PACKAGING
MANUFACTURERS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SET BAIL
QUALITY STANDARDS NEEDED TO
MEET SPECIFICATIONS PRECLUDES
STATES FROM UP ONE CONTAINERS.
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
EXCLUDE THERMAL FORMS FROM THE
COMING OPERATE THIS BILL ALSO
ADDRESS CONTAMINATION ISSUES
ABOUT SEE YOUR DETAILS. AND
ENCOURAGE THE COLLECTION OF
FORMAL FORMS THAT WILL
SEPARATELY BE BAILED. IN
SUMMARY WE BELIEVE IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AVAILABILITY
OF CLOSENESS TO MY RESIDENCE.
WILL COME ABOUT MAYBE FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT. I DON'T RECYCLE
BECAUSE REQUIREMENT THAT SPUR
DEMAND AND WE DON'T HIRE RATES
A COLLECTION AND RECYCLING.
THESE VALUABLE MATERIALS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING LANDFILL.
THE BILL ALSO CREATE JOBS THANK
YOU SIR- ONE OF MANY PRE SHADER
INPUT- ALL RIGHT. BEFORE WE
TURN TO A MISTER WILKERSON
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MANAGING COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
PURPOSES THAT WAS REQUIRED FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM AMBERG. HERE AMBERG HERE
BORJAS. PORGES PRIZE. COPY AT
ALL. THE RUSSELL. DID I FAIL
HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE
HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED LEHRER
HERE SKINNER EASTERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI WAY CASKEY HERE YOU
HAVE SIX PRESENT EVER FORM ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUORUM ALL RIGHT MISTER WILSON
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. AND THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO ZERO SENIOR
AMERICAN. GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AMERICAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
SCOTT WILKERSON I'M THE CHIEF
PROCUREMENT OFFICER AT
BONDUELLE FRESH AMERICAS. YOU
MAY KNOW IT IS READY PAC FOODS
AND RB STORE BRAND HERE IN
UNITED STATES WE ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST PRODUCERS OF FRESH
READY TO EAT SALADS AND WEKEEP
HEARING FROM THE COUNTRY. AND
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE SOME OF THE
LARGEST RETAILERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
BASIN. SALINAS AND IRWINDALE
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA CAN TO
SET THE PACE FOR THE REST OF
THE NATION AND THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL PRODUCER
AND EXPORTER. AND THERMOFORM
PACKAGING SUCH AS CLAM SHELLS
HAS REVOLUTIONIZED THE ABILITY
CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO TRANSPORT.
WHO'S TO CONSUMERS ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY. THIS TYPE OF PACKAGING
HELPS PROTECT THE PRODUCE FROM
DAMAGE CONTAMINATION AND
REDUCES FOOD WASTE. PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING MADE WITH POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED CONTENT ARE
INCREASINGLY A GLOBAL PRIORITY
FOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
CONSUMER BRANDS AND RETAILERS.
ARE COMPLETE THE JACKET AT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AT 1100% OF
OUR PACKAGING DESIGNED TO BE
RECYCLABLE OR REUSABLE. HE ALSO
MADE FIRM COMMITMENTS FOR THE
USE OF RECYCLED P. E. T.
THERMAL FOR. RECENTLY MOST THAT
RECYCLE MATERIAL IT'S FROM
PLASTIC BOTTLES WHICH
INCREASINGLY IN HIGH DEMAND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE WHICH
SETS MINIMUM CONTENT ON PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. HOWEVER
WE'RE FACED WITH THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY COLLECTING
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS. ADD
ENOUGH QUANTITY TO SUPPORT
ADEQUATE SUPPLY. WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT BECAUSE THEY WILL HELP
ENCOURAGE COLLECTION OF THIS
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL. AND ENABLE
US TO MEET OUR SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS TO THE RECYCLED CONTENT
MANDATE. WE ALSO NEED THIS BILL
TO CREATE A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WE'VE MADE INVESTMENTS IN
RECYCLABLE PRODUCT THAT HAS
RECYCLED CONTENT. AND THIS BILL
WILL PROPEL THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN FOR MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE PACKAGING. SOME
MANUFACTURERS OPPOSE THIS BILL-BECAUSE OF THE REGARDING THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER WILKERSON-
ALL RIGHT- LET'S TURN NOW LET
ME REFER THE I'M JUST GOING TO
REVIEW THE BIDDING HERE. SO
WE'RE GONNA ALLOW EACH SIDE
EQUAL TIME- AND I REALIZE THAT.
I'M JUST ALLOWED UP THE SUPPORT
SIDE GO WELL OVER FOUR MINUTES
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS EACH
SIDE'S GETTING EQUAL TIME. OFF
FOR THE MOST PART DIVIDED
BETWEEN TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH ALL RIGHT. SO NOW
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY
CONCERNING AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
SEEING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
SAYING NOT EVERYONE TWELVE
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT
MOTOR IF YOU CHEW THEM UP.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE TO
NINETY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHN THE CLAMP APPLICANT EASTON
DIEGO AND SUPPORTED AS A. B.
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINETEEN NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
VERSION NICOLE CRAINE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL THE
NATIONAL EXPRESS POUR ON BEHALF
OF THE CLEAN THESE LOBBYING
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TO FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT YES
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF PUBLIC STREET ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSORS WHO
ALREADY SPOKE THE SIX EIGHT IN
THE PORT. THANK YOU. TWENTY
THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE TO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RECORD TRACK OF VICE
CHAIR AT THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY GET INTO THE
OPTICS APART THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE TWO FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER. FROM THE
HELP OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
HELPFUL AND NATIONAL PICTURE
ACTION COUNSEL WITH THE COURT
AT THE MANIFESTATION WE HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE FORMULAIC
WHICH BUT APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JARED HARPER CREEK IF
YOU THOUGHT COME BACK ONLY
SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU. LINE
TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
TERRY MEMBER SOPHIA SO EACH ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN THE OFFICE
OF MAYOR BREED IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT INTERVIEW. ALL
RIGHT WELL LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED PRIMARY OPPOSITION
MISTER TIM. SE SPEC. MR SAY
STICK ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. YES
THE MEDICARE CONSULTING WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
THERE ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER KERR MEMBERS
SYMPATHETIC WITH AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT THEY STILL SEEK TO
ACCOMPLISH HOWEVER WE DO
BELIEVE SOME AMENDMENTS ARE
NECESSARY AROUND A FEW AREAS
ONE BEING THE FEASIBILITY OF
USING RECYCLED MATERIALS AND
FOOD CONTACT PACKAGING- THE
AVAILABLE. SUPPLY OF RIGHT
RECYCLED RESIN THAT'S CURRENTLY
IN THE MARKET PLACE. TO MEET
THE MANDATE PROPOSED IN THE
BILL. CAN PROVIDE MANY FACTORS
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE
FLEXIBILITY. GIVEN CURRENT
MARKET CONDITIONS RECLAMATION
CAPACITY AND U. S. FDA
REQUIREMENTS FOR USING RECYCLED
RATHER THAN IN FOOD PACKAGING.
HI IT'S ARGUED THAT THE
AVAILABLE LIVE RECYCLED RESIN
THAT I'M LIKELY TO BE
SUFFICIENT. TO ACHIEVE THE
MANDATE OF PERCENTAGES. WE HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR AND HALF OF THOSE.
FROM LANGUAGE YOUR GRASSY
CONCERN. THOSE CHANGES WOULD
PROVIDE MANUFACTURERS WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE TIME
ALLOW FOR POWER CYCLE YEAH HE
RESPECTED CONTENT PERCENTAGES.
FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY
FEE OR BOTH BASED ON CERTAIN
CRITERIA INCLUDING THE
AVAILABLE TO BUY RECYCLED
RESIN. AND REQUIRE POWER CYCLE
THE BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH.
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS HOW MANY REVENUE
GENERATED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. PENALTIES ARE
BEING SPENT. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT TO WORK WITH
THE. AUTHORS IN THE SPA. AT THE
BUILDING FOR OUR HOPE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO DISCUSSION ENOUGH
TO CRAFT THE FEASIBLE- AND
GLOBAL FILL. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OP TO TODAY. THANK YOU
SIR AND I NOTE THAT- THERE IS
ENOUGH WITNESS ENOUGH. MISS
GAIL DELAHUNT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I AM GAIL DEL HANA AND
I REPRESENT WHAT YOUR GROWERS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS GROW
FRESH PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA
ARIZONA COLORADO AND NEW MEXICO.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
RECYCLING THE PLASTIC
CONTAINERS WE USE THAT PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF OUR PRODUCE.
HOWEVER WE HAVE THREE MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL. AND
ARE POSING LESS AMENDED AT THE
TIME. WE HAVE TO JERK BUT WE
HAVE SHARED THESE CONCERNS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND CO AUTHOR AND
PROVIDED THEM WITH THEM JUST
SUGGESTED AND THEN THAT. FIRST
THE BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE
DISCRETION FOR CAL RECYCLE TO
EXTEND THE COMPLIANCE RATE
GREAT. IF THE RECYCLED CONTENT
IN THERMOFORM PACKAGING IS NOT
AVAILABLE IN SUFFICIENT
QUANTITIES. AT REASONABLE
PRICES. THE SUBJECTING FARMERS
TO ENFORCEMENT YOUR NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. EVERY OTHER AGENCY
HAS HAD AND STILL HAVE HOT
BUTTON. ALLOW FOR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. SECOND THE BILL
EXEMPTS MANUFACTURERS FROM THE
COURT RIGHT ACT THAT DOES NOT
GUARANTEE THAT ONCE AN ENTITY
IS FORMED AND GATHERS UP ALL
THE THERMOFORM CLAM SHELLS WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET THAT APPLIED
THAT. WE ARE CONCERNED THE
SUPPLY WILL GET SOLD OFF THE
TEXT FILE. WHICH IN TURN DRIVES
UP OUR SUPPLY. TODAY THE POST
CONSUMER P. E. T. BOTTLES ARE
UP THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. BUT
THERE IS ALREADY A MAJOR
DISRUPTION IN THE MARKET. THIRD
THE BILLS EXEMPTION FOR THE
FARMER IN THE FIELD DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR THE FARMERS WHO
HARVEST THEIR CROP. TO THE
COOLING FACILITY AND THEN
PACKAGES IT FOR SHIPPING. THE
BILL THREE FARMERS WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS FOR SIMPLY USING
THERMOFORMED CONTAINERS TO SELL
THEIR PRODUCE. WHILE FRMERS
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
PURCHASING RECYCLED CONTAINERS
THEY ARE IN THE FOOD GROWING
BUSINESS NOT THE PLASTIC
CONTAINER MANUFACTURING THE- WE
ASK THAT YOU CALL THE COMMITTEE
THROWING THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT SEEING NONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE SAYING NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LISTER THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB. FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TOM SHE HE
ON BEHALF OF TECHNO PLEX
MANUFACTURER FOOD TRAYS
COMMONLY USED IN SUPERMARKETS
AND WHAT YOUR DEPARTMENTS. IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED AND
WE WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH MR SHOSTAK OF THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR. ONE
THREE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBER THIS IS LAUREN
AGUILAR ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN IN THE PACKAGING AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
FLEXIBLE PACKAGING ASSOCIATION
ALSO AND IN A CALL TO LET THE
MEDITATION. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR MEMBERS CODY BAWLED ME
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHTY
WELL LET'S COME BACK TO THE
FLOOR- MEMBERS WHO WISH TO ASK
QUESTIONS- CENTER WHITE HOUSE
YES YEAH MISTER TURNER I'M
LOOKING FOR CLARIFICATION ON
THE DEFINITION. OF THE COMPACT
COMMINGLING RATE THEORY RECENT
AMENDMENTS AFTER OR BEFORE-
AFTER HE Q. TALK ABOUT THE FORM
OF THE PLASTIC MATERIAL VERSUS
THE TYPE OF THE TYPE IS THE
RESIN IS THE IS THE SAME. AS
THE ONE BUT WE'RE SEPARATING
RATHER THAN WE'RE SEPARATING
BOTH OF THEM AND I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THAT IF THE RESIN IS THE SAME
AT AN END I GUESS THE REASON
FOR. RT ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING I
WAS ON THAT- MISTER- DAVID TO
CANCER THAT. DAVID ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. I AM I'M HERE YES-
THE REASON WHY WE'RE LOOKING TO
HAVE THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CONTAINER SEPARATED OUT BECAUSE
WITH THE B. SEVEN NINETY THREE
BOTTLES ARE REALLY GOING TO END
UP BEING RECYCLED AND MR TO GO
BACK INTO BOTTLES. AND GIVE
THEM A FORMS ARE NOT SEGREGATED
OUT- THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE SAME
SITUATION THAT WE'VE HAD UP TO
THIS POINT WHICH IS WHERE THEY
ARE NOT COLLECTED- AND MOST
AMANDA BEING SENT TO LANDFILL
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PLATFORM CONTAINERS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR RECYCLING TO GO
BACK INTO. NORMAL FORMS ARE
ALSO SOME- PROPERTIES THERMAL
FORMS- THE MOLECULAR WEIGHT
THROUGH THE IVIES ARE LOWER
THAN BOTTLES AND THEY REALLY
ARE COMPATIBLE TO BE RECYCLED
WITH BOTTLES EITHER MOST OF THE
BOTTLE RECYCLERS WILL SPEAK
AROUND THE STATE. THEY HAVE NO.
THERMAL FORMS IN THE DALES
WHATSOEVER. MISTER CHAIR BUT
THAT WE GET INTO THAT'S THE
TYPE BIKE I GET THAT THE PET
ONE AND THE PET FOR A GUY I SEE
THAT SEPARATION I'D LIKE. ALL
MANUFACTURERS TO BE PEP ONE THE
QUESTION IS THAT. 80% OF. THE
BOTTLES THAT ARE RECYCLED NEVER
GET TO CURBSIDE THEY GO
DIRECTLY TO RECYCLING CENTER
THERE CO MINGLED WITH OTHER
PLASTICS SO THAT. YOU'RE ONLY
DEALING WITH 12% OF THE WORLD
AND- I KNOW A SENATOR THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE. OF THE
RECYCLING TO RECYCLERS VERSUS
CURBSIDE SO THAT WORLD WOULD
SHRINK THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
THAT ABANDONED THEIR THEIR
BOTTLES SO IT'S ONLY A SMALL
PERCENTAGE PROBABLY SINGLE
DIGITS. AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT BUT IF
WE FOCUS ON THE TYPE. IT WILL
GET MORE BANG BANG OUT OF THAT
BECAUSE- THEY'LL BE THE BOTTLES
WILL BE GOING TO THE RECYCLERS
AND THE OTHER PLASTICS. WE GET
IN BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S JUST A LOOP ON THE-
THE- THE- CLAM SHELLS RIDER IN
THE INCOME COLLECTING THESE
THINGS- IT'S A CONCERN. THAT
THE IN THE BIG IN THE LONG RUN
HI I DON'T WANT US TO CREATE A
BUNCH OF WORK FOR PEOPLE. WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT. IT IS MORE
IMPORANT FOR US TO GET TO THE-
THE MANUFACTURING OF THE-
MATERIAL SO THAT IT'S IN TAP
ONE AND IT'S ALL IN THAT IN
THAT CLOSE LOOP- I URGE THE
AUTHORS TO. TO WORK ON THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A BUT- WE MAY
BE SHIFTING SOME COSTS HERE FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE AT THE- WASTE
TREATMENT PLANT PLANTS- FOR A
VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF RECOVERY
WHERE WE COULD TACKLE MINGLE
RATE. IF IT'S IF I'M SEPARATING
CONTAMINATION FROM MAYONNAISE
FROM CONTAMINATION WITH. ONE
IMPACT TWO AND THREE SO THAT'S
THAT'S A DIFFERENT BED I THINK
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THERE
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
THE SUBJECT JUST- LET SEVERAL
ACCOUNTS KENO- THROUGH THE
CHAIR THAT THE BEVERAGE BOTTLE
MANUFACTURERS ACTUALLY HAVE
OTHER SIMILAR ISSUES AND SO WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS IT. SPECIALLY WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SEVEN NINETY
THREE WE DEFINITELY WANT TO
ECONOMY FOR THE BEVERAGE
BOTTLES AS WELL. PARTY THANK
YOU SEVERAL CASKEY- SEEING NO
OTHER MICROPHONES RAISED- IS
THERE A MOTION. WELL LET'S
LET'S DO THIS WE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM ACTUALLY-
LOOK USER IS OUR MOTION.
SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
SOMEONE MEMBER IRWIN OR TANG
OKAY I JUST WANT TO SAY WE ARE
CONTINUING TO AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED WORK WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
MENTIONED WAS- THE DEFINITION
OF PRODUCER AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT SWITCHING THAT TO- THE
THERMOFORM ABOUT PURCHASER SO.
THESE ARE WE WANT THIS BILL TO
WORK AND WE WANT THIS TO BE
FIXED REALLY SOMETHING THAT IS-
THAT IS- TREND SETTING IN THE
WORLD THIS IS OUR BILL LAST
YEAR WAS SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE TO GET THIS RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ANYTHING FURTHER NOTHING
NOTHING FURTHER ALL RIGHT THEN
SHE COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
TO HANG WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR DO TO US SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI. I'M
BURGER I BOARDED. OR JUST NO
I'LL BE IT'LL. THE RUSSELL THE
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ BY
HERZBERG JONES LAYERED LAYERED
I. SKINNER STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI WAY CASKEY I THAT- FIVE TO
ONE SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL A YES CENTER LAYERED. THE
CENTER LAYER THAT OUR COMMUNITY
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MADAME CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AMBER HI-
BURKE I PURCHASE BOARD IF I CAN
BE AT ALL. KELLY IT'LL HI DID I
FEEL THE REST SO I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI HURTS BURG JONES
LAYERED LAYERED ICE STERN I'M
SORRY SKINNER. STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI WAY CASKEY I. YOU
HAVE SEVENTY ZERO MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT ON
A CALL OF ONE OTHER
HOUSEKEEPING ITEM- LATE
BREAKING. ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
THREE FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD- IS GOING TO BE PUT OVER-
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND SOME TIME
HERE THE NEXT LITTLE WHILE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS DISCUSSING A B.
THIRTY FIVE. AND A. B. FIVE-
EIGHT SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL- IN TANDEM ALL RIGHT SO
THAT THAT WILL BE HEARD TODAY-
THE NEXT- I SEE SOME REMEMBER
WICKS IS HERE READY TO PRESENT
A B. ONE FOUR ZERO FIVE SEVEN
MEMBER WICKS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR TIME ON THIS BILL
WITH MANY CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING WITH THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF CODE NINETEEN IT IS
IMPORTANT THERE ARE STRONG
PROTECTIONS TO PREVENT WELL
INTENTIONED BUT MISINFORM
CONSUMERS FROM FALLING INTO
WORSE FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
THERE IS CURRENTLY LITTLE TO NO
REGULATION DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY DOES NOT REFLECT THE
CHANGING PRACTICES OF THIS
INDUSTRY WHICH IS MATED FORSMAN
MORE DIFFICULT. THIS LACK OF
REGULATION HAS LED TO INCREASED
PREDATORY BEHAVIOR WITHIN THE
DEBT SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY.
MOREOVER THE LACK OF REGULATION
OF THIS GROWING INDUSTRY HAS
RESULTED IN CONFUSED AND
FRUSTRATED CUSTOMER SPENDING
ADDITIONAL MONEY. AND TIME
TRYING TO DEAL WITH
UNANTICIPATED DEBT. COLLECTIONS
LAWSUITS OF THEIR ENROLLED
DEBTS. AB FORTINO FIVE WILL
MODERNIZE CURRENT LAW TO BETTER
REFLECT INDUSTRY'S PRACTICES
AND IMPROVE REGULATIONS OF THAT
CEMENT COMPANIES BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING THINGS. BE CLEAR THAT
ALL THAT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES
OPERATING CALIFORNIA ARE
COVERED BY CALIFORNIA LAW.
HEARD IT DOES SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES FOM ENGAGING IN
DECEPTIVE AND MISLEADING
PRACTICES REQUIRE CRITIC
CRITICAL DISCLOSURES THAT WOULD
ALLOW CONSUMERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
FINANCIAL OPTIONS. AND LASTLY
PROVIDE CONSUMERS INJURED BY
BAD ACTORS WITH REMEDIES. THERE
IS A NEED FOR LEGISLATIVE
ACTION TO PROVIDE GUARDRAILS
OVER THE DEBT SETTLEMENT
INDUSTRY BEFORE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CONSUMERS WHO HAVE
ALREADY OR ARE CURRENTLY
SUFFERING THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO SUPPLEMENT THE WORK I. D. F.
P. I WILL PROVIDING CONSUMERS
WITH ROBUST PROTECTIONS THAT
THEY URGENTLY NEED NOW. THE
SPONSORS I'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OPPOSITION
RECENT MOMENTUM ADDRESS A
NUMBER OF OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
AND HAVE MOVED OPPOSITION
INCLUDING A FCC. A NARROW IT A
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND C. B. R. I. TO
NEUTRAL. THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND
SUPPORTED BY NUMBER OF LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATIONS AND CONSUMER
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE
DESIREE WHEN ORDERS FROM THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
THANK YOU. SHARE MY CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. ANDREW
WENT WHITE JACKET BECAUSE LOOK
AT THE CLINIC I DO THINK YOU
NEED A LOT BETTER WE ALSO HAVE
HEPATITIS BUT TODAY CORRECT
IAGO MASCULINITY. BUT YEAH THAT.
OVER THE LAST YEARS PACKAGING
WRECKING AT THE HAPPENING WE
COLLECTION. OF CREDIT CARDS
ALARMINGLY. INCREASE BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEE WHERE WILL THEY GET.
IT RIGHT THAT THEY STARTED OFF.
A LITTLE BIT OF EXCELLENT PLAN.
FOR MANY YEARS BUT NOT
MEDICALLY NOW I COULD YOU LOOK.
AT IT ON THE RISE. IF THERE
HAVE BENEFITED FOR MARKET
COMPETING WITH THAT THEY'VE GOT.
UNDER HOW. THE MARKET QUICKLY
CAN STOP OW. EIGHTY FOUR FIVE
THE PAIR DECLAN PRACTICES ACT
IS NOT A BAN ON THAT SOMEONE AT.
THE TOP OF MY CUT OFF ACCESS
TO. SERVICES TO ANYONE
INCLUDING INCOME COMMUNITIES.
HOW NO MATTER THAT DATA COMING
OUT OF CALIFORNIA I PROVED BY
THE FACT THAT THAT BULLET THERE
TODAY ARE STILL OFFERED IN THE
FORTY THREE STATES THAT
REGULATE THAT PUBLIC PRACTICE
AT. THE BILL DID NOT CUT OFF.
LIKE THAT YET YEAH I THE BODY
COMPANIES. HAVE BEEN REVERSED
YEAH YEAH I. WILL BE ABLE TO
ENFORCE THE ACT ITSELF. EIGHTY
FORTUNE FIVE DEAD GIVE YOU. A
REAL. I THANK ALL THE COMPANIES
TO CLEARLY OUT WHY THAT IMPLANT
AT AND GET CONTROL OF THE COURT
OFF PERIOD THAT THE MATURE%
IRREPARABLE DNA TO CRY. NEVER
HAD A LITTLE ADVERTISING. AND
THE SECOND THAT CONTRACT.
EFFECT WELCOME TO PROCEED WITH
THAT GOVERNMENT REPEATED IT
AGAIN IF YOU VILLAGE HAS COME
BACK TO GET THERE I MARK. IT
OCCURRED MARKETPLACE COME- THE
PLAY FIELD BY ALL THAT THE
COMPANY CALIFORNIA THE FIVE
THINK THAT IT WILL. RESULT IN
MORE OFTEN FOR CONSUMERS. AND
THE WIDER PICTURE EIGHTY
FORTUNE FIVE WORK TO RESTORE
THE BALANCE IN THE HEALTH OF
THE INDUSTRY. I GET IT THE
REPORT RESPONSIBLY MASTERED
THAT REQUIRE YOU TO DO SO AND
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR CREDITORS
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH A
CUSTOMER. AND EXPECTED WHEN YOU
WILL HEAR FROM A REAL CONSUMER
GRAPHS MADE THE CONNECTICUT
JEWISH ACTUALLY BUT THAT IS AN
AREA THAT I HAVE SEEN WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT DOCUMENT YOU KEEP
IN MIND THAT YOUR HEART AT THE
MOMENT HAS AFFECTED HER. BUT
THAT I. RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
EYES OUT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MR THE ELBOW AS- HI. GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON TURNED HERE MEMBERS
OF THE CAN MY NAME IS GREG OR
NOT GONNA HIGH POLITICAL YEARS
OLD I'M A SINGLE WOMAN WAS NO
DEPENDENTS I LIVE IN INGLEWOOD
AND NINE FINANCIAL AND MENTAL
WELLBEING HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED
BY THE DEFENSE BELIEVES THAT
SETTLEMENT COMPANY INTO THE
COMPANY'S LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
AND THE IMPACT OF THEIR
SERVICES MY CREDIT HAVE TO WASH
THEM RIGHT THAT HAS NOT BEEN
RESOLVED AND I'M ALSO BEING
SUED BY ONE OF MY CREDITORS I'D
MAKE TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR I
RELY ON OVERTIME BUT AFTER MY I
WOULD REALLY DO BECAUSE THE
COLD AIR. WITH THIS KIND OF
STARTLED EVEN MORE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET MY ONLINE OKAY CLICK THAT
OPTION FOR HER. YOU KNOW THEY
MADE HIM A TARGET I'VE BEEN.
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THE AND- I
FIND OUT THAT THEY- I THOUGHT
THE MONTHLY PAYMENT FOR GO TO.
PAYING DOWN MY DEBT AND AFTER
THE WORK WITH MY CREDITORS TO
CREATE A MORE AFFORDABLE-
PAYMENT PLAN FOR ME- I WAS
RELUCTANT. WHEN THE AGENT OF
THE COMPANY SAID THAT I NEEDED
TO ENROLL IN. ONE MORE DAY YOU
NEED THE PEN BALCONY MINIMUM
DEBT REQUIREMENT. I TRUSTED
THEM BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN. LIKE
PAPER ON MY PART I THOUGHT IT
WAS STRANGE FOR THE AGENT TO
CHANGE MY INCOME IN ORDER TO
SHOW. THAT I COULD PAY TWO
FIFTY A MONTH BUT I TRUST THAT
THEY BECAUSE IT IS A LARGE
COMPANY AND I THOUGHT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE PROFESSIONAL. I
HAD TO WORK SIX DAYS A WEEK IN
ORDER TO PAY THE CONTRACT AT
TWO FIFTY ONE- PER MONTH. I WAS
WILLING TO DO IT BECAUSE I WANT
TO MAKE IT UNDER CONTROL. I
NEVER WANTED TO SHORT CHANGE MY
CREDITORS ARE TRYING TO GET A
DEAL FOR MY DAD. IT WAS ONLY
ABOUT TRYING TO BE RESPONSIBLE
WITH MONEY MAKING MY GOOD
CREDIT. BECAUSE IT'S LESS
EXPENSIVE TO MOVE THE CARNEGIE
IS OUT AND SO I NEEDED TO HAVE
MY CREDIT IN GOOD STANDING.
ADMIRING I'VE- LEARNED WHAT.
KIND OF MAN ACTUALLY IT'S SEVEN
MONTHS AFTER I SIGNED UP WHEN I
WAS PERSONALLY SERVED WITH A
LOCKED IN THAT HOME. FORGET
THAT I THOUGHT I WAS PAYING OFF
I'M ANGRY I'M FRUSTRATED AND
AFRAID I THOUGHT I WAS DOING
THE RIGHT THING NOW MY CREATIVE
DINING. AT ME IF I WANTED TO
STOP PAYING MY CAREER. I WOULD
HAVE DONE THAT RIGHT SHALL
CONTINUE TO FIFTY A MONTH THAT
I WAS STAYING. MENTALLY THE
BURDEN OF BAD WEATHER HEAVY BUT
THEY SO YOU'LL HAVE TAKEN MY
STRESS TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL I
FOUND FOR NOW. FROM INSIDE THE
LINGERING. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
YOU COULD IT UP. THAT I ASSUME
IS THE BILL. YES CHANGE IT
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCHALL
RIGHT- LET'S TURN TO OTHER ANY
WITNESS IN THE GAS IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. ONE FOUR ZERO FIVE
SEEING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NOT A ROOM ONE TWELVE
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY ONE FOUR ZERO FIVE.
WOULD BE GRATEFUL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF BABY FORTINO FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOURTEEN OH FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NINE
THREE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
HIS BELIEF AIRING THE PUBLIC
LIFE AND THEY'RE IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY FORTINO FIVE. THANK YOU
NINE THREE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN CLIFF
BURGO FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTINO FIVE
THANK YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIELLE
CANDOR HI THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGARET GLASHEEN ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN FAIR CREDIT
COUNCIL WOULD BE TRUNDLED FRANK
THANK YOU AFTER WORKING OUT. OF
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A VERY- VOTER IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THE SORRY LET'S NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE ONE WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE LISTED-
MISTER MICHAEL THURMAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO
THE MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
GERMAN AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
LOCATED IN PASADENA CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
FORTINO FIVE AND LET THE MAN
THAT. I REPRESENT LAW FIRM THAT
OFFERED THAT SETTLEMENT
SOLUTIONS TO CONSUMERS ADVISING
MY CLIENTS ON COMPLIANCE ISSUES
AND DEFENDING THEM IN STATE AND
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. BESIDES
HELPING CONSUMERS RESOLVE THEIR
DAD'S LAW FIRMS CAN ASSIST
CONSUMERS BY DEFENDING
COLLECTION LAWSUITS BROUGHT
AGAINST THEM BY CREDITORS AND
DEBT COLLECTORS. PROSECUTING
VIOLATIONS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS COMMITTED BY CREDITORS AND
COLLECTORS AND INVITING
CONSUMERS ABOUT BANKRUPTCY AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO THAT
SENTIMENT AS WELL AS FILING
BANKRUPTCY ACTION. WHEN
APPROPRIATE. I'M CONCERNED THAT
THE ATTORNEY EXEMPTION BRADY
FORTINO FIVE IS NO EXCEPTION AT
ALL. THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
STATES THAT IF ANY ATTORNEY
CHARGES ANYTHING FOR HIS OR HER
SERVICES. DATA TURNING NOT
EXEMPT FROM THE STATUTE.
WITHOUT A REAL ATTORNEY
EXEMPTION EIGHTY FORTINO FIVE
WILL EITHER THE TRUTH WARRIORS
FROM REPRESENTING CONSUMERS WHO
NEED THEIR PROTECTION. FOR
THEIR LAWYERS WHO ARE UNAWARE
OF THE D. FORTINO FIVE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
KERRIER. BUT THEY'RE SIMPLY.
TRYING TO HELP THEIR CLIENTS
OUT. IN MIND THAT LAWYER ALWAYS
REGULAR BY THE- ALREADY WELL
LOOK TO DO SHERRY PROBABLY TO
DO DO TO THEIR CLIENTS. AFTER
JERRY NOW INSURANCE ALL READ BY
THE FEDERAL WE BOUGHT AND
DRIZZLE WILL BE RIGHT BY THE
AGE. MANSION THANK YOU KNOW.
FOR THIS EIGHTY YOU KNOW FIVE
EXEMPT ANY CALIFORNIA WHO
PROVIDES LEGAL ADVICE. AND YOUR
LEGAL DEFENSE. TO CONSUMERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR. ALL
RIGHT- AS A MEMBER WE EXCEL ASK
A LITTLE LATER ON TO RESPOND TO
MR THURMAN'S- CONCERNS- OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION PRINCIPAL OPPOSITION
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
KNOWN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S
TURN THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE
IN A POSITION TO- A. B. ONE
FOUR ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
FOURTEEN OH FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHICH AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTINO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
NINE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES I AM- MY
NAME IS JAMIE AND I'M A MEMBER
OF ANY PARTY TENNIS UNION AND I
WANT TO SUPPORT. I WANT TO
SUPPORT. EIGHT NINE ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE ON A
B. ONE FOUR ZERO FIVE MODERATE
OR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE FOUR ZERO FIVE. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER- I SEE NO
MICROPHONES RAISED- THEIR
MOTION. CENTER WHITE HOUSE HE
MOVES THE BILL- SELLING MEMBER
WICKS- YOU CARE TO CLOSE IN AND
RESPOND TO MR THURMAN'S ISSUE
SURE- APPRECIATE THE CONCERN WE
ARE WORKING WITH A VARIETY OF
LEGAL AID CLINICS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO ARE DEALING FIRST
HAND WITH THESE ISSUES AND
HELPING. CONSUMERS WHO HAVE
BEEN VICTIMS OF PREDATORY
BEHAVIOR AND WE STAND WITH THEM
TO TRY TO CREATE BETTER LEGAL
REMEDIES SO THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE. MORE RECOURSE
AND ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND THEY HAVE- RATES
AS THEY GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- I DON'T KNOW IF
DESIREE ALSO FROM THE EAST
BETWEEN LAWSON WANTS TO ADD
ANYTHING IN ADDITION TO THAT.
THIS WIN ORACLE. I DON'T THINK
WE. THE DETAILS ARE CONCERNED.
THE BIG CONCERN WAS WITH
RESPECT TO EXEMPTING A LAWYER'S.
EXACTLY YEAH I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE BILL ACTUALLY
STATE THAT YOUR LOVER BUT NOT
HARD FOR SERVICE IS REGULATED
BY THE TITLE IT IS NOT A BLIND.
THE ABOUT EACH CHARGE FOR A
SERVICE AT ANZAC INCORRECT
FEEDBACK BETWEEN BENCHES ARE
VERY VERY VERY NEARLY. IT
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT IN
YOUR CHART IN YOUR- APPLE ID
THURSDAY YOU ARE NOT EXEMPT
FROM THE CELL. BUT IT TURNS
YOUR PROVIDING GOT SETTLED IN
AND I HAD TO LEARN TO OTHER
LEGAL REPRESENTATION AS
COLLECTION MARKET I THINK YOU
CAN. LOCK IT. AREN'T THAT. SO I
THINK THAT. TAKE A CLOSER
READING BECAUSE THE GREAT GREEN
THEIR OWN NARROW EXTENSION HERE
AND PROBABLY APPLIED THE TRAIN
WILL NOT QUALIFY UNDER THEIR
BELT ALREADY THANK YOU- SOMEONE
THERE WEEKS K. AT JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR
WHAT KOWSKI MEN CHIEF COUNSEL
YOU CALL ROLL THIS IS A B.
FORTINO FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER
WHERE X. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE VIEW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. HI AMBER
I BURGESS- JUST NOT VOTING. AT
ALL. I DID I SOLD. THE REST SO
I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG. JONES LAYERED. LAYERED
ICE SKINNER. STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI Y. CASKEY  YOU HAVE SIX TO
ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN- SO REMEMBER IRWIN AND
THEN WE WILL GO BACK TO- STR
SAID SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SO REMEMBER WHEN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
AT SEVEN FIVE ONE WHICH IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES THIS BILL
WILL PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED
COUNTY RECORDERS TO ACCEPT
ELECTRONIC REQUESTS TO ACCESS
CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS WHICH
ARE BIRTH. MARRIAGE AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES CURRENTLY TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES USE REMOTE
PROOFING TO PROCESS THESE
REQUESTS INCLUDING MY- HOME
COUNTY OF INTER A IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAINTAIN
SAFE. CONVENIENT ACCESS TO
CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS WHICH
ARE OFTEN REQUIRED TO OBTAIN
BENEFITS SERVICES OR INSURANCE
TO ENSURE THE SECURITY OF THESE
RECORDS EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE
UPDATES THE STATUE TO ADHERE TO
THE GOLD STANDARD OF
INFORMATION SECURITY. WHICH IS
THE NEW STANDARD IT IS
ROUTINELY CITED AND USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
NUMEROUS OTHER DEPARTMENTS. BY
REVISING THE CODE TO REFLECT
NEW STANDARDS EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
ONE FOLLOWS THE PRACTICE OF CDT
AND AS WELL PROVIDES IMPORTANT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LAW
ALLOWING FOR ALTERNATIVE USES
OF. ALTERNATIVE TYPES OF
VERIFICATION EVIDENCE TO BE
USED INCREASING ACCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT HAVE A
GOVERNMENT ISSUED IDOR UTILITY
ACCOUNT. WHAT THE PROGRAM
SUNSETTING THIS YEAR WE NEED TO
TAKE LEGISLATIVE ACTION NOW OR
ELSE CALIFORNIANS WILL LOSE THE
ABILITY TO REQUEST A VITAL
RECORDS ONLINE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY WE HAVE A BROAD
CLASS CLOSER REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. AND ON THE LINE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE
HAVE GREG CIRCLE. THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF VITAL CHECK- MR
UGH GROSS LAW CENTER. MR GROWS
CLOSER ARE YOU AVAILABLE. WELL
I'M SORRY I HOPE WE'RE NOT USE
THE FOLKS IN THE GALLERY BUT I
APPRECIATE GO AHEAD CLOSURES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR IT'S FIRST
TIME PRESENTING IN PERSON
MYSELF IN OVER A YEAR- RUGGLES
BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION- THE
RECORDERS ROLE WHEN IT COMES TO
VITAL RECORDS IS TO PROVIDE. A
SAFE AND SECURE- MAINTENANCE OF
THEM ALL WE MEAN TO MAKING SURE
THAT FOLKS CAN STILL GET ACCESS
TO ME LITERALLY KEEP THE BANK
NO PAPER LOCKED IN A SAFE AND
OUR OFFICE- FOR YEARS NOW YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OF HAD TWO WAYS OF
REQUESTING THESE RECORDS WANTED
TO COME IN PERSON AND SIGN A
STATEMENT SAYING THEY'RE
AUTHORIZED TO GET IT THE OTHERS
TO GET A NOTARIZED STATEMENT
AND MAIL IT TO US. FOR MANY
YEARS IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES HAS
BEEN A THIRD OPTION WHICH IS
ONLINE- A DEDICATION PROCESS
FOR IDENTITY THIS LEGISLATURE
TWENTY SIXTEEN IS OUR ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT AUTHOR IS THAT USING
CALIFORNIA AND AS THE SUMMER
WOMAN STATED- WE'VE HAD TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES USING IT BEFORE
BECAUSE IT INCLUDED COUNTIES
LIKE LA AND VENTURA AND SINCE
CODEINCLUDES COUNTIES LIKE
MONTEREY. AS WELL AS SANTA
CLARA AND OTHERS SO IF SEVEN
FIFTEEN ONE DOES NOT PASS TODAY
THIS OPTION IS ELIMINATED FOR
ALL COUNTIES WE BELIEVE IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING SAFE
AND SECURE ACCESS THESE RECORDS
THIS LAW SHOULD CONTINUE AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
THANK THE SOMEONE FOR CHAMPION
ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MR
CIRCLE MR CIRCLE AVAILABLE IN
PERSON- NO MR CIRCLE YOU ON THE
PHONE. YES SIR I'M ON THE PHONE
AND- I'M A- IF ANY TECH.
QUESTIONS SHOULD ARISE DURING
THE HEARING. ALL RIGHT LET ME
JUST BE CLEAR- THE SALOON- WHEN
YOU YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT
SAYS POST. YES ALL RIGHT TO-
OKAY LET'S LET'S TURN TO OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORTING THE GALLERY ROOM
ONE TWELVE LET'S TURN THE PHONE
LINES THOSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FIVE ONE TWO TWO UP.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD GO AHEAD
IN- ALLOW THOSE WISHING SAYS
FIND SUPPORT TO VOICE THEIR
VIEW THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION THE POSITION. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE ONE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THAT ONE THEN ZERO
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER.
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HEARD ON BEHALF OF
THEIR COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE LOOK
AT MY NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOHN MEMBERS LEE AND THE POCKET
ON BEHALF OF TECH THAT IS PART
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND IT WILL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT HERE WE HAVE ONE MORE
THAT IS QUEUED UP. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORTED. EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE ONE. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE UP THREE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS MONOCLONAL BEHALF TAXI
AND THE PORT. THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO WHEN WE CANNOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN Q. HERE ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES PRIMARY WINS AND
OPPOSITION BECCA PRIMER MILDER
AND CATALINA SANCHEZ- MISTER
KRAMER MILDER ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
I AM ALL RIGHT FLORIDA
SECRETARY MATTER- RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF A CELL YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN
SEVEN FIVE ONE THREE YEAR
MORATORIUM ON BIOMETRICS IS NOT
ENOUGH TO SEASIDE CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY AND NEW WAYS TO
REMOTELY REQUEST I DON'T RECORD
OUTLINED IN THE BILL ARE BOTH
UNNECESSARY AND- INEFFICIENT.
FIRST BASE AROUND TECHNOLOGY
OFTEN FAIL TO IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUAL CORRECTLY
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND WOMEN I'VE MET ITSELF HAD
THAT AND USING SUCH AN ERROR
PRONE PROCEDURE WOULD ONLY
DECREASE GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY
OTHER BIOMETRICS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
PROBLEMS I FACE SURVEILLANCE
WELL THE REMAINDER HAVE NOT
BEEN EVALUATED TO DETERMINE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THEY PRODUCE
BIASED RESULTS. COMPANIES LIKE
CLEARVIEW A I SECRETLY BUILD
FACE RECOGNITION DATABASE AND
PROVIDE THEM TO BUSINESSES
POLICE AND ICE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT USE TAXPAYER MONEY
TO BOLSTER THIS EXPLOITATIVE
AND BUY IT WRITTEN WITH THEM
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE WOULD
REPRESENT THE FIRST TIME
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE THINGS IN
THE USE OF THIS ECLIPSE BY
ERROR PRONE AND RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY BIOMETRIC
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY. BUT
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE IN PREVIOUSLY
RESTRICTED THE USE OF
BIOMETRICS. USUALLY IF YOU NEED
REST. GIVEN THE REST AND LACK
OF A BY BOTH. ACCOUNTING AND
YOU BY MY I AMERICA. THE BILL
SHOULD BE IN THE AMENDED TO BAN
VIOLENT IN THE CARD. RATHER
THAN OFFER VERY AND YEAR.
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ONE IS OFTEN
NOT. CHANGE PEOPLE GET THIRTY
COPY OF ID RECORDS. FOR YOUR
HEALTH NAME HAS BEEN TO
REMOTELY REQUEST VITAL RECORDS
ONLINE BY SUBMITTING IT THE END
OF THE NOTARIZED AFFIDAVIT OF
THEIR IDENTITY. WITH MOBILE
NOTARIES ESPECIALLY DIFFERENT
NOTARIZATION SYSTEM MEANS A
SAFE. AND VIABLE OPTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS. I APPRECIATE THAT
MANY OF THE MEN AND SHE THAT.
COLLECTED AND VERIFIED I.
CANNOT BE USED SHARE MR OR- THE
OTHER ENTRY FEES FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE. AN IMPORTANT AMENDMENT
ABOUT HOWEVER WITHOUT A BAN ON
BIOMETRICS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
REMAIN IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN FIVE ONE ALREADY THANK
YOU. MISS CATALINA SANCHEZ. YES
ED SHEERAN MEMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN AND KAISER
REPRESENTING THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION I'M
THINKING OPPOSITION GET BLANK
CHECK BEFORE YOU TODAY FOR THE
STATEWIDE GOVERNMENTAL USE THAT
ANY KIND OF BIOMETRIC
IDENTIFICATION TECHNOLOGY. WE
APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL FACIAL
RECOGNITION AND OTHER BIOMETRIC
FROM THE BILL BUT DO NOT AGREE
THAT APPROVAL SHOULD BE
AUTOMATIC AT THE END OF THE
THREE YEARS. EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
ONE REPRESENTS A MASSIVE
EXPANSION OF GOVERNMENT USE THE
BIOMETRIC THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
IN THE FACE OF THE MEXICAN
OPPOSITION TO GOVERNMENT YOU
WITH BANDS AND SEVERAL CITIES
ALREADY I'M A TOTAL ABSENCE OF
GUARDRAIL AND INFLATION ITSELF.
IF THE INTENT OF THE BILL TO
MAKE GOVERNMENT WORK BETTER
ERROR PRONE SOFTWARE IT'S
UNLIKELY TO HAVE THE EFFECT
WOULD BE N. I FE AUTHENTICATION
PROCESS GUIDELINES CITED IN THE
BILL. NOTHING THAT THEY CAN
CONCERN ABOUT EXASPERATING AND
I GUESS THE REST WITH THE USE
OF BIOMETRIC EQUIPMENT ALONG
RACE AND GENDER LINE.
PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN LASTLY THE
DANGER THE WIDESPREAD USE OF
BIOMETRIC BY GOVERNMENTS HAVE
BEEN DEMONSTRATED NO MY
TELEPHONE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AVAILED THEMSELVES OF
THE USE OF FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY. FROM CLEAR VIEW A.
I. WITHOUT THE AUTHORIZATION OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. A REVIEW
OF CLEARVIEW AI. WANT WORKMAN-
THAT USE THAT TECHNOLOGY ABOUT
A HUNDRED FORTY ONE ONE AGENCY
THAT USED THAT ABOUT FORTY OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY
SPOKESPERSON DIRECTLY. DENIED
USE OF THE SOFTWARE TO THE
PRESS. IF OF. SOFTWARE OFF THE
WILL LIE LEAD TO YOU. BY OTHER
TO. INCLUDING ONE. WITH OR
WITHOUT OTHER THEY- EIGHTY
SEVEN ONE IF DIALING ON
COLLATERAL YOU BUT EXPERIENCE
SHOWS THAT VIOLENCE WILL NOT
PREVENT BUT YOU. IT WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO THAT END BALANCE
IN MOTION WITHOUT A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
SPECIFIC BIOMETRIC TECHNOLOGIES
ARE BEING AUTHORIZED. AND
WITHOUT CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR
THEIR CORPORATE YOUTH IN PLACE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M GONNA
TURN THE GAVEL OVER HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT TO SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI BUT BEFORE I DO- AND
I HAVE TO DEPART TO PRESENT
ANOTHER BILL. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS MEASURE- YOU SPEND
A LOT OF TIME. AND- IT IT A LOT
OF PASSION TO THIS ISSUE- WE
HAVE CONCERNS I HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
BIOMETRIC DATA AND ALSO- WITH
RESPECT TO FACIAL RECOGNITION
TECHNOLOGY IN THE US THERE'S A
THREE YEAR MORATORIUM AND AT
THE END OF THREE YEARS WE'RE
VERY HOPEFUL THAT THAT THAT
TECHNOLOGY WILL EVOLVE TO THE
POINT IN TIME WHEN IT IS SUCH
THAT THAT WE CAN- HAVE VENDORS
DISSEMINATES COUNTY RECORDERS
SO- HAVING SAID THAT- I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO DEPART THE WHITE
HOUSE GIVEN TURNED GAVEL OVER
TO YOU THANK YOU SIR. I HAVE
THAT ON THE PILE. GALLERIA
THIRTY MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY
DID OPPOSE. AB SEVEN FIVE ONE.
I'D SEEN NONE OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE- CONTROL ROOM.
NONINTEREST BEARING ON THING
THEN RIGHT MODERATOR LET'S TURN
TO THE PHONES CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OPPOSING AB. SEVEN FIVE
ONE- IF YOU ARE IN A POSITION
OF EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE. ONE
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO MY
NUMBER THREE THREE SIX. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIELLE CANDOR
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
THREE FORTY SIX. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG CALLING FROM OPEN
PRIVACY WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION- WE SUPPORT
THE STATEMENT. OF BOTH THE
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS I WOULD SAY
THAT HOPE IS. NOT ENOUGH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER THREE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YUP I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF SENATOR HENRY STERN AND I
AGREE WITH THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO REMOVE
AUTOMATIC APPROVAL OF
BIOMETRICS IN THREE YEARS.
THANK YOU WITH THE LOCAL I.
NUMBER THREE TWENTY FIVE. HELLO
THIS IS ANASTASI OF ANNAPOLIS
MEMBER OF RACE AND EQUITY AND
ALL PLANNING AND SAN FRANCISCO
TENANTS UNION OPPOSED THE THREE
TWENTY FIVE I MEAN YOU THINK
THAT WAS MY LINE NUMBER. FIVE
THREE TWO FIVE. THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SEVEN. I DON'T THINK SO I THINK
IT'S- YES THIS IS ME. TAKING
THE NAME HERE- CONSTRUCTION-
CENTER SKINNER I WANT TO- MY
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FIVE
ONE. CHRISTIAN AND GREEN WHICH
IS AN ISSUE THAT. A HE- SEVEN
FIVE ONE I'M SORRY I CAN'T AND
I'M GREAT I'M JUST TOO OLD.
HELLO. THANK YOU NECKS NEXT
RECORD. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN CUBA SHELTER OKAY WE
SEEN WAS CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING IT BACK TO-
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS- A SEVEN
MEMBER- WHEN I WILL- ASK IT IT
DID THE BILL REMOVES SUNSET
DATE THAT WAS SET IN A. B. AT
TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX AND AS WE
HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THERE IS A CONCERN
OF. THE AFTER THE MORATORIUM
BIOMETRICS AND FACIAL
RECOGNITION- TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS IN. DEVELOPED BEING USED IN.
A BODY HURT THE YEAR WITH THE
OPPOSITION- THE. WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING ON THAT EFFORT VERSUS
CONTINUING- EXTENDING THE
SUNSET AND HAVING THE
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPED. OKAY SO
THE PERSISTENT THIS REMOVES THE
SUNSET TO ALLOW COUNTY
RECORDERS TO CONTINUE TO. GIVE
VITAL RECORDS OF REMOTELY SO
THAT'S THE ONE SENSE SUNSET WE
ALIGNED IT BECAUSE OF THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY SOME OF
THE PRIVACY ORGANIZATIONS WE
DID SAY WE WOULD DO A THREE
YEAR MORATORIUM ON ISSUES LIKE
USING BIOMETRICS OR FACIAL
RECOGNITION VALVE MAKE REALLY
CLEAR. THE MAIN THING WE WANT
IS TO FOLLOW NEW STANDARDS AND
WHEN ONE OF THE CALLERS SAID WE
SANCTIONED THE USE OF FACIAL
RECOGNITION WHICH IN THIS
STANDARD SAY IS NOT READY FOR
PRIME TIME I THINK THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT DISINGENUOUS BECAUSE
NO STANDARDS ARE THE GOLD
STANDARD AND WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS PROTECT OUR VERY MOST
PRIVATE INFORMATION SO. COUNTY
RECORDERS DO NOT USE FACIAL
RECOGNITION OR BIOMETRICS
REMOTELY THEY USE- THEY VERIFY
IDENTITIES THROUGH KNOWLEDGE
BASED SYSTEMS WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS A FEW YEARS DOWN THE ROAD IF
THESE- TECHNOLOGY. SHOW PROMISE
IT WOULD BE A WAY TO GUARANTEE
YOUR PRIVACY SO THAT SOMEBODY
ELSE IS NOT ABLE TO GET YOUR
RECORDS SO WE WANTED TO LEAVE
THAT OPEN AND SEE HOW THE
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPED. JUST AS
MR FIT MR TING'S BILL- DID ALSO
AND IT IS ALSO A LITTLE
DISINGENUOUS TO SAY GOVERNMENT
IS NOT ALREADY USING OF A
BIOMETRIC DATA BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE A NOTARIZATION OF YOUR YOU
KNOW A MORTGAGE OR TITLE. YOU
ARE USING BIOMETRICS THOSE ARE
FINGERPRINTS SO AGAIN COUNTY
RECORDERS HAVE NO EXPECTATION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO USE THIS
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IF A FEW YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD IT TURNS OUT THAT
THESE KNOWLEDGE BASED SYSTEMS
START TO BE HACKED WELL THEN
YOU WOULD HAVE TO DEVELOP. A
WHOLE SYSTEM AT A BANK OF-
PERHAPS SOME PRINTS AND COMPARE
TO THEM NONE OF THAT IS
AVAILABLE CURRENTLY BUT BECAUSE
I AM THE- EURO I I'M VERY
INVOLVED WITH- CYBER SECURITY I
KNOW THAT THE MOST CRUCIAL
THING IS KEEPING YOUR PRIVATE
INFORMATION PRIVATE WHICH IS.
WHY I FIND THE ARGUMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION SO DISINGENUOUS.
OKAY I MEAN BECAUSE THESE ARE
SOME GROUPS THAT WE- RELY ON TO
PROVIDE US WITH YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE DEVELOPING OUR-
THEORIES ON- THE WHAT IS A DATA
SECURITY WHAT IS A PRIVACY
BREACH AND TRY AGAIN THEY'VE-
THEY'VE RAISED THE POINT THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST. STATUTE THAT
EXPLICITLY WILL ALLOW FOR- THE
USE OF FACIAL SERVING OTHERS
THREE YEARS CENTERS NO THERE IS
NO LANGUAGE ON THAT ALL THE
LANGUAGE SAYS IS THAT WE ARE
ABIDING BY THE HIGHEST SECURITY
STANDARDS WHICH IS NO STANDARDS
AND THEN. SPECIFICALLY THEY
WERE CONCERNED THAT BECAUSE-
THIS IS A VERY VERY LONG GUIDE
MENTIONS OF BIOMETRIC DATA OR
FACIAL RECOGNITION THAT THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S WOULD BE
USING IT THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY NOT
USING IT. IT'S JUST LISTED IN
THE NEST STANDARDS. OKAY.
SENATORS OFFICES HERE MAX THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND- I TOO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW YOU DO
A LOT OF WORK IN THIS SPACE- AS
I HAVE IN THE PAST AS WELL AND
SO I WANT I KNOW YOU'VE DONE
YOUR DUE DILIGENCE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND ENSURING THAT-
NO OTHER MUNICIPAL AGENCY OR
THIRD PARTY OR STATE AGENCY-
FOR ANY PURPOSES SHALL
DISTRIBUTE OR SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WHICH I THINK IS
ALREADY- REALLY A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD HERE- IN ADDITION TO
THE NEST ELECTRONIC
AUTHENTICATION- GUIDELINES
OFFER THE MULTI LAYERED-
IDENTITY PROOFING WHICH I THINK
IS WONDERFUL. NOW I'M JUST
BUILDING OFF OF WHAT SENATOR-
WE'LL GET WITH THE CHAIR HAD
MENTIONED ABOUT THE BIOMETRICS
BECAUSE I DO SHARE THAT CONCERN
AS WELL BIOMETRICS IN ADDITION
TO FINGERPRINTS COULD BE YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW I YOUR IRIS-
YOUR FACE OF COURSE RECOGNITION
WHICH I KNOW IS IT'S GOTTEN A
LOT OF HEAT BACK HOME AND IN MY
DISTRICT SO CAN YOU. CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE AND
WHAT TYPES OF BIOMETRICS COULD
BE USED AFTER- IF THIS SHOULD
BE IN A MOVE AFTER THREE YEARS
I MEAN I IT WOULD BE AGAIN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS NOWHERE NEAR
READY FOR REPORTERS TO USE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE VENDOR THAT USES
IT THEY ARE NOT PLANNING ON
USING IT IT'S JUST MENTIONED IN
THIS BUT IF YOU WANT AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW YOUR YOUR- BIOMETRICS
PROTECT YOUR DATA YOUR IPHONE
READS YOUR FACE AND- THAT THAT
IS A ONE WAY THAT- IT IS MUCH
SAFER THAN- USING YOUR PASSPORT
A PASSWORD TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOBODY HAS ACCESS TO YOUR
PHONE. BUT AGAIN THERE IS NO
TECHNOLOGICAL WAY THAT
REPORTERS WOULD DO THIS THEY
WOULD HAVE TO PURCHASE A
DATABASE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COLLECT FOR THE DATABASE AND
THEN THEY WOULD HAVE TO COMPARE
TO THE DATABASE THE ONLY PLACE
THAT I HAVE REALLY SEEN THIS
HAPPENED IS AT THE AIRPORT.
WITH CLEAR SO THE REASON THE
WEIGHT CLEAR WORKS THAT- YOU.
YOU WOULD. WILLINGLY PUT YOUR
FACE INTO A DATABASE AND YOU
ARE COMPARED EVERY TIME YOU GO
TO THE THREE SECURITY TO THAT
DATABASE. BUT THERE IS NO
INTENTION HERE OF DOING THAT AT
ALL. WE ONLY TOOK THE AMENDMENT
BECAUSE OF THE PRIVACY GROUPS
THAT WERE CONCERNED THAT IN THE
NEXT STANDARDS WHICH ARE AGAIN
THE STANDARDS USED BY. STATES
AND TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES AND
DRIVE YOU KNOW YOU COME FROM A
TECHNOLOGY BACKGROUND. THE
HIGHEST LEVEL STANDARDS AND
THEY THAT THOSE STANDARDS GO
THROUGH- EVERY POSSIBLE THING
THAT HAS TO DO WITH CYBER
SECURITY SO. THEY MENTION
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND AGAIN IN
THERE THEY SAID THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH IDENTIFYING PEOPLE
OF COLOR. THEY DON'T RECOMMEND
USING IT BUT THEY DO
CONTINUALLY UPDATE THAT- THOSE
STANDARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE THE VERY HIGHEST LEVEL.
YEAH AND I HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
WILL- PROBABLY LAY OFF OF THE
BILL TODAY JUST CONSIDERING THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS RELATED AND ALTHOUGH
IT'S JUST AN ESTIMATE. YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
RECORDERS WILL BE UTILIZING
THAT. IN THE IMMEDIATE IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THEY COULD.
ANSWER THAT- WHERE I SORT OF
HAVE THE ISSUE THERE BUT I
WOULD LOVE TO CHAT WITH YOU
MORE ABOUT THAT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS. CENTRE COVER YEAH
YOUR RECORD HIGHS WILL DEVELOP.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKES UP THERE
IS A MOTION BY CENTRE COVER
EURO- THIS SET A SIMILAR IRVINE
AS I JUST SAID YOU'RE
UNDERSTAND. I DON'T KNOW WHY WE
HAVE THAT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO USE
IT BUT- IT'S M. S. I HAVE SENT
MY CONCERNS ALSO SO YOU MAY
CLOSE. YEAH I JUST- I WANT TO
REITERATE WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE COUNTY RECORDERS
ARE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
CONVENIENCE TO AND SAFE ACCESS
FOR RESIDENTS TO- CERTIFIED
VITAL RECORDS SO WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. HI
MOTION IS THIRTY PASSES AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION
CHIEF COUNSEL OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL YEAH THIS IS A B.
SEVEN FIFTY ONE- BY A FAMILY
MEMBER- WHEN WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR CAPITO THE MOTION WAS
STATED BY THE CHAIR. UMBERG
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS I CARRY IT
ALL. YET ALL I DID ALSO. THE
ADDRESS SO I. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED LAYERED HI
SKINNER STERN WAY CASKEY NO WAY
CASKEY NO THANK YOU WILL COOK
PUT THAT MATTER ON CALL NOW
LET'S GO TO FIGHT AN ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN ALSO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- WHEN THE
MENTAL HEALTH STATEWIDE DIRECT
DIRECTOR OF CRISIS SERVICES-
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL- AND
THIS IS A B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE WHICH HAS AGAIN RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH
A FULL TIME STATEWIDE DIRECTOR
OF CRISIS SERVICES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO DEVELOP AN
EFFECTIVE CRISIS CARE SYSTEM.
THAT CAN SAVE LIVES AND
RESOURCES ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS AND A COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED CRISIS NETWORK IS
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE IN
GETTING THESE CALIFORNIANS THE
HELP THEY NEED WITH ME IS ALICE
HAWTHORNE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND DANNY
OFFER FROM NAMI CALIFORNIA MR
HAWTHORNE. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE. OUR HOSPITAL'S
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE STATE
FEDERAL HEALTH CRISIS. FIRST WE
DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS BEING
MADE BY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IF YOU'RE INTO A
CRISIS DELIVERY SYSTEM AND WE
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORK BEING DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN OUR COUNTY PARTNERS. TO
BETTER COORDINATE SERVICES.
HOWEVER IF YOU STILL NEED IT
AND THE CRISIS DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF-
ENTRANCE AFTER SHORT ACT. WHICH
COVERS INVOLUNTARY PSYCHIATRIC
HOLDS. DEPENDING ON YOUR
LOCATION IN THE STATE YOU WILL
HAVE NOT ONLY TO SUPPORT ACCESS
TO SERVICES BUT ALSO DIFFERENT
FROM ALL RIGHT. A. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE IS NECESSARY FOR
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS. THAT
GREATER CONSISTENCY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE'RE THANKFULFOR
SOME MEMBER WOULDN'T LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERATION. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I THOUGHT.
VERY GOOD LET'S GO WITH THAT MR
OFFER YOUR NECKS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER WITH THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NOBBY CALIFORNIA SH
AND WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND FAMILY MEMBERS AS
WELL AS THEIR LOVE. FOR LIVING
WITH A SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS-
LAST FALL WE SURVEYED OUR
MEMBERS ASKING THEM HOW THEY
FEEL THE LPS ACTORS WORKING FOR
THEM AND WE GOT BACK OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED RESPONSES.
THAT'S BY FAR THE LARGEST
RESPONSE THAN ANY ISSUE THAT
I'VE SEEN IN MY TIME WITH MOMMY
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THEIR
RESPONSES- WERE NOT. GREAT MOST
OF THEM SHARED HORRIFIC
STORIES. ABOUT THE DIFFICULTIES
THEY HAD ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
SERVICES. SO IN SHORT THE
OPERATIVE WORD FOR THIS BILL IS
FOCUSED WE'RE ASKING TO HAVE
SOMEONE IN A LEADERSHIP ROLE AT
DH CS WHO CAN FOCUS FULL TIME
ON- THANK YOU AND WE REQUEST
YOUR I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
NUMBERS FROM THE SENATE GALLERY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE SEEING THEN LET'S
TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPICE SAYING NONE
ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES TO.
THOSE WHO WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THEN WE WILL G TO MY NUMBER
THREE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON ADRIAN SHELTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT AND ABC. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MY NUMBER.
THREE FORTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON JONATHAN CLAY ON
BEHALF OF SCRIPTS HELP AND
SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY THREE FORTY
NINE EIGHTY THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
SORRY ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU WE
LOOK AT LINE NUMBER. THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. MY NUMBER THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. OPS WELCOME BACK
HERE. MMHM I HAD MY NUMBER
THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LIES%
OPEN SORRY THIS IS NEAR MARTIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND TRUMP
REPORTED EIGHTY THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU WE WERE BOTH
GOING NUMBER HE. SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER
THOROUGHBRED ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SHELBY DEWBERRY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND THEN CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL AND COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WHEN WE LOOK
BACK ON MY NUMBER THREE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN BURGESS MY NAME IS
WENDY **** REPRESENTING
SYCAMORES ARE BASED IN LA
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S
SELF ALL THE SAME PROCEDURES I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE YLER WINDY
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION MR
INDY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ACCOUNTED TO HIM FOR HELP
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF YOUR
RESPECTFUL IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH IF I'M
FULL TIME THE WIDE DIRECTOR OF
CRISIS SERVICE THAT WHILE THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME AMENDMENTS TAKEN
TO DATE THAT HELP CLARIFY THE
POSITION APPLIED ACROSS PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC INSURANCE NOT AT THE
COURT MEETING WELL. THE
DIVISION CONTINUES TO BE OVERLY
BROAD AND DUPLICATE ABOUT.
NAPPER EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE IN ADDITION TO OTHER
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRES THE
CONVENING MEETING LOCAL LEADERS
TO DEVELOP A STATEWIDE BAN HERE
HOUSE CREDIT CARE DELIVERY
PROFOUND INCLUDING THE YOUR
YOUR LIFE IN THE NTIONAL
GUIDELINES FOR QUITE THE CARE
PUBLISHED BY THE FEDERAL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATION.
WHICH DATA LOCAL LEADERS WOULD
IMPLEMENT THIS PROVISION
CREATES CHALLENGES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IT ON ONLY CREATE
THE MANDATE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUT ALSO APPLIED
THE GUIDELINE WHICH IS NOT
READILY APPLICABLE ARE
PRACTICAL FOR CALIFORNIA AND
ITS RURAL AREAS COMPOUNDING. AS
AN EXAMPLE THE GUIDELINES
PROPOSED REGIONAL TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN CALL CENTER TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AVAILABILITY- PRACTICE
MOBILE RESPONSIVE ANYWHERE
ANYONE ANYWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY IN CRISIS
STABILIZATION FACILITIES
AVAILABLE IN HOME MIKE NON
HOSPITAL ENVIRONMENT. WHILE
ADMIRABLE TO STRIVE TO ACHIEVE
IT IT'S NOT PRACTICAL AND SMALL
AND RURAL COUNTIES WHERE THE
NUMBER UP QUITE. LOUD THEIR
LONG DISTANCES TO TRAVEL AND IN
SOME CASES EVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOES NOT OPERATE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN. MANDATING A SPECIFIC
MODEL DOES NOT WORK AND IF THEY
WERE DIVERSE POPULATIONS LIKE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA AND TOOK THEM
THIRTY EIGHT FIFTEEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL MEETING LOCAL
NEEDS. THERE CONTINUES TO BE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE DUPLICATIVE
OF OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND GO
BEYOND THE CRISIS SERVICES AREA
WHILE I'VE BEEN EXAMPLE THE
DIRECTOR WOULD MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICE
AT. AN OFFICER BECAUSE THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION IS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO CREATE YEAH I
PRIORITY BASED ON THAT. ONE
THOUSAND FOUR AUTHORED BY
SENATOR. FROM TWO THOUSAND. THE
H. THE ACTED. AND WHAT A COPY.
ON THE DAY THEY CAN ON JAN
TWENTY EIGHT. SHARING CONCERNS
WITH THE TELE YOU PLUG IT THAT
BECAUSE THING THAT I. HELPING
IN THE SERVICE AGENT. HE B. H.
EIGHT DOT PORT AFTER BUILD OUT
THE CRISIS THE LETTERS ON BUT
THE NOT BELIEVE THAT BETTER.
CALL SURVEY AND BUILD MY KNEE
OF OUR LOCAL AND COMMUNITY
MEETING FAIR HOUSE PRICES
SUPPORT PRETTY BRIEF AND WE
WERE SO. I'M TOLD MAYBE THERE
THIRTY REQUEST AND HELP ON THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY GOOD NOW
LET'S MOVE TO ANY WITNESS. IN
THE SENATE GALLERY LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF. AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE SAYING NONE
THE SCHOOL ROOM- ONE TWELVE. I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY THERE TO
TESTIFY SO MODERATOR PLEASE-
QUEUE UP THE- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION- WAITING
TO TESTIFY. ON. AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE. SURE IF YOU ARE
APPLE OF AB THIRTEEN ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN. AND WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF IT THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I WAS- LISTED
UNDER OUR SUPPORT BUT I
WOULDN'T CALL NINE SO I WISH TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
OUR MAYBE THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
MY NAME IS MARIE COLLINS THE
COST WITH THE FEDERAL. CENTERS
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
WE ARE PROUD TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WHICH IS
TIMELY AND MUCH NEEDED ON THE
GROUND. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AMERICAN LET'S HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION MODERATOR. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER.THREE THIRTY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JAY AND
COMMUNICATOR IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA- CONSTRUCTION- AND
SENATORS HERE AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE PEACH CAN ISSUING
AMMUNITION- IT WOULD BE SIXTEEN
THIRTY ONE. IN ENGLISH THANKS
TO ALL THE OTHERS WHO OPPOSED.
IT THANK YOU YEAH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE CUED UP IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD LET'S CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING FOR
INFECTED- MEMBERS TO HAVE ANY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE THE
CHURRO ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE SO MOVED
BY CENTER CONSOLIDATES. OUR
SUMMER WHEN YOU MAY CLOSE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF THE LONG LIST OF
SUPPORT WE HAVE AND WE HAVE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH OUR
SPONSORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND NAMI
CALIFORNIA. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ASSOCIATIONS BUT WE DO KNOW
WHAT IS HAPPENING CURRENTLY IS
NOT WORKING AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN THE MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG. OR JESS BOARD IS NOT
VOTING. COLORADO I DID I SO DID
I SO I'VE GONE SILAS GONZALEZ
BY HERZBERG JONES LAYERED
LAYERED BY SKINNER STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
YOU HAVE FIVE TO ZERO MEMBERS
MISSING VERY GOOD I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER. TWO
WE'LL PUT THAT MATTER ON CALL I
THOUGHT I SAW A CENTER BRADFORD
HERE. HI WHAT'S UP FRONT I SEE
A SEVEN MEMBER OCULAR CURRY
HERE- MEMBERS IT'S TURN TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE AP- HEY. LET'S
CALL. CHECK THAT LET'S GO TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. A. R. NUMBER
SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD-ON
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR AN FBI
SURVEILLANCE TAPES CENTRE
BRADFORD YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. AND
YOUR RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISS
SHEERAN'S CINEMA. AGARRAR CURRY
FOR A LOAN ME TO. JUMP IN HERE
REAL QUICK MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT- THAT'S J. R. SEVEN AS
CHAIR OF A LEGISLATIVE BLACK-CAUCUS I THINK THIS IS A
CRITICAL. THE ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO- WRITING THAT A
TERRIBLE WRONG THOUGH. IN THIS
NATION AND THIS MEASURE CALLS
FOR THE DESTRUCTION OF A MORAL
RECORDINGS AND TRANSCRIPTS OF
THE REVEREND DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. DR MELISSA KING
JUNIOR LED THE MODERN CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT FOR OVER
THIRTEEN YEARS. AND FROM HIS
ELECTION AS A SPOKESMAN FOR THE
MONTGOMERY IMPROVEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN DECEMBER OF
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE UNTIL IT
SAYS THE NATION FIFTY THREE
YEARS AGO WHILE STANDING. ON
THE BALCONY OF HIS ROOM AT THE
LORRAINE MOTEL. DR KING WAS
UNDER CONSTANT SURVEILLANCE
TODAY DR KING IS ONE OF THE
MOST REVERED LEADERS THIS
COUNTRY AND THIS WORLD HAS EVER
KNOWN. THIS GREAT MAN'S LEGACY
CHALLENGE THE MORAL COMPASS OF
THIS NATION CREATING A SURGE OF
GENES RELATED TO EQUITY
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE. DR KING
BELIEVED IN THE WORDS OF HIS
LIFE TO ENSURE. THAT THE FULL
PROMISES OF THIS COUNTRY WILL
REALIZE FOR ALL HUMAN BEINGS
REGARDLESS OF RACE COLOR OR
CREED. THE FBI BEGAN MONITORING
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR IN
DECEMBER OF NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
DURING HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
MONTGOMERY BUS BOYCOTT
SUPPOSEDLY BUT WRONG FEE SOUL
BECAUSE OF CONNECTIONS WITH THE
COMMUNIST PARTY. FBI DIRECTOR
J. EDGAR HOOVER WAS
AGGRESSIVELY HOSTILE AND
OBSESSED TOWARDS DR. KING
ORDERED HIS AGENTS TO ENGAGE IN
COVERT OPERATIONS AGAINST HIM.
OPERATIONS LIKE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROGRAM
WHICH WAS CREATED TO
INVESTIGATE BLACK NATIONALIST
HATE GROUPS TARGETED. AUTHORS
THE N. DOUBLE ACP AND OTHERS
STILL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
LEADERS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
UNDER THE FBI'S DOMESTIC
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROGRAM DR
KING HIS FAMILY AND ASSOCIATES
WERE SUBJECTED TO VARIOUS KINDS
OF FBI SURVEILLANCE THE FBI
EVEN SENT DR KING A NOTE URGING
HIM TO COMMIT SUICIDE IN ORDER
TO AVOID HUMILIATION OF THE
RELEASE OF THESE PUBLIC.
ILLEGALLY GATHERED TAKES AND
RECORDINGS AND TRANSCRIPTS.
THAT THE FBI HAD- RECORDED IN
SECURE ACCORDING TO A US SENATE
COMMITTEE CONVENED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES TO
INVESTIGATE THE FBI DOMESTIC
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIONS THE
COMMITTEE TO TERMING THE
FOLLOWING. RATHER THAN TRYING
TO DISCREDIT THE LEADS
COMMUNISTS TO IT BELIEVES WERE
ATTEMPTING TO INFLUENCE DR KING
THE GENERAL INSTEAD ADOPTED A
CURIOUS TACTIC OF TRYING TO
DISCREDIT THE SUPPOSED TARGET
OF THE COMMUNIST PARTY'S
INTERESTS. BEING DR KING
HIMSELF THESE RECORDINGS ARE
SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED BY THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY SEVEN. WHAT
THE FBI DID TO DR KING AND
OTHERS WAS UNLAWFUL VAN AND
IT'S A LAWFUL TODAY IT WAS IN A
LOSS OF LAWFUL INVASION OF
PRIVACY. FURTHERMORE THIS WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SEARCH UNDER
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT TO THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION. THE
FBI LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
POLICE FORCES HAVE USED THESE
SURVEILLANCE TACTICS TO TARGET
BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHERS
FIGHTING FOR RACIAL JUSTICE FOR
DECADES THEY EVEN USE IT TODAY.
AND YET WE CAN SEE THE STATUS
BEING CONTINUED. TO BE USED TO
TARGET BLACK ACTIVISTS IN ORDER
ORGANIZATIONS AS RECENTLY AS
LAST YEAR AFTER THE MURDER OF
GEORGE FLOYD. FOR EXAMPLE BLACK
ACTIVISTS IN SAN FRANCISCO HAD
TO SUE THE CITY AND THE COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF UNLAWFUL
SURVEILLANCE TACTICS. THIS IS
WHY THIS RESOLUTION IS NOT ONLY
CALLS FOR THESE UNLAWFUL TAPES
TO BE DESTROYED IT ALSO CALLS
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ROUTE PREVENT. SIMILAR ABUSES
THIS RESOLUTE RESOLUTION
FOCUSES ATTENTION ON THE
FAILURE IN OUR HISTORY THAT
MUST BE CORRECTED. LEAST WE
IGNORE- ISIS UNLESS WE HAVE A
NOR IT AND CONTINUE TO PREPARE
PREPARED TO WAIT THE SAME
INJUSTICE AGAINST OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS I THINK
MEMBERS HISTORY SPOKEN FOR
ITSELF AND THESE TAPES NEED TO
BE RE SPORTS STORY I MEAN
DESTROYED I'M SORRY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
AND NINE CENTER SO IT'S CLEAR
MY MIND YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE- AMENDMENTS IS OUTLINED IN
THE STAFF REPORT. YES WE ARE
OKAY EXCELLENT SO LET'S MOVE TO
GERMANY AT. THE NET TODAY WHO
IS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. MR
THAT TAKE THANK YOU CHAIR
AMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF THE ADVANCEMENT OF COLORED
PEOPLE THE END OF LEASE E. P. I
AM HERE TO SHORE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR S. J. R. SEVEN THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR THE ADVANCEMENT
OF COLORED PEOPLE WAS AND STILL
REMAINS ONE OF THE LARGEST AND
MOSTINFLUENTIAL CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES. DR KING'S INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE N. DOUBLE ACP DATES
BACK TO HIS POSITION ON THE
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF THE N.
DOUBLE ACP MONTGOMERY BRANCH IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES THROUGH
HIS LEADERSHIP AND THE VARIOUS
BOYCOTTS MARCHES AND RALLIES OF
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES BUT THE
MARCH ON WASHINGTON AND UP
UNTIL HIS ASSASSINATION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. LIKE DR
KING AND SEVERAL NOTABLE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST AT THE TIME THE
FBI INVESTIGATED THE N. DOUBLE
ACP FOR SUPPOSED CONNECTIONS
WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY. THE
INVESTIGATIVE TACTICS USED
RANGED FROM PLANTING INFORMANTS
AND BUGGING HOTELS IN HOUSE
PHONES AMONGST OTHER THINGS BUT
NO ONE DEALT WITH THE BURDEN OF
THE INTENSE UNWARRANTED
SURVEILLANCE. MORE THAN DR
KING. THE FBI DID EVERYTHING IN
THEIR POWER TO INFRINGE UPON DR
KING'S RIGHT UNDER THE PRETENSE
OF PROTECTING THIS COUNTRY FROM
COMMUNIST FROM COMMUNISM. THE
FBI SURVEILLANCE RECORDINGS OF
DR KING. WE MADE WITH THE
INTENTION TO DISCREDIT HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AS A WHOLE. DR KING
LIVED THE LAST YEARS OF HIS
LIFE WITHOUT ANY SEMBLANCE OF
PRIVACY WHILE CARRYING THE
TREMENDOUS BURDEN OF BEING A
BLACK PERSON IN AMERICA. LET US
NOT BE ABLE FOR BOTH FULL
PARTICIPANTS IN THE HISTORICAL
ATTEMPTS TO DEFAME THE
CHARACTER OF DR KING AND
INSTEAD EMBRACES LEGACY AND
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO THE FIGHT
FOR EQUITY AND JUSTICE. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII
AND W. C. P. I'D LIKE TO THANK
DR SENATOR BRADFORD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I URGE YOUR OFFICE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE SENATE GALLERY LIKE
THIS- SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. J.
R. SEVEN SEEING NONE. WILL TURN
TO ROOM ONE ONE TO SEEING THEM.
SEEING NONE. LET'S TURN TO THE
CONFERENCE CALL AND MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANYONE
WITH. WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. J. R. SEVEN
PLEASE BEGIN. YEAH IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. J. R. SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF F.
J. R. SEVEN. ONE NINE ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF THE
THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER THREE FORTY PICTURE
LINE IS OPEN. I MIGHT HAVE IT
ON MUTE. OKAY REALLY FAT AND
THERE THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q.
MESSENGER OKAY I HAVE NO- FROM
A FORMAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AS ANYBODY IN THE
GALLERY THAT'S SUPPOSED TO S.
G. R. SEVEN C. NINE LET'S TURN
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE A
MODERATOR PLEASE CHECK THE
PHONE SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION- HI ON OF S. G. R. A
SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. IF YOU
ARE IN A POSITION OF S. J. R.
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NOT THE OPPOSITION OF S.
J. R. SEVEN ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE
CAN GO TO THE LINE OF THREE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO NO S.
J. R. SEVEN HAD. AT THREE
THIRTY SEVEN YES- I APPROVE
DEFINITELY- YES I COULD HEAR IT
S. T. E. R. SEVEN. THANK YOU
YOUR NEXT. THEN WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYMORE IN Q. MESSENGER OKAY SO
LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
ON A PETITION IN SUPPORT ARE
THE MEMBERS HAVING QUESTIONS
CENTER BORDERS. YOU RECOGNIZE.
THE RESEARCH RESEARCHER ALEX
SEGMENT- ME RECORDS POSE A
QUESTION FOR YOU TOO THE AUTHOR
IF HE'D BE WILLING TO ACCEPT
VERY GOOD- DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERN THAT THESE MATERIALS
ARE OF SUCH HISTORIC IN
ACADEMIC VALUE THAT TO DESTROY
THEM WOULD BE- SIGNIFICANT LOSS.
TO THE BACKGROUND FROM THAT ERA
ESPECIALLY AS WE'VE GONE
THROUGH- THE CULTURAL AND
SOCIAL CHANGES RIGHT NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE FOR SOME TIME
THAT THESE THINGS OFFER
SIGNIFICANT VALUE. AS MANY
THOUGHTS ON THE FUTURE CENTER
ROGER PLEASE- WHAT HISTORICAL
VALUE OR CULTURAL VALUE DOES IT
HAVE TO LEGALLY LARGECAP
SOMEONE BE IT IN THE PRIVACY OF
THEIR OWN HOME INTO THEIR OWN
PRIVACY OF THEIR OWN OFFICE. OR
IN THEIR HOTEL ROOM I SEE
ABSOLUTELY NO VALUE TO. CULTURE
TO SOCIETY TO THIS NATION OR TO
THE WORLD FOR ILLEGALLY GAINED
WIRETAPS OF A PRIVATE CITIZEN
WELL I THINK YOU JUST ANSWERED
THAT. MAYBE IN YOUR EARLIER
STATEMENTS THAT THIS IS OF
SERVICE SUCH SYMBOLIC
IMPORTANCE WITH THE OVER REACH
OF LA ENFORCEMENT. THAT THIS
IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF HOW
THINGS SHOULD NOT BE DONE. AND
WITH THAT YOU KNOW IT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN ACADEMIC
VALUE DOES IT NOT. THE STORY OF
THE LEGAL WIRETAPPING ITSELF
DOES THE CONTENT OF THE WIRE
TAP NO THERE IS NO VALUE AND
WHATEVER. OFFHAND THE
CONVERSATIONS DR KING MIGHT
HAVE BEEN HAVING WITH
ASSOCIATES FRIENDS AND FAMILY
THAT BRINGS NO VALUE WHATSOEVER
THE FACT THAT IT WAS LEGALLY
DONE I THINK IT'S A LESSON TO
BE LEARNED HERE WILL HOLD THIS
GOVERNMENT HAS INTRUDED
ESPECIALLY ON PEOPLE OF COLOR.
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS FOR NUMBER
OF YEARS A DOCTOR KING WAS
ALIVE. IN IT F ITSELF THAT
STORY NEEDS TO BE TWELVE BUT
WHAT WAS RECORDED THAT WAS
CAPTURED ILLEGALLY NOT A SINGLE
PERSON IN THIS ROOM RIGHT HERE
THAT WANT THEIR HOME OR THEIR
OFFICES ILLEGALLY WIRETAPPING
HOPE THAT. FIFTY YEARS LATER IT
WOULD BE. THOUGHT TO BE
EDUCATIONAL IN ANY SENSE OF THE
MAGIC NEXT. THANK YOU HI- I
PERSONALLY THINK THAT MANY OF
THE POINTS THAT MINE THAT MY-COLLEAGUE HAS HAS MADE. ARE
MERITORIOUS. EVEN IF WE DON'T
LIKE HOWEVER ON HOW THINGS
WERE- OBTAINED IN THIS CASE
PATENTLY ILLEGAL. THAT- OUR
SCHOLARS- WILL DRAW UPON THESE
IN THE YEARS AHEAD IN TO.
REMOVE FROM THE ARCHIVE. ACCESS
TO THOSE I KIND OF. THE SHOE ON
THE OTHER FOOT AND I RESPECT
WHAT HE'S ABSOLUTELY TRYING TO
DO- IF- IF. THE SHOE WERE ON
THE OTHER FOOT AND- FOLKS WERE
TRYING TO GET THE BRITISH
ARCHIVES TO DESTROY THE RECORDS
OF GANDHI I THINK THERE MIGHT
BE AN ISSUE- THAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM. AND I DON'T LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED I THINK IT'S WRONG IT
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL IT WAS
ILLEGAL. BUT THERE IS
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE- THAT I
THINK WE COULD BE LOSING- IF
WE- TOSS IT OUT. JULIE NOTED
OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE.
QUESTIONS FOR DISCUSSION. THING
IN CENTER PRESS FOR YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU THIS YEAR- IN
DR KING'S CLOSING REMARKS AT
THE END OF WAYS TO BE
EMANCIPATION DAY RALLY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN DR KING
ELOQUENTLY STATED THERE'S
NOTHING GREATER IN THE WORLD
THAN FREEDOM. IT'S WORTH GOING
TO JAIL FOR IT'S WORTH LOSING A
JOB FOR IT'S WORTH DYING FOR.
AND UNFORTUNATELY DR KING DIED
FOR THAT FREEDOM UNFORTUNATELY
DID NOT LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO
EXPERIENCE THE FREEDOM THAT HE
HAD HOPED FOR AND THAT HE HAD
FOUGHT FORCE SO VIOLENTLY
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. FOR THE
LAST FOUR AND A HALF YEARS OF
HIS LIFE FROM NOVEMBER NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE UNTIL HIS DEATH IN
APRIL NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT DR
KING LIVE WITHOUT ANY SEMBLANCE
OF PRIVACY. OR FREEDOM. THIS
RESOLUTION IS JUST A FIRST STEP
TOWARD RIGHTING THE WRONGS DR
KING AND MANY BLACK PEOPLE THAT
HAVE AND CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE
DO THIS ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE AN
INVASION OF PRIVACY BY THE FBI.
LET US URGE OUR NATIONAL
ARCHIVES TO FINALLY GRANT DR
KING THE PEACE AND PRIVACY THAT
EVERY CITIZEN IS DESERVED BUT
THAT A BAITED HIM FOR MOST OF
HIS LIFE. WITH THE DESTRUCTION
OF THESE ILLEGAL TAPES THEY
PROVIDE NO CULTURAL NO
EDUCATION OR NO NATIONAL
BENEFIT WHATSOEVER. WE OWE IT
TO THIS GREAT MAN WE OWE IT TO
HIS LEGACY BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE OWE IT TO HIS FAMILY WE OWE
IT TO THIS NATION TO DESTROY
THE TAPES I RESPECT WHAT I
THRIVE OFF. THANK YOU SENATOR
SET IN MOTION SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SO MOVE TO- CHIEF COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS S.
J. R. SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED AMBERG
BURGESS. BARGES NO KELLY IT'LL
CARRY IT OUT I DID I SAW. THAT
I SAW I ABLE AND SILAS.
HERTZBERG HERZBERG BY JONES.
LAYERED LAYERED I SKINNER STERN
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WHY CASKEY
I'D GIVE FIVE TO ONE SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ART WILL
PUT THAT MATTER ON HOLD THIS
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS A P. ELEVEN HUNDRED BY- AS A
MEMBER AND YOU ARE CURRY. ON
COMMUNICATION SERVICES
DISASTERS REPORT A SIMILAR
PLEASE PROCEED GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED WHICH REQUIRES
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
UP EMERGENCIES OF DIRECT
DISASTERS. THE WILDFIRES OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
CAUSE MASSIVE DEVASTATION FOR
PROPERTY LOSS A
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
DAMAGE. MANY PEOPLE REPORTED
THAT THE MOBILE PHONES WENT
DARK AND INTERNET SERVICE
WITHOUT A CELL TOWERS WERE
DAMAGED AN UNDERGROUND FIBER
LINES ARE BURNED. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AN ONLINE
SURVEY FOUND THAT 64% OF
RESPONDENTS THE FILM ACCOUNT AS
WELL PART AFFECTED AREAS LOST
LAND LINE PHONE SERVICE. JUST
LAST YEAR THE TWENTY TWENTY
LOSS WERE REPORTEDLY DAMAGED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING
DESTRUCTIONS AND PHONE SERVICE
IN THE AFFECTED AREA. IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THESE DEVASTATING
FIRES THE STATE THE PC HAVE
FOCUSED HEAVILY ON THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THE MASS
OF DESTRUCTION. EVEN TODAY
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL
IMPACT OF THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS HAVE HAD ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS AND
HOW TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED. CONCRETE
RECOVERY PLANS ARE NOT SHARED
WITH THE P. C. OR THE
LEGISLATURE HIS JOB IS TO
OVERSEE THESE COMPANIES AND
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
WE NEED THIS INFORMATION TO
MAKE SURE GOVERNMENTS ARE
HELPING IN THIS REPAIR EFFORT.
NOT IMPEDING RESTORATION ELEVEN
HUNDRED OF RECORDS PC TO
COLLECT INFORMATION
TELECOMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER EMERGENCIES OR DISASTERS.
I WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS
BILLS REQUIRED REPORTING IS NOT
MANDATED TO BE SUBMITTED DURING
THE EMERGENCIES THEMSELVES BUT
IS INSTEAD A LOOK BACK TO MAKE
SURE GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKING TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS IN THE SHORT
TERM. DURING EMERGENCIES AN
APPROPRIATE SERVICE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL ECONOMIES AFTER. DISASTER
IN THE LONG TERM. IT ELEVEN
HUNDRED NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
REGULAR EMPLOY AFFAIRS ARE
INFORMED OF TELECOMMUNICATION
SERVICE FAILURES. AND NETWORK
DAMAGE AFTER NATURAL DISASTERS.
WITHOUT INFORMATION REGARDING
THE METHODS AND TECHNOLOGY USED
TO REBUILD THERE'S NO WAY TO
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS HAVE THE
SAME OR IMPROVED ACCESS FOR
RELIABLE NETWORK. FOR MOST
CALIFORNIANS RELIABLE. VOICE
TELEPHONE SERVICE IS NECESSARY
TO REACH NINE ONE ONE. WITHOUT
IT THE ABILITY TO CONTACT
EMERGENCY SERVICES IS LIMITED
OR NON EXISTENT. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IS AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR FRANK
THEY WERE SAYING ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE. AND
BRENDA VILLA NUEVA TELECOM
REGULATORY ATTORNEY ON BEHALF
OF TURN VERY GOOD- MR RK.
HERKIMER DEEP. BUT THANK YOU
CLOSE ENOUGH- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM FRANK ARSON BY
PRESIDENT THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE. ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
WORKERS EAGERLY AWAITED CHECK
MINE IS PROUD TO CO SPONSOR KT
ELEVEN HUNDRED. WE ASK THAT THE
PATH AT ELEVEN HUNDRED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNICATIONS
AND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS HOLY AND PROPERLY RESTORED
FOLLOWING AN EMERGENCY. THREE
W. MEMBERS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
SENT OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. TO
RESTORE AFTER MERGING SIX
WHETHER IT IS URBAN WORLD
RECORD SERVICE AND RETAIL
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. OUR
GOAL IS AND SHOULD BE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY PHONE IS UP AND
RUNNING IN THE SHORTEST TIME
POSSIBLE. IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MEANS POSSIBLE FOR LONG TERM
SERVICING ABILITY. OUR WORKERS
HAVE OFTEN HEARD FROM CUSTOMERS
CAN NOT ONLY WHAT THEY'RE
CERTAIN DRUG BECAUSE OF AN
EMERGENCY. BUT AT THE COVERAGE.
MAP RECORD TO PROLONG. EVEN
WITH MANY OTHER. ARE BACK
ONLINE. HE ALSO KNOWS THE PLAN
SERVICE ACCORDING FOR. NEVER
FULLY READ. EVEN COMMUNE BALL
COMPUTER OUTAGES. YOU MUST
ENSURE ERIC. AND PUT. WHAT WE
WERE. RIGHT NOW THERE ARE GOOD
OVER AND TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
LONG REPAIR AND REHABILITATION
WE'RE- PRACTICES. YOU
ATHLETICALLY THERE SHOULD BE
MADE AWARE OF ANY OF YOUR- ARE
NOT BEING PUT BACK ONLINE AND
MUST HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
EVERYONE IN YOUR DISTRICT HAS
THERE YOU CAN START THE MOST
AFFECTED THE POSSIBLE. I THANK
ALL THE BLOOD WORK WHENEVER
POSSIBLE OR REPLACING OLD
OUTDATED COPPER WITH MORE
COPPER. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THESE COMMUNITY NETWORKS NOT
RELATE ON TOP THAT MEASURES WE
OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LEARN THE LESSONS
OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
WILDFIRES. THEM TO RESTORE
DIGNITY TO HOLD PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE THEY
SERVE. WE ACTIVELY SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN HUNDRED FORGIVENESS.
FILL IN THE WAY OF A PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON. AND OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BRENDA AGAIN WITH. MANY TURNING
WITH TURNED SIX YEARS OF
FEDERAL LEVEL I DON'T YOUR
PARTY EXPERIENCE AT THE FCC.
TURNED CONCOURSE ONE THIRD OF
THE ELEVEN HUNDRED AND THANKS
THE FAMILY MEMBER WE ARE
CREEPER GREAT LEADERSHIP. WHEN
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS ARE
DAMAGED DURING A DECLARED
DISASTER. SEARCH WRITERS JUST
FINDING DIFFERENT WAYS TO
RESTORE SERVICE AND IN THE
SHORT TERM CONVEYS INFORMATION
AND REPORTING REQUIRED PRIVACY
QC. HELLO YEAH AND THAT HE
SHOULD. NOT THE STATE'S ROLE
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS DOES NOT
END ABRUPTLY WHEN PHONE SERVICE
WAS JUST TEMPORARILY RESTORED.
AND FOR THIS REASON AT ELEVEN
HUNDRED COMPLEMENTS CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS. TAKING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DISASTER
UP TO TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A DISASTER.
CORRECT PROVIDERS WITH A
MINIMUM ABOUT THE DAMAGED WORK
IN THE MATERIALS USED HI MY
NAME. WITHOUT THE VEIL THE
CHIEF EUGENE NORTHERN
LEGISLATURE CAN INSURE ABOUT
RESIDENTS PROPERTY OR IMPROVE
SERVICE I'M NOT RELIABLE
NETWORK JUST AFTER. AND IN
ADDITION TO IMPORT THE CURRENT
TAX THAT RECOGNIZES THE SERVICE
PRICE OF FACILITIES TO IDENTIFY
THE INFORMATION FOR WHICH-
RUSSIA MAY PRESENT. THREAT TO
EITHER PUBLIC. OR PRIVATE
PROPERTY OR THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING. INTERNET
ALSO SUPPORTED THE EFFORTS TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL APPLICABLES
LONG IN ORDER SUPPLIES.
INCLUDING TV SECTION YOU CAN
FIGHT. EIGHTY THREE TO PROTECT
THIS INFORMATION. I FINALLY THE
BILL CALLS FOR PROVIDERS TO
SHARE THEIR SPACE IN RESTORING
SERVICE TO PRE DISASTER LEVELS.
FIFTEEN FEET AND THE
LEGISLATURE WHO RECEIVED THE
INFORMATION THROUGH YEAH I
THINK YOU GOT A RECORD. WHAT
DOES HE- RIGHT CONCRETE TO HELP
AND TO THE OBSTACLES THE FORMER
NXT DOCTOR STRUCK. WHAT BAD I
URGE YOU SHOULD OF ATLS HUNDRED
AND NINETY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO THE SENATE GALLERY
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED. SIGNAL TURNED TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE THERE'S NOBODY THERE
SO MODERATOR- PLEASE PROMPT
THIS WITNESS IS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF P. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. MODERATOR ANY
INDIVIDUALS HERE AND SUPPORTING
OF AB. ELEVEN HUNDRED. OKAY NOT
HEARING I WILL COME BACK IF
THERE'S- WITNESSES ON THE LINE
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION- IT IS
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A BURNER
ROSCOE HERE'S TO OPPOSE IN
PUBLIC IN THE SENATE GALLERY MR
OSCAR PLEASE FOR C. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF BURNING A
ROSTER WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED. THE U. S.
HOMELAND SECURITY HAS
DESIGNATED SIXTEEN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SECTORS SECTORS
THAT ARE VITAL AND CRITICAL TO
THE ECONOMY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
OF THE COUNTRY- COMMUNICATIONS
IS ONE OF THOSE AND FOR THAT
REASON INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURES ARE CONSIDERED.
CONFIDENTIAL WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
TO SHARE INFORMATION WITH STATE
AGENCIES ABOUT OUR RESTORATION
EFFORTS AND OUTAGES WHEN THEY
OCCUR IN FACT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THIS LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED A NEW LAW THAT REQUIRES
US WITHIN AN HOUR OF DISCOVERY
MANAGES TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH TELL- YES
WHICH WE DO IT'S ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED. WHAT WAS THE EXTENT
OF THE DAMAGE- WHEN DID WE
RESTORE IT SO THAT INFORMATION
IS PROVIDED TO THE STATE AND IS
PROVIDED TO CALLAWAY S. WHICH
IS THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AGENCY. SO WHAT ARE THE
CONCERNS WE HAVE HERE IS THAT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
IS GOING TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AN MAKE IT PUBLIC
MAKE IT PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
WHICH IS OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE TIMING IS
BETTER DISCLOSURE OF THAT
INFORMATION. CURRENT LAW TODAY
ALREADY REQUIRES THAT WHEN
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS ARE
DESTROYED AND THAT THEIR WRIST
D. OR RESTORE TO EQUAL OR
BETTER QUALITY. IF ANYONE IS C.
W. A. HAS FOUND A SITUATION.
WHERE A COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDER HAS FAILED TO RESTORE
TO EQUAL OR BETTER IT IS THEIR
OBLIGATION TO REPORT THAT. YEAH
WE'VE GOT US IN THE PAST TO
NAME AT LEAST ONE COMMUNITY
WHERE THIS HAS OCCURRED. AND NO
ONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
SO THIS IS MORE OF AN ACADEMIC
EXERCISE- FOR EXPANDING THE
JURISDICTION FROM BIANCA- YES
INTO ANOTHER STATE AGENCY. BUT
THAT INFORMATION IS PROVIDED
AND FOR THAT REASON WE'RE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
THE GALLERY TO- IN OPPOSITION
OF. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED. LET'S
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY
THERE. ALREADY A MODERATOR I'M
GONNA TURN BACK TO YOUR
UNDERSTAND THAT WE FOUND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. ELEVEN HUNDRED SO IF YOU
COULD Q. THE MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
OF AV ELEVEN HUNDRED FIRST I
BELIEVE THERE'S- A DOZEN OR SO.
YES I WILL DO THAT- IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF P. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTY CAN YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
YVONNE NELSON I'M WITH
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I AM
A SUPPORTER OF MAYBE ELEVEN HAS.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE- OF WORK. HERE THE KILLING
UP STILL. WE'RE GOING TO THE
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JANET FEELS THAT I'M A
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINE FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF. EIGHTY ELEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU WE RECORDED
LINE NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU MIGHT HAVE A MEAL. OKAY WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES ONE OF THE SCOTT TURNER I'M
WITH T. W. A. DISTRICT NINE
STRONG SUPPORT OF A VIDEO OF
ANOTHER. THANK THANK YOU WITH A
QUOTE ONLINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON WITH
SORENSON WITH COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
ELEVEN HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MY NUMBER THREE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER THREE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. STRONG WINDS FROM
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINE FOUR ZERO
EIGHT AND WE A. B. ONE ONE
ZERO. OR THE BUT. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. MAYBE ELEVEN HUNDRED.
HE DROPPED OUT THANKS NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
THE HOTEL MY NUMBER THREE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS CARLA COMPLICITY FROM
THE W. EIGHT LOCAL NINE FOUR
ONE THREE AND WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF- OF THE OF THE ONE
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED. NEXT
THANK YOU LOOK FINE NUMBER. TWO
NINETEEN- NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY WE'RE GOING TO LINE
NUMBER THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE WOMAN IN THE
LOBBY WITH ALL OF OUR- MORE
RESIDENTS SECOND COUNTY AND I
AM THE POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR A
LOCAL NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE ELEVEN HUNDRED. MAYBE
ELEVEN ON NEXT THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD. YES MY NAME
IS KEEPING ME IN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
AND A- HUNDRED. THANK YOU. SIX
THANK YOU. WE WERE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU MIGHT OPEN A NEW. WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER TWO SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE WILL TRY TO GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE AT NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK WE CAN HEAR YOU HEAR.
OKAY OKAY. HEY LET'S TRY A LINE
NUMBER. TWO OH ONE MY NUMBER
TWO OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE LINES ARE OPEN OKAY THE
CRAP OUT OF THE QUEUE. PAULA J.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT LET'S
SUM LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE HEARD FROM
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND
ON- HERE IN THE CAPITAL IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO. A. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. IF YOU ARE IN A
POSITION OF AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT THE OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
ONE EVERY THREE SEVENTY ONE.
ARE YOU. BY NUMBER. THREE
SEVENTY ONE. IN MY NUMBER.
SIXTY TWO. SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE HAVE NO REASON LAST
MONTH I'M NOT SURE HERE LET'S
SEE HERE MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
ONE. ALL RIGHT. CLEARLY YES GO
AHEAD GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY I WANTED TO LET YOU
GUYS KNOW WE WORK AT ALL THE
BOTTOM JUST CUT OFF THE BIKE
FOR LIKE THREE MINUTES AND THEN
WE HEARD YOU GUYS AGAIN SO I
HAVE TO BE SOMETHING ROLLED THE
PHONE LINES BUT I DO WANT TO
SAY MY NAME IS KENYAN JOBS AND
C. W. A. NINE THOUSAND THREE
AND I'M A 100% SUPPORT. AB
SEVEN HUNDRED. OKAY. ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE. THERE
ARE NO MORE IN Q. MESSENGER. SH
EACH. IF THERE ANYBODY
LISTENING TO THE- YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THROUGH I GUESS WE'D
CALL BACK IN. AND GET BACK INTO
THE QUEUE MODERATE ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE PHONE LINES AND- WE DO
HAVE ONE I JUST QUEUED UP NOW
IN ITS LINE NUMBER HE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THANK YOU- YEAH I
ADDED EARLIER MY NAME'S ANTHONY
TESTS- I AM WITH COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
FIVE TEN OUT OF ORANGE COUNTY.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF ABIA
LOOKING UNDER. OKAY THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF TWO
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY HEARING NO RESPONSE
WE WILL TRACK BACK AND IF THERE
ARE NO OTHER THING YOU AS OF
RIGHT NOW. OKAY LET'S GIVE IT A
SECOND TO RE PROMPT. ONE ZERO
YOU GET INTO THE QUEUE. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA TRY NUMBER TWO
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE DEFINITELY
MUST BE SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THE PHONE LINE SOMEWHERE. MY
NUMBER TWO TWENTY ONE CAN YOU
HEAR US LINE IS OPEN. YEAH THE
ICKET. PERSON DROPS SO THERE
ARE NO MORE I DON'T THINK YOU
RIGHT NOW. LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA CALLING IN
FROM ACROSS THE STATE ON ELEVEN
HUNDRED LET'S BRING BACK TO
MEMBERS WE HAVE OUR CHAIR. HAS
RETURNED- THERE ARE LITTLE.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AS IT TURNED OVER TO
THE CHAIR MISS OCULAR KERR YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WROTE. CHIEF COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
A. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG. HI LINER NUMBER FIVE%
BORJAS KELLY IT'LL CARRY IT OUT
I DID ALSO THE REST SO I A.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ BY HERTZ BERG
HURTS BERG I JONES LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SKINNER. STERN
WHITE HOUSE SKI WHITE HOUSE SKI
I. YOU HAVE SEVENTY ZERO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. THANK YOU THE
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU SIR
WHAT KOWSKI I AM INFORMED THAT
YOU DID AN EXCELLENT JOB WHILE
I WAS GONE- NEXT MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL WHAT WHAT IS NEXT ON
OUR AGENDA. ALL RIGHT I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA- FILING
A NUMBER FOR A. B. SIX NINE
FIVE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS. EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE WILL PROTECT
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT IN
CALIFORNIA FROM ABUSE NEGLECT
AND EXPLOITATION BY EXPANDING
AND ENHANCING THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. BUT TWENTY
THIRTY ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE THE NUMBER OF ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH DISABILITIES
WILL GROW FROM ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO THREE MILLION
IN TWENTY SIXTY. CALIFORNIA'S
AGING POPULATION IS ALSO
INCREASINGLY SUFFERING
HOMELESSNESS ACCORDING TO UCSF
RESEARCHERS HALF OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY. WITH HALF OF THOSE
BECOMING HOMELESS AFTER THE AGE
OF FIFTY. ONE OF THE GREATEST
THREATS TO FULL INCLUSION AND
EQUITY FOR ALL AGES IS ELDER
ABUSE WITH ITS ESTIMATED IMPACT
410% OF OLDER INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVE AT HOME TOTALING IN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOSSES
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
ADDRESS THIS TWO PRONGED ISSUE
OF HOMELESSNESS AND ELDER ABUSE
EFFECTIVELY THE STATE NEEDS TO
INVEST ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
INTO THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. TO FILL SUCH A NEED
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE WOULD
EXPAND AND ENHANCE THE APS
SYSTEM FOR OLDER INDEPENDENT OF
DOLLS. BY LOWERING THE AGE OF
ELIGIBILITY FROM SIXTY FIVE TO
SIXTY TO SERVE HIGHLY
VULNERABLE ADULTS. BY EXPANDING
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TO PROVIDE LONG TERM CASE
MANAGEMENT AND BY BUILDING UPON
THE SUCCESSFUL HOME SAFE
PROGRAM TO ASSIST THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES CLIENTS WHO
NEED HELP WITH HOUSING ISSUES.
BY EXPANDING THIS OPERATIONAL
CAPACITY MORE OF OUR ELDERLY
POPULATIONS CONFINED SAFE AND
STABLE HOUSING. IT WILL ALLOW
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TO SERVE AND EXPANDED OLDER
ADULT POPULATION ANYMORE
UPSTREAM AND TO INTERVENE
EARLIER IN SITUATIONS BEFORE
THEY REACH A CRISIS POINT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE APOLLO VS GAS
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTOR ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS VIVIAN IN
BAKU WITH JUSTICE IN AGING.
ALREADY THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IT. THIS PAULA- YEAH
BECAUSE OR THE ON. MACH TWO ARE
THERE. YES GO AHEAD. GREAT THE
PLAN NUMBER APOLOGIZE DIRECTOR
OF LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY FOR THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AT ONE EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FIVE I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
THE COUNTY PERSPECTIVE AND ASK
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
WHICH AIMS TO GROW THE ATF
PROGRAM I'M HOME SAFE PROGRAM
WITHIN THE ATF PROGRAM TO MEET
THE NEED WE ARE SEEING. WITH
THE GROWING OLDER ADULT
POPULATION. YEAH OKAY SERVES
THEM THE ONE ABOUT ONLY AND- I
DON'T. POPULATION IS NOT. AN
UNCLE HOW CRISIS WHICH HAS BEEN
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE
COMBINED. I'M NOT AMONG ONLY
ONE OFTEN BEGUN IF YOU LOOK OR
EXPLOITATION. THE OLDER ADULTS
OFTEN HAVE COMPLEX HEALTH OR
MENTAL HEALTH OR COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS SUCH AS DEMENTIA
ARE LIVING IN POVERTY ON A
FIXED INCOMES ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY YOU HAVE FALLEN IN LOVE
WITH HER. ON. A TREATMENT PLAN
FOR EACH AND- EIGHT RESUME
INCLUDES BOTH NUMBER ALL AND SO
IF HE- OTHER REASONS COMPLEX OF
THEIR NEEDS. BUT WITHIN CURRENT
RESOURCES EIGHT YEAH UNABLE TO
GIVE THEM THE TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU FOR CALLING.
I DON'T PART OF THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU WILL MAKE THE
EXISTING HOME SAFE PROGRAM FROM
THAT DEPOSIT THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY HOMELESS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROGRAM IS
NOT COUNTING. WE HAVE FROM
HUNDREDS THE HOME PLATE I'M
HIKING MONEY. IS INVOLVED.
DURING FOR THOSE WE SERVE ANY
YES ON THE PROGRAM ALSO HAVE
INCREASED BUT WHAT PART. IF
YOU'RE GOING INCLUDE INCREASED
WITH HOUSING NUMBER SEVEN. ZERO
ONE FOUR NINE AND HOSPITALS WE
NEED ACTION TO BE DONE TO
PREVENT WHEN WE GOT HOME AMONG
THE MANY DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MOST AT RISK. THANK
YOU FOR COMING EMBRYO IN
HEARING. IMPORTANT MEASURE ON.
WHAT. FIVE HUNDRED HUNDRED
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU- IS
MISS- A BOX TO ONLINE. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAY NEED TO BE IN A BOX
YOU REPRESENTING JUSTICE IN
AGING ECHO CONTENT THAT THAT'S
REQUIRED. WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE I'VE BEEN ORGANIZATION
JUSTICE IN AGING BELIEVE THAT
NO MATTER YOUR RACE GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION ABILITY LANGUAGE OR
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN AND WE SHOULD
ALL BE ABLE TO ACCESS RESOURCES
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS WE NEED.
TO THRIVE AND TO GROW OLDER
THEREFORE WE SUPPORT INCREASED
FUNDING FOR APS IS THERE AN
INTEGRAL PART IN FIGHTING
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES THAT AFFECT
OLDER ADULTS OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. HAVE
YOU HEARD THE NUMBER OF OLDER
ADULTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND GROWING BUT
EVEN MORE CONCERNING IS THAT
BLACK OLDER ADULTS ARE
OVERREPRESENTED AMONG THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. 43% OF
HOMELESS ADULTS ARE BLACK WHILE
BLACK PEOPLE MAKE UP ONLY 13%
OF THE NATIONAL POPULATION.
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE OF THE AFTER
EFFECTS OF DISCRIMINATORY
HOUSING PRACTICE AND THE FRONT
BRAKE ON TACKLING THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OLDER ADULTS
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY AN EQUITY
ISSUE INCREASED FUNDING TO EPF
WILL DIRECTLY WORK TO CREATE
MORE EQUITABLE AGING FOR BLACK
OLDER ADULTS AND. OTHER OLDER
ADULTS THE COLOR IN CALIFORNIA.
MARK REFLECTED CHANGES ABC
NINETY FIVE MAKER TO DRESSING
EQUITY ISSUES. AMONG ALL ADULTS.
IN ADDITION. THE PAGE. AND
PROVIDING MORE FUNDING WILL
IMPACT THE OLDER ADULT
POPULATION. GREW BY GIVING APS
WORKERS THE FLEXIBILITY THEY
NEED TO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN A
HOLISTIC WAY. I THINK A LOT OF
COUNTY DO FUNDS IN WAYS THAT
THAT SUPPORT CLIENT CENTERED
RESPONDED. WHICH TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE COMPLEX NEEDS A
BILL. TO A HOMELESS AND AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS. JUST GIVE ME A
DRINK WE GOT FUNDING. PROGRAM
TO ADDRESS BOTH THE H. IN ORDER
TO HOME. AND THE GROWTH IN THE-
ADULTS. ACCOUNT THREE THING.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IN TAKING
STEPS TO PROVIDE EQUITY TO ALL
OLDER ADULTS AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MOROCCO. ALL IGHT OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX NINE
FIVE IN THE GALLERY SEEING NONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE-
MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE UP THOSE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. SIX NINE FIVE. SURE IF YOU
ARE IN PART OF EIGHTEEN SIX
NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BACK IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX NINE FIVE ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE LOOK AT ONLINE A FEW
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WOULD BE FANTASTIC BEHALF OF
ANTI ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING ATS WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE DEBATE IN CROWD
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THE NEXT ONE IS BLIND
NUMBER FOUR OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SYLVIA SO LISA SCHON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT AND
FRESNO AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TRY
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY EIGHT I FIND
OVER TO LADY. MR KERRY MEMBERS
GENE HEARST CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALES NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER THREE FORTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
MESSENGER ALREADY ALLISTER AND
OPPOSITION I SEE WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS ONE PRINCIPAL WITNESS
AN OPPOSITION MR RICHARD-
CALHOUN MR KAHANA YOU ON. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR US MUST COME HOME
GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M RICHARD CALHOUN
CO FOUNDERS LEADERS HERE
REMAINS OPPOSED TO A B. SIX
NINETY FIVE AS AMENDED ON JUNE
TWENTY NINTH BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUED USE OF OR PERSONS
UPDATING THAT HAND ON PAGE
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY FIVE AND THE
UNINTENDED NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT
HAS ON ELDERS IN FACILITIES.
THAT PARAGRAPH EFFECTIVELY READ
IF THE SUSPECTED ABUSE OCCURRED
IN LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
REPORT SHALL BE MADE TO THE
LOCAL COMMENTS MAN THIS
CONTINUES TO PARROT THE TWENTY
TWELVE LANGUAGE THAT NO LONGER
COMPLIES WITH THE PENAL CODE
THREE SIXTY EIGHT POINT FIVE.
AS A RESULT OF S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE SEMANAS PASSING
JUST LAST YEAR SINCE THE FIRST
OF THIS YEAR ALL FORMS OF ELDER
OR DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE OR
CRIMES LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS HAD
AND CONTINUES TO HAVE EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION TO INVESTIGATE
CRIMES. YES EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE AND CURB REPORTING FINDS
AN ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY I
WAS MEANT FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
AND HAVE NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING AUTHORITY THUS
PREVENTING LAW. ENFORCEMENT
FROM DOING THEIR ASSIGNED TASKS.
A TO STAY COMMON. STRICT COMP.
RIGHT PREVENT THE OP. YOU
GETTING 75% OF THE REPORTS THEY
RECEIVE AS A RESULT THE FUTURE
VICTIMS AND THE LIVING AND
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES WILL
BE EFFECTIVELY DENIED THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PROTECTION
PROVIDED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ALSO IF EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE
PASSES AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
FIFTEEN SIX THIRTY WE'LL HAVE A
REVISION DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. BUT NOT COMPLY WITH AN
EXISTING TWENTY TWENTY ONE PRO.
CEDAR IS REQUESTING THAT EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE I'D BE AMENDED
IF ANYTHING THAT CONFORMS THAT
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PERSON A PENAL CODE THREE SIXTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE. ONE EASY WAY
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS IS SIMPLY TO
CHANGE OR AND ON PAGE EIGHT
LINE TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THEY GIVE US A CALL
HOME ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. TO- A. B. SIX FIVE
AND THE GUY SEEING IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE. ON THE
PHONE LINE IS MODERATOR VIEW TO
THEM UPPER MODERATOR RATHER IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE THEM UP THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIX NINE
FIVE. ACTIVATION OF EIGHTEEN
SIX NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THEN WE WILL CUT
THE LINE FOUR OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE MEMBERS ENTER LANGLEY
FROM THE HELP AMERICA ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO CAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN A POSITION OF A. B.
SIX NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
NINE ZERO. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALREADY THANK YOU BACK TO THE
CHAMBER'S SEEING NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- IS THERE MOST- I'M
SORRY MISTER WHAT KOWSKI CENTER
WHITE HOUSE SKI. SO WHAT ELSE
HE MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT-
NO THE MICROPHONES RAISED. SO
THE NUMBER ON THE WALL DO YOU
CARE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A V. SIX NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADEMOLA.
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE KI THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI- BERG HI. BOARD YES.
ZERO ZERO I THE RUSSELL RUSSELL
ICON SUNLESS GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG. CHRIS BERG HI JONES.
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED ICE
SKINNER. STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WHITE HOUSE TI. GIVE EIGHT TO
ZERO WITH MEMBERS MISSING
ALREADY WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL- NEXT- IF WE'RE IN REGULAR
ORDER I SEE- AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAUER K.
HIM BUT I SEE SOME REMEMBER
CHEW WHO'S STANDING AT THE
PODIUM AND I DO NOT SEE A
SALOON OR BAR CAME UP WITH FOUR
BEGIN I WANT TO WELCOME OUR
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY WERE
PLEASED TO SEE CALIFORNIANS
RETURNING TO THE STATE CAPITOL
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE YOU
OBSERVE YOUR GOVERNMENT IN
PROGRESS. ALL RIGHT. SO THIS
FOR THOSE OF YOU LISTENING AND
WATCHING- WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THINGS OUT OF ORDER A BIT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ASSUME
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT AT
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. I AM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OUR CANADA
STEPPED OUT FROM MEETING SO SHE
TOLD ME I GOT TO POP UP ONLINE
WHICH ALL RIGHT WE APPRECIATE
YOU GOT. QUITE A BOMB THERE ARE
SOME NUMBER TWO I HOPE YOU
REMEMBER THIS IN THE FUTURE. I
WILL REMEMBER THIS TO MY DYING
DAY ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT- SO AB
ELEVEN. EIGHTY FOUR PHYLUM
NUMBER THIRTEEN. OF THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU SENATORS
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
ENSURE. PATIENT PRIVACY. LET ME
START BY FIRST THANKING THE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND ACCEPT ALL
OF THE MOMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
INCLUDING SEVERAL AGREED TO IN
SENATE HEALTH. THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THAT A CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION REQUEST APPLIES
TO ALL SERVICES. REMOVED
EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS FROM
THE LIST OF DOCUMENTS IN WHICH
HEALTH PLANS MUST NOTIFY.
PATIENTS ABOUT THE CCR PROCESS
AND CLEAN UP DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION PROVISIONS.
SENATORS THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE PRIVACY OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NOT THE PRIMARY POLICY
HOLDER FOR THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE. SUCH AS THOSE RUN
THEIR PARTNER'S HEALTH PLAN FOR
YOUNG ADULTS COVERED ON THEIR
PARENT'S PLAN BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX. UNDER THE ACA. IN
SOME INSTANCES THE PRIMARY
POLICY HOLDER MAY RECEIVE
INFORMATION. ABOUT CARE
PROVIDED THAT THE PATIENT DOES
NOT WANT REVEALED TO THAT
PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER. IN SOME
CASES IT WOULD BE EVEN
DANGEROUS FOR A PRIMARY POLICY
HOLDER TO RECEIVE INFORMATION.
ABOUT WHAT SERVICES THE PATIENT
HAS RECEIVED. FOR EXAMPLE. A
WOMAN WHO'S ACCESSING
REPRODUCTIVE CARE OR CARE
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
MAY NOT WANT HER PARTNER TO
KNOW SHE'S ACCESSING THAT CARE.
A TRANSGENDER YOUTH MAY NOT
WANT THEIR PARENTS TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE ACCESSING HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. THIS BILL UPDATES
EXISTING PATIENT PRIVACY LAWS
TO DO SEVERAL THINGS FIRST. IT
AUTOMATICALLY ENSURES A
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THE
INSURANCE COMPANY REGARDING
SENSITIVE SERVICES AS DEFINED
ARE CONFIDENTIAL. AND NOT SENT
TO THE PRIMARY POLICY HOLDER.
SO IT. EXISTING DEFINITION OF
SENSITIVE SERVICES TO INCLUDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE AND
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE.
EXTENDING AUTOMATIC
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THOSE
SERVICES AND THIRD. IT ENSURES
THAT PATIENTS WHO ARE RECEIVING
SENSITIVE SERVICES HAVE A
PATHWAY TO REQUEST CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS FROM THEIR
HEALTH PLAN. BUT I WANT TO BE
CLEAR SINCE WE'VE HEARD SOME
RECENT OPPOSITION SUGGEST
OTHERWISE THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE EXISTING MEDICAL CONSENT
LAW NOR DOES IT CHANGE THE AGE
OF CONSENT FOR ANY SERVICE. ALL
IT DOES IS ENSURE THAT FOLKS
WHO NEED CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS CAN RECEIVE IT.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR MAIN WITNESSES-
MOLLY ROBSON FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND CHRISTINE SMITH
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
TO END DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. BACK
TO CHURCH ALREADY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TWO- MISS ROBSON OR
MISS SMITH. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND WAS KIND OF FUNNY TO
CALIFORNIA. WE REPRESENT THE
SEVEN. BILLION TO SERVE NEARLY
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION.
PATIENTS ACROSS THE STATE EACH
YEAR. HUNDREDS SPONSORING
EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
BUILD ON THE IMPORTANT WORK OUT
BECAUSE THE MONIKERS UNDER
TOUGH IN THE PAST AT THE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AGO. THE END
OF THE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PATIENTS CONTINUE TO FIND IT
DIFFICULT ACTION SIDE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW. TO GAIN
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR THEIR
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S HEALTH
CENTRES CONFIDENTIALITY IS AT
THE CORE. OF ITS ROLE AS A
TRUSTED HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
WHEN PATIENTS SEEK. THEY MAY
NOT RE. THAT ABOUT THE THEY
RECEIVE MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE BY
REACHING OUT AND SAYS OUT AND-
THIS IS. TRUE FOR MINORS AND
YOUNG ADULTS FROM THEIR PARENTS.
ANYONE HAVE NAVIGATE COVERAGE
ISSUES WITH THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE KNOWS THAT IT'S NOT A
SIMPLE OR EASY PROCESS. EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL SHIFT
THE DEFAULT POSITION TO THE ONE
WHERE THE HEALTH PLAN
AUTOMATICALLY DIRECT
COMMUNICATION TO THE PATIENT.
RATHER THAN HAVE THE PRIMARY
SUBSCRIBER OF THE PLAN YOU
SHOULD RECEIVING CERTAIN TYPES
OF SERVICE AT. PERSONAL AND
CONFIDENTIALITY IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT ALL PATIENTS CAN
CONTINUE TO ACCESS NEEDED
SERVICES WITHOUT YOUR JUDGMENT
FOR THEIR DECISION. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS AND THEIR INFORMATION
OUR KATHY. PRETTY GREEN AND
THANK HER NONE OF THE PRODUCTS
ON THREE ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR AND.
WHATEVER JUST PART OF THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISS
SMITH. MISS SMITH IS NOT ONLINE.
I BELIEVE SHE IS WAITING FOR A
SPECIALIST- ALL RIGHT LORD I
DON'T SOMEWHERE ONLINE ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE GALLERY
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR NOT
SEEING ANY ROOM ONE TWELVE
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S KEEP THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ABIA LEVIN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTEEN ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
ONE NINE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FOUR OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINETY FOUR OH SIX. I
APOLOGIZE I'M GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE MATTER
NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF NERO
CLOSELY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THEN
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BACKER KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU CUL DE
IA
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE NUMBER THREE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT VENTURE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STITCHES NINE IN SPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
THIS IS TOMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
APPEAR IN THE PORT OF EIGHTY
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR YOU WOULD
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I DO NOT
SHOW ANYBODY QUEUING UP
RESEARCHER ALREADY THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF WE LOCATE
MISS CHRISTINE SMITH IF YOU LET
US KNOW AND WE MAY. REVERT BACK
TO HER- BEFORE WE TURNED
OPPOSITION I MEAN FOR AVOIDANCE
OF DOUBT A SALOON OR TO YOU YOU
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS THAT
CORRECT DOESN'T BEGIN YES HOW
ARE YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT- NOW LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION I SEE WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- AARON FRIDAY AND
STEPHANIE WATKINS. ARE EITHER
OF YOU ON THE PHONE. YEAH
FRIDAY ALL RIGHT MISS FRIDAY-
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ERIN
FRIDAY AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
BAY AREA CHAPTER OF PARENTS OF
RAPID ONSET GENDER DYSPHORIC
KIDS WE ARE PART OF A NATIONAL
GROUP WITH HUNDREDS OF PARENTS
WE ARE NOT A RELIGIOUS GROUP WE
ARE NOT TRANSPHOBIC OR ANTI GAY
IN FACT SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE. STRONGLY OPPOSED EIGHTEEN
I'M LEVIN EIGHTY FOUR BECAUSE
RETURNS AND TODAY. THE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO FORCE INSURANCE
POLICY HOLDERS MAINLY PARENTS
TO BE I'M WAITING CO
CONSPIRATORS AND THE
STERILIZATION OF THEIR OWN
CHILDREN. IT MAKES PARENTS
TACIT ENDORSERS OF EXPERIMENTAL
MEDICINE BEING USED ON THEIR
KIDS. THESE YOUNG ADULTS AND
KIDS HAVE BEEN MARRIED OF
MENTAL ILLNESSES INCLUDING
AUTISM THE TRAUMA. THESE YOUNG
ADULTS ARE INSTRUCTED THAT
PARENTS SHOULD QUESTION THEIR
OUT OF THE BLUE. TRANSNATIONAL
TRANSPHOBIC AND MUST BE
REJECTED. THIS IS WHY THEY SEEK
SPARE MENTAL TREATMENTS IN
SECRET. NO EVIDENCE BASED
STUDIES EXIST THAT PROVED THAT
CROSSSEX HORMONES. OR
SURGERIES ALLEVIATE GENDER
DYSPHORIA IN THE LONG TERM OR
LOWER SUICIDE RATE. IN FACT
STUDIES SHOW THAT SUICIDE.
SUICIDALITY INCREASES TWO FOLD
POST SURGERY. TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF D. TRANSITION OR ASSERT THAT
THEY DID NOT RECEIVE THE
PROMISED WOULD BE. FROM THEIR
GENDER DYSPHORIA. GENDER
CLINICS ALONG WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL HE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE
PERMANENT STERILIZATION. CAN
OCCUR IN AS LITTLE AS FOUR
MONTHS AFTER BEGINNING CROSS
SEX HORMONES. THEY HAD MEANT
THAT THE LONG TERM SIDE EFFECTS
ARE LARGELY UNKNOWN. NO
DISTRESSED YOUNG ADULTS CAN
UNDERSTAND THE LIFE ALTERING
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE
EXPERIMENTAL TREATMENTS.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD PROUDLY
STATE THAT NO MENTAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENT IS NEEDED BEFORE IT
NETS OUT. TO REALLY BE CAUSING
CROSS SEX HORMONES THE GENDER
CLINICS REQUIRE AT MOST ONE TO
TWO SESSIONS. TO PRY THE NAMELY.
CAUSALITY LEADER. WITH ONE TO.
ONE WINDOW INTO OUR PARENTS OUR
CHILDREN TO DISTRACT. LET US
GET THE MEDICAL TREATMENT FOR
KIDS BEFORE THEY EMBARK ON A
STATE SANCTIONED BULLET TRAIN.
TO STERILIZATION PLEASE REMOVE
GENDER IDENTITY FROM THE BILL.
DON'T REPEAT THE TRAGEDY BEING
ADDRESSED BY EIGHTY ONE ZERO
ZERO SEVEN TODAY. UNDER WHICH
THE STATE IS CONSIDERING PAYING
THIS FRIDAY POINTING ONLY DYING
TO READ MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM-
ALL RIGHT. MISS STEPHANIE
WATKINS ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. I
AM MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT MISS
WATKINS TO GO AHEAD MEMBERS. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STUDY WHAT CAN BE ON THE HALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. I'D LIKE
TO FIRST EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR
CONTINUED WILLINGNESS TO HEAR
OUR CONCERNS REGRETTABLY AS
ABILITY PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
STAGNANT REMAIN OPPOSED.
PREVIOUSLY REFERENCES MEASURE
SEEKS TO EXPAND THE MANNER IN
WHICH AND LOWER YOUR INSURER
CAN SUBMIT A REQUEST TO HAVE
THEIR MEDICAL INFORMATION
REDIRECTED TO AN ALTERNATIVE
ADDRESS OFTEN REFERRED TO AS A
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
REQUEST. AS WELL THE OBLIGATION
OF PLANT INSURANCE HONORS THOSE
REQUESTS. UNFORTUNATELY AT THE
START OF THIS PROCESS WE DID
NOT FULLY APPRECIATE HOW BROAD
THE INTERNET THE BILL WISE AND
HAVE MOSTLY FOCUSED ON PRIVACY
ISSUES RELATED TO SENSITIVE
SERVICES AND THE NEED AND
DESIRE TO UPDATE THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION. TO ENSURE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AND
SERVICES RECEIVED THE FULL
PROTECTIONS INTENDED BY THE
ORIGINATING LEGISLATION. AS
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER AT ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WAS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED
UNDERSTANDING THE CRITICAL
BALANCE OF ENSURING PATIENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO IMPORTANT
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. ALSO
PUSHING THAT MINISTRY TO BURDEN
THAT WOULD BE PLACED ON PLANT
MANAGER. AT LIMITING THE TYPE
OF ACCOMMODATION IS NOT IT IS
NOT EASY AS IT WOULD SEEM ONLY
REQUIRED INITIAL WORK AROUND BY
THE PLANS BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES
THE PLAN TO CONTINUE TO TRACK
EACH REQUEST TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMBINATION THING APPROPRIATE
MAKE KNOWLEDGE AND HONORED BY
ALL VENDORS. THE BILL CAMP THE
NIGHT OF THE OBLIGATION ON
PLANS ON A CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION REQUEST NO LONGER
BEING LIMITED TO TRANSIT
SERVICES BUT INSTEAD WILL BE
BROADLY APPLIED ALL CURRENTLY
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT TO
REQUEST DEFEATING OUR HEAD BUT
ALLOWS FOR REASONABLE STANDARD
TO BE APPLIED. WHICH ALLOWS THE
PLANTS SOME FLEXIBILITY ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR REMAINS THAT
FLEXIBILITY AND REQUIRES PLANS
AND ENSURE THE ON OR OFF USING
AN ART. UNKNOWN VOLUME OF
REQUESTS AS WELL AS THE
POTENTIAL ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AND COSTS THIS COULD PLAY SOME
PLANS AND INSURERS WOULD
CERTAINLY CONCERNING.
ADDITIONALLY THE MOST RECENTLY
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS INCLUDE AN
EXTENSIVE LIST OF NOTIFICATION.
REQUIREMENTS WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE IMPORTANT TO INSURE ALL IN
REALLY AND ENSURE THEIR WAY
THEY'RE RIGHT. NOW PROVISIONS
IN GO BY AND BEYOND WHAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED. WITH THAT IN
MIND WE WOULD LIKE TO.
CONVERSATION AROUND THE SECTION
ENSURE THE WE ARE IN A CERTAIN
THE INSIDE THE ROOM IF YOU'RE
CRAP BUT IN A PROPER. YES OF
COURSE. THANKS I'M WITH MIGHT.
HE TO LOOK FORWARD TO THE COME.
THANK ARE THANK YOU. BYE OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
GALLERY. GO AHEAD MY NAME IS
GREG BIRD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU BUDDY THANK YOU ANY
OTHERS IN THE GALLERY SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
IN OPPOSITION. ROOM ONE TWELVE
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
ONE EIGHT FOUR. SURE IF YOU'RE
IN A POSITION OF EIGHTEEN ONE
ONE EIGHT BORDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF THE THREE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHELLE
CONNOR LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA. IN
A LETTER OF OPPOSITION WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EPLF EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
TO BE LINED NUMBER TWO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAURIE I AM A LEGISLATIVE
INTERN FOR THE RIGHT FLANK
LEAGUE OF SOUTH- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE. THOSE
ALREADY THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FOUR TWENTY TWO PROBABLY ALL
THE ONE DOING THE- MANY
HARRINGTON. AND JOHN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. HERE'S. THE LINE
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY FIVE. GO
AHEAD AND ALL THE NADI. AND
WHAT ARE YOU CURRENTLY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT MODERATOR I THINK WE'VE
GOT A TWO LINES ON AT THE SAME
TIME- OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION. I AM
LOOKING FOR A- LINE HERE TO
MAKE SURE. HEY WE HAVE LINER
FOR TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE HAD.
OKAY THE DROUGHT FOR NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
SUSAN ARNOLD I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE WE GET
THAT IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER. THREE NINETY EIGHT. HI
I AM MARTY WELL LOIS AND I AM
WITH THE PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS
OF EATING DISORDER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND I AM STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE
NUMBER THREE NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
I AM CATCHING DAQO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FIFTY FIVE
FAMILIES THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHAPTER OF PARENTS OF RAPID
ONSET GENDER DYSPHORIC HITS
YOUR HEARD EARNED FRIDAY SPEAK
FOR US AS WELL TODAY I LIVE IN
RICHMOND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER. FOUR TWENTY. YES THE
BRAND THEN I CONCERNED HEARING
FROM RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DEFINITELY NOT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YES HELLO BUT ME YES IT IS
HI YES MY NAME IS VICTORIA
YOUNG AND I AM A CONCERNED
PARENT AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION I'M FROM CAMARILLO
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FOUR TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU FOR
CALLING OFF THE INSURANCE ON A
QUICKCALIFORNIA HEARING ABOUT
TRIAL TO IDENTIFY IT I
TRANSACTION AS AN ADOLESCENT.
MIGHT STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK
YOU MODERATOR IF YOU COULD GIVE
AN ESTIMATE AS TO HOW MANY
OTHERS ARE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
IN IN THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW
ALREADY THANK YOU. SURE MY
NUMBER FOR SIXTEEN. YES MARK
THE SHORTS WITH PARTNERS FOR
ETHICAL CARE AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU- TRANSCODER
TEACHER- CONCERNED PARENTS IN
STRONG UP THE DISPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS RENEE JASA MARA I AM
A BIG AREA CURRENTLY HE MAKES
THE TRANSITION- AND INSPIRON
DISPOSITION. OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR OH EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE I WAS
UNABLE TO GET IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE SUPPORT OF MY NAME IS ROXY
ANGLE NEVER CAN BE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND LEARN.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
AND THE LAST THING THAT WE HAVE
IN QUEUE IS THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- ALSO APOLOGIZE I AM
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SALE OF
MY NAME IS ELENA. MANUAL WITH
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE TRUMP THE
PORT OF EIGHTY ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR THANK YOU ALREADY THANK
YOU. OUR MODERATOR IF THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER- I DO NOT SEE ANY
MICROPHONES RAISED- IS THERE A
MOTION. SO IT GETS ALL THIS
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT-
SIMILAR TO THE U. KERR CLOSE.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AS I STATED BEFORE- WHILE I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS MAY HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON. THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY OF THE
RATE. OF LGBTQ YOUNG PEOPLE
JUST WANNA MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
CHANGE EXISTING MEDICAL CONSENT
LAWS IT DOESN'T CHANGE. WHAT
SERVICES A MINOR CAN CONSENT TO
WHAT IT DOES SAY IS IF A
PATIENT IS ABLE TO CONSENT TO A
SERVICE- WITHOUT THEIR PARENT
THE COMMUNICATIONS IN THAT
CARE. SHOULD BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT AND AGAIN-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SEVERAL
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SANDRA GONZALEZ MANAGE
ACCOUNTS RECALLED CALLED ROLE
YES THIS IS A B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER Q. WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALES
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. HI
BURGER I BOARDED. KELLY IT'LL
FOR ME AT- I DID ALSO. THE REST
SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG. HERTZBERG I'D JONES.
JONES NO LAYERED LEHRER DIE
SKINNER STERN WHY CASKEY Y.
CASKEY I. YOU HAVE SEVEN TO ONE
SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING
ALREADY THANK YOU. THE BILLS ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT- LET'S LET'S
JUST GO IN ORDER HERE SO THAT
THE FOLKS WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
OR WAITING KNOW WHERE WE'RE
HEADED- I SEE- I DO NOT SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HIM
BUT I DO SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT. AND I SAW I THOUGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM A LITTLE
WHILE AGO I SEE THAT- SO
REMEMBER HOLDING IT. THE OTHERS
ARE WAITING- ALL RIGHT. SO
LET'S LET'S TURN NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT BUT
BEFORE WE DO LET ME REVIEW THE
GROUND RULES HERE THE COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY TODAY IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPATION. OF WE'RE
ALLOWING FOUR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE DIVIDED BY TWO SPOKE TO BE
APPROPRIATED AS TWO TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
A WE MAY MAKE CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS BUT THE FOUR MINUTE
RULE WILL APPLY- WE WILL
PROVIDE EQUAL TIME TO EACH SIDE.
IN TERMS OF THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN A MEET TO FASHION A
WILL PROVIDE TEN MINUTES ON
EACH SIDE OF THAT TESTIMONY.
AND WHEN YOU TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT AS THEY WILL BE
REFERRED TO AS A E TOO IF YOU
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION. AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. SEVEN
MEMBERBENNETT YOU HAVE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A B. SEVEN ONE
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SAYS SPEAKER. OF
THE CHAIR WELL FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH- OUR OFFICE SAID
WE ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS A. B. SEVEN ONE SIX
MODERNIZES OUR COURT SYSTEM TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO ONE OF THE THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT. OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM REMAINS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF SOCIETY
DURING THESE UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES AND I THINK WE'VE LEARNED
TO COPE WITH THAT- THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT WE SHOULD AT
LEAST CONSIDER DOING
DIFFERENTLY AND COURT ACCESS IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE- IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY A KERN COUNTY
COURT COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO AN OPEN
HEARING. ALTHOUGH THE HEARING
WAS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC SOME
FAMILY MEMBERS AND OTHER
OBSERVERS WERE BARRED FROM
ENTERING HE COURT AND WERE NOT
PROVIDED WITH AN ALTERNATIVE TO
VIEW OR LISTEN TO THE HEARING.
SIMILARLY CONSTITUENTS FROM MY
OWN DISTRICT WERE DENIED REMOTE
PARTICIPATION TO VIEW AN OPEN
COURT PROCEEDING AS COURTHOUSES
PHYSICALLY CLOSED FOR
EVERYONE'S SAFETY DURING THE
PANDEMIC PUBLIC ACCESS TO FALL
OPEN LEGAL PROCEEDINGS THE
RIGHT UNDER THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION WAS BEING LIMITED.
A. B. SEVEN ONE SIX WOULD
REQUIRE COURTS TO PROVIDE
REMOTE ACCESS TO HEARINGS VIA
AN AUDIO STREAM TO OPEN
PROCEEDINGS STRIKING A BALANCE
BETWEEN MATING FULL ACCESS IN
COURT FLEXIBILITY. WITHOUT
LIMITING A JUDGE'S ABILITY TO
HOLD COURT CLOSED PROCEEDINGS-
WHEREVER IT IS APPROPRIATE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WITH ME TODAY IS LIBBY
SANCHEZ FROM SEIU. THANK YOU
SOME REMEMBER MISS SANCHEZ
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PLEASE STAND
HAS ON BEHALF OF THE SEIU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING COURT
REPORTERS EMPLOYED BY THE
COURTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SEVERAL BILLS CURRENTLY BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE WHICH ADDRESS
REMOTE APPEARANCES PRINT AND
PROCEEDINGS IN THE COURT WITH
ALL THE DETAILS WE HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE ABILITY
OF OUR COURT REPORTERS TO DO
THEIR JOB. THANK YOU THE
OFFICIAL VERBATIM RECORD
WITHOUT THIS RECORD PARTIES ARE
UNABLE TO FULLY EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS ON APPEAL WHICH CAN BE
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC. FOR
THOSE MOST LIKELY TO BE
DISENFRANCHISED THE INDIGENT
LIMITED ENGLISH LANGUAGE
SPEAKERS AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL WE LIVE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF. THE STAFF
IN BOTH HOUSES. WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY WITH US TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS THEREBY ENSURING
THAT THIS STILL STRIKES. A
BALANCE BETWEEN THE NEEDED THE
PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO OBSERVE
CERTAIN COURT PROCEEDINGS AND
THE NEED OF THOSE EMPLOYED BY
THE COURT TO BE POSTED FROM
HARM AND TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOBS. MANY OF YOU LIKELY HEARD
REPORTS OF THE RECENT
CONSERVATORSHIP. BRITNEY SPEARS
WITH FAMILY MIGHT NOT KNOW THAT
PROCEEDING WITH FULLY
TRANSCRIBED AND PUBLISHED.
TRANSLATIONS COURT REPORTERS
BUTINSTEAD BY SOMEONE NOT
OBLIGATED UNDER ANY LICENSING
LEGAL OR ETHICAL. I'M NOT SURE
IF YOU WILL THE SUBJECT OF SUCH
AN ON OFF SWITH TRANSCRIPT NOT
BEING A WELL KNOWN STARS BUT
INSTEAD OF BEING SUMMONED
MOTHER OR DAUGHTER. IMAGINE NOT
MOTHER OR DAUGHTER SUFFERING
FROM A DEEPLY PERSONAL MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ISSUES AFFECTING
THE RIGHT CHOICE HONEYMOON AND
LIBERTY IMAGINE THAT IN SUCH A
PUBLISHED TRANSCRIPTS IN USED
IN A LATER COURT PROCEEDINGS.
WHICH SUCH AUTONOMY OR LIBERTY
MIGHT BE DELLA TORIES FLEA AND
PERMANENTLY AFFECTED. BILL
PROTECTION AGAINST SUCH A
TRANSCRIPT EVER BEING USED IN
THIS WAY THERE BY PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF PARTIES TO
PROCEEDINGS I'M PROTECTING THE
SANCTITY OF THE OFFICIAL- BETA
BLOCKERS WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THE COURT'SPRIMARY OBLIGATION
IS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
WORKERS. THERE ARE. MYRIAD
ISSUES WHICH WILL ARRIVE AT THE
CORE CONTINUE TO RELY ON REMOTE.
FOR CORPORATE THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT AT LEAST YOU'LL BE IS
IMPORTANT ARE ADDRESSED SO THAT
PARTY TO PROCEEDINGS AND COURT
WORKERS DON'T HAVE TO DO YOUR
UPPER BODY. FOR MOTHER. AND
THEN IF THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHERS SUPPORT SAYING NO ELSE
AGAIN. IN ROOM ONE NO ONE INSP-
IN ONE TWELVE. DURING NOW THE-
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF B. SEVEN
ONE SIX ON THE PHONE LINE. UP
PLEASE MAKE YOURSELF KNOWN. AND
EVERY MINDERS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN PRESS THE ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY SEVEN ONE
SIX. AGAIN PRESS THE ONE THEN.
ZERO AND AT THIS TIME YOU DO
HAVE TO ONE MAKE YOU LOCAL
CHANNEL LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACKER KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOT HELLO TO LINE
THREE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE AND AT THAT
TIME THERE. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE ALL RIGHT LET'S TURNED
OPPOSITION THEN- WE HAVE AND
THE- LAVINE MOM MUSLIM IMAM.
I'M HERE I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANNUALLY WHEN BOMB ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
SIXTEEN AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED. WE OPPOSE THE ADDITION
OF LANGUAGE RELATED COURT
REPORTERS OFFICIAL BOOK
VERBATIM RECORDS AND EVIDENCE.
L. EIGHTY SEVEN ONE SIX WITH A
LAUDABLE EFFORTS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC ACT WITH THE COURT
PROCEEDINGS DURING AN
UNPRECEDENTED GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO CODE OF CIVIL
PROCEDURE SECTION ONE TWENTY
FOUR THAT ADDING ENTIRELY NEW
TOPIC. NAMELY THE INTEGRITY OF
THE OFFICIAL COURT TRANSCRIPT.
WHITE FIFTY ONE TWENTY FOUR IS
ABOUT OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
COURT PROCEEDINGS IT IS TRYING
TO BULLY AND RATHER ELEGANTLY
THE PRINCIPLE OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
HI THAT WAS ONLY MODEST
EXCEPTIONS LISTED IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE PUBLIC. ADDING
NEW TOPICS UNDER CUT THE FORCE
AND CLARITY OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
DIRECTIVES. THE ONLY MEMBER
BENEFITS ORIGINAL GOAL WITH
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTEEN LIKE TO
ENSURE THAT THE AFRICAN SECTION
ONE TWENTY FOUR WOULD BE
PRESERVED IN THE AGE OF
TECHNOLOGY. THE COURT EVEN WHEN
PHYSICALLY CLOSED DUE TO THE
MOST SERIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH
AS FIRES EARTHQUAKES GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WOULD REMAIN
ACCESSIBLE AND TRANSPARENT. IF
PASSED INTO LAW SOME FUTURE
COURT WILL BE ASKED TO REVIEW
THESE MISPLACED PROVISION THE
COURT WILL REVIEW THE LANGUAGE
AND IT WILL PONDER THE NEEDFOR
ANY REASON THE LEGISLATURE
ADDED NEW LANGUAGE ON A NEW
TOPIC WE'RE THERE ALREADY EXIST
EXTENSIVE STATUTORY PROVISION.
NEW STATUTORY LANGUAGE MUST
HAVE MEANING IT MUST AND THE
BODY OF EXISTING LAW AND THE
COURT IN EXERCISING THEIR
DUTIES LET'S TRY TO UNDERSTAND
AND GIVE EFFECT THE NEW
STATUTORY LANGUAGE. WE ARE
INVITED TO THE FAMILY MEMBER
GOT IT INTENDS TO WORK WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ADDRESS OUR
ISSUES AND WE CONTINUE TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR SUCH A MEETING
HOWEVER TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB SEVEN SIXTEEN AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. ALREADY
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY A
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ON
THE PHONE LINE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE TO
A. B. SEVEN SEVEN ONE SIX. AND
MAYBE TRYING TO AS IN MY IF YOU
WISH TO. PRESS THE ONE THEN.
AGAIN ONE THEN. AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE LOCAL
TIELINE TWO EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE AND
WORKING WITH THEM TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
KIA BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER SEEING NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- IS THERE A MOTION.
SETTER HERS BERG MOVES THE
BILL- ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT-
AND I KNOW YOU'VE- CONFIRM TO
US THAT YOU'RE GOING TO WORK
WITH JUDICIAL COUNCIL. TO
ADDRESS THIS TENSION THAT
NATURALLY EXIST BETWEEN PRIVACY
TRANSPARENCY AND THE
APPROPRIATE. ORDER OF THE
COURT- AND SO I TRUST THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHARE AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH- G. JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE-
VALUABLE INPUT ON THIS BILL.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE ALREADY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT MAN AND SHE
KILLS YOU CALL THE ROLL YES IS
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTEEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER BENNETT WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST.
AMEND AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE. HI AMBER I BOARD JESS.
PERRY AT ALL. THE RUSSELL. THE
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG FOR ITS BURGER I
JONES JONES I LAYERED. WHERE'D
I SKINNER STERN BY CAL SKI- YOU
HAVE. SIX ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WITH THE ON
CALL- ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S GO
THROUGH THE FIREWATER I DON'T
SEE LET'S SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAR QUE HAN SOLO MEMBER BLOOM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO- SOME
MEMBER CHAWL. THERE JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE STANDING AT THE
PODIUM WHY WOULD I RECOGNIZE
YOU DO SO ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM- EIGHTY
SEVEN TO ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR EIGHTY SEVEN TO ONE WILL
INVALIDATE DENSITY RESTRICTIONS
AND PRIVATE COVENANTS THAT DO
NOT ALIGN WITH LOCAL ZONING.
UNTIL THE MID TWENTIETH CENTURY
RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
WERE USED AS A TOOL TO
SEGREGATE AND RED LINE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS- DECISIONS AND
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAVE
MADE THESE RACIALLY RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS UNENFORCEABLE
HOWEVER. THESE COVENANTS OFTEN
CONTAIN OTHER VESTIGES OF
DISCRIMINATION SUCH AS LIMITS
ON THE NUMBER AND SIZE OF UNITS
THAT CAN BE BUILT. THE DENSITY
LIMITS ALSO CONFLICT WITH LOCAL
ZONING CODES THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. DESPITE THEIR
DISCRIMINATORY ORIGIN IN CLEAR
CONFLICT WITH LOCAL ZONING
DENSITY RESTRICTIONS ON HOUSING
COVENANTS REMAIN ENFORCEABLE
AGAINST AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER. AT SEVENTY ONE WILL
PROVIDE A PROCESS TO REMOVE
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING COVENANTS
AND ENSURE THAT WE BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS WHILE
PRESERVING AND STRENGTHENING
LOCAL CONTROL. THIS MEASURE
CLARIFIES THAT DENSITY
RESTRICTIONS IN PRIVATE
COVENANTS ARE UNENFORCEABLE
AGAINST A 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. UNDER AB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS WHO NO LONGER RESIDE
ON THE PROPERTY CANNOT USE
COVENANTS TO CURTAIL MUCH
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. WITH ME TESTIFIED
SUPPORTER BRANDON PAYETTE WITH
PUBLIC COUNSEL AND HAY SEUSS
HERNANDEZ WITH THE COMMUNITY
CORPORATION OF SANTA MONICA ARE
YOU MR PAYETTE. OR MR NANDO'S
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. ELEVEN
SENATORS- MY NAME IS BRANDON
HEY I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
ACCOUNT OPEN NATION'S LARGEST
PRO BONO EARNED. YOUR TRUST AND
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE- EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
CENTRIST DEMOCRAT POSITION OF
PROPERTY OWNERS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO BUILD THAT MUCH AUDIBLE
HELPING ON THEIR PROPERTY AT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION WILL
COMMIT. AND RAISE THE
DEVELOPERS FROM OUR PAST SHOULD
HAVE NO SAY IN THE DECISION.
MANY PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE RACIAL RESTRICTIONS THAT
WERE DESIGNED TO PROHIBIT
PEOPLE OF COLOR. UNFORTUNATELY
RESTRICTIONS THAT LIMIT
DEVELOPMENT ON A GIVEN PARTIAL
TO A CERTAIN NUMBER OF. ARE
STILL TREATED AS ENFORCEABLE
THAT EVEN IF THOSE PRIVATE
DENSELY RESTRICTION CONFLICT
WITH THE APPLICABLES RUNNING
CODE AND ARE CONTAINED IN THE
SAME DOCUMENT AS EXPLICITLY
RACIST RESTRICTION. EIGHTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE ADDRESSES THIS
PROBLEM BY IMPLEMENTING A
SIMPLE PROCESS REPORTABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO REMOVE
PRIVATE DEATH THE DESTRUCTION.
WITHOUT THIS PROCESS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WILL BE
FORCED TO CONTINUE WALKING
AWAY. FROM OTHERWISE IDEAL
PROJECT BACK. THE BILL WOULD
NOT MAKE ANY CHANGES THE LOCAL
DINING CULTURE LAND USE RULES
AND THE CAREFULLY CRAFTED MR
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION MEASURES
MEASURES. THAT LIMIT
DEVELOPMENT I MEAN IF. WE HAVE
A PUBLC COUNSEL ON THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR-
SEVEN TWENTY ONE TO CONTINUE
THE PROCESS. OF HIRING
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATORY. THANK YOU RT
THANK YOU MISS PAT SIR ANAND IS.
YEAH HELLO THIS IS THE HEAD TO
HEAD ON THIS HONORABLE
COUNCILMEMBERS I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF HELPING FOR COMMUNITY
CORPORATION OF SANTA MONICA WE
ARE A MIDSIZE NONPROFITS HAS
OPERATED AFFORDABLE HOW THE
AFFLUENT WEST SIDE OF LOS
ANGELES FOR ABOUT FORTY YEARS
NOW. I COULD START BY THANKING
A FAMILY MEMBER RICHARD
BLOOMBERG CHAMPION AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR MANY YEARS. MEEDER
SAID THAT CREATED MANY
QUALITIES THAT MAKE IT EASIER
TO DO OUR WORK AND INCREASINGLY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT
COMMUNICORP IS HERE TODAY AT
THE COSPONSORED EIGHTY SEVEN TO
ONE BECAUSE AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE SHOULD
POLICY MAKERS TOPICAL WE FACE.
IN HOPES THEY CAN BE FIX THE
ISSUES RAISED BY EIGHTY SEVEN
TO ONE PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE
BECAUSE THEY PERPETRATE THE
POLITICAL INTEGRATION OF
NEIGHBORHOOD AS AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER I HAVE
WITNESSED. A COVENANT WITH
EXTREMELY UPSETTING RACIAL
COVENANTS ALONG WITH THE
COMPANY TENTATIVE DESTRUCTION
MULTIPLE TRYING TO REMOVE SUCH
COMPANY CAN'T CALL A LOT OF
MONEY AND- AND EXTENDED A COURT
PROCESS AFTER PROPERTY ALREADY
ZONED FOR DESIGN FOR MULTI
FAMILY HELPING FUND THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WE SHOULD NOT BE.
WORKING WITH PRIVATE- PRIVATE
OWNERS IN ONE PROJECT IN
PARTICULAR THE PROPERTY ITSELF.
IS THE ONLY MULTI FAMILY. THE
ONLY THING IN THE WAY IS A-
OUTDATED- WHAT. WOULD OWNER
FROM THE NINE FOR. THAT
PROHIBIT MORE FAMILY. IT LOOKS.
OVER A HUNDRED UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAS NO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CURRENTLY. I
THINK FOR THE MANY COVENANTS
RECORDED IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE. OUR
COSPONSORED PUBLIC COUNSEL WHO
HAS EXPRESSED AN EXPLAIN MORE
ABOUT THE COMPANY THAT HAS
WORKED VERY HARD- VERY HARD AT
THE PROFIT SO THAT MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN BE
BUILT. WE CANNOT BEGIN TO
ADDRESS EXCLUSIONARY
NEIGHBORHOODS WITHOUT
ATTRACTING RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS WE ARE JUST A PORK
FAMILY MEMBERS. ALONE EIGHTY
SEVEN TO ONE AS A STEP TOWARD
TOWARD AND THE SECOND QUESTION
IS PACKED WITH THIS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR NANDO'S
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY SEEING NONE IN
SPAIN- ROOM ONE TWELVE ALSO
SEEING NONE. OF THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATE OR IF YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
SEVEN TWO ONE. AND MAYBE EVEN
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW.
FOR EIGHT SEVEN TWENTY ONE
PRESS ONE. ZERO NOW. AGAIN
LONDON ZERO. ANALYSTS SAID WE
DO HAVE TWO IN THE QUEUE- WE
HAVE ABOUT FOUR ACTUALLY WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE FOUR FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT
LEVEL OF KERR LINE FOR FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT COULD BE ON
THE HOT ONE. ARMY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND EARLY JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOR FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SADDAM S.
ROMMEL'S ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF B. B. SEVEN TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
MEXICO LOOK TO THE LINE THREE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EARLIER THIS IS- KIND OF THE
JOHN MUHAMMAD WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICAN SLAVE
DESCENDANT CLOCK ANGELA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MATER ANYONE ELSE ON
THE OTHER LINE I'M SORRY GO
AHEAD. YES SORRY ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE IN THE
QUEUE- WILL COMBINE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MEGAN- THE BERKELEY
TENANTS UNION AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO TO LINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ANNA BABY
OPEN UP CLOSE MEMBER OF SAN
FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO TO
LINE FOUR OH TWO PLEASE WELL I
HAD. REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER INSTRUCT THE-
THANK YOU. IN AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU. I HAVE ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION ANYONE. YEAH I SEE
NO WITNESSES LISTEN OPPOSITION
ANYWAY THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NON ROOM ONE
TWELVE SITTING NOT ON THE PHONE
LINE MATTER IS A NEW ONE THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO. AB.
SEVEN TWO ONE. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE PRESS
TO LONDON'S THERE ON NOW AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO TO UPHOLD. ONLY
TO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. LOCAL
CAROLINA FORD THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOR
THIRTY EIGHT AIRLINER THEY LEFT
THE QUEUE ONLY TO HAVE ONE MORE
QUEUING UP IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT. WILL NOT GO TO LINE FOR
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M ANGELA NIRVANA FROM
THE COALITION FOR JAZZ.
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO PRESS THE NUMBER SORRY
ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S
READ BACK TO THE CHAMBER-
SEEING NO MICROPHONES RAISED
CENTER CAL SKI. I DO HAVE A- A
QUESTION I GUESS THE POINT TO
MAKE IS WE HEARD THIS IN- A
HOUSING AND AT THE TIME I
RAISED THE CONCERNTHAT I HAD
THAT THAT THIS IS WELL THE
STAFF REPORT IS A WONDERFUL
TIME. EXPLAINING WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS IN THESE RESTRICTED
GOVERNMENT COVENANTS THE
SOLUTION IS TO VERO VERY
NARROWLY LIMITED REMOVAL THESE
COVENANTS WITH A HUNDRED
PERCENT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING I
GUESS AT THE TIME I REACHED THE
POINT THAT WHY WOULD WE NOT
ALLOW 50% AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
30% AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAUSE-
AS WE SEE THESE THESE OF. THESE
RESTRICTIONS ARE OF A POOR AND
TO THE TO WHERE WE I THINK MANY
OF US THINK OF CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND I SPENT SOME TIME THINKING
ABOUT AS HE DID SUPPORT THE
MATTER IN A IN HOUSING I'M GOOD
AT STAYING THE DAY AND I GUESS
IT'S A MINORITY VOTE BECAUSE I
WELL I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
INDICATING THAT. THEIR SPONSORS
ARE 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
BUT ENTHUSIAST AND BUILDERS I
THINK THAT THESE TYPES OF
RESTRICTIONS AND SOME OF THE
RECALL SOME OF THE TESTIMONY WE
HEARD TODAY FROM PEOPLE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THESE
REMOVED. I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCELERATE THAT AND ALLOW OTHER
TYPES OF DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD
COME IN TO REMOVE THESE
RESTRICTIONS AND NOT JUST A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO.
THAT'S THE REASON. FOR MY
EXTENSION ALREADY THANK YOU.
OTHERS I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES THEIR MOTION.
SENATORS ALSO MOVES THE BILL
ALL RIGHT- YOU COULD CLOSE SOME
NUMBER BELOW. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND- MEMBERS- I THINK
THIS IS AN INCREMENTAL BILL
THERE CERTAINLY ARE STEPS THAT
CAN BE TAKEN IN THE FUTURE AS-
THE SENATOR AND I DISCUSSED- IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE- WE'VE BEN
ABLE TO OVERCOME A SURPRISING
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT CAME UP
WITH THE BILL WITH RESPECT TO
LAND TRUSTS AND RECORDERS AND
SO I THINK WE'VE LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR. FUTURE WORK BUT
FOR NOW THIS IS ABOUT A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ARE EDGY THANK YOU THANK
YOU COUNSEL YOU CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS THE EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI. AMBER I PURCHASE.
BURGESS NO PARTY AT ALL. DID I
SELL. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ BY
HERTZ BERG HURTS BERG HI JONES
JONES NO LAYERED. LAYERED I
SKINNER STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI
MY CASKEY NOT VOTING- YOU HAVE
FOUR TWO TWO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. RT THANK YOU
PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT- SOME
MEMBER BLUM WE HAVE A. B. NINE
ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'D
LIKE TO- START JOB BY ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND A COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING. VERY-DILIGENTLY ON THOSE AMENDMENTS.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN WILL
ALLOW TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
CAPTURE IMAGES OF VEHICLES THAT
VIOLATE TRANSIT ONLY LANES AND
BLOCKBUSTER OPS. DESPITE CLEAR
MARKINGS AND SIGNAGE TRANSIT
ONLY LANES ARE FREQUENTLY
IGNORED. BUS ONLY LANE
VIOLATIONS AND PARKED VEHICLES
FORCED TRANSIT OPERATORS TO
MANEUVER AROUND CONGESTED LANES
AND MAKE DROP OFFS FURTHER FROM
THE CURVE. CURB VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE SERVICE DELAYS AND POSE
SAFETY ISSUES TO DRIVERS TO
RIDERS WHO NEED ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE AND TWO OTHER
VEHICLES AS WELL. CAMERA
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY HAVE SHOWN GREAT
SUCCESS IN REDUCING VIOLATIONS
AND IMPROVING TRAVEL TIMES.
BOTH PROGRAMS REPORTED CLOSE TO
IT 20% IMPROVEMENT IN ON TIME
PERFORMANCE AND SAW A REDUCTION
IN REPEAT VIOLATORS. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTEEN WILL PROVIDE
TRANSIT AGENCIES WITH A COST
EFFECTIVE TOOL TO ENSURE SAFE
AND RAPID BUS SERVICE
ESPECIALLY FOR BUSY STREETS
WHERE IN PERSON PARKING
ENFORCEMENT IS SIMPLY NOT
REALISTIC. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN ALSO CONTAINS
GUARDRAILS FOR CONSUMER AND
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. NEW
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS MUST GIVE
NOTICE TO THE PUBLIC ISSUE
WARNING NOTICES IN ADVANCE OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND PROVIDE
OPTIONS TO REDUCE OR WAIVE THE
COST OF CITATIONS. ADDITIONALLY
IMAGES OF VIOLATIONS CAN BE
RETAINED FOR NO MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS AND CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
PURPOSES OF PARKING ENFORCEMENT.
WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL INSURE LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CITATIONS WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
BUS RIDERS WITH ACCESS TO SAFE
AND RAPID TRANSIT SERVICE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. NINE SEVENTEEN OR MICHAEL
TURNER THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT LA METRO AND
STEPHEN JONES THE EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS REPRESENTATIVE AT AC
TRANSIT THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
TURNER- MISTER JONES. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS IS
MICHAEL TURNER ON BEHALF OF THE
LA COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM MENTIONED
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES TO A
FAULT INSTALL FRONT FACING
CAMERAS ON OUR VEHICLES TO
ASSIST WITH IMPORTANT FOR SMITH
PARKING VIOLATIONS IN TRANSIT
ONLY LANES. AND THAT BUS STOPS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR
WRITERS AND HOW THIS PROGRAM
FITS INTO THAT. IN LA COUNTY
60% 66% OF BUS RIDERS IDENTIFY
AS LATINO 15% IDENTIFY AS
AFRICAN AMERICAN THE MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF METRO'S BUS
WRITER IS LESS THAN EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR. THE
ABILITY OF THOUSANDS OF THESE
WRITERS IS BEING DELAYED BY
PEOPLE WHO PARK ILLEGALLY AND
BUS ONLY LANES. FOR A SINGLE
CAR THAT IS ILLEGALLY PARKED IN
THE BUS LANE UP TO EIGHTY BUS
RIDERS ARE DELAYED EACH MINUTE.
THAT'S ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND
RIDERS AN HOUR IF IT TAKES AN
HOUR FOR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO CLEAR THE BUS LINE. WITH
THIS ADORED EACH METRO ANOTHER
TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN PARTNER
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
ALREADY HAVE PARKING
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY THE ONE
IN REITERATE THAT WE ARE NOT
ISSUING THE PARKING CITATIONS
WERE WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY. WE'RE
SPONSORING THE MEASURE TO
AUTHORIZE THIS SO AS WE DEPLOY
TRANSLATOR TRANSLATED FORSMAN
PROGRAM BUT ALSO AS WE EXPAND
OUR- TRANSIT ONLY LANE NETWORK
WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER TWENTY
NINE MILES OF TRANSIT ONLY
LANES BUT THAT'S EXPANDING TO-
SIGNIFICANTLY. OVER THE NEXT- A
FEW YEARS TO OVER A HUNDRED
MILES. OF TRANSIT ONLY LANES
IMPROVING THE SPEED AND
RELIABILITY OF OUR BUS NETWORK
THROUGH THIS MEASURE WILL BE
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THAT
PROGRAM AND WILL HELP INCREASE
MOBILITY FOR MILLIONS OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
REDUCING CONGESTION. I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE ALSO THAT
ILLEGALLY PARKED CARS THE
SAFETY HAZARD BECAUSE ABOUT
SOMETIMES HAS TO SWERVE INTO.
TRAFFIC LANES IN ORDER TO- IN
ORDER TO THE VIA. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFY AND I
WILL STOP THEIR- THANK YOU MR
TURNER- MISTER JONES. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR STEPHEN JONES
AC TRANSIT EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
REPRESENTATIVE URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTEEN MILLION TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS RELY ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO CONNECT THEM
TO THEIR JOB MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS SCHOOLS AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL ACTIVITIES. BUT
TRANSIT SYSTEM CANNOT PROVIDE A
SAFE AND RELIABLE SERVICE TO
THESE WRITERS WHEN MOTORISTS
ILLEGALLY PARKED THEIR CARS IN
TRANSIT ONLY LANES OR TRYING TO
STOP. ILLEGAL PARKING MAKES
TRANSIT LAISSEZ LESS RELIABLE
LESS ACCESSIBLE. AND LESS
EQUITABLE EIGHTY TRANSIT 65% OF
OUR WRITERS ARE LOW INCOME AND
75% OF PEOPLE OF COLOR. NEARLY
HALFOF OUR WRITERS DON'T EVEN
HAVE ACCESSTO A WORKING
VEHICLE. THE FACT IS IT IS THE
PUBLIC TRANSIT RIDERS WHO
SUFFERS THE MOST WHEN MOTORISTS
DELIVERY TRUCKS AND RIDE SHARE
SERVICES PARK ILLEGALLY AND
ABOUT THEM. CURRENT LAW A LOT
OF THE TRANSIT USE CAMERAS TO
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL PARKING IN
THE TRANSIT ONLY LANES OF OUR
NEW BUS RAPID TRANSIT SYSTEM.
THE CAMERAS ARE WORKING. ON
AVERAGE WE ISSUE LESS THAN FOUR
TICKETS PER DAY ON A LINE THAT
CARRIES SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED RIDERS PER DAY AND IT'S
PROJECTED THE CITY CARRYING AS
MANY AS ELEVEN THOUSAND RIDERS
PER DAY. OUR AVERAGE ON TRACK
PERFORMANCE EXCEEDS 80% AND
WE'VE RECEIVED ZERO PRIVACY
COMPLAINTS. EVERY DAY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE RIDE OUR BUS RAPID
TRANSIT SYSTEM BUT THE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE WILL DELIVER
THEM SAFELY AND ON TIME GOOD
JOB SCHOOL COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND MORE. ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO
RIDE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
DESERVE THIS LEVEL OF SERVICE.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY WILL HELP
ENSURE THE TRANSIT RIDERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
BENEFIT FROM A SAFER MORE
RELIABLE MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
MORE EQUITABLE PUBLIC TRANSIT
SYSTEM I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTEEN THANKS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION RT THANK
YOU MISTER JONES OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN. THING NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE
IN SPORT. EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN. LADIES AND JOHN I'M IF
YOU WERE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTEEN NINE ONE SEVEN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN LONDON
ZERO. AND LEAVE DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT. FIFTEEN AND THEY Q.
LOCAL COMBINED FOR FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR CURRENT
MEMBERS SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND FIND WORK
THANK YOU THANK YOU. KNECHTEL
MULTI LINE FOR FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ANASTASIA KOWALCZYK WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS FROM BEHALF
OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOSHUA SHOP FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
INCLUDING OUR SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
AND AS WELL THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MAXIMO TIELINE AT THREE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HE MAY BE NEEDED. MAXIMO
TIELINE FOUR THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS DEFAULT COMING UP THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR COURTNEY
TRANSPORTATION WILL SUPPORT THE
BABY NINE SEVENTY THANK YOU
THANK THANK YOU. MAXIMAL
TIELINE FOUR THIRTEEN PLEASE
CALL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MOIRA TOP
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO
LINE FOR SIXTY PLEASE FOLLOW
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FALCONS ALL THIS ON BEHALF OF
LONG BEACH TRANSIT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TIELINE Q.
FOURTEEN PLEASE GLAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
PRINCETON RELIGION THESE ARE
STATE AND STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
DRIED UP. THANK YOU NOT AT ALL
ALIGNED FOR FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATTHEW CYBERLINK ONLY
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
PARKING ASSOCIATION OR THANK
YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE FOR SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HERE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN
MAXIMO TO LINE FOR SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE
MAY BE NEEDED. HELLO EVEN
MILLER- TURNS AROUND IN SAN
FRANCISCO ONE OF WHICH SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU. IN MAXIMO
TIELINE TWO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITH THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN A
CAP RATE ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S BRIDGING
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAXIMAL CAROLINE FOR SIXTY TWO
PLEASE CALL I HAD. THIS IS
DEREK PAGE ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
BAKERY THAT WRITERS UNION IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TIELINE THREE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS- AMERICA ON THE
RESIDENTS OF A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR HENRY STERN IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. SH
AND AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE ALREADY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATE WE'RE
GONNA TURN OUT TO OPPOSITION
BUT FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU AND
WELCOME TO OUR GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE
YOU HERE PARTICULARLY YOUNG
PEOPLE SAYING THEIR GOVERNMENT
WORK ALL RIGHT. LET'S TURN NOW
TO OPPOSITION- WE HAVE TWO IN
OPPOSITION- FIRST OF AT LEAST
THE MAIN OPPOSITION FIRST UP.
REAL SHARP. REAL SHARP IN
BECCA- KRAMER MILDER. OR EITHER
YOU BILLABLE. YES THIS IS REAL
SHARP GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WE ARE SORRY I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA I WORK WITH PEOPLE
BURIED UNDER THE WEIGHT A
PARKING VIOLATION FOR MY CLIENT
THE VIOLATIONS ARE A TREMENDOUS
SOURCE OF INSTABILITY PASSING
THIS BILL WOULD SEVERELY
BURDENED LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
BY GREATLY INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS ISSUED AN
IMPOSING MANY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THAT. THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS ISSUED
PRELIMINARY DATA FROM AC
TRANSIT SHOWS A FOUR HUNDRED
AND 70% INCREASE IN THE TYPES
OF VIOLATIONS ISSUED THROUGH
THE PILOT PROGRAM THE
TECHNICIANS WILL BURN SOME MORE
THAN OTHERS LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WILL BE HIT HARD BECAUSE THESE
TEMPTATIONS DEPRIVE THEM OF A
LARGER SHARE OF THEIR INCOME
GIG WORKERS WILL BE ESPECIALLY
AFFECTED I'M BLACK AND BROWN
WOMEN WILL PAY A STEEP PRICE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THEY BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF LEGAL
THAT. WHETHER OR NOT THEY
RECEIVE THE VIOLATION VIOLATION
CAP CATASTROPHIC IMPACT FOR
THOSE WHO MANAGE TO PAY THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR VIOLATION
THE MONEY MAY COME OUT OF FOOD
BUDGET- RANTS OR CHILD CARE
COSTS- PERMANENT LAND WHICH IS
NOT A FAIR TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS LYING AROUND FOR
THOSE WHO CAN'T MANAGE TO PAY
THE IMPACT EVEN WORSE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION CANNOT BE RENEWED
IF THERE'S OUT AND PARKING
VIOLATION. TO THOSE TICKET TO
THIS PROGRAM WHO DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY- COULD LOSE THE
ABILITY TO DRIVE AND AS WELL AS
ANYBODY WHO RELIES ON THAT
VEHICLE COULD LOSE THE ABILITY
TO DRIVE THERE BY THREATENING
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO WORK AND
GET THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL THE
BILL SPONSORED SUGGESTS THAT
ALL OF THIS WILL BE BLUNTED BY
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT OPTIONS FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT LARGELY ON TRAIL IT'S
OUR EXPERIENCE THAT ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM. AVAILABLE TO
THOSE WITHOUT LAWYERS ARE
SPARSELY USED ANDCAN'T
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF BEING
USED AND PUNISHMENTS FOR NON
PAYMENT BEST PRACTICES IMPOSE A
STEEPLY DISCOUNTED TO BE
AUTOMATICALLY OR ISSUE WARNING
AFTER THE FIRST. DEFENSE NOT
VIOLATIONS. THOSE ARE SUPPOSE
SHARE YOUR COME TO POWER
TRANSIT WE SHOULD EFFICIENT
RELY STATE AND SUSTAINABLE OP.
WE DO COMPLETE FOCUS ON OTHERS.
FOR THEM. BUT USING AUTUMN AND
FOR. TO INCREASE TRANSCRIBING
WILL HARM MANY OF THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT TRANSIT
AGENCIES SEEK TO SERVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT- WE HAVE A
BECCA KRAMER MODERN. MISS
KRAMER MILDER ARE YOU AVAILABLE.
IF YOU ARE NOT WE COULDN'T WE
COULD TURN TO OTHER OPPOSITION
THEN COME BACK TO YOU- OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO WITNESSES
OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR IF WE FIND- MISS
KRAMER MILDER IF YOU ALERT US
OTHERWISE- WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO OTHERS. IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE BACK ON
THE LINE. ALL RIGHT HELLO
BACKGROUND. YOU MIGHT BE NEEDED
ON YOUR END. ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
NOW. ALL GREAT. I'M EITHER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION EIGHTY
NINE ON THAT AND SEE IF WE
COULD CONSTRUCTIONS IN TRANSIT
ONLY LANES BY RELYING ON THE
FALSE NOTION THAT INCREASED
SURVEILLANCE IS AFFILIATION BUT
THE FIVE HUNDRED OKAY THEN
TENSION EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN
GOES OO FAR BY FOSTERING THE
USE OF SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY.
FOUNDERS AND FUNDERS THAT MAKE
SENSE OF THE RAP THAT THING
HURTING THE USE OF SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE CAMERAS ON
PUBLIC BUSES AND A. L. PRT V.
NINE NINE SEVEN RELIES ON THE
FALSE NOTION FOR ME ON BENEFITS
THE COMMUNITY THAT ARE
AVAILABLE I COULD HOWEVER
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
USED AGAINST THE VERY
CONSTITUENCIES. LANDLORDS ARE
THINKING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
OAKLAND WHERE WE CAMERAS WERE
INSTALLED ON A LINE THAT RAN
THROUGH THE CITY WELL IT.
HAPPENED IN KANSAS HAS. RED
LIGHT CAMERA PROGRAM OFFERED.
TALE YEAH I THAT FOR ME ON.
TRAFFIC FROM. WELL THERE ARE
BEEN IN. RADIO CHECK I'M- STUDY
SHOW THAT RED THEY CAN'T ACT IN.
CERTAIN TYPES OF COLLISION.
WHAT I'M WORKING CONSEQUENCES
MAY EIGHTY NINE MONTHS AND THEN
SURVEILLANCE. BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO THE CRIPPLING
FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS UNABLE TO PAY THE PRICE
OF THE TICKET. IT IS NINE ONE
SEVEN GOLD MAYBE MAKING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION MORE EFFICIENT
IS IMPORTANT BUT THEY'RE NOT.
THEY'RE NT THE SOLUTION I LOVE
IT AND SO IN OUR OFFICE FIND
OUT THERE ARE MORE EFFECTIVE
WAYS OF ACHIEVING CLEAR HAND
THE ONLY LANE SECTION
INSTRUCTING HER GO MEDIAN
PREVENT CARS FROM PARKING
ILLEGALLY. BY ADDING MORE MINDS
THAT CLEARLY INDICATE WHEN AND
WHERE MOTORISTS WHO PARK.
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THOSE
METHODS INSTEAD OF SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY. TEN EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN. THE COMMITTEE MAN PUTS
ON A PILOT PROGRAM REQUIRE
EIGHT RECORD ON MY IMPACT
EITHER. AND PROVIDING A MY OF
NOTRE IT BOB AND THEN TAKE A-
EASY FOR YOU SOME OF THE- OF
DELL. WHEN LAYING WHEN THEY
EIGHTEEN ONE. SIX AGAIN ACROSS
THE STATE WE ARE UNABLE TO GO
NEUTRAL ON THE. BILL YEAH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION- AGAIN KNOWN IN THE
GALLERY KNOWN A ROOM ONE TWELVE
OTHERS ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO UPHOLD
THE EIGHTY YEAR NINE ONE SEVEN
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE ON NOW
AGAIN THIS IS FOR OPPOSITION OF
THE EIGHTEEN NINE ONE SEVEN. SO
WE NEED TO HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN
THE CUBICLE CAROLINE FOR FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WINE FOR
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY BE NEEDED. ARMANI YES YOUR
HONOR. NO ONE IS ON THE LINE TO
SHOW ME MY NUMBER SO WE ARE ON
THE NUMBER. OKAY YOU'RE- DOING
A- EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE
THANK YOU ALREADY THANK YOU.
THE MAXIMO CAROLINE AT THREE
SEVENTY NINE THE THOUGHT HAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
MEMBERS DANIELLE KENDO CARTER
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION
RESPECTIVELY IN A POSE. THANK
YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
MAXIMO CAROLINE FOR FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JUDY FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SAFER STREETS LA ECHOING ACLU'S
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY WELL SPRING
BACK TO FLOOR CAESAR WHITE
HOUSE HIS MICROPHONE UP. YES I
AM MR SURE I'M A LITTLE TORN
HERE BECAUSE ON THE ONE SIDE I
WANT TO SEE THE- BUS LANES
FLOWING QUICKLY BUT- THE-
AFFORDABLE R. OR- PEOPLE
REPRESENTING POOR PEOPLE OF MY
DISTRICT AND IN MY COUNTY HAVE.
APPROACHED ME ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY HAVE SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS. LOOKING
ON THE SIDE OF THE IMPACT OF
THE PEOPLE WHO DRIVE THE CARS
AND PARK THEM OR OR INDEED. THE
CARD. THE BUS LANE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS OF PEOPLE OF FAT AND I
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS TO THE
AUTHOR TO GIVE IT A SIXTY DAY
LIMIT BUT ONE OF THE- ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT THEY HAVE IS
THAT THEY CAN GIVE PEOPLE
WARNINGS BECAUSE A LOT OF. A
KID PEOPLE WARNING WHEN THEY'RE
PARKED CARS PARKED THERE AND
THERE COULD BE ALL THESE
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT-
OUTLINED IN THE STAFF REPORT
RATHER THAN JUST A PICTURE OF
THE CAMERA AND I WAS WONDERING
I KNOW THAT THAT AMENDMENT
WASN'T TAKEN I WAS WONDER IF I
COULD HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR. ON
THE- ONE FREE PASS OR WHATEVER
WHICH EVERYONE A CALL AFTER THE
SIXTY DAY PROHIBITION. THE
WARNING TICKET. YEAH THE- OTHER
NUMBER BELOW LET ME- DEFER TO
US STEPHEN JONES FROM AC
TRANSIT. ONE OF THE- THE IDEA
OF A WARNING TICKET- FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARK ILLEGALLY
IN BUS ZONES WHAT MEAN THAT
TRANSLATED TO- WOULD HAVE TO-
MAINTAIN OR SPECIFICALLY LONG
COURSE IT WOULD HAVE TO
MAINTAIN A DATABASE TO IDENTIFY
THOSE PEOPLE- BEEN HAVE MAYBE
EARNED ASECOND FOR YOU KNOW
THE FIRST FINE BECAUSE WE WOULD
NEED TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY-
WARNING TICKETS. WERE- I
COULDN'T IT WILL. AND THEN
MAINTAIN THAT DATABASE SO THAT
IF THAT PERSON- VIOLATES THE
BOSS OF ME DOING AGAIN BUT WILL
NEED TO KNOW THAT WELL THEY'VE
JUST TURNED THEIR OFFICIAL
FIRST. I NEVER. THOUGHT I WOULD
YOU KNOW REQUIRE INDEFINITELY
THE MAINTENANCE OF A DATABASE
AND WE HAD NO INTEREST IN DOING
THAT. SO WHAT I KNOW OF THE AC
TRANSIT HAS A- A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT IS BEING INCORPORATED INTO
SOME BIG AND BEING MADE
PERMANENT I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE FOR THE AUTHOR
FOR AC TRANSIT IS THAT. MY
FIGURES SHOW THAT THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY SHERIFF'S HAVE GIVEN OUT
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY KITS THAT
WERE ISSUED BY THESE CAMERAS-
AND MANY OF THEM AS THE
OPPOSITION HAS POINT OUT OF
MANY OF THEM ARE TO LOW INCOME.
IN THREE YEARS SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN THERE'S ONLY BEEN
THIRTY TWO PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN THE IN THE LOW
INCOME PAYMENT PROGRAM- AND IT
JUST SEEMS IN ONE YEAR SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHT TICKETS IN
THREE YEARS THIRTY TWO PEOPLE
SO NOBODY. I THINK IT'S IT IT
APPEARS THAT THE PROGRAM IS
THERE SO WE WANT TO HAVE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE MAKE A LITTLE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR PAYMENT A
MONTH BUT NOBODY'S DOING IT AND
I WAS WONDERING IF ALAMEDA
COUNTY COULD RESPOND TO. THAT
MEEKER PARTICIPATION RATE. YEAH
SO I THINK WHAT WE SEE IS THAT-
WELL FIRST- WE DON'T KNOW THE
FINANCIAL STATUS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECEIVE THE
TICKETS- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
REFERENCE THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINE TO GET THE MACHINE. THIS
YEAR- BUT LET ME LOOK- DISTRICT
WIDE AT THE TICKET THAT- I'M
SORRY THE INDIVIDUALS WHO DO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LOW INCOME
PLAN- PROGRAM- WE SEE THAT-
THEY ARE- NOT PAYING ON THEIR
NOT PARTICIPATING. THE PAY DOWN
THE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS
FINE DISSOCIATED WITH. OUR
CAMERA PROGRAM- THEY'RE PAYING
FOR- FIND ASSOCIATED WITH FOR
EXAMPLE MAYBE PARKING AT A- BUS
STOP ORNATE NA- HANDICAP LOAN.
AND THAT INFRACTION COULD BE.
ANYWHERE THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT NOT ONLY LONG ARTICLE
B. R. T. LINE. SO I THINK WHAT
WE HAVE HERE REALLY IS A
SITUATION WHERE. THE ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS FINE-
WELL NOT INSUBSTANTIAL IS
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE IS A
LITTLE MORE MANAGEABLE FOR
FOLKS- AND THAT- FOR THE FOLKS
WHO ARE. PARTICIPATING. IN THE
LOW INCOME PAYMENT PLAN. THERE
DOING SO DOING THEIR INSTALL
THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR DID NOT.
AND AND AGAIN YOU DON'T REALLY
SEE- YEP AGAIN THE CROSS
MILITARY TO INDIVIDUALS OVER
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF YEARS
OR SO- PARTICIPATED IN THAT
PLANT SO IT'S REALLY. ABOUT
PLANNED- THE PARTICIPANTS-
OPTUS STADIUM TO PAY DOWN THE
LARGER FINES. I GUESS I GUESS
MR CHERRY IT'S CONCERNING
BECAUSE THE APP THE OPPOSITION
IS POINTING POINTING OUT THAT
THEY BELIEVE THAT THE HEAVY
BURDEN IS GONNA FALL ON LOW
INCOME DRIVERS AND WOMEN WOMEN%
OF COLOR THAT HAVE ALL THESE
DUTIES IN TRYING TO PARK THE
CAR AND GET IN THERE THAT
THAT'S IT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
RECONCILING WHAT THE- AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE. PAYING THE
FINE SIR- ARE NOT PROTESTING
THE LOW INCOME PROGRAM ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
WHAT CAL STATE SENATOR ALSO.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I'M
SORRY I MISSED THE BEGINNING OF
THIS CONVERSATION- AND I JUST
WANT TO ALSO I THINK OF THE
ISSUE THAT'S BEEN RAISED IS THE
IMPACT ON THE POOR PEOPLE- I
SERVED ON. I SERVED ON A
WALLACE CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB
FIVE AND WE TOOK SEVERAL
ACTIONS- ACTUALLY THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET- TOOK BUT-
ACTION BUT ON THIS BUDGET WE
TOOK AN ACTION OF. INCREASING
FROM TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. TO
HELP THE TRAFFIC AND NON
TRAFFIC IN OUR INFRACTIONS AND
SO HERE WE ARE PAIN BECAUSE
PEOPLE AREN'T ABLE TO PAY. FEES
BOTH FOR TRAFFIC AND NON
TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS IT'S A DEBT
THAT BUILDS ON THEM PERSONALLY
IT'S A DEBT THAT WE'RE ONLY
KIDDING OURSELVES AND NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO PAY OFF BUT THERE'S-A REAL IMPACT ON THEIR ON THEIR
LIVES THERE'S AN IMPACT ON. IF
YOU HAVE THESE TICKETS YOU CAN
GET REGISTRATION FOR YOUR CAR
BECAUSE YOU HAVE AN OUTSTANDING
PARKING FEE- AND THERE'S A
PENALTIES COULD BE AS HIGH AS
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS SO-
I AM. EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE EXPANSION OF THIS- EVEN IF
THERE'S A SUNSET DATE- THAT'S
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS- THAT PEOPLE
OF DEBT- THEY COULD GET THE
TICKET THEY COULD STAY ON THERE
STAY ON THE RECORDS AND THAT SO
I THINK VERY DETRIMENTAL SO
I'M- SORRY I'M SURE THERE'S A
RESPONSE FROM THE AUTHOR. SEVEN
NUMBER BLOOM YES- THANK YOU FOR
THE- QUESTION THE- THAT THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- WAS OF
CONCERN IN THE LAST THE- A
COMMITTEE AND WE ADDRESSED IT
BY- REQUIRING OPTIONS TO REDUCE
THE FINE OR WITH- EVEN WAIVE
THE TICKET TO- IN CIRCUMSTANCES
THEN THE- AGENCY WOULD HAVE THE
DISCRETION. TO DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS IN THE PROPER
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND THE- UHHUH WE
BUILT IN A SIXTY DAY PUBLIC
EDUCATION PROGRAM- IT WAS A
THIRTY NOW- WITH THAT TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS A SIXTY DAY WARNING
CITATION PERIOD AND- AS I SAID-
OPTIONS MUST BE PROVIDED IT'S
NOT DISCRETIONARY IT'S- THAT
OPTIONS MUST BE PROVIDED TO
REDUCE OR WAIVE THE COST OF A
CITATION. FOR THOSE WHO NEED TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
PROVISIONS I WOULD- ASK MEMBERS
TO TAKE NOTE THAT TRANSIT
RIDERS THEMSELVES ARE
PREDOMINANTLY LOW INCOME AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN LA
COUNTY. 66% OF BUS RIDERS
IDENTIFIES LATINO 15% AS
AFRICAN AMERICAN IN THE MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF METRO'S BUS
RIDERS IS LESS THAN EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND FOR
AC TRANSIT THE STATISTICS ARE.
ARE SIMILAR. HAVE THESE ARE THE
MAIN BENEFICIARIES LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS ARE THE MAIN
BENEFICIARIES OF THIS BILL THEY
DESERVE SAFE EFFICIENT BUS
SERVICE AND THIS BILL TRIES TO
DRAW THE RIGHTBALANCE- THE
ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD POINT
OUT IS THAT- OF THOSE TICKETS
THAT WERE ISSUED MANY OF THOSE
WERE SURELY DELIVERY DRIVERS
WHO ARE DELIBERATELY VIOLATING
CUT THE BUS ONLY LANES AND- AND
TNCS AS WELL WHO ORGANISED IT
OTHER MAKING A LIVING- OUT
THERE ON THE STREETS AND I
REALIZE THAT FOR MANY OF THEM
IT'S TOUGH BUT THEY CAN'T BLOCK
BUS ONLY LANES IN THE PROCESS
AND TO- THEY WILL BE THE FIRST.
TO TAKE HEED OF WARNINGS I
BELIEVE AND IT- AND TO NOT
CONTINUE VIOLATING. RIGHT NOW
IT'S JUST TOO EASY TO VIOLATE
AND THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
PROLIFERATION OF VIOLATIONS AND
BUS ONLY LANES. THANK YOU SO
NUMBER OF SIR JOHN'S. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MR BLOOM I'VE
I'VE BEEN REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH THIS BILL AS WELL AS-
GOING BACK AND FORTH ON AND I
ACTUALLY CAME IN HERE- THIS
AFTERNOON OPPOSED TO IT BUT-
YOUR- OPENING WITNESS SAID
SOMETHING THAT PIQUED MY
INTERESTED I'D I'D MISSED IN
THE ANALYSIS IN THAT- IT'S NOT
THE- TRANSIT AGENCY THAT'S
ISSUING THE CITATION IT'S- A
LOCAL AGENT LA I. I'D LIKE FOR
YOU TO EXPAND ON THE
EXPLANATION THE LOCAL AGENCY
THAT IS AUTHORIZED. TO ISSUE-THE CITATIONS AND THEN ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS. I APPRECIATED
ABOUT THE BILL EVEN BEFORE
COMING AS IT HAS TO BE REVIEWED
BY A HUMAN BEING- IT'S ON
AUTOMATIC- TICKET LIKE THE RED
LIGHT TICKETS- USED TO BECAUSE
I'M I WAS ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO
THOSE- SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN THOSE
TWO THINGS- WHO WHO HAS THE
AUTHORIZATION TO REVIEW THE
VIDEO IN EACH OF THE CITATION
AND WHAT AGENCIES. HAVE THE
AUTHORIZATION TO ISSUE THE
CITATIONS AND I AND BEFORE ALL
THAT I WANT TO SAY THAT I.
AGREE WITH YOU IN YOUR ANSWER
TO THAT- CONCERNS ABOUT THE LOW
INCOME FOLKS BEING CITED VERSES
THE LOW INCOME FOLKS ARE RIDING%
ON THE BUS BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE
ONE PERSON IT'S INCONSIDERATE
AND PARKS. IN THESE BUS LANES
YOU'VE GOT DOZENS OF PEOPLE ON
THE BUS- THAT MAY BE LATE TO
WORK OR- A CHILD'S- DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT THE- IN. I THINK WE
GET WE NEED TO BALANCE THAT SO
I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT ANSWER
BUT BACK TO MY QUESTIONS THE
PERSON WHO. IS AUTHORIZED IN
THE AGENCY THAT OPERATES PLEASE
ONE ANSWER FOR TO A MISTER
TURNER. WHO AGREES THAT ISSUE
INITIALLY. OUR MISS TURNER
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU-
THIS IS MICHAEL TURNER YEAH
THIS WE SET THIS UP IN A IN A
WAY. WHERE WE WOULD WANT TO SET
THIS UP RATHER IN A WAY WHERE
WE WOULD METRO WOULD NOT BE
DOING. ANY OF THE PARKING UP
ENFORCEMENT THE S. THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ENSURING THE
TICKET. WOULD REMAIN WITH THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY WHICH IN
OUR CASE IS MOSTLY THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. SO WE WOULD- THE
ROLE WE WOULD PLAY WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY THAT THERE WAS A
PARKING VIOLATION. AND IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- OR
WHATEVER CITY THE- FACILITY IS
pTICKET THROUGH THEIR NORMAL
PROCESS THESE AND- OR THEY
WOULD VALIDATE THE TICKET AND
THEN ISSUE THE TICKET. THROUGH
THEIR NORMAL PROCESS THESE BUT
THEY WOULD ALSO PROCESS
WHATEVER FINE- FEE WAIVER WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE. CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THIS THE PERSON THAT IS
AUTHORIZED. TO REVIEW THE VIDEO
AND- ISSUED A CITATION. YEAH WE
WOULD- COORDINATE THAT WE
HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED WHO EXACTLY
WOULD DO THAT WHETHER THAT
WOULD BE A METRO EMPLOYEE OR A
CITY OF LOS ANGELES EMPLOYEE-
BUT THERE WOULD BE A HUMAN THAT
REVIEWS- THE VIOLATION TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S VALID BUT IT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE A POST
OFFICE OR IT COULD JUST BE A-
AN AGENCY STAFF MEMBER THAT'S
TRAINED. IN THIS PARTICULAR. I
THINK MY PREFERENCE WOULD BE
FOR TO BE A POST OFFICERS SO
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THE- BUT-
I'LL LET YOU ANSWER TO THAT.
SEVEN NUMBER BELOW. ALLAH LET
MISTER TURNER RESPOND TO THAT.
YEAH I MEAN WE WOULDN'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT IT WAS A POST
OFFICER. ALL RIGHT- AND I SEE
ALSO- SET A COUPLE EUROS
MICROPHONES UP AND TURNED. YEAH
I APPRECIATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL I YOU KNOW
I LOOK AT IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY AND I AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LAST COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO MAKE
MANY OF THE- OF THE ISSUES THAT
YOU MADE WHICH IS THAT- WHAT.
THIS REALLY IS A BALANCE
BETWEEN- BETWEEN HAVING PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE RULES
AROUND WHERE YOU CAN. WHERE YOU
CAN DRIVE AND WHERE YOU
SHOULDN'T BE DRIVING IT- OF
SINK OR A FAMILY CAR BECAUSE
IT'S A IT'S A TRANSIT- LANE AND
THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE THE TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION RELY ON
IT AND DEPEND ON IT TO BE ON
TIME AND- AND BE ABLE TO STOP
AT THE STOP WHERE THEY NEED TO
GET OFF AND- AND YOU KNOW A LOT
OF TIME TO MAKE EXCUSES ABOUT.
WELL YOU KNOW POOR PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE AFFECTED BY IT BUT
I'M I'M IMPRESSED BY HOW- YOU
YOU STRUCTURED IT SO THAT
THERE'S SOME OPTIONS THERE'S A
PUBLIC EDUCATION DISTRICT
THERE'S- WARNINGS AND THEN
THERE'S THE FLEXIBILITY WITH
THE TRANSIT AGENCY TO BE ABLE
TO DECIDE. TO FORGIVE A FINER
TO BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH A
DIFFERENT WAY FOR IT TO BE PAID
AND- AND THE REALITY THE
SITUATION IS THAT POOR PEOPLE
HAVE NO CHOICE MANY TIMES THEY
HAVE TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND IT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT THAT IT BE ON TIME
AND PART OF THE CHALLENGE I
HAVE WITH. WITH THE DETRACTORS
OF THE CAMERAS IS THAT- IF YOU
DON'T ENFORCE. PEOPLE DON'T PAY
ATTENTION. AND I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU BUT THESE RED LIGHT.
PEOPLE WHO RUN RED LIGHTS DRIVE
ME CRAZY. BECAUSE IF I MOVED
WHEN IT TURNED GREEN I'D BE
BROADSIDED MANY TIMES AND SO.
AND PART OF THE PART OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE STOPPED
ENFORCING. RED LIGHT WITH
PATROLS AND SO THIS IS A VERY
SIMILAR SITUATION WHERE I'M AT.
NOT ENFORCING OR NOT HAVING
ENOUGH STAFF TO ENFORCE THE
RULES ABOUT WHERE PEOPLE SHOULD
GO IF YOU IF YOU DON'T DO THE
ENFORCEMENT THEN IT BECOMES
WORSE AND WORSE AND WORSE. AND
I THINK THIS IS A BILL THAT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE I AM
CONCERNED YOU KNOW MY
PRIORITIES ALWAYS BEEN WORKING
FOLKS- BUT THEY GOT TO FOLLOW
THE LOSS IN ONCE THEY GET A
WARNING ONCE THEY THEY FIND OUT
THAT- THAT THAT IT IS GOING TO
BE ENFORCED I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE. ARE PROJECTED HERE SO-
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO- MOVED ABOUT.
ALREADY THANK YOU OTHERS. THE
OTHER COMMENTS NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IN A CYNICAL YOU'RE
MOST BUILT IN THE HEART. THIS
THIS IS THE CLASSIC CASE WE'VE
GOT SOCIETAL VALUES THAT OUR
ATTENTION WITH ONE ANOTHER-
WHETHER IT'S THE ESCALADE
DRIVER WHO JUST SIMPLY DOESN'T
CARE AND PARKS IN THE TRANSIT
LANE VERSUS THE DOOR DASH
DRIVER WHO BASICALLY HAS TO
PARK THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
OTHER ALTERNATIVE. THAT'S A
TOUGH CHOICE THE TRANSIT LANES
DON'T WORK THEN YOU HAVE LOW
INCOME RIDERS WEREN'T USING
TRANSIT OR CAN'T USE RANSIT
EFFICIENTLY- YOU'VE GOT ALL
SORTS OF DUE PROCESS ISSUES
HERE IT IS YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED WITH RESPECT TO WHO'S
GOING TO VALUE WAIT. THE
VIOLATION OF WHETHER THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME MITIGATION
MEASURES SO THAT THOSE WHO
CAN'T AFFORD IT- HAVE SOME SORT
OF MITIGATION EASURE- THERE'S
ALSO SOME ISSUES WITH RESPECT
TO TECHNOLOGY I APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU
WORKING WITH US ON THESE
ISSUES- THAT'S WHY WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO REPORT IN
THREE YEARS AND THERE'S A
SUNSET OF FIVE YEARS. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALSO ADDING AN
ADDITIONAL PERIOD OF TIME IN
TERMS OF WARNING AND- I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES AS
THEY INVOLVED BECAUSE THESE ARE
TOUGH ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR- ATTENTION TO THEM. ALL
RIGHT HAVING SAID THAT- THEN
SHE CANCELED THE CALL THE ROLL.
THERE WAS A MOTION BY SOME A
COUPLE EURO- I'M SORRY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I APOLOGIZE
HI RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ALL RIGHT. GREAT CLOTHES
ALL RIGHT- CYNICAL EURO. CENTER
CAREER MOVES THE BILL WOULD NOT
ACHIEVE COUNCIL OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL NO WORRIES THIS IS ABC
NINE ONE GAVIN HIRED. YES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT TO GO. A. B. NINE ONE
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR COPY
AT ALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BERG. I AM BERG
FIVE BARGES. BARGES I HAVE A
YELLOW. W. AT ALL I DID ALSO.
THE DRESS UP NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG.
HERTZBERG BY JONES JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED I SKINNER
STERN. STERN. NOT VOTING STERN
NOT VOTING. WHITE HOUSE SKI
WHITE HOUSE GATE NOT VOTING YOU
HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL ALL RIGHT-
CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE BIDDING
HERE- IN IN FILE ORDER NUMBER
SIX ASSEMBLY PERSON POWER QUE
HAN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER NUMBER TEN
THEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO- SO-
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CHARLES
SENATOR CHARLES HERE ALL RIGHT
SO YOUR CHILD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND ALSO WELCOME TO OUR
GUESTS HERE IN THE GALLERY
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO OBSERVE
YOUR GOVERNMENT PROGRESS WITH
PARTICULARLY LIKE TO HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE HERE SO THAT THEY CAN
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS AT THIRTEEN WOULD
ESTABLISH CRITERIA. FOR THE
PROCUREMENT OF HYORI'S
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS BY
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES IN ORDER TO
MINIMIZE THE RISK OF BIASED. OR
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACTS FROM
THEIR DESIGN AND APPLICATION.
THE USE OF AUGER THEM DRIVEN
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS OR
ADAS. CAN ASSIST WITH CREDIT
DECISIONS EMPLOYMENT SCREENING
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY MARKETING
AND DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT
SERVICES JUST TO NAME A FEW.
HOWEVER PULLEY DESIGN ADS IS
CAN ALSO CREATE AN UNFAIR
BIASED AND INACCURATE RESULTS.
CAUSING DISPROPORTIONATE HARM
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHILE ALSO
UNDERMINING TRUST IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. SO WHEN IT COMES TO
ACQUISITION OF THESE SYSTEMS BY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WE MUST
EXAMINE THE STATE'S PROCUREMENT
POLICIES CLOSELY. GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES NEED TO CONSIDER
UNIQUE POLICY CHOICES INHERENT
IN MACHINE LEARNING SYSTEMS.
INSTEAD OF TREATING THEIR
PURCHASES AS USUAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTING DECISIONS AND
FOCUSING SOLELY ON PRICE
INNOVATION AND COMPETITION THEY
SHOULD ALSO EXAMINE THE GOALS
VALUES AND RISKS INVOLVED IN
THESE SYSTEMS. OTHERWISE THEY
MAY FAIL TO MEET PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS OF OVERSIGHT OF
THE SYSTEMS. AND INADVERTENTLY
CREATE NEW HARMS. LET ME SHARE
SOME EXAMPLES WERE POORLY
DESIGNED OR UNDERSTOOD. PUBLIC
SECTOR AGRI MISSING- SYSTEMS
HAVE CAUSED HARM TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE IN MICHIGAN IN AN
EMPLOYMENT AUGUR THEM
WRONGFULLY ACCUSED FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WELL FRAUD
FORCING MANY OF THEM TO PAY
HEAVY FINES. DECLARE BANKRUPTCY.
OR HELP THEIR HOMES FORECLOSED
UPON. IN MEDICAID WAS. LOST
ACCESS HOME CARE NURSE VISITS.
AND MEDICAL TREATMENTS. OF
ERRORS IN IT THEM. DETROIT THE
MARKET AND ARE THEM USE TO THE
PUBLIC HOUSING SUBSIDIES AND
TAX AND IT UP THERE A FIGHT
COULD. FOR AWAY FOR THE DETROIT
POOREST IN PREDOMINANTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CALLED WRITERS
AWHILE AGO HE CORRECTLY
TRANSLATED POLICY INTO AN
AUTOMATED PUBLIC BENEFITS
SYSTEM KNOWN AS CAL WIN. WHICH
IMPROPERLY DENIED MEDICAID TO
FOSTER CHILDREN IN VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL LAW IT MOST RECENTLY AN
ACLU STUDY SUGGESTS THAT AN
AUGER THEM USE FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION MAY HAVE LEFT MORE
THAN TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
MANY OF THEM FROM BLACK AND
LATINO X. COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
PROPER VACCINE SUPPLY THE LIST
GOES ON. SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ESTABLISH CLEAR GUIDELINES ON
HOW TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND EXPLAINED THE
ABILITY OF THESE SYSTEMS. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO DO
THE FOLLOWING ONE IDENTIFY
WHICH EDS IS OURHIGH RISK. TO
CONDUCT AN INVENTORY OF ALL
HIGH RES EDS IS THAT ARE BEING
USED TO DEVELOP OR PROCURE BY
PUBLIC AGENCIES THREE ENCOURAGE
A PROSPECTIVE CONTRACTOR TO
SUBMIT AN ADS IMPACT ASSESSMENT
REPORT. TO EVALUATE THE PRIVACY
AND SECURITY RISKS THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT MAY RESULT IN
UNFAIR BIASED OR DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT FOR REQUIRED THE STATE
AGENCY AWARDING A CONTRACT TO
PROVIDE A COPY OF THE REPORT TO
ALSO EXPLAIN. HOW THE PUBLIC
CAN ACCESS AND CORRECT THE
RESULTS AND FIVE MAKE THE
REPORT AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
ONLINE IF APPROPRIATE. AS NOTED
BY THE WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM
GOVERNMENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
LATITUDE OF USING THE BLACK BOX
ALGORITHMS THAT INCREASINGLY
CHARACTERIZE ORGANISMS DEPLOYED
IN THE MARKETPLACE OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE SYSTEMS DO NOT CREATE NEW
HARMS CLOSE RACE TO THE LEGAL.
LEGAL RIGHTS HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC INTERESTS OF
INDIVIDUALS- RESULT IN UNFAIR
BIASED OR DISCRIMINATORY
DECISIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I WILL. THANK YOU SOMEONE
THEM WERE CHA- DO ACCEPT THE
MEMBER THAT ARE PROPOSED YES.
YES THANK YOU- WE HAVE VINCENT
LEE- I BELIEVE ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT ALL
RIGHT MR LEE YEAH. A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS VINCENT LIFE BEGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE WHERE I WORK TO
ENSURE THAT TECHNOLOGY CLOSES
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP AND BUILD
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. BUT YOU
THE A. I. AND GOVERNMENT THE
GALLERY. YEAH ONLY 30% OF
AMERICANS ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THE GOVERNMENT IS UP TO THE
TASK OF MANAGING A I. PUT THE
BOOKING THE BOND IS A DISTINCT
LACK OF OVERSIGHT AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE IN OUR GOVERNMENT.
ESPECIALLY AROUND A. I. IN FACT
YOU CAN TAKE WHAT HAPPENED AT
MICHIGAN- OVER FORTY THOUSAND
pUNEMPLOYMENT FRAUD BY THE
ALGORITHM A COPY WHICH AGAIN
OVER FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER MICHIGAN WAS
INVOLVED IN A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT. IT WOULD TURN OVER
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
THOSE AFFECTED THROUGHOUT ALL
OF THIS THE AGENCY IN CHARGE
HAD LITTLE OR NO IDEA OF HOW
THE SYSTEM WORKS OR EXACTLY
WHEN BROCK. INTACT INVESTMENT
WOULD HELP PREVENT THIS OUTCOME
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP THOSE IN
CHARGE UNDERSTAND HOW THEIR
SYSTEM WORKS AND RECOGNIZE THE
ISSUES THAT LED TO MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS AND THE DISASTROUS
ROLLOUT OF THE SYSTEM. THIS IS
WHY WE NEED THE WE DON'T WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA A.
B. THIRTEEN OF THE WAY TO BUILD
TRUST IN OUR INSTITUTIONS. AND
PROTECT VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE PUBLIC AT ALL THE MORE.
AS WE TO MODERN AND IMPROVE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES- AND YOU
KNOW EIGHTY THIRTEEN IS VERY
MUCH LIKE TOUCH REGULATION OF
AUTOMATED DECISION. THAT WE
TAKE STOCK OF ADMITTING HIRING
A ITEM. WE KNOW WHEN WE'RE
USING AI TO MAKE KEY GOVERNMENT
DECISION. THAT THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP AND
OPTIONAL IMPACTED SENTIMENT A
QUESTIONNAIRE CENTRALLY BUT AT
THE BELLBIRD. AND GENERALLY
WORK WHETHER THEY'RE A I CAN
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ARTICULATE DEPLOYED INCORRECTLY.
AND HOW TO MINIMIZE THOSE RISKS.
SIMPLY PUT THESE ARE THINGS
THAT SHOULD BE TO CLOSE TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES AS A MATTER OF
COURSE AND WILL HELP THEM MAKE
WELL INFORMED DECISIONS WHEN
THEY PROCURE AUTOMATED DECISION.
FINALLY A. B. THIRTEEN IS
NARROWLY TAILORED ONLY APPLYING
CASES OF GOVERNMENT
PROCUREMENT. ONLY INSTANCES
WHERE- THE DECISIONS THAT SOME
DETERMINED THAT THAT THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY HOW THE
LEGAL RIGHT. THE DECISIONS
AROUND YOU KNOW PUBLIC BENEFITS
ELIGIBILITY CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SENTENCING OR HOW. IT ALL AREAS
WHERE THE RISK OF A WRONG
DECISION AT HIGH AND YOU KNOW
OUR GOVERNMENT HAS A STRONG
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET IT RIGHT.
AND THEN THANK YOU MR. OKAY
YES- NO FOR THOSE REASONS I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY SEEING
NONE. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE ON THE PHONE LINE MODERATE
YOU TOO UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. ONE THREE. IF YOU ARE IN
PART OF EIGHTY ONE THREE. ONE
OF THEM THEY'RE ALL SET IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE THREE. WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER FOUR OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS REBECCA BOTH OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
SUPPORTERS THANK YOU. THREE
SEVENTY NINE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YELL KENDO
CHRYSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE
SUPPORT. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT NOW TURNING THE
OPPOSITION MR ROBERT MOULTRIE.
ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. MR
MOULTRIE. MODERATORS MR
MOULTRIE AVAILABLE. AND TAKING
A LOOK HERE. I YES HE IS HOLD
ON HERE. LINE. AT SOME POINT
YOU WILL YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ROBERT. GOOD THANK YOU. CAN YOU
GET HOW MUCH YOU CARE YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. APOLOGIES I DON'T
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND THAT
HAPPENED THAT WAS NOT NEEDED ON
MY END- BUT- ROAD WHICH WOULD
HELP ME CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE SEXUALLY OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN I'M ARE BEGINNING A
DEBATE ON POLICY CONCERNS AS
WELL ACTUALLY THE BILL. AT A
POLICY LEVEL WE SEE AB THIRTEEN
IT DRIVING UP THE DIFFICULTY OF
BIDDING PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL
EMPLOYERS AND THEREFORE
INCREASING COUGH BOTH
BUSINESSES AND STATE WITHOUT A
CLEAR COMMENSURATE BENEFIT- I
THINK KNOWLEDGE THE A MAN. WE
APPRECIATE THE INTENTION BEHIND
THE CRAZY MAN WE DO NOT DEMAND
THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESSING THE
CORE ISSUES WITH MAGNUS RUNNING-THE DEFINITION OF AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS FOR HIGH RISK
APPLICATION- I DON'T LIKE THE
FLAG THAT DESPITE THEM AS SOME
AMBIGUITY THE TESTIMONY. BY NO
MEANS LIMITED TO MACHINE
LEARNING AND THOSE KIND OF
SITUATIONS WHERE THAT THAT
SYSTEM INTRODUCING ITS OWN
RULES IN FACT QUITE BROAD- ALSO
LIKE THE BLACK BACKGROUND
ISSUES HERE THEY'RE IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. PERSON CALLING
FOR PRIVATE CORRECT THAT WILL
INCLUDE TOUCHING ON THE TOPIC
OF AUTOMATED DECISION MAKING
SYSTEM AND WE DON'T THINK THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING DEPARTED
MELODY DRAFTING SIMILAR OR
POTENTIALLY CONFLICTING
DEFINITIONS OF THE THING TERM
AT THE SAME TIME. THERE'S A LOT
THAT THE PRH A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT MEET THAT TERM.
ALSO IS LIKE THE FLAG AT THE
CORE CONCERN HERE'S
DISCRIMINATION AND
UNINTENTIONAL DISCRIMINATION
BY- PROBABILITY WE DON'T. WE
DON'T ACTUALLY COVERED BY. THE
UNREASONABLE RIGHT BACK HAS
FALLEN- MY CONTRACT THAT ENTITY
SECURING THE UP SOME SOFTWARE
THAT HELP SORT THAT THE- FROM A-
WE'LL PUT IT DOWN TO. BECAUSE
IN THE COSTS. AND THEN IF.
DISCRIMINATION OCCURRED IN THE
EIGHTEEN WITHIN SUED RELATED-THAT. THE BURDEN WOULD ALREADY
ON THE APPLICANT BRINGING THE
SOFTWARE SO WE DON'T THE
DISCRIMINATION AS AN
OUTSTANDING CONCERN GIVEN THAT
FRAMEWORK- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE HOPEFULLY BEFORE KIND OF
TIME. THAT WE DO NOT SEE THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTS THAT MUST
ACCOMPANY THE APPLICATION IT
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO DO ARE THEY A
QUESTIONNAIRE AS QUOTED BY
BELIEVE THAT THE SPONSOR. IF
YOU LOOK TO THE TOPIC AND-
SECTION. TWELVE ONE ONE FIVE
THREE. THREE IF YOU WOULD GO
AHEAD AND WRAP IT UP. WELL YES
SORRY- BASE AMID CONCERNS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED AND- ARE
RESPECTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON THE PHONE LINE. BUT
IF YOU TO HELP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN. WE'D
BE GRATEFUL. IF YOU ARE IN A
POSITION OF EIGHTY ONE THREE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ZERO. AND
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER OR THREE
FORTY SIX. GO AHEAD MY NUMBER
THREE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FOUR NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING THIS
IS JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY. OPPOSE THE BILL
THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO A PHOTO LINE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THE ANY TACKED ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER. FOUR
NINETY. MY NUMBER FOUR NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT NEED
MORE WHILE I'M HAVING THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION EIGHTY PARKING.
THANK YOU. FOUR NINETY TWO.
GOOD EVENING MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS MADELEINE KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF TEXAS A AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER. TWO SIXTY THREE. HI DON
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF AN
ASSOCIATION OF SPECTACLES THANK
YOU. FOUR SEVENTY NINE. THE
LORD GAVE ME WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
THREE FORTY SIX. HI I'M I'M
TRYING TO CALL IN IN SUPPORT
BUT FOR SOME REASON THE PHONE
WASN'T PICKED UP THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
PRIVACY CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THIRTEEN.
THANK YOU. AND NOT ONLY HAVING
Q. THE FOUR FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NOT ONLY THAT BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION AND WE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE AT THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU. ALREADY
THANK YOU. OTHERS IS POOR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
THERE ARE NONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER CENTER
BOARD JUST. THANK YOU CHAIR. I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING TIME
TO CHAT WITH ME- WE SPOKE AT
GREAT LENGTH- A FEW TO A FEW
DAYS BACK AND- I'VE GIVEN A LOT
OF THOUGHT THIS IS THIS IS A
TOUGH ISSUE- BUT I THINK AT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I
EXPRESSED. TO YOU WERE ON
BEFORE I THINK STILL STANDS-
AND I. IF YOU ALLOW ME I THINK
I'D LIKE TO KIND OF WALK JUST
WALK THROUGH SOME OF THE
VULNERABILITIES- IN THE
PROPOSAL. AND A. I. IS
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE IN HAS
BEEN A GAME CHANGER. AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO ADJUST- WITH
CERTAIN PRIVACY RELATED
MATTERS- THE CONFINES OF HOW AI
IS INCORPORATED INTO OR OR
DAILY LIFE. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
I THINK THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL RIGHT HERE IS THAT. A. I.
IS BUILT ON DATA. AND
PREDICTIVE DATA. SO THAT POLICY
MAKERS OR- INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
THE CONSUMERS OF THAT
INFORMATION USE IT AS A AS A AS
pA PLATFORM. FOR A VARIETY OF
FUNCTIONS SO. SOMETIMES YOU
HAVE BIAS THAT'S ALREADY BUILT
IN- TO THE INFORMATION
GATHERING ALGORITHM. AND THAT
IS PROBLEMATIC AND THEN
SOMETIMES IT IS SELF REALIZING
OVER TIME. I THINK THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT THEY CAN MAKE THIS
A LITTLE BIT BETTER AND OF
COURSE I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU
THIS YEAR BILL. ONE IS. THESE
THESE BUSINESSES COBBETT IN
VALUE THEIR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THEY HAVE EVERY REASON
TO PROTECT THAT INTEREST AND BY
FORCIBLY DISCLOSING INFORMATION
ABOUT THE UNDERLYING FACTUAL
ASSUMPTIONS THAT GO INTO A
PLATFORM LIKE THIS. COULD
REALLY COULD REVEAL PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION SO THE IDEA OF
MAKING THE FINDINGS ARE PUBLIC
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLY DANGEROUS
ANIMAL DISINCENTIVE EYES
BUSINESS FROM WANTING TO MOVE
INTO PUBLIC CONTRACTS. AND SO
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS I
HAD TO YOU AND I'LL LEAVE IT TO
YOU TO CONSIDER WHETHER ITS
MERITORIOUS OR NOT IS NOT
MAKING THIS INFORMATION PUBLIC.
IN ANY FASHION THAT WOULD
REVEAL THE INTELLECTUAL OUR OUR
PRODUCT. THE OTHER IS- THERE
SHOULD BE A SELF CORRECTING
AUDIT SYSTEM WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH THE- MEDIC IN THE- THE
RISK ASSESSMENT OR WHATEVER THE
REPORTING TERMINOLOGIES USED IN
HERE IS THAT IF AN ALGORITHM
REVEALS A DISPARATE IMPACT FOR
AN UNINTENTIONAL DISPARATE
IMPACT ON INDIVIDUALS BEING
SINGLED OUT BY VIRTUE OF THE
AREA MODELING. THAT THERE BE A
CORRECTIVE INTERNAL PROCESS
THAT THE STICKER PARTICIPATE IN.
BUT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE I THINK ONE OF THE CALLERS
POINT OUT IS THAT DO WE HAVE
THE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO GET
INTO THIS LEVEL OF DETAIL. AND
I THINK- WHEN YOU ADD ALL THAT
TOGETHER- THIS I THINK WOULD BE
A PERFECT- BUILD TO MOVE INTO A
TWO YEAR PROCESS IN MY
ESTIMATIONS I THINK. THERE ARE
THERE ARE THERE SOME STRONG
MERIT TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING I
HAVE ABSOLUTE RESPECT FOR THIS
AUTHOR. AND DIVING DEEP INTO
THIS AREA. BUT IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. ALLOWING IT TO BE PUBLIC.
COULD DISINCENTIVE VICE PUBLIC
CONTRACT- PURSUITS. FROM
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO
PROTECT. INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
ARE NOT GOING TO- ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN AND PARTICIPATE. IN
MAKING IT. OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA BRIEF BUREAUCRATS.
REVIEWING INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THIRD PARTIES
HAVING PUBLIC ACCESS TO DATA
POINTS OR INFORMATION THAT
COULD BE STOLEN AND RE
APPROPRIATED ELSEWHERE IN
INDUSTRY AND OVERSEAS. SO WITH
THOSE I'M I'M GONNA PROBABLY
REFER RESPECTFULLY DECLINED TO
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME BUT I
THINK IT HAS SOMETHING THERE I
WOULD JUST WISH YOU COME BACK
NEXT YEAR WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE VETTING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THOUGH FULLY RESPECT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING ALREADY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD HE WAS
RESPONDING YOUR CLOSE UP I'LL
RESPOND RIGHT OUT THAT'S ALL
RIGHT. YEAH WELL SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND THANK
YOU FOR TAKING TIME TO CHAT
WITH ME THE OTHER DAY AND I
DEFINITELY RESPECT YOU FOR.
YOUR POSITION ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF DATA AND ALSO INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY IN FACT- YOU KNOW I'LL
BILL REALLY DOES NOT. REQUIRE
THE DISCLOSURE OF ANY
PARTICULAR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY ON THE PART OF THE
VENDOR IN FACTORIES VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT
SAYS THAT YOU KNOW. PLEASE DO
NOT PROVIDE US WITH ANY TRADE
SECRETS OR PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION AND ON TOP OF THAT
THE CD T. WHEN IT RECEIVES ANY
POTENTIAL TRADE SECRETS OR
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SHOULD NOT
DISCLOSE THAT INFORMATION. TO
IT UNTIL A THIRD POINT IS THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY WE ARE ASKING WE ARE
ENCOURAGING THE VENDORS TO
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION IN THE
FORM OF A- IMPACT ASSESSMENT
REPORT. YET THEY DON'T HAVE TO
DO SO AND WHEN THEY DO PROVIDE
INFORMATION DATE TOTALLY HOW
THE DISCUSSION OF WHAT TO
DISCLOSE AND WHAT NOT TO
DISCLOSE TO THE CDT. SO THERE
IS EXPLICIT LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW
WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T DON'T
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT THESE VENDORS ENTRY
SEQUENCE AND WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE. N. ON TOP OF THAT THESE
VENDORS. BEING THE. SUPPLIER OR
THE ODD MAN YOUR THANK THESE
FROM THEY ARE SHOULD KNOW THEY
HAVE. AS TO WHAT IS SO WHAT
WOULD CONSTITUTE TRADE SECRETS
OR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY TODAY
SHOULD BE IN A BETTER POSITION
TO DISCLOSE TO DECIPHER WHAT
IS. OUR PROPRIETARY VERSUS NON
PROPRIETORY STILL AND THEN R.
AS FAR AS THE SELF CORRECTING
MECHANISM YEAH I THINK THAT'S
ALREADY KIND OF BUILT IN
BECAUSE WHEN WE DO ASK THE
VENDOR TO PROVIDE THE IMPACT
ASSESSMENT REPORT. WEDNESDAY
CONDUCTED HOUSE THEY WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ESSENTIALLY FIND
OUT WHAT'S WRONG WITH THEIR
SYSTEM IF ANYTHING- HIGH LIKE
THE FUNCTIONALITY OF THEIR
SYSTEM. THEY DISCOVERED THAT
YOU KNOW THEIR SYSTEMS WOULD
CREATE SOME KIND OF BIASED OR
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT ON PEOPLE
THEN D. SHOULD HAVE THEYOU
KNOW THE KNOWLEDGE TO ACTUALLY
OUR SELF CORRECT. TO THE WOULD
BE AUDITING THEMSELVES WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR INDEPENDENT
AUDITING FIRM AND OUTSIDEWITH
THIRD PARTY. VENDOR BUT YOU
KNOW ESSENTIALLY WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO TELL US WHAT STEPS THEY
HAVE TAKEN TO. BASICALLY A
MEDICARE OR OR- ADDRESS
DIVISIVE SITUATION. BUT BUT
YOUR POINT IS OUT OF WHAT HE
CAN TO. ALL RIGHT OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SINGLE OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED AS THEIR
MOTION. SO WHAT COUNTS CAN MOVE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU
SILLY MEMBER CHILD FOR YOUR-
YOUR YOUR- WILLINGNESS TO MEET.
AND TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
THE COMMITTEE- IN PARTICULAR
CHANGING THE BILL FROM BEING A
REQUIREMENT TO BEING
ENCOURAGED. OTHER SEVERAL
MODIFICATIONS THAT I THINK-
NARROW THE SCOPE OF A NUMBER OF
DEFINITIONS- AND HAVING SAID
THAT- MANAGE ACCOUNT SO IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. OH I'M
SORRY IT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
ASK FOR YARD ALL RIGHT THERE WE
GO. THIS IS ABC THIRTEEN BY A
FAMILY MEMBER CHILD. BUT WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. AMBERG
I'VE FORGES. FOR JUST NOT
VOTING KERR YET ALL. DID I SO
DID I SO I. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. TODD JONES. JONES
NO LAYERED LAYERED ICE SKINNER
STERN STERN I WACO SKI WHY
CASKEY I YOU HAVE SIX TO ONE
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALREADY
WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT ON CALL- I
HAVE AN IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT THAT-
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A MANDATORY
BUDGET MEANING THAT'S ABOUT TO
COMMENCE- I THINK THE FOOD IS
HERE FOR DINNER IF IT IS NOT IT
WILL ARRIVE MOMENTARILY SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE REQUIRED
TO DEPART FOR THE BUDGET
BY THE TABLE AND- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ACTUALLY BREAK FOR
DINNER WE'RE JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PLOW ON THROUGH-
WE'RE MAKING A GREAT DEAL
PROGRESS WE'RE WE'RE NEARLY
HALFWAY DONE WE HAVE EIGHTEEN
MORE BILLS TO HERE. SO HAVING
SAID THAT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER K. HAND IS HERE. I DO
NUMBER SIX A. B. ONE THREE FIVE
SIX- AND LET ME LET ME INQUIRE
ALSO. THE SERVER MARKET ARE YOU
ALL YOU'RE ALSO PRESENT
PRESENTING- SOMEONE OR LOWS
BILLS WELL- AND THAT IS ITEM.
NUMBER THIRTY THREE FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE FOLLOWING ALONG.
WITH YOUR PROGRAM ALL RIGHT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
TERREL TAKE A BABY THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX FIRST FIRST ON THE
AGENDA I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
EXTENSIVE WORK TO ENSURE THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL. AND THE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE WRITTEN
STATEMENT TO PREVENT POSTING OF
IMAGES OF PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS THEY WERE FINE THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THE INTENT TO
INTIMIDATE THEY HAD AN EXPRESS
EXEMPTION FOR THE PRESS AND
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION. WITH THAT
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX A BILL THAT
UPDATES OUR LAWS TO ADDRESS THE
INSIDIOUS THREATS THAT PATIENTS
AND PROVIDERS AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA
FACE. ROE VERSUS WADE IS THE
LAW OF THE LAND PEOPLE HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SEEK
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTHCARE HOWEVER
DAILY PROTESTS AND INCREASING
HARASSMENT ONLINE NOW
FUNDAMENTALLY THREATEN THIS
RIGHT EVERY DAY PATIENTS ARRIVE
AT CLINICS AND AGREED WITH
CAMERAS IN THEIR FACES
HARASSMENT PHYSICAL
INTIMIDATION AND THREATS OF
ONLINE BOXING. THESE PATIENTS
ARE MOSTLY UNINSURED AND THE
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE WOMEN OF
COLOR THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF ANONYMITY AT A
HOSPITAL AS I DID WHEN I WAS
PREGNANT. THEY ARE TARGETED
BASED ON ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
THAT THEY'RE SEEKING. TODAY
EXTEND BEYOND THE CLINIC
ENTRANCE NEW CAMERA
CAPABILITIES ALLOW PROTESTERS
TO FILM AND IDENTIFY PATIENTS
AND PROVIDERS. SO THAT THEIR
HELPER RIGHTS MEAN NOTHING.
PROTESTERS POST THESE IMAGES ON
WEBSITES TARGETING REPRODUCTIVE
RIGHTS AND MAKING PROVIDER OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION AVAILABLE
ONLINE TO MILLIONS OF USERS.
THIS DOXING THREATENED LIVES
CURRENT LAW IN THE FACE ACT WAS
WRITTEN DECADES AGO AND DOES
NOT REFLECT THE SEVERITY OF THE
THREAT. PROTESTER GROUPS ARE
WELL ORGANIZED AND WELL FUNDED
THE LOW FINES AND PENALTIES
HAVE SIMPLY NOT DETERRED THEM.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE PRIVACY
AND PHYSICAL SAFETY OR PRE
REQUISITES FOR ACCESSIBLE
HEALTHCARE ESPECIALLY
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
SOMEHOW WE'VE ACCEPTED THE
STATUS QUO. OVER PENALIZES
MARIJUANA POSSESSION BUT LEAVE
THESE YOUNG WOMEN OF COLOR
VICTIMS OF DEATH THREATS SIMPLY
FOR SEEKING TREATMENT. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX UPDATES ARE
LOST TO INCREASE FINES FOR THE
ONLINE HARASSMENT AND
INTENTIONALLY TERRORIZING
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS. IT ALSO
INCLUDES NEEDED TRAINING FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ACTUALLY TO
ACTUALLY PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES
AND PROTECT CLINICS. TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX I'M JOINED VIA PHONE
BY STEVEN MENDOZA SECURITY
SPECIALIST AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD PASADENA AND SAN
GABRIEL VLLEY. AND LEAVE THEM
OFF THE BOARD. ON ALL COUNCIL
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CALIFORNIA. I YOU VERY MUCH-
MISS MATSUBARA MISS MISS MILTON
BALUCH MATSUBARA. ARE YOU
AVAILABLE THANKS. FOR MR YES I
AM SORRY GO AHEAD CLOSURES AM I
GOING FOR YOU ARE. HELLO YES
MISS MATSUBARA YES YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
WITH THE MOB BORROW MY CAR HIT
BILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SEVEN PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES WHO
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE NEARLY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION VISITS
ANNUALLY TO PATIENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE'RE WORKING
EXTREMISTS HAVE TARGETED
HARASSED AND THREATENED
ABORTION PROVIDERS FOR DECADES
BECAUSE LIKE ACTIVE VIOLENCE
AGAINST PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS.
HEALTH CENTERS ARE SEEING A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
THREATENING SECURITY INCIDENTS
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS. THE
TACTICS OF ANTI ABORTION
EXTREMIST BIRD RESTED AND
DESIGNED TO FRIGHTEN AND
INTIMIDATE PATIENTS FROM
SEEKING MUCH NEEDED HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND CLINIC STAFF AND
PROVIDING THAT CARE BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORRIED FOR THEIR
SAFETY AND PRIVACY.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR TOO LONG
THERE'S BEEN A CULTURAL
COMPLACENCY AROUND EIGHTY ANTI
ABORTION TERRORISM WHICH HAS
HELPED IN BOLDON IN NORMAL LIFE
THREATENING BEHAVIOR OUTSIDE.
OF THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. IT THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX UPDATED THE THING OF. THAT
SPECIFICALLY PROTECT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS TO
REFLECT THE REAL THREAT THE
DIGITAL AGE. THESE PATIENTS AND
PROVIDERS FACE HARASSING AND
THREATENING BEHAVIORS THAT THEY
WALK OR DRIVE TO THEIR DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS OR TO WORK. THE
CASE BEING RECORDED BY BODY
CAMERAS GOT TO PEOPLE WHO
FOLLOW THEM AS THEY APPROACH
THE BUILDING OR HAVEN'T FOUND
THEIR THEIR CARDS BEING BILLED
AS A PARKING ENTER THE HELP
CENTER. FOR PATIENTS ARE TRYING
TO ACCESS SENSITIVE SERVICES
THESE ACTIONS INCITE FEAR TO
DETERRENT ON. GETTING THE CARE
THEY NEED AND IN DANGER THAT BY
WIDELY IDENTIFYING THEM ONLINE
AS PATIENT TO PROVIDER OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. PATIENTS THAT HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT TO PRIVACY WHEN ACCESSING
IMPORTANT SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. AND THEY
SHOULD BE FREE OF INTIMIDATION
AND THREATS. FOR THESE REASONS
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
EIGHTY THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. AND
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF AND AN
OPPOSITION. FOR WORKING WITH US
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. THANK
YOU MISS SMITH. ALL RIGHT MR
MENDOZA. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS I'M STEPHEN MENDOZA THE
SECURITY SPECIALIST AT. THE END
THANK YOU BOTH VALUE HERE TO
PORT BABY THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
HEARTILY HAD PROVIDED THE
COMMUNITY WITH REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUAL HEALTH CARE FOR MORE
THAN EIGHTY FIVE YEARS FOR THE
PAST SIX MONTHS WE PROBABLY
ADMINISTER COPA NINETY BACKING
FOR THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I'M HERE TODAY
TALKING ABOUT R. FIVE HEALTH
CENTERS ALL OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
TARGETED ATTACKS AND EVEN SHOT
AT BY ANTI ABORTION EXTREMISTS
ARE HELPING OUR STAFF AND
PATIENTS ARE REGULARLY HARASSED
AND PUT IN DANGER FOR PROVIDING
AN ACCESS TO CARE IN THE PAST
YEAR WE'VE EXPERIENCED THIRTY
SEVEN PROTESTS INCREASE FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS. THE MOST
ALARMING THREAT WE RECENTLY HAD
WITH SOMEONE DRIVING BY OUR
HELP CENTER CITY A HIGH POWERED
AUTOMATIC BB GUN OUR FACILITY
HE SHOT APART INTO MULTIPLE
TIMES OVER SEVERAL MONTHS
BEFORE ULTIMATELY PEACOCK WHEN
THE TOPIC WAS ERECTED A TWENTY
TWO CALIBER GUN WAS FOUND IN
HIS VEHICLE ALONG WITH A BB
GUN. THANKFULLY NO ONE LOOKS AT
HER WE HAD WINDOWS BROKEN AND
OTHER DAMAGE TO OUR FACILITY
BUT THE REAL IMPACT WITH
EMOTIONAL TOLL THE PAD ON THE
FRONT LINE STAFF MANY SHARED
THEY FELT UNSAFE AT WORK THEIR
MIND WENT TO THE COLORADO
SHOOTING THAT TOOK PLACE AT A
PLANNED PARENTHOOD A FEW YEARS
AGO. THE CARD ADDED STRESS ON
TOP OF PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED
MEDICAL CARE IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC THE STREET INCIDENT
CAUGHT THE BEER TRAUMA FOR
HEALTH CENTER STAFF WHICH LED
INTO HIRING SECURITY GUARDS AND
THAT THE NEW SECURITY EQUIPMENT
AND BRIANNA THOMAS ALFA. DO YOU
GET INTO THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT
OUR BUSINESS AND THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS WERE ABLE TO SEE OUR
FRONT OFFICE STAFF MEDICAL
CALLED OUT OF WORK WE GRAPPLED
CHECKING PATIENTS FOR MEDICAL
PROVIDERS THE RABBINATE BUT OUR
STAFF AND PATIENT EXPERIENCE
ARE UNLIKE ANY OTHER HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE TO HAVE
FALLEN. THROUGH AND FROM THERE
CARDS FOR THE PROTECTION. CALL
TO CANCEL THEIR APPOINTMENT OUT
OF FEAR OF GETTING TACKLED OR
HURT BY A PROTESTER OUR VENDORS
ARE YELLED OUT AND POCKET FOR
DELIVERING THE MEDICAL SUPPLIES
WE NEED. A PATIENT AND STAFF
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
GET THE BASIC HEALTH CARE FREE
OF INTIMIDATION AND SCARE
TACTICS I STRONGLY. URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF A. B. THIRTY FIFTY
SIX. I AVAILABLE FOR QUITE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR ALL
RIGHT LET'S TURN THE OTHER WAY
IN MEGAT C. NONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE NONE THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATOR IF YOU TWO OF THOSE
YOU SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE THREE
FIVE SIX. WE'D BE GRATEFUL. IF
YOU AREN'T PART OF. EIGHTY ONE
THREE FIVE SIX ONE NINE ZERO.
THEN WE WILL GO TO LINE FIVE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU CHAIR RYAN
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STITCHES NINE SUPPORT. NEXT
PLEASE. LINE. FOUR OH EIGHT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE HANDLED
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS A LOT TO
LINE FIVE OH FIVE. YOUR NUMBERS
THIS IS ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF
NERO PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIVE
TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NOT A NEGATIVE YES THE
MANUAL CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AT THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY ONE
THREE FIVE SIX IN THE QUEUE
ALREADY LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE
IDENTIFIED AS MAIN WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- BUT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THE GALLERY YES
IN THE GALLERY. IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO GREG BIRD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
OPPOSING UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. FOR WRITING OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION- IN THE GALLERY
SAYING NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE. ON
THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IF YOU
TWO OF THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO. EIGHTY ONE
THREE FIVE SIX. IF YOU ARE IN A
POSITION OF EIGHTY ONE THREE
FIVE SIX. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND
WE WILL START WITH MY NUMBER
FIVE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BACK
A CREAMERMATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION WE
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
PRIOR LANGUAGE WE ARE REVIEWING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. THANKS TO A LOCAL LINE.
FIVE HUNDRED. YEAH MICHELLE
CONNOR I AM A MEMBER OF THE
PROJECT THAT THE FOUNDATION OF
OUR CORNEA I AM IN THE MINORITY
WOMAN TARGETED BY ABC THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX AND I STRONGLY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. THE LINE
NUMBER FIVE THIRTEEN. MY NAME
IS SUSAN AREN'T ALL IN LOVE AND
TURNING WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER. FOUR EIGHTY THREE.
YES MR SHARE THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
FOR FIELD SO THE COMPANY
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER FOUR NINETY FOUR. YES
YOU READ THE BRENNAN PRESIDENT
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RIGHT TO LIFE THE DEFENDANT
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION AND
RECOMMENDED. THANK YOU. AND
MISTER CLEAR WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
I SEE NO MICRO ALL I DO SEE ONE
WOULD RAISE CENTER BY CAL SKI.
YES- MISTER CHAIR I'VE I FEEL
COMPELLED TO SAY SOMETHING AS A
LEGISLATOR- WHO'S IT READILY.
SADLY SAY TO FOLKS THAT I'M PRO
CHOICE AND I HAVE A 100% VOTING
RECORD IN MY ELEVEN YEARS HERE
I'M ALSO AN ATTORNEY. AND THIS
LEGISLATION CAUSES ME IS A
GREAT CONCERN LET ME EXPLAIN
IT'S OFTEN THE CASE WITH FIRST
AMENDMENT. RIGHTS TO FREE
SPEECH AND FREE EXPRESSION IT'S
EASY SUPPORT FREE SPEECH WHEN
YOU LIKE THE SPEECH THAT YOU'RE
HEARING. BUT IT'S FAR MORE
DIFFICULT TO SUPPORT THE RIGHT
TO FREE SPEECH WHEN YOU FIND
THE MESSAGE REPUGNANT. AND
THAT'S PRECISELY THE TIME THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
DEFEND THIS RIGHT. I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS BILL IS MADE HAD
MANY- A MAN MR TAKEN BY THE BY
THE AUTHOR BUT IT DOES CALL OUT
THE FACT THAT THE EXISTING
CRIMES ARE NOT BEING PROSECUTED
PROSECUTED IN SOME PLACES IN
OUR STATE. BUT I CANNOT VOTE
TODAY TO SUPPORT. OF ONE
HUNDRED FOOT A PRUNER AROUND
THE HEALTH FACILITY JUSTIN THIS
IS I WOULD NOT SUPPORT A
HUNDRED FOOT PRIMER AROUND A-
GUN STORE OR COURTHOUSE. THIS
BILL MAY NOT BE DISCRIMINATORY
ON ITS FACE IT'S PLAINLY
DISCRIMINATORY IN THIS FACT FOR
THOSE REASONS AS A STAUNCH PRO
CHOICE SENATOR AND A SUPPORTER
OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS. I REGRETTED
REGRETTABLY CANNOT SUPPORT IT
TODAY. THANK YOU SO I CAL SKI-
SEEING NO OTHER MICROPHONES
RAISED. IS THERE A MOTION YES
AND A CONSULT. SENATORS ALSO
MOVES THE BILL ALL RIGHT- SOME
REMEMBER DO YOU CARE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR CHAIR I'LL JUST
ADDRESS THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUE- HI TO BETTER TOURNEY
AND ONE WHO BELIEVES DEEPLY IN
THE CONSTITUTION THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT BUT AS YOU AND
THE MANY LAWYERS HAVE TOUCHED
THIS INCLUDING A PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THE ACLU AND THE
COMMITTEES WHICH HAVE BEEN
BEFORE. WE ARE ALLOWED TO
RESTRICT SPEECH WHEN THERE IS A
COMPELLING GOVERNMENT INTEREST
AND IT IS NARROWLY TAILORED I
WOULD FIRST SAY THAT THE FACE
ACT IS ALREADY IN LOS SO MOST
OF THIS IS ALREADY BEEN IN
PLACE AND IS CLEARLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE IS A
COMPELLING GOVERNMENT INTEREST
TO ENSURE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND THAT MEANS ALL HEALTHCARE
INCLUDING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. AND WE WORKED INCREDIBLY
HARD TO NARROWLY TAILOR THIS
BILL TO ENSURE. THAT THOSE. YOU
WANT TO SPEAK HAVE THE RIGHT TO
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE RIGHT TO. BUT THEY WILL NOT
HAVE TO CONTINUE THE ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO INTIMIDATE.
THREATEN AND STOP THESE
PATIENTS FROM GETTING THE
HEALTHCARE THEY DESERVE. SO I
STAND FIRMLY BEHIND THIS BILL
BELIEVE IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES IS AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY A FAMILY
MEMBER. OUR K. HAAN- BUT THE
MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALES. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. AMBERG
BY BARGES. HEAVY AT ALL. THE
RUSSELL GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HURTS BURKE. JONES JONES NO
LAYERED SKINNER STERN STERN I
WAKE HOUSEKI NO WHITE HOUSE SKI
KNOWS SO FAR YOU HAVE TO READ
IT TO YOU WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL- NEXT TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARK AND YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
THREE WHICH IS- A. B. TEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW SAT CORRECT YES THANK YOU
GUYS FOR TRAVELERS YEARS- I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR YOUR
THOROUGH ANALYSIS THIS BILL
REQUIRES A RETAILER WITH FIVE
HUNDRED OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
GENDER NEUTRAL RETAIL SECTION
OF TOYS IN CHILD CARE ITEMS IF
THEY CHOOSE TO MAINTAIN THE
LABELING OF KIDS SECTIONS BY
BOYS AND GIRLS. THE RETAILER
CHOOSES TO SIMPLY LABEL TOYS
OUR KIDS HE DID DISH ON GENDER
NEUTRAL SECTION WILL NOT BE
NECESSARY IN TODAY'S CULTURE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
STOP REINFORCING GENDER NORMS
THEY CAN BE HARMFUL. I WANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES
NOT APPLY TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THE KOBE NINETEEN
RESTRICTIONS LESSENING KIDS
START GOING BACK TO SCHOOL WE
WANT TO PROCESS THEIR SHOPPING
TO BE A POSITIVE EXPERIENCE
AFTER AN UNPRECEDENTED YEAR OF
STRESS WE ARE CREATING A
WELCOMING PLACE FOR ALL
CHILDREN SO THEY CAN WEAR WHAT
THEY LIKE AND MOVE AWAY FROM
THE STEREOTYPES OF THE ONLY
BLUE FOR BOYS AND ONLY PINK FOR
GIRLS. AS A MOTHER MYSELF WHO
HAS BOTH SONS AND A DAUGHTER
I'VE TAKEN MY CHILDREN TO
STORES AND BE DISAPPOINTED WHEN
MY DAUGHTER HAD TO GO TO A
SECTION LABELED BOYS IN ORDER
TO GET TOYS THAT ALLOWED HER TO
BUILD OR DO SCIENCE. THE GENDER
STEREOTYPES THAT ARE BEING
REINFORCED OUR STORES TODAY
LEAVE A CHILD TO FEEL JUDGED OR
IS IT THE ACTIVITY BUT HERE SHE
IS CHOOSING ISN'T APPROPRIATE.
AND SO THIS IS A SIMPLE CHANGE
THAT. THAT STOPS THE
STEREOTYPES FROM BEING
REINFORCED AND ENSURES THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE WELCOMED
EVERYWHERE. OUR OWN INCLUDING
ABERCROMBIE H. AND M. OLD NAVY
JOHN LEWIS AND ZARA WHICH ONCE
UNISEX APPAREL LINES FOR KIDS
MEANWHILE TARGET MADE HEADLINES
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN IT
DECIDED TO DO AWAY WITH THOSE
GENDER BASED SCIENCE IN SOME
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS HOME AND
TOYS. THE LITTLE GIRL LIKE MY
DAUGHTER WANTS TO SIGN SKATER
DINOSAUR TOY TO PLAY WITH SHE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO ASK ME TO
TAKE HER TO A VOICE SECTION SHE
SHOULDN'T FEEL LIKE SHE'S
BUYING THE WRONG WAY WE SHOULD
SIMPLY LET THESE KIDS BE KIDS.
THIS WON'T HURT ANYONE BUT IT
COULD DEFINITELY HELP A LOT OF
CHILDREN. WITH ME TODAY IS
BRITAIN SIRES AND ANJALI SOURCE
ON BEHALF OF ROBERT SMITH AND
THE FOOD PRODUCT. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH. CORPORATE
INSIDERS ARE THE VIEW YOUR
AVAILABLE. I DO NOT SHARE
PROGRAMS WITH A I DON'T B. MATH
ON THEIR- ALL RIGHT. THEIR
CHAIRMAN RIGHT CHECK OUR
NUMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE NINE
MY NAME IS BRITAIN PARDON I'M
NINE AND A HALF YEARS OLD I
THINK YOU MAY KNOW AB TEN
EIGHTY FOURTH TURNED OUT OF MY
YEAH BUT I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD GET THIS FAR THERE ARE SO
MANY LITTLE KIDS OUT THERE WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY FIT INTO
SOCIETY'S EXPECTATIONS IT CAN
BE SO HARD FOR THEM TO LOOK AT
A PARTY IN THE GIRLS SECTION
FOR TORY DANCER IN THE BOYS
SECTION AND FEEL EYES ON THEM
AS THEY WALKED INTO. A SECTION
LABELED FOR THE OPPOSITE GENDER
I ASK WHO ARE SUPPORTIVE OF ME
BUT NOT EVERY KID HAS I CAN
JUST IMAGINE A CHILD BEING
PULLED OUT OF A SECTION LABELED
FOR THE OPPOSITE GENDER WELL
WHAT IF IT WASN'T LIKE THAT
WHAT IS THE TWENTY THIRD
TEARING DOWN THE WALLS BETWEEN
ACTS ACTS ACTS WINES AND MADE
SO MANY KIDS FEEL. LIKE THEY
BELONG YEAH I MEAN I GUESS I'M
JUST TRYING TO MAKE KIDS. FEEL
COMFORTABLE PLAYING WITH TOYS
FROM. FROM BOTH A GIRL AND BOYS
TO. THANK YOU. THANK ALL RIGHT-
I THINK MISS SOURCES TESTIFYING-
IN LIEU OF MISTER SMITH IS THAT
CORRECT. ZUMA'S SORES ON THE
PHONE. WELL LET'S LET'S GO TO
OTHERS AND SUPPORT IN THE MISS
SOURCE TURNS UP WILL ALLOW HER
ENOUGH TO TESTIFY ALL RIGHT
OTHERS IN SUPPORTING THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE IN- ROOM
ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE ON THE
PHONE LINES MR THE PHONE LINES
THOSE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU AREN'T
A PART OF AB ONE ZERO EIGHT OR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF FOUR
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS TOMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER LINE REALLY Q.
DANIEL GOOD CARE OF ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALREADY
LET'S NOW TURN TO. HELLO HELLO
YES. THIS IS ANDRE PARK I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO SPEAK BUT
UNFORTUNATELY YOU COULDN'T HEAR
ME ALL RIGHT. YOU'RE YOU'RE NOW
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU BRIGHTEN YOUR LEADER
AND AN INSPIRATION I FELT WOULD
BE WISE TO LISTEN TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE MORE. HI MY NAME IS
ANJALI FORTHCOMING EXECUTIVE AT
THE FLUID PROJECT AND GENDER
FREE FASHION BRANDS I DON'T GET
TO IT OUR GENDER BENDING
EXPANDED TRAINING PLATFORM
OPERA CORPORATION I'M THINKING
TODAY THE PROFESSIONAL INVOLVED
IN THE SPACE BUT ALSO AS A
MOTHER. A MOTHER WHO IS TRYING
HARD TO READ HER CHILD FREE
FROM OUTDATED GENDER ROLES AND
STEREOTYPES THAT SOCIETY PLACES
UPON US. LET'S BEGIN BY NOTING
THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING TODAY IS
NOTHING NEW LIKE WE HEARD
EARLIER MAJOR RETAILERS ARE
ALREADY ADOPTING MEASURES TO BE
GENDER THE DEPARTMENTS. TARGET
HAS ADOPTED GENDER NEUTRAL BABY
CLOTHING DATE THE GENDERED TOYS
AND BEDDING AND WHO WILL DO THE
SAME. WITH KIDS SHOES- IF I USE
MY THE- MY SON PLAYS WITH HIS
DOLL. THESE CALL AND TAKE WALKS
IN THEIR STROLLER AND I'M
INCREDIBLY PLEASED BY THEIR
BECAUSE RESEARCH SHOWS THIS
PRACTICE. CAN LEAD TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A MORE SENSITIVE
CARING HUMAN UNFORTUNATELY
DESTROYED WOULD BE CONSIDERED
GIRL WICE BY MANY. BAD
BASKETBALL. HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW
TO BE TRUE SOCIETAL
EXPECTATIONS AROUND GENDER
IMPACT EACH AND EVERYONE OF US.
WE ARE LIMITED BY GENDER BINARY
CONSTRUCTS ALL OF US. BOYS ARE
RAISED FULL OF AMBITION
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUCCESS HOLD
WHICH CHOICE THEY CAN PLAY
WITHIN WHICH THEY CAN. GIRLS
ARE TAUGHT TO BE NURTURING ME
AND CRYING BUT EQUALLY LIMITING
SELECTION OF TOYS. IF YOU WALK
THROUGH A TYPICAL RETAILER YOU
WILL FIND A GIRL SECTION FULL
OF PINK AND GLITTER WITH
LANGUAGE. LIKE MILE STAY HAPPY.
BUT OTHER SIDE OF AISLE WITH
BLUE AND GRAY WITH GLAND
READING. LEGEND FUTURE-
HOPEFULLY RETAILERS WILL WAKE
UP ONE DAY BUT HOW MUCH LONGER
WILL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN HAVE
TO WAIT. CHILDREN WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PLAY AND EXPRESS
THEMSELVES WITH THEIR OWN
CREATIVITY GROW UP TO HAVE A
GREATER AWARENESS OF THEIR
IDENTITY AND SELF ESTEEM AND
BECOME AGENTS OF GENDER
EQUALITY. I REALIZE THIS MAY
SEEM. SMALL AND PERHAPS
INCONVENIENT FOR SOME BUT
DECONSTRUCTING THE AREA IS JUST
THE BEGINNING OF UNLEASHING A
YOUNGER PERSON FULL POTENTIAL.
WE ARE CAPABLE OF AND I BELIEVE
RESPONSIBLE TO CREATE SAFE
SPACES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR ALL
PEOPLE REALLY CAN'T. START.
THANK YOU THE SOURCE IF YOU
COULD WRAP IT UP. SURE I JUST
WANNA WRAP THAT THEY THINK
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND I REALLY AM VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE SELF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION MISTER GREG BIRD IN
OPPOSITION TO. AB. ONE ZERO
EIGHT FOUR. SURE REMEMBERS MY
NAME'S GREG BIRD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL AND REMOVING THE BAN
ON SEPARATING CHILDREN'S
CLOTHES AND TOYS BY SEX AND NOW
CHILDREN'S CLOTHES HAVE BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE BILL AS WELL
SO THAT'S GOOD. BUT WE STILL
OBJECT TO THE STATE DICTATING
TO RETAIL STORES HOW TO MARKET
THEIR PRODUCTS TO THE CUSTOMERS
FIRST OFF THE BILL IS CONFUSING
AND IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLY WITH
THE BILL REQUIRES A RETAIL
STORE TO CREATE A GENDER
NEUTRAL SECTION OR A REASONABLE
NUMBER OF EIGHT ITEMS ARE TO BE
PLACED. BUT THE BILL DOES NOT
THE FINAL WORD REASONABLE NOR
DOES IT EXPLAIN WHAT ITEMS
SHOULD BE PLACED IN THE JUNE
GENDER NEUTRAL SECTION. IF A
PARTICULAR ITEM IS INCLUDED.
WON'T THAT GIVES SOME A CHILD
OR ACTIVIST A REASON TO
COMPLAIN WHO WILL RESOLVE THESE
DISPUTES. NO STORE WILL EVER BE
ABLE TO KNOW FOR SURE IF
THEY'RE COMPLYING. A BILL LIKE
THIS ALTHOUGH ALSO OPENS THE
DOOR TO A NEVER. ENDING NUMBER
OF COMPLAINTS FROM ACTIVIST
GROUPS WHO DON'T LIKE THE WAY
STORES ARE MARKETING THEIR
PRODUCTS TO ONE SEX OR ANOTHER.
RETAIL STORES HAVE A RIGHT TO
BE LEFT ALONE TO DECIDE HOW
BEST TO MARKET THE PRODUCTS TO
THEIR CUSTOMERS BASED ON WHAT
MARKET RESEARCH TELLS THEM THE
CONSUMERS WANT. IT WILL NOT BE
PERFECT THEY WILL GET IT WRONG
SOMETIMES BUT WHEN THEY GET IT
WRONG THAT PRODUCT WON'T SELL.
THE MARKET MARKET WILL DO A
BETTER JOB OF MEETING PUBLIC
NEEDS AND THEN YOUR LAW WILL. A
LITTLE MARKER SEE THAT PROTECTS
THE FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION LIKE
CARS. NO INDIVIDUAL OR
LEGISLATOR HAS THE RIGHT TO
TELL A COMPANY OWNER WHAT
MESSAGES ABOUT GENDER THEY CAN
USE TO SELL THEIR PRODUCTS.
STATE LEGISLATORS NEED TO STOP
FORCING THEIR PERSONAL OPINIONS
UPON THOSE THEY DISAGREE WITH.
THIS IS THE ILLEGAL USE OF
POWER. LEGISLATOR SHOULD
RESPECT THE VIEWS OF OTHER
PEOPLE AND TRIED TO PERSUADE
THEM TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS
INSTEAD OF USING THEIR
LEGISLATIVE POWER TO FORCE
THEIR VIEWS ON OTHERS. IT'S A
VIOLATION OF FREE SPEECH
BECAUSE IT'S COMPELLED THE
GOVERNMENT SPEECH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
STRONGLY OPPOSES AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR ENCOURAGES THIS COMMITTEE
TO REJECT THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
ZERO EIGHT FOUR PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELF KNOWN. IF YOU ARE IN A
POSITION OF. EIGHTY ONE ZERO
EIGHT FOUR ONE NINE ZERO YEAH.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FIVE
HUNDRED GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
FIVE HUNDRED YOU'RE OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO. SO I HAD.
SOME QUESTIONS OR SHELL CON
CONCERNED WOMEN FOR AMERICA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU NOW I'M-
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
FOUR NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THE BRAND BUT IT'S
AN ADVENTURE CUCAMONGA IN
OPPOSITION. BY NUMBER FOUR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE HUNDRED ALL. OKAY MY
NUMBER. FOUR SIXTY FIVE- THE
CLOTHES. THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER THAN THE Q.
MESSENGER. ALREADY THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB.
ONE ZERO EIGHT FOUR. I DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE QUEUED UP AND AS OF
RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT BRING IT
BACK TO THE CHAMBER- QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- C. NG NONE IS THERE A
MOTION. SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES
THE BILL ALL RIGHT- WOULD YOU
CARE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BAR CAMERAS WE HAVE A SIMILAR
NUMBER LOW THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I HAVE A
AND YOUR HARD WORK TODAY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
THEN CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL YEAH THIS IS
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY FOUR BY A
FAMILY MEMBER HELLO WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AMBERG HI AMBER
GUY BURGESS. PORGES NO PARTY AT
ALL. DID I SO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HI HURTS BERG. JONES
JONES NO LAYERED SKINNER STERN
WAY CASKEY. YOU HAVE TO DO TO
WITH- MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT ON CALL- I'M GOING TO
ASK FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BOARD JUST TO TAKE OVER THE
CHAIR PERSONS SHIP HERE
MOMENTARILY. YES ALL RIGHT. THE
DO YOU HAVE THE CON. I BELIEVE.
WE HAVE- SOME REMEMBER CORREO
IS NOT PRESENT BUT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER HAS BEEN
HERE FOR QUITE SOME TIME
WAITING I SAW HIM JUST A MOMENT
AGO- AND AFTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
COOPER WOULD BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIS WHO'S ALSO BEEN HERE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. AND WE'LL GIVE
THEM JUST A MOMENT TO ARRIVE
AND I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN HERE ON ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT B. TEN TWENTY. IT
COMES ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER I'M GONNA LEAVE YOU IN
THE VERY CAPABLE HANDS OF
CENTER BOARD JUST THANK YOU MR
CHAIR. QUESTION CAN. THANK YOU.
WE GOOD ALL RIGHTS. OKAY MOVING
ON TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
D. B. THREE EIGHT SIX- BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER- DO YOU
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN ANALYSIS ON PAGE
NINE COMMENTS FIVE YES. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT- THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THE THING IS IF YOUR
COLLEAGUES WITH ALL THE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS OUR PENSION SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING TO DO THEIR PART. TO
PROTECT THE POSITIONS IN THE
PENSIONS OF OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS. MET A BRICK HOUSE THE
BATHROOM I RAN BACK IN THE
BATHROOM. SO THE CATCH MY
BREATH. A. B. THREE SIX IS
INTENDED TO GIVE OUR PUBLIC
PENSIONS THE DELETE ACCESS
EVERY TOOL POSSIBLE TO INVEST
AND MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S PENSION
FUNDS. WITH BILL CREATED PUBLIC
RECORDS DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE
THAT WILL ALLOW PUBLIC CITIZENS
SYSTEMS LIKE CALPERS TO GUESS
WE PURSUE INVESTMENTS IN THE
PRIVATE LOAN MARKET. THE SAME
WAY YOUR FINANCIAL INFORMATION
IS HELD CONFIDENTIAL BY YOUR
MORTGAGE COMPANY THE BILLS
THAT'S BASED TREASURE TO
PROTECT A BORROWER'S
INFORMATION. IF THE PENSION
SYSTEM'S WOMEN'S CAPITAL
THROUGH A PRIVATE LOAN
AGREEMENT. SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL SO THE PAY STRUCTURE TO
BRING THESE INVESTMENTS IN
HOUSE WITH THE PAY OUTSIDE
FIRMS TO MANAGE THESE LOANS.
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE PROVIDE
CERTAINTY FOR POTENTIAL
BORROWERS IN BY BRINGING THE
THIS WORK IN HOUSE CALPERS CAN
SAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN FEES THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE TO PAY. TO OUTSIDE FIRMS
LIKEWISE IS BILLED UNDER THE
EXISTING POLICIES OF CALPERS.
BOARD WHICH THE POLLS THE
PUBLIC INFORMATION AND IN HOUSE
PROCESSES FOR TRANSPARENCY
PURPOSES. I'VE TAKEN IS THAT
THE MINISTER CHRISTMAS
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL NUMBER ONE
PROVIDE INFORMATION FOR
COLLATERAL THE CONSTITUENT
OWNERS. NEVER TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
INFORMATION ON THE ORIGINAL
LOAN NUMBER THREE BY FIVE YEAR
SUNSET. WITH ME TODAY ARE DANNY
BROWN CALPERS LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS DIVISION CHIEF WHO'S A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. RIGHT
MOVING ON TO FOLKS WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF BELIEVE
WE HAVE A- DANNY BROWN HERE TO
SUPPORT MODERATE CAN YOU- YEAH-
ABOUT PHYSICALLY PRESENT YES
PRESIDENT ALL RIGHT GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
DANNY BROWN. THE CALPERS BOARD
OF ADMINISTRATION THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL. LET ME START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE HARD WORK THAT THEY PUT
IN ON THIS BILL- EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX CREATES A DISCLOSURE
STRUCTURE THAT WILL PROVIDE
CALPERS INTERNAL STAFF. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECTLY LEND
MONEY TO PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES. BRINGING SOME OF THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE LOANS IN
HOUSE WILL ALLOW US TO REDUCE
FEES WE PAY TO EXTERNAL
INVESTMENT MANAGERS. WHILE ALSO
GIVING US MORE CONTROL OVER THE
LOANS WE MAKE. WHEN MAKING
THESE LOANS STAFF WE NEED TO
ENSURE THE LOANS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE POLICIES SET BY THE
BOARD AND THE THIRTY DELEGATED
TO THEM IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE CALPERS BOARD IS
FULLY BRIEFED ON INVESTMENT
DEAL FLOW. BEGINNING TO END AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE INVESTMENT
TEAM AS A TO DO SHOULD
RESPONSIBILITY TO INFORM THE
BOARD. IF AN INVESTMENT IS
PROBLEMATIC OR OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH POLICIES. IT
OVERALL INVESTMENT STRATEGY.
FOR THIS IS STRUCK IS NOT NEW.
IT IS A MODELED AFTER THE
PROTECTIONS ALREADY PROVIDED.
IN CURRENT LAW TORCH DURABLE
MANAGERS WHO MANAGE PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS FOR US- THEREFORE
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSED
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS BALANCE
EXISTING MARKET EXPECTATIONS
WITH THE NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY
IN CALPERS INVESTMENT
ACTIVITIES. AND I THINK YOU AND
I JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
BUT LET'S MOVE ON TO WINE- ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
SEEING NONE OF MOVING INTO
OVERFLOW IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THE THREE BODIES AND ONE TWELVE.
NO ONE APPEARS TO BE- TO BE
PRESIDENT ALL RIGHT- MODERATOR
MOVING ONTO TELECONFERENCE DO
WE HAVE ANY FOLKS- IN THE QUEUE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
IF SO PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW
MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY IF YOU ARE IN FOURTH OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SIX PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THAT IS SUPPORTED
A. B. THREE EIGHT SIX. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN THE
QUEUE. FIRST FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FOR THE LINE OPEN. HELLO SHARE
MEMBERS STILL GET THIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. FOR THANK YOU WE
HAVE MY NUMBER FIVE TWENTY FOUR.
I KNOW I AM A COCOA. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHECKING-
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO.
THEN WE WILL GO TO NINE NUMBER
FIVE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS
STARTING IN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SUPPORT.
FOR ZERO AND WE HAVE MY NUMBER
FOUR FIFTY FIVE. THANK GOOD
EVENING AFTER TEARING MEMBER
SPENDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THERE ARE NO OTHER THAN
THE QUEUE THERE ARE LET'S DO-
ONE FINAL ASK ANYBODY ELSE-
WISHING TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT.
OF PLEASE- QUEUE UP RIGHT NOW
LET'S ASK ONE LAST TIME
MODERATOR. IF YOU ARE IN PART
OF AB THREE EIGHT. ONE NINE
ZERO. IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX. ALL RIGHT DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WERE GONNA GONNA FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A DAVID
SOROS ON THE LINE IN- IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR IS THERE A
MISTER SORES ON THE LINE. IN
HIS LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR HUNDREDS OF REASONS
THANK YOU I'M DAVID STORES WITH
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION RETIRED AFTER
THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
PROSECUTOR IN SILICON VALLEY.
ALSO REPRESENTED PROSECUTORS
AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TODAY I'M
WONDERING WHEN I'M GOING TO
TELL MY TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS ABOUT THE BAD FAITH AND
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY THE
CALPERS USED TO BRING THEIR
LENDING SECRECY BILL BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE HEALTH KERR
STOOD BEFORE THE LAST CANADIAN
AGREED TO TAKE ART THE
AMENDMENT. BUT THOSE AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE STILL IN PRINT HAVE
DISAPPEARED TODAY IT CHANGED
NOT EVEN MENTIONED BY CALPERS
REPRESENTATIVES WHEN WE MET
WITH THEM AFTER THE LAST
COMMITTEE WHAT WE DIDN'T LEARN
IN THAT MEETING IS THAT A
STRATEGY THAT IS PRESENTED TO
US AS A HIGH RETURN ALONG WITH
DISTRESSED BORROWERS IS
ACTUALLY INTENDED TO SECURE LOW
INTEREST LOANS TO BILLIONAIRES
WHO ALREADY COLLECT. HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS IN FEES THAT ARE
PROJECED TO EXCEED CALPERS AND
HIGHER OPERATING BUDGET IN THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR THE SWEETHEART
LOANS OF PUBLIC TRUST FUNDS TO
BILLIONAIRES WILL BE EXEMPT
FROM ANY DISCLOSURE OF
COLLATERAL WORK TERMS ALLOWING
BOTH USED TO BE SIMPLY POCKET.
THE CALPERS CEO AND BOARD
PRESIDENT RECENTLY ADMITTED TO
COVERING UP THEIR CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICERS UNLAWFUL
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST. WITH THE
SAME BILLIONAIRE. RESIN FORMER.
ADMITTED A LITTLE TAKING SURE.
FULL OF CASH THAT REGION WITH
SAME. BILLIONAIRES WHEN I STUDY
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW FORTY YEARS
AGO I WAS TAUGHT THAT THERE
MUST BE NARROWLY TAILORED BASES
FOR OVERRIDING AND EXPRESS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S ARTICLE ONE
SECTION THREE RIGHT NOW. WHAT
SHOULD I TELL MY TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS THERE'S A
COMPELLING INTEREST IN LANDING
PUBLIC TRUST FORMS ON SECRET
TOMBS THE BILLIONAIRES THAT
OUTWEIGHS THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
KNOW. HOW THEIR GOVERNMENT
CONDUCTS THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR SERVERS
MOVING ON TO THE GALLERY IN THE
OTHER FOLKS WISHING TO OFFER
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NINE MOVING INTO OVERFLOW ONE
TWELVE ALSO SEEING NONE
MODERATOR IN A MOVING ON TO
TELECONFERENCE ANY FOLKS IN THE
QUEUE IF SO HOW MANY- WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB-
THREE EIGHTY SIX. IF YOUR
OPPOSITION IS EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
S. OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN THREE
EIGHTY SIX. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE REMIND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO SIMPLY
STATE THEIR NAME AND THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION MY
NUMBER. FOUR SIXTY NINE. JACQUE
HAWK FORD THREE FIFTY THOUSAND
BALLY AND THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION IN THE STRONG GROUP
POSSIBLE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER FIVE TWENTY. HELLO THIS
IS DAVID ROSENBAUM ARE SPEAKING
FOR POSSIBLE FREE CALIFORNIA
ALSO AN EXTREMELY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WHAT.
ALL MEDICAL BOOK A LINE. FOR
FIFTY FOUR. J. J. KILLEN SAID
BETTER FISHERY A NON PUBLIC
SECURITY INTEREST IN COLLATERAL
IS NOT PROTECTED OR FORCIBLE I
ASKED FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
WE NEED SIGN NUMBER. FOUR FORTY
ONE. I WASN'T GIVEN A NUMBER
MAYBE THAT MANY. IT IS. OKAY
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS SIKI
WEBBER AND THE LEGISLATIVE LAY
UPON THE PEACE AND FREEDOM
PARTY CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO
CALPERS STAKEHOLDER RESORT
ABOUT MY PENSION I'M OPPOSED.
AND AS THE THANK YOU. THANKS
THERE ARE NO OTHER THING QUEUE
AND THAT IS THE POSITION OF.
838-611-1011 LAST REQUEST IN.
JUST LET ME KNOW. PROVISION OF.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THREE ONE
ZERO. WELL WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE QUEUED UP AT THOSE NOW
MISTER YEAH WAIT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK
ROOM NOISE. OR SOME OTHER
ONLINE. ALL RIGHT- HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
BRING IT BACK TO THE FLOOR SAID
EARLIER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR- I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR IT IS
ALWAYS KIND OF FUNNY BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T FACE THE AUTHOR WHILE
YOU'RE ASKING THE QUESTIONS AND
BE ON THE MARK BUT- FIRST. THE
WITNESS FROM THE RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND OUR ANALYSIS SAYS
THE H. R. AMENDMENTS THAT THEY
REQUESTED WERE TAKEN- AND HE
SAID IN HIS TESTIMONY THAT.
THEY WEREN'T TAKEN COULD YOU
CLARIFY WHETHER YOU HAVE TAKEN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY OFFER.
WE TOOK A MINISTRY COMMITTEE
AND MR STORIES NEVER GIVES
AMENDMENTS ARE COULD YOU
PREPARE MYSELF SORRY. WE TOOK A
MINUTE FOR THE COMMITTEE MR
SOARES NEVER DO WITH AMENDMENTS.
THEY WERE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
I BELIEVE IT WAS ON PAGE NINE
ABOUT THE AUTHOR ATTESTED TO
ACCEPTING- IF THAT MIGHT ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OKAY IT ON PAGE TEN
IT SAYS THEY WERE PLEASED WITH
THE OMIT AMENDMENTS BUT HE SAID
IN HIS TESTIMONY THAT THEY HAD
SO IT IF IN FACT THERE ARE MANY
MYTHS THEY HAVE WOULD YOU
CONSIDER THEM IT SOUNDS LIKE
FROM THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
THAT. I MEAN COULD YOU REVIEW
pWERE THESE CENTER THAT WAS ALL
THE DISINGENUOUS STATEMENT BY
MR SOROS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE TO TELL YOU IT WAS
DISINGENUOUS ON HIS PART. SO
YOU DON'T BELIEVE THEY HAVE
OFFERED YOU ANY AMENDMENTS.
THEY MAY HAVE OFFERED WAS A
CALIPER THAT WE TAKE THEIR NAME
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BACK AND FORTH BUT I
MEAN THE WHOLE I'VE I'VE I'VE
BEEN HERE SEVEN YEARS SENATOR
AND JUST THE WHOLE INFLAMMATORY
BILLIONAIRES THE BOOGEYMAN AND
DISPLAYS STATEMENT ALONE- VERY
INFLAMMATORY OUR GET THAT
THAT'S INFLAMMATORY IF HE'S A
CONSTITUENT AND I KNOW HIM OKAY
AND- IF HE SAID THEY OFFER
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE HIM SO.
LET'S JUST TRY TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE DISHES THEY'VE
OFFERED. AMENDMENTS I WOULD
HOPE YOU WOULD LOOK AT THEM.
EIGHT AND SIX SECOND WORRY-
THERE WAS TESTIMONY AGAINST AND
THERE IS IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS
FROM VERY VERY S- CLIMATE
ACTIVISTS PHILOSOPHY CALIFORNIA
AND THERE WASTHE- THE THREE
FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND YET
WHEN I READ THE ANALYSIS IT
DOESN'T TELL ME WHY- ADVOCATES
IN CLIMATE WOULD OPPOSE THE
BILL DO YOU KNOW COULD YOU
SPEAK TO THAT AT ALL. I'M NOT
SURE THE RATIONALE IS HERE WITH
HER THINKING IS. THEN THE MAIN
ISSUE I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT.
IS THAT WHEN THIS BILL CAME UP
IN THE PRIOR COMMITTEE. I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE BE ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN
PERS. THAT IF THERE'S NOT
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF THESE
LOANS OR THE TRANSACTIONS WHICH-
MAY WELL BE TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE- THAT PRIVATELY THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF PURSE
WOULD HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
BE ABLE TO BE ON TOP OF THIS
AND IF THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T RIGHT. IT WOULD. ARE
THERE WOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY
THROUGH THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
ELECTED BOARD MEMBERS OF HERS.
BANNON ASKING PERSON AT THAT
HEARING I COULDN'T GET A CLEAR
ANSWER IN THE LETTER- THAT CAME
SUBSEQUENTLY. TALKS ABOUT THEIR
PROCESS FOR DAT IN LOTS OF
OTHER THINGS BUT IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO ADDRESS THAT CLEARLY
AND THEN SOMEBODY SENT ME-
SOMEBODY SENT ME A STATEMENT
THAT SAYS ALL INVESTMENT
DOCUMENTS ARE MADE AVAILABLE TO
THE BOARD PRIOR TO AND AFTER
UNDERWRITING IF THE STAFF
BELIEVES THERE'S ANY PROBLEM
WITH AN EXISTING OR PENDING
INVESTMENT THAT IS FRAUDULENT
DISCLOSURE DOCUMENTS ARE
POTENTIAL DEFAULT STAFF IS
REQUIRED TO INFORM THE BOARD OF
ANY CONCERNS AND ANY BOARD
MEMBER CAN REQUEST ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTS FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION. THIS IS THERE
SOMEBODY THAT STILL ON THE LINE
FROM PURSE THEY COULD SAY
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S TRUE
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T COME CLEARLY
FROM THE LOBBYIST AND IT
DIDN'T- GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
PERSON IT DIDN'T COME CLEARLY
IN THE LETTER BUT IT COMES
CLEARLY IN THAT STATEMENT IS
THAT STATEMENT TRUE. THROUGH
THE CHAIR. SENATOR MISTER BROWN
ZERO LIKE TO HAVE AN ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. THE CARD IS THE
MIKE BACK ON ARE THERE WE GO-
MISTER BROWN YOU WOULD YOU-
CARROT DANCER THAT. THE MIKE'S
NOT ON THERE HI THERE. YEAH
GOING ON NOW OKAY- THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- SENATOR
LAYERED AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT BEING ABLE TO CLEARLY-
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION THE FIRST
TIME- WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT FOR
THE MOST PART THAT IS TRUE BUT
I WOULD BE RELUCTANT TO SAY
THAT ALL DOCUMENTS ARE
PROVIDED. YOU KNOW TO THE BOARD
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A LOT OF
DOCUMENTS THAT STUFF LOOKS
LOOKS OUT BUT ULTIMATELY THE
BOARD AS FIDUCIARIES ARE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ALL INVESTMENT
DECISIONS THEN THEY SET THE
POLICIES AND DELEGATE.
AUTHORITY TO STAFF TO MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS BUT THE STAFF
MUST KEEP THE BOARD INFORMED OF
THE INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'RE
MAKING WHILE THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS SO THEY ARE
KEPT INFORMED THEIR PROVIDED
INFORMATION AS THE BILL'S GOING
AS OF PROPOSALS GOING THROUGH
DUE DILIGENCE ONCE A PROPOSAL
IS- FINALIZED UNDER THEIR BOARD
DELEGATED AUTHORITY AT ANY ANY
TIME SOMETHING FALLS OUT OF
THE- OUT OF THE- IS. OUT OF THE
BOARD POLICY OR DELEGATED
AUTHORITY THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
BRING THAT TO THE BOARD'S
ATTENTION AND OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
GOING TO BRING ANY OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT MAY ARISE WITH
THAT. ENTITY THAT MAY IMPACT
THE INVESTMENT TO THE BOARD'S
ATTENTION THEN THEN MAYBE I
SHOULD GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
QUESTION OF THE LAST HEARING.
AND THAT QUESTION WAS
BASICALLY- IF THE BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING FEES
OR HAS THE ACCOUNTABILITY HOW
DID THEY KNOW. ONE ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL TRANSACTIONS IS
FLAWED BECAUSE THE ANSWER THAT
THREW US OFF IN THE LAST
HEARING WAS. THEY COULD REQUEST
PAPERS OR BACKGROUND DOCUMENTS
ABOUT ANY TRANSACTION BUT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO KNOW THAT THAT
TRANSACTION IS FLAWED OR
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE AND
WHEN I WAS TRYING TO GET AT. IS
HOW WAS THEIR ACCOUNTABILITY
HOW DO THEY KNOW WITHOUT THEM
HAVING TO GUESS WHERE THERE'S A
PROBLEM. IN A WAY THAT THERE'S
TRUE ACCOUNTABILITY BY KEEPING
THIS PRIVATE. BUT HAVING A
PUBLICLY ELECTED BOARD THAT IS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ANNA. ANNA OKAY
AND THE REASON I GO BACK TO
THAT QUESTION IS I'M NOT SURE
YOU JUST AGREED TO THE
STATEMENT THAT I READ TO YOU
THAT ONE OF THE ADVOCATES GAVE
TO ME. THAT ADDRESSES THAT
ISSUE SO LET'S GO BACK TO THAT.
SO HOW DO WE KNOW THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE BOARD
IN THESE TRANSACTIONS. IN YOUR
UNIT ADDRESSING THAT TO MISTER
BROWN OR YES ANDREW THE CHAIR
TO MISTER BROWN SORRY WE WERE
HAVING A DIALOGUE SO- SURE- SO
THE- STAFF. BRINGS THOSE TO THE
BOARD'S ATTENTION THE BOARD
REQUIRES CERTAIN INFORMATION TO
COME TO THE BOARD- FOR THESE
INVESTMENTS SO THOSE WOULD BE
BROUGHT TO THE BOARD'S
ATTENTION FROM FROM STAFF THEY
COULD ALSO BE BROUGHT TO THE
BOARD'S ATTENTION. THROUGH
THEIR- INDEPENDENT. CONSULTANT
THAT THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT TO
OVERSEE THE INVESTMENTS AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY THEY MAY PICK UP
SOMETHING THEMSELVES FOR A
STAKEHOLDER. NEWSPAPER OR
SOMETHING COMES TO THEIR
ATTENTION THEY MAY I STAFF
THOSE SO. I THINK THERE'S A
NUMBER OF AVENUES BUT
ULTIMATELY. I THINK IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
INVESTMENT TEAM TO- FIGURE
THOSE THINGS OUT AND BRING
THOSE TO THE BOARD'S ATTENTION
SO THEY'RE AWARE OF THE- WEAR
OF THEM THEYCAN GIVE THEM
EXTRA SCRUTINY. IF THEY NEED TO.
THEN. OKAY THEN LET ME DRIVE
THIS IS A THIRD WAY IF IT'S
OKAY THROUGH THE CHAIR. BOMB.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT SOMETHING
DOESN'T GO ON FOR A WHILE
BEFORE IT'S BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF THE BOARD R. I
MEAN WERE BEING ASKED TO TAKE A
LEAP HERE AND I THINK IN
EXCHANGE FOR TAKING AWAY WE
WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ABILITY TO
GET ON A PROBLEM IN SHORT ORDER.
I MEAN THE- WELL THE WAY TOO
FAR AWAY FROM THE C. SPEAKER
HER THE MIKE- I MEAN THE BOARD.
IS THE FIDUCIARY SO THEY HAVE
ULTIMATE RESPONSIBILITY OF ALL
INVESTMENTS AND THEN THE STAFF
ALSO HAS A FIDUCIARY DUTY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE MAKING.
INVESTMENTS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR OF OUR-
RECIPIENTS AND OBVIOUSLY THERE
ARE LEGAL ISSUES THAT THEY
DON'T DO THAT THEY CAN GET SUED
THERE'S- YOU KNOW STIRS-
STAKEHOLDERS WILL BRING IT TO
YOU KNOW BRING. THIS UP TO THEM
I MEAN THERE'S OBVIOUSLY- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OVERSIGHT IF
THEY'RE NOT DOING THE RIGHT
THING SO RIGHT I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY THEY HAVE
TO PUT IN PLACE THE SAFEGUARDS
SO THAT THE STAFF KNOWS WHEN TO
BRING THINGS TO THEIR ATTENTION
AND STAFF HAS THE EXPERTISE TO
KNOW WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH THE PARTICULAR INVESTMENT.
THAT CONCLUDES YOUR INQUIRY YES
IT DOES I. I STILL FEEL
AMBIVALENT. BUT I APPRECIATE
THE EXCHANGE HAVEN'T FIGURED
OUT WHAT I'M GONNA DO YET THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
INDULGENCE. OF THE COMMITTEE
BEEN A LONG HERE I ALWAYS
PROMOTE- DIALOGUE AND EXCHANGE.
NOW MOVING ON TO OUR OUR
FEARLESS CHAIRMAN I DO BELIEVE
HE WANTED TO PARTICIPATE. WELL
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EXCELLENT
CHAIRMANSHIP THERE I'M GONNA
LEAVE YOU AS THE CHAIR HERE
UNTIL WE FINISH THIS BILL- AND
I MISSED SOME OF THE COLLOQUY.
BUT FOLLOWING ON TO WHAT I
THINK CENTER LAYERED WAS
TALKING ABOUT- IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND I KNOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER YOU WHAT
I'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS BILL WE
SPENT SOME TIME. TRYING TO
CONTINUE THAT QUEST FOR
ADEQUATE TRANSPARENCY AND STILL
FULFILLING THE GOAL WHICH IS-
MAKING SURE THAT IN A- WAY THAT
THE TAXPAYERS CAN BE PROUD OF.
THAT THAT WE MAXIMIZE PROFIT
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT I RECALL
YOU YOU'RE CONTINUING
COMMITMENT. TO WORK ON THIS TO
TRY TO MEET BOTH OF THOSE
GOALS- I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS
TODAY- YOU'VE ADDED A SUNSET
WE'VE ADDED A SUNSET AND ALSO.
A PROVISION THAT UP PROVIDED
FOR THE TRANSPARENCY AS TO THE
CONSTITUENT OWNERS. BUT I TRUST
YOU WILL CONTINUE THAT QUEST.
TERMS OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY. YES YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT RIGHT RT THANK YOU
BACK TO YOU MR THANK YOU I JUST
HAVE A CUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR MAYBE MISTER
BROWN- MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THAT THERE WAS AN ASSUMPTION OF
A 7% RETURN- THAT HAS NOW I
THINK DROPPED AROUND. MAYBE SIX
POINT EIGHT BUT IN REAL TERMS
IT'S AROUND SIX DOES THAT SOUND
ACCURATE. THEREABOUTS. SO IT
DID GO DOWN TO SIX POINT EIGHT
DUE TO A RISK MITIGATION
STRATEGY AS A RESULT OF OUR
RECENT- RETURN RETURNS IN THE
20% RANGE BUT THE BOARD IS
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THE
ASSET LIABILITY MANAGEMENT
CYCLE NOW ALSO THAT DECISION IS
NOT GOING TO BE MADE TO LATER
THIS YEAR OR EARLY NEXT YEAR AS
TO WHETHER THE DISCOUNT RATE
WILL GO DOWN EITHER EVEN
FURTHER IT'S REALLY A POOR
DECISION AND SO WE'RE JUST
GOING THROUGH THAT PROCESS BUT
IT IS POSSIBLE TO GO DOWN
FURTHER THAN SIX POINT EIGHT.
OKAY AND- IF THERE IS IF THERE
IS A LOSS- WHAT IS THE STATE'S
ROLE. AT SOME POINT IF THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL LOSS. OF THE STATE
IS EXPECTED TO STEP IN AND MAKE
A CONTRIBUTION IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE. IT IS ACCURATE FOR
THE STATE PLANS BUT NOT FOR THE
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH US THE SCHOOLS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT THE
STATE HAS FIVE PLANTS IS SO TO
THE EXTENT WE DON'T HIT OUR-
RATE OF RETURN. THE
CONTRIBUTION RATES WILL GO UP
FOR THE STATE GOT IT GOT IT. I
THINK THERE'S SOME STRONG
ARGUMENTS BACK AND FORTH ON
THIS CALPERS WANTING TO- PURSUE
MORE- RISKY BUT- LUCRATIVE-
INVESTMENTS. ARE TO DRIVE UP ON
THE PRTFOLIO AND THEN OF
COURSE YOU HAVE THE PUBLIC-
EXPECTATION OF ACCESS GIVEN IT
BEING A PUBLIC. SEMI PUBLIC
ENTITY. BUT THIS IS BECAUSE
IT'S NOW MOVING INTO THE- THE
VENTURE CAPITAL THE INVESTMENT
WORLD THROUGH THIS PROCESS-
THERE'S A BIT OF A RUB ON.
KEEPING INFORMATION- EXAM FROM
THE TRADITIONAL- ACCESS POINTS
FROM THE PUBLIC- SO I THINK. I
IS THERE NOT A- HYBRID WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAYBE NOT
NECESSARILY THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL PROTOCOLS OF-
PUBLIC INFORMATION ACT- OR FOR
YOU WELL THAT'S ACTUALLY
FEDERAL BUT- PUBLIC INFORMATION
ALL RESPONSES THAT. COULD GET
MORE INFORMATION IF THERE WAS
MORE DUE DILIGENCE IN INQUIRY
BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BEYOND
THE- THE NAMES AND PRINCIPLES
AND- OTHER INFORMATION THAT YOU
AGREE TO THROUGH COMMITTEE-
AMENDMENTS. I THINK THIS RAP
RECORD CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THE RIGHT NOW THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT FOLKS DIDN'T PROVIDE
ANY INFORMATION. A CONCERT YOU
REPEAT THAT PLEASE I'M- SORRY I
MISSED YOU CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
THE PRIVATE INVESTMENT FLOWS
WITH SET UP RIGHT NOW THEY
DON'T PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION.
THE PRIVATE BROKERS AND I THINK
MISTER BROWN CAN VERIFY THAT.
IS THAT IS AN ACCURATE SIR I'M
SORRY I MENTIONED THAT EARLIER
THAT. WHEN CALPERS MOVES
THROUGH A THIRD PARTY BROKER
FOR THESE TYPES OF INVESTMENTS.
IT THEN. GOES OUTSIDE OF THE-
PUBLIC DISCLOSURE- OBLIGATIONS
THAT CORRECT- THAT IS CORRECT
THE ONLY THING THAT GETS
REPORTED OUT IS. YOU KNOW THE
PRIVATE FUND WE EAT THE
EXTERNAL MANAGER USE AND-
RETURN INFORMATION AT THE
AGGREGATE LEVEL BUT THERE'S NO
INFORMATION ON THE ACTUAL
INDIVIDUAL. LOANS OR
INVESTMENTS. GOT IT GOT IT ALL
RIGHT THAT'S HELPFUL. ALL
RIGHT- THING NO OTHER MIKES.
OFF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE UP
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OUR OUR OWN THINK INSURANCE
STAFF AN INCIDENT EARLIER FOR-
OTHER INPUT. INFORMATION TO
APPRECIATE IT. COUNSELOR WOULD
YOU- WISH TO. CALL FOR THE VOTE
I WOULD. HI THIS IS A. B. THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER. BY WITH A MOTION BY.
FOR ME THE MOST THAT'S RIGHT
THREE. I THINK- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. BILL MOTION BY- SENDER-
NUMBER. OKAY MOTION BY SENATOR
UMBERG. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI AMBER
GUY BURGESS. REWARD IS NOT
VOTING. AT ALL THE RUSSELL
GONZALEZ HURTS BERG JONES NO
JONES NO LAYERED. HEY SKINNER
STERN WHY CASKEY NO MY CASKEY
NO. OUR SERVER IT'S ONE TO TWO
WITH MANY MEMBERS MISSING. BUT
ON CALL. ALREADY THANK YOU
SENATOR BORDERS RIGHT BACK TO
OUR. FILE ORDER- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CORIO NOT HERE- NEXT WE'LL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES WITH A.
B. FIVE ZERO TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR SENATORS TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO
I'D FRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF SPECIFICALLY
TIM GRIFFITHS FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF TO MAN THE BILL WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS
AMENDMENTS UNDER CURRENT LAW
WHEN H. AWAY HOLD SELECTION FOR
ITS BOARDS OF DIRECTORS IF THEY
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
RUN FOR OPEN POSITIONS THEY
MUST STILL GO THROUGH ALL THE
FINANCIAL PROCEDURES. OF HAVING
ELECTIONS THIS PLACES A HUGE
BURDEN ON YOUR CHOICE AND
ULTIMATELY THE COST FOR THESE
UNNEEDED ELECTIONS GET FUNNELED
DOWN TO THE HOMEOWNERS A FEW
YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATORS
PASSED A MEASURE TO ALLEVIATE
THIS SITUATION BY ALLOWING
LARGE HOAS. TO DO A VOTE BY THE
COMMISSION IF THE EXACT NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO SIGNED UP TO RUN
FOR A POSITION MATCHES THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS OPEN
UNFORTUNATELY THAT MEASURE ONLY
APPLIES TO EACH ALWAYS WITH SIX
THOUSAND OR MORE UNITS. OF ALL
HOAS WERE LEFT OUT EIGHTY FIVE
A TWO IT'S A SIMPLE MEASURE TO
ENSURE THE SAME ELECTION
PROCEDURES MAY APPLY TO HOAS OF
ANY SIZE I SHOULD NOTE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
ELECTION PROCEDURES UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES IF MORE
PEOPLE SIGNED UP TO RUN THE
OPEN POSITIONS THAN THIS BILL
DOES NOT COME INTO PLAY A
REGULAR ACTION STILL HAPPENS.
IN ADDITION WITH THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS FROM THE
SOMEBODY WE GIVE HOMEOWNERS
ADDITIONAL NINETY DAYS NOTICE
ABOUT UPCOMING ELECTIONS ON TOP
OF THE EXISTING THIRTY DAY
NOTICE AND AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THIS COMMITTEE'S MANDATES THESE
NOTICES SHALL INCLUDE
INFORMATION. ON WHO HAS BEEN
NOMINATED TO RUN THUS FAR AND
WHAT PROCESSES IF NOBODY
DECIDES TO PULL PAPERS LASTLY
ACCORDINGLY TO STAKEHOLDERS
DATA AB FIVE A TWO THERE ARE
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOR
ASSOCIATIONS WITH A THOUSAND OR
MORE UNITS IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING 1% OF THE TOTAL
68% OF THE SOCIAL AGENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE FIFTY UNITS ARE
LESS TOTALING MORE THAN
3300052% OF THE ASSOCIATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BUDGETS OF LESS
THAN A. HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR
THE EXPENSE OF AND I NEEDED A
LET. COULD BE SO. I'VE WORKED
WITH OPPOSITION DISASSEMBLY AND
HERE IN THE SENATE TO TAKE
MAJORITY OF THEIR AMENDMENTS
AND MANY HAVE NOW MOVED TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION. WITH ME HERE
TODAY VIA PHONE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS MIKE VON AT THE LA
COUNTY. MAINTENANCE
CORPORATION. OF THE- COMMITTEE
MANAGER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I. VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- SO IN ORDER TO DAVIES- TOM
FEELEY FREELY IS HERE WITH US
ALSO. ANOTHER MEETING ALL RIGHT
SO- MR VAUGHN IS HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT- THOSE IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE ON THE PHONE LINE OF
MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE UP THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE ZERO
TWO. WE'D BE GRATEFUL AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE OH
TWO PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ON
NOW. AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. IANS TWEET DO YOU HAVE
ONE ON THE LINE AND WE'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. AND AGAIN
THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE OH TWO IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT BEFORE YOU GO TO THE
FIRST CALLER. LINE FIVE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MEDICARE EXTENDERS CARDS WHICH
AIRS ON THE ARAB COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE IN COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE
NEED TO HAVE ONE MORE IN THE
QUEUE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE FOR SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER
WHAT ON THE HELP OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS IN COURT.
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE ALRIGHT LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION I SEE THEIR TWO
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MARJORIE MURRAY AND-
ANY KELLY. I MISS MERRY ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. FOR MISS KELLY. ANY
KELLY OR MARJORIE MURRAY. YOU
HEAR ME I CAN HEAR YOU IT GO
AHEAD WHAT. YEAH. I DON'T HAVE
ANY. OKAY. I CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS. WELL THE WRITERS
CENTRAL TO THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION SENIORS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION. HOLDS EVERY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD TAKE
AWAY THOSE RIGHTS AND INTRODUCE.
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO ONE ONE OF
THOSE BILLS. OUR MAIN CONCERN
ABOUT IT WITH THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT THE DECISION
TO DO BOARD DIRECTOR WITHOUT A
VOTE BY THE MEMBERS. DONALD
SECRET THAT SAID WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THEM AND REQUIRING THAT THE
DECISION TO USE EXCLAMATION BE
PUT TO A VOTE AT A PUBLIC
MEETING THE SENIORS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN IT GOES
A LONG WAY. TOWARD SHEDDING
LIGHT ON THE CAR WHAT USED TO
BE A SECRET DECISION IT'S NOT A
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THESE CHANGES AS A
RESULT OF THE AMENDMENTS.
CHARACTER CALIFORNIA LINE
RETIRED AMERICAN E. YOU KNOW
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL THE WE WILL
OF COURSE. CONTINUE TO MONITOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOB. ANY
THIS ME. BUT I APOLOGIZE- ANY
KELLEY BLUE. OUR GENERAL NUMBER
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
THIS IS MARJORIE MURRAY CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION LAW. WELL WE WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT HIM GRAPHICS. PARDON
THE LANKY ABOUT HER DIFFICULT
NO. WAY OUT YOU. KNOW ALL THE
ISSUES ARE COULD BE CONSIDERED
OKAY WE ALSO WANT TO THANK. THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTING YOUR.
MODERATOR DO YOU DO WE LOSE
CONNECTION- SHE'S SO CAN I SAID
I'M NOT SURE. ONE SECOND.
MERGER YOU ON THE LINE. YES I
AM. OKAY THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
BE A GLITCH GO AHEAD WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES. THANK YOU I KNOW
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS IS THE
CHANGE FROM. ALLOWING THE
ACCLAMATION TO BE MANDATORY NOW
IT IS AN OPTIONAL CHOICE. AND
FURTHERMORE THE BOARD MUST VOTE
IN PUBLIC AT A PROPERLY NOTICED
MEETING ON THE DECISION WHETHER
TO USE ACCLAMATION. THIS IS
ALSO A MEETING AT WHICH
HOMEOWNERS HAVE A VOICE. WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
APPELLATE COURTS HAVE FOUND
THAT HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS ARE
CREATED BY GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES WHOSE POWERS AFFECT
THE LIVES AND HOME OF THE
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE IN THEM.
THEIR SELF GOVERNING COMMUNITY
MEMBERS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DECIDE. THROUGH ELECTIONS WHO
WILL GOVERN THEM. WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE BELIEVE MAY
EIGHTY FIVE ONTO A WORKABLE
BILL. WE ARE NOW IN A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THE LEGISLATION BUT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR IT
AS IT CONTINUES ITS LEGISLATIVE
GERMAN AT THE CAPITOL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR MURRAY
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN THE GALLERY
IN SUPPORT EXCUSE ME AN
OPPOSITION STRIKE THAT IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE SAYING
NOT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. BUT
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
APPOSITION TO- EIGHTY FIVE ZERO
TWO. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO UPHOLD EIGHTY FIVE
OH TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN TO UPHOLD EIGHTY FIVE OH
TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AND
IT'S LIKE WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
POSTED TO WHEREVER THAT
CRIMINAL CALIFORNIA CLOSED.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
THE KIA. OKAY BRING BACK THE
CHAMBER. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
YES SIR WHAT KELSEY I WILL MOVE
THE BILL. IS THAT WHAT COUNTS
HE MOVES THE BILL ALL RIGHT-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID YOU CARE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU COUNSEL YOU CALL THE
ROLL YES THIS IS AB FIVE OH TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR RIGHT
CASKEY THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS. AS AMENDED AMBERG HI-
BURGER I'D GORGEOUS. HE DEBBIE
AT ALL W. AT ALL HI DRESSED SO
DRESS SO I GONZALEZ HERZBERG
JONES HI JONES I LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SKINNER STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI Y. CASKEY I. YES
SIXTY ZERO WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
HE ALL RIGHT REMEMBER THE LONG
CALL. SIMPLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
IF WE WERE TO GET MEDALS MEDALS
FOR THE MOST PATIENT LEGISLATOR
TODAY YOU WOULD GET THAT MEDAL
YOU'VE BEEN WAITING VERY VERY
VERY PATIENTLY FOR QUITE SOME
TIME SO THANK YOU- THE FLOORS
NOW YEARS FINALLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BILL AND BY
THE WAY I AM PRESENTING FIRST
EVEY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT- THIS
CALL IS INTENDED TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CONSISTENTLY HAD TO FIGHT
FOR EQUAL ACCESS TO PUBLIC
SPACES AND BASIC CIVIL RIGHTS
FOR SAFETY AND INDEPENDENCE.
RATES AVAILABLE TO THOSE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES AB FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT WOULD PREVENT THE
SALE OF EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMALS AND THEIR EQUIPMENT AS
BEING MISREPRESENTED AS TO HAVE
THE SAME RATES AS A GUIDE
SIGNAL OR SERVICE DOG AND IT
WILL REQUIRE THE SALE OF
EMOTIONAL UPPORT ANIMALS AND
EQUIPMENT TO BE ACCOMPANIED BY
A WRITTEN NOTICE. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT A
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER
PROVIDING DOCUMENTATION
RELATING TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NEED. FOR AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
DOG THAT IS NOT A GUIDE SIGNAL
OR SERVICE DOG AS DEFINED.
UNLESS THE HEALTHCARE.
ACTIVATION COMPLIES WITH
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS MEMBERS
THE IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL CAME
FROM AN NPR STORY THAT I HEARD
LASTYEAR. THAT HAD A FAMILY
TALKING ABOUT HAVING ADOPTED
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS A TRAINED
ANIMAL AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMAL FOR THEIR ARTISTIC SON.
ONLY TO HAVE THAT ANIMAL TURN
AROUND AND KILLED THEIR OTHER
PETS IN FRONT OF THIS CHILD NOW
IT TURNED OUT THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO SOLD THEM THIS ANIMAL FOR A
COUPLE THOUSAND DOLLARS HAD
ADOPTED THE WEEK BEFORE FROM
THE ANIMAL SHELTER. THAT IS
BECAUSE UNDER THE LAW THERE IS
NO SUCH THING AS AN EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL THERE'S NO
TRAINING FOR AN EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL THAT'S REQUIRED.
LIKE I LIKE SERVICE DOGS AND
SERVICE ANIMALS BUT THE PUBLIC.
IS VERY CONFUSED BY THESE TERMS
AND THAT'S WHY THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE PREYING ON THIS VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND IF
YOU DON'T MIND MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO TRY TO HOLD UP A
COUPLE OF ILLUSTRATIONS. THAT
WERE RESTAURANTS AND OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ALLOW SERVICE
DOGS IN THEMSELVES ARE CONFUSED
ABOUT WHAT A SERVICE DOG IS AND
WHO'S SUPPOSED TO BE ALLOWED
INTO THEIR ESTABLISHMENT. THIS
WAS A SIGN THAT MY STOPS ON
FRONT OF TRADER JOE'S THAT SAYS
NO PETS ALLOWED. SERVICE
ANIMALS SPECIFICALLY TRAINED.
TO HELP SOME OF THE DISABILITY
ARE ALLOWED NOW. THIS IS A
SERVICE ANIMAL CALLER THAT
TELLS A RESTAURANT OR
ESTABLISHMENT THAT THAT ANIMAL
IS A TRAINED SERVICE DOG ON THE
INTERNET YOU CAN GO AND BUY
THIS CALLER THAT IS MEANT TO
LOOK PRETTY MUCH IDENTICAL TO
THE SERVICE DOG COLLAR BUT IT
SAYS EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL.
THIS PET IT. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THESE ANIMALS ARE NOT
TRAINED IN THE SOME OF MY
WITNESSES ARE GOING TO TESTIFY
HAVE ATTACKED HUMANS- THEY'VE
BEEN ATTACKS ON OTHER SIR ON
SERVICE ANIMALS AND REALLY
LEADING TO PEOPLE WHO NEED
SERVICE ANIMALS TO FEEL AFRAID
TO BRING THEIR ANIMALS INTO
THESE ESTABLISHMENTS. NOW- THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO CURTAIL
THAT MISINFORMATION AND TO HELP
TO PUSH BACK AGAINST THE
FRAUDULENT SALE OF
CERTIFICATIONS THAT IMPLIED TO
PEOPLE THAT THEIR PET WILL NOW
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS RATES AS A
SERVICE DOG THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE BNP COMMITTEES AND
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH NO
NO VOTES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
THIS EVENING IT SAYS MORNING
BLITZ EVENING AS WELL AS
CROSSMAN FROM CANINE COMPANIONS
AND RABBIT OUT FROM GUIDE DOGS
FOR THE BLIND I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL. BUT THANK YOU BEFORE
THEY TESTIFIED DO YOU ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PROPOSED ON PAGE ELEVEN AND
TWELVE YES I'M SORRY WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT- BLOODY TOWEL ONE PERSON.
WHO DO WE HAVE ON THE PHONE-
BALLS BRONZE MEN OR ROBBIE
DOLLAR BILLS. WE'VE GOT BOTH
ALL RIGHT I'LL I'LL GO FIRST MY
NAME IS WALLACE GROSSMAN I AM.
SHE'S AN ADVOCACY COORDINATOR A
CANINE COMPANIONS- I'M ALSO
SERVICE DRUG USER. MY SECOND
CANINE COMPANION SERVICE DOG.
WITH A VICTIM OF DOG ATTACKS
MULTIPLE TIMES IN OUR TWO AND A
HALF YOUR PARTNERSHIP. HE WAS
AN EXCEPTIONAL SERVICE DOG BUT
AFTER TEN INSTANCES IN PLACES
WHERE PETS DOGS AND EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS ARE NOT
PERMITTED. HE COULD NO LONGER
WORK EVEN IN MY HOME. HE WAS HE
WAS A GREAT. OF MY RETIRED
SERVICE DOG WHO WAS CAUSING HIM
STRESS JUST BY YOUR PRESENCE
BEING THERE I RETIRED MY
SERVICE DOG WORK AT AGE FOUR
AND I LOST MY INDEPENDENCE IT
TOOK ME YEARS AND IT'S STILL
WORK IN PROGRESS TO MAKE TO NOT
HAVE A DRAMATIC RESPONSE TO
DOGS THE PLACES FOR PET DOGS AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT DOGS ARE NOT
PERMITTED. THE CONFUSION AROUND
ACCESS RATES DUE TO FRAUDULENT
AND MISLEADING BUSINESS
PRACTICES IF NOT VICTIMLESS ITS
IMPACT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
WHO TRULY RELY ON SERVICE DOGS
TO LEAD INDEPENDENT LIVES I AM
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIX EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOT ROBBIE
DIAL. THANK YOU MR CHAIR OF
THANK YOU MEMBERS. I WANNA
COLLECT ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SHOWN HERE WHAT THEY'D BE
FORCED SIXTY EIGHT IS ALL
ABOUT. IS THE PROTECTION OF
PRICE FOR INVIOLABLE POPULATION
THAT DEPENDS. ON THE- RIGHT BUT
WHAT HARD TO EARN. TO ALLOW US
TO PARTICIPATE. FULLY ABOUT
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SAFELY
WITH DIGNITY AS WELL- IN A
RECENT SURVEY THAT SHE SHE I
CONDUCTED. 79% OF. SERVICE
ANIMAL USERS REPORTED THAT
THEIR- SERVICE ANIMAL WATCH A
TRACK CALLED- LUNGED OUT. I
UNCONTROLLED ANIMALS IN PUBLIC
NEED TO STICK TO THE AREA.
ABOUT 64% OF PARTICIPANTS IN
THE SURVEY ALSO REPORTED THAT
THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LEGITIMACY AND THE PURPOSE OF
THEIR SERVICE ANIMAL THE
QUESTION BASICALLY OF THEIR OWN
MISCIBILITY. AS A RESULT OF ALL
THAT SIXTY SEVEN POINT 5% OF
PARTICIPANTS REPORTED THAT
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE HAS BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. BYE ALL OF
THE. THE ATTACK WHICH YOU TEACH
THESE ROSALYN SERVICE ANIMALS
THAT BOTHERED BECAUSE WE HELLO
ME NO MATTER WHERE YOU GO. 93%
OF SERVICE ANIMAL USERS
REPORTED TO HAVE COME ACROSS. A
LOT OF CONTROL PANELS BOTH IN-THE COMMUNITY THIS IS IMPACTING
NOT JUST A SERVICE ANIMAL.
USERS HANDLERS. ALMOST JUST
REPORTED BUT ALSO THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WE JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TO ALLOW US TO PARTICIPATE WITH
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. SAFELY AND WITH
DIGNITY. NOT BECAUSE I THINK
THE QUESTIONS ARE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SAYING NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
KNOWN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE THOSE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
IT. AB FOUR SIX EIGHT. PLEASE
QUEUE UP. MODERATOR WE'VE BEEN
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR SIX EIGHT. YES THE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN
AT THE WIND BEEN FERAL IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
FOUR SIX EIGHT AGAIN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONLY IF YOU HAVE
ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE IN THE QUEUE
WELL FIRST GOTO LINE FIVE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER
THE QUOTE ON BEHALF OF HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES
AND CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE HOTEL LINE FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THAT'S WHO CARE
MEMBERS CHRIS WHY SAKE FROM THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
INSURANCE WE'RE THOUGHAND YOU
THINK THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
NITRO MOTEL LINE AT ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARGIE DIED THEN AND
I REPRESENT GOLDEN STATE GUIDE
DOG HANDLERS AND WARM STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TO LINE FOR
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY NEXT ALMOST ALIGNED
ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I JUST WANT. NEXT WE'LL MOVE
CAROLINE FIVE FORTY PLEASE SO I
HAD. HI ALLISON SCHALLERT IN
LOS ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE LISTED IN AS PRIMARY
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ARE THERE ANY- IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR SIX EIGHT
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
OUR PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB FOUR SIX EIGHT. THE
ACCIDENT I VERY MINOR IF YOU
WISH TO LOCAL. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE. ZERO
WE DO HAVE A QUEUE IN THE QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR NINETY
SEVEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS RUBEN HEALTH WORKERS ARE
DEPORTED BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
SUPPORT DOES HAPPEN A POST
POSITION ON THE BILL- BOARD HAD
CONCERNS THAT SOME OF THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS. COULD
REQUIRE HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS- THEY COULD
BECAUSE HE KNEW THE PUBLIC'S
ACCESS TO EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMALS WHEN THEY'RE NEEDED DUE
TO LIMITING HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS ABILITY. TO TO
ISSUE NOTICES- AUTHORIZING
THEM- THE AUTHOR. HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO HEARING THE
BOARD'S CONCERNS AND E LOOK
FORWARD. TO CONTINUING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE QUICKEST
WAY IS THAT ANY- REQUIREMENT
THAT REGULATE- PRACTITIONERS
ABILITY FOR QUITE FURTHER THE
MORE CLOSELY. EXAMINED THANK
pLINE UP THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DIANA-
HAMILTON AND I ACTUALLY GOT
MIXED ON THE SUPPORT AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MORE
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS ON ESAS
ARE VITALLY NECESSARY TO
PROTECT LEGITIMATE SERVICE DOGS
I HAVE A SERVICE DOG ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM- ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. TO AB
FOUR SIX EIGHT AT. AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE INTHE
QUEUE OKAY I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED HERE- IS THERE A MOTION.
SIR LAYERED MOUSSE ALL RIGHT
SETTLER LAYERED MOVES- AB FOUR
SIX EIGHTY K. TO CLOSE. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO SPEAK WITH THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES WAS VERY
LATE TO OPPOSITION. I WILL SAY
THAT. THE THE HAVING AN . AN
ESA DOES ALLOW IF IT'S WRITTEN
ANYBODY CAN BUY A PET TOO YOU
KNOW THE SUPPORT THEMSELVES
HAVING THE ESSAY GIVES YOU A
CERTAIN PRIVILEGE WHEN IT COMES
TO FOR INSTANCE BEING ABLE TO
RENT AN APARTMENT WITH THE DOG
WHEN YOU MIGHT OTHERWISE NOT BE
ABLE TO. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT A THERAPIST ACTUALLY
EVALUATE PEOPL FOR THAT NEED.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT IS
PEOPLE JUST LITERALLY CALL A
THERAPIST ON THE PHONE. AND SAY
YOU NEED THIS AND THEN THEY
SEND THEM THE PRESCRIPTION
HAVING A DOLL- TO MARSHAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS TO BE PART OF
AN ONGOING THERAPY IS NOT A
PILL THAT YOU TAKE WHEN YOU GET
IT AND ALL THE SUDDEN YOU'RE-
YOUR STRESS OR WHATEVER YOU'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IS CURED. ALL
THAT WE'RE ASKING IS THAT THE
PERSON WHO GETS THE ESA HAS AN
ONGOING RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT
THERAPIST THAT THEY ARE NOT
JUST LITERALLY. PHONING SOMEONE
OUT BECAUSE THEY'RE OFFERING A
SERVICE ON THE INTERNET JUST TO
GIVE ANYBODY A CERTIFICATE
THAT'S ALL THAT WE'RE REQUIRING
AND WE THINK THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SPEAK WITH THE BOARD I THINK
WE CAN ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT THE MAN CHIEF COUNSEL
IF YOU'D CALL THE ROLL. I YES
THIS IS EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG. HI AM
BERG I BURGESS. ABIERTO COVER.
I DID ASK. CONSULT HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI JONES HI JONES HI
LAYERED ON LAYERED I SKINNER.
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI. YOU HAVE
FIVE TO ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALREADY WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. SO REMEMBER
FREEMAN AT TEN TWENTY FLOORS
YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE BILLS
TAKE COLDER FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. AS
YOUR ANALYSIS NOTES WE HAVE
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH ONE
OF THE MAIN THE MAIN
STAKEHOLDER THAT WAS STILL IN
OPPOSITION WHICH WITH THE DEBT
BUYERS ON AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
ALLOW HOSPITALS TO CONTINUE
CONTRACTING WITH THOSE DEBT
BUYERS UNDER CERTAIN
CONDITIONS. GIVEN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE'S DEADLINE WE'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS BEFORE THE BILL WAS
HEARD IN APPROPRIATIONS.
MEDICAL DEBT IS A SIGNIFICANT
DRIVER PER BANKRUPTCY POVERTY
AND RACIAL INEQUALITY IN
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM OUR PREDECESSORS IN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A KEY
REFORMS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
AT RISK BUT THE HOSPITAL PEER
PRICING ACT AND THE FAIR DEBT
CUT DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT WERE DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
DEBT COLLECTION. AND INCREASED
PATIENT AWARENESS OF FREE AND
DISCOUNTED MEDICAL CARE
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
PATIENTS WHO RECEIVE MEDICAL
SERVICES AND ARE UNINSURED OR
UNDER INSURED THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE CAN IT. CAN BE FULL
OR PARTIAL DISCOUNTS OF THEIR
BILLS OR PAYMENT PLANS OR BOTH.
NOW THE HOSPITALS MUST FOLLOW
THIS A DEBT COLLECTORS ALSO
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE SAME RULES-
AND THERE ARE OTHER PROTECTIONS
AVAILABLE TO PATIENTS WITH A
COLLECTION PRICE A PREP PROCESS
SUCH AS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAY
TIME PERIOD. BEFORE THEY CAN
REPORT A PATIENT ACCOUNT TO A
CONSUMER CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCY OR COMMENCE OF ALL
ACTION AGAINST THE PATIENT. AND
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
PATIENTS TO APPLY FOR THE KERR
FOR WHICH THEY COULD BE
ENTITLED. HOWEVER DESPITE THOSE
PROTECTIONS PATIENTS ARE STILL
NOT BENEFITING FROM THE LAW
KAISER HEALTH NEWS REPORTED IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT NON
HA HA A PROFIT HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA COULD HAVE. BUT DID
NOT PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CHARITY CARE TO PATIENTS
PATIENTS INSTEAD OF REPORT
BEING DISCHARGED AND RECEIVING
MEDICAL BILLS WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL OR COULD
HAVE APPLIED FOR A CHARITY
CARE. WORSE THOSE HOSPITALS
OFTEN SELL PATIENT ACCOUNTS TO
COLLECTION AGENCIES WHICH THEN
ALSO FURTHER NEGLECT TO INFORM
PATIENTS BUT THEY COULD APPLY
FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE.
CONSEQUENTLY THESE PATIENTS
FACE NEGATIVE CREDIT REPORTING
AND FINALLY COLLECTIONS
LAWSUITS RIGHT AT THE TIME WHEN
THEY'RE MOST VULNERABLE WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN SICK OR ILL. TO
ADDRESS THE GAPS IN EXISTING
LAW AND STRENGTHENS PROTECTIONS
FOR CONSUMERS AND OUR
RESIDENTS. AB TEN TWENTY WILL
STRENGTHEN STATE ENFORCEMENT
OVERSIGHT OF A HOSPITAL FAIR
PRICING ACT BY PENALIZING
HOSPITALS THAT DON'T COMPLY.
PROVIDE PATIENTS WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR BILLS AND HOW TO APPLY
FOR PUBLIC PROGRAMS LIKE
MEDICAL. AS WELL AS CHARITY
CARE AT THE TIME OF DISCHARGE
AND ALSO WHEN THE BILL IS SENT
TO COLLECTIONS. EXTENDED VERSE
CREDIT REPORTING AND
COMMENCEMENT OF CIVIL ACTIONS
FROM A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. AND
REQUIRE DEBT COLLECTORS AND
DEBT BUYERS TO CERTIFY THAT THE
PATIENT HASBEEN SCREENED FOR
PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BEFORE FILING A
LAWSUIT. IT ALSO RAISES THE
INCOME LEVEL FOR FINANCIAL%
ASSISTANCE FROM THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE POVERTY
LEVEL 24100% MEMBERS MEDICAL
DEBT IS AN OBSCENITY THAT WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE IN CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN WITH AT THE VERY LEAST WE
SHOULD BE OFFERING THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE UNDER THE LAW TO
THESE PATIENTS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON OR TRACY
DOUGLAS WITH. THAT SET UP LEGAL
SERVICES. AND MOTOHARU
SUPERMARKET FROM THE PUBLIC LAW
CENTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOU IN MY
CORRECT THERE'S NO LONGER ANY
OPPOSITION THE BILL. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S
NO LONGER ANY OPPOSITION THAT
THAT WE ARE AWARE OF ALL RIGHT-
TRACY DOUGLAS AND MANOHAR.
SUPERMARKET. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL WITHOUT
OPPOSITION. GOOD EVENING SURE
AMBER AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY MY NAME IS
MARISSA KUMAR AND I'M THE
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY FOR THE
HELP ALL UNITS. OF PUBLIC LAW
CENTER A NONPROFIT LAW FIRM
THAT PROVIDES FREE LEGAL
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENTS. OVER THE
YEARS I'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
MEDICAL BILLING ISSUES BUT IT
IS INCREDIBLY DISTURBING WHEN
DEALING WITH HOSPITAL BILLS.
FOR LOW INCOME UNINSURED OR
UNDER INSURED CLIENT NEVER
OFFERED. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY FOR CHARITY CARE. CASE IN
POINT IS MONIQUE DAVIS- CLIMATE
TESTIFIED PREVIOUSLY FOR THE
BELL WHEN YOU PUT IN THE PRIMER
OR LIFE. WHEN IN NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO DEVELOP
AN EXCEEDINGLY RARE BONE MARROW
DISORDER. DEADLY SICK FOR THE
NEXT YEAR AND A HALF MONEY
WOULD BE RUSHED TO THE ER ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS AND ADMITTED
FOR A WEEK OR MORE AT OVER FIVE
DIFFERENT HOSPITALS. EACH VISIT
COMPOUNDING HER MEDICAL DEBT.
MONEY CANNOT WORK AND HER
HUSBAND HAD TO MISS WORK TO
CARE FOR HER. WHILE AT AN
ORANGE COUNTY HOSPITAL EVEN
TOLD HER HUSBAND TO BORROW
MONEY FROM FAMILY MEMBERS. TO
PAY OUT OF POCKET BEFORE THEY
WOULD CONTINUE HER TREATMENT.
NONE OF THE HOSPITALS IN FOR
MONIQUE ABOUT POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL HELP. WHEN YOU START
TO RECEIVE NUMEROUS BILLS IN
THE MAIL AND HOSPITALS WILL
CALL MONIQUE'S HUSBAND
DEMANDING PAYMENT. MONIQUE AND
HER HUSBAND WERE SCARED FELT
ALONE AND TERRIFIED AT TIMES
MANY THOUGHT MAYBE IT WOULD BE
BETTER HAD SHE DIED BELIEVING
HER HUSBAND OF THE STRESS AND
FINANCIAL BURDEN. THE BUILDING
MOUNTED IN THE CALLS INCREASED.
WHEN IT WAS TURNED OVER TO
COLLECTION AGENCIES- CREDIT WAS
RUINED BUT NOT UNTIL MANY
CONTACTED PUBLIC LAW CENTER.
THAT SHE LEARNED SHE SHOULD'VE
GONE HELP FROM THE HOSPITAL TO
REDUCE REDUCE OUR BILL. AND SET
UP A PAYMENT PLAN. THAT SAID
PATIENTS SHOULD NOT NEED A
LAWYER TO BE OFFERED THE
FINANCIAL IF IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE.
PUT YOURSELF IN OUR CLIENTS
SHOES IMAGINE GETTING SICK OR
INJURED THEN ADDING INSULT TO
INJURY WITH UNAFFORDABLE
MEDICAL BILLS AB TEN TWENTY IS
CRITICAL TO ADDING FURTHER
CHARITY CARE PROTECTIONS
ENSURING THAT WE'RE TREATING
OUR FELLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WITH HUMANITY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO I
MEAN THANK YOU HONOURABLE
MEMBERS BUT SENATE GIVEN
NONPROFIT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION AND WE ARE PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR AT TEN TWENTY. MY
WORK ROUTINE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHAT WE KNOW HARD
DESCRIBES AS A PRETTY CLEAR
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ARE NOT
PROVIDING CHARITY CARE WHEN
THEY COULD AND ARE ALSO NT
TELLING PATIENTS ABOUT IT
SHOULD BE A BILITY. MEDICAL
DEBT HAS DEVASTATING ATTACKS
CONTINUE PEOPLE INTO POVERTY
THEY MIGHT LOSE THEIR HOUSING
THEIR AFFECTION FOR CLOSURE THE
STRETCH FROM DEBT PILING UP A
COLLECTION CALLED HORSE WITH
THEIR HEALTH. WHERE'S THE NEEDY
FORCED TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
MEDICAL DEBT IS THE LEADING.
CAUSE OF CONSUMER BANKRUPTCY.
MAYBE TEN TWENTY PROVIDE
CONSUMERS. FOR PATIENTS IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS IT INCREASES
ELIGIBILITY 24100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE IT ADDS
STATE OVERSIGHT I HATE HOSPITAL
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE POLICIES
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE. HOW DOES
THE NEW CHOIR TO GIVE NOTICE OF
THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
POLICIES AS WELL AS DEBT
COLLECTORS AND BUYERS TO
PATIENTS. REQUIRES DEBT
COLLECTORS AND ADMIRERS TO SHOW
THAT THE PATIENT HASN'T SCREEN
FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IN
FILING A LAWSUIT. REALLY
HOSPITAL DEBT BUYERS TO ENSURE
THAT DATA CAN BE TRANSFERRED
BACK TO HOSPITALS WHEN THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ASSISTANT
THERE IS NO INTEREST CHARGE
FROM HOSPITAL. THAT MY CLIENTS
EFFICIENT BUILDER SENIOR SHOULD
MERGE INTO CARE NEEDED SURGERY
FOR CONDITIONS AT NO TIME DID
THE HOSPITAL NEVER LET THEM
KNOW ABOUT CHARITY CARE THEY
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
REFERRED TO LEGAL AID FOR HELP.
ISSUES SHOULD NOT BE AN
ATTORNEY TO TELL THEM ABOUT.
FINANCIAL OPTION. FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT SHOULD NOT BE A
PAGAN HARD TO GET SHOULD BE
GRANTED READILY AVAILABLE. I
THINK IT'S NOT THE ONLY LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATION OR ANYTHING
PROBLEM MY COLLEAGUES FROM
OTHER LEGAL SERVICES OR
FOURTEEN I THINK ISSUES. I AM
CALM STRENGTH IN THE HOSPITAL
FOR PRICING ACTUALLY EVEN
THOUGH IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ATTORNEY. BENEFIT FROM AN AD
INTENDED. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BEFORE WE TURN TO OTHER SUPPORT
LET ME APOLOGIZE FOR MY COMMENT
A MOMENT AGO YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING VERY PATIENTLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AS HAVE YOUR WITNESSES
BEEN WAITING VERY PATIENTLY.
AND I DIDN'T MEAN TO CUT THEM
OFF- I KNOW THAT THE DAY IS
LONG AND WE'VE GOT A NUMBER OF
BILLS IN FRONT OF US BUT MANY
OF THEM LET ME APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN TO
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT SEEING
NONE IN THE GALLERY SEEING NONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- ALL RIGHT-
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TEN
TWENTY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IMPORTED. EIGHTY TEN
TWENTY. ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAVE ABOUT SIX IN THE QUEUE
RIGHT NOW. WE'LL START WITH ONE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING GENTS
LAURIE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE ENTER A NUMBER. LESS
THAN THERE ACTUALLY MY
COWORKERS. AFTER I THINK THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER. THREE SEVENTY
NINE. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIELLE CANDOR CARTER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. Q. AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE FOUR OH TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING REBECA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXUS LINE NUMBER FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING YES MEAN COLORED ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE NUMBER FIVE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL GOOD EVENING IN WARDHA
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION OR THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY TEN TWENTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE WE HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP RESEARCHER
ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
OPPOSITION- I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTEN OPPOSITION-
MISS CLASS DINNER MR LYNCH ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. HI THIS IS KEN
LYNCH WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE RECEIVABLES
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION THAT
THAT BUYING INDUSTRY- WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THE BILL.
AND WITH A COMMITMENT TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS WE HAVE REMOVED
OUR OPPOSITION AND- APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR LYNCH MISSED LASTING ARE
YOU ONLINE. YES I AM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MARGARET GLAD TO
BE HERE ON BEHALF OF CAPIO THE
NATION'S LARGEST FIRE. MEDICAL
DEBT I ECHO MR LEDGER
COMMENTING WITH THE AMENDMENT
THE AUTHOR HAS MADE TO ACCEPT
HAPPY A LOCAL OPPOSITION TO
SUPPORT WE THANK THE AUTHOR HER
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US TO REACH A
COMPROMISE. ALL RIGHTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- OTHERS WHO WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OR-
OTHERWISE- THE SIGNAL N THE
GALLERY SAYING NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE ANYONE ELSE. ON THE LINE
ANYONE ON THE LINE MODERATOR IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TEN TWENTY.
IF YOU ARE IN A POSITION OF
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN AT THAT POSITION A.
B. TEN TWENTY ONE THEN. ZERO
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT BRING I BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SAYING NONE IS THERE A
MOTION SIR HERZBERG MOVES THE
BILL- SEVEN OR FREEMAN YOU CARE
CLOSE. TO SAY THAT I APPRECIATE
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MAN CHIEF COUNSEL
YEAH THIS IS A B. TEN TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REED MEN- WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG.
HAMBURGER I PURCHASE. A VEHICLE.
ZERO I DID ALSO. WANT SELES.
HERZBERG HERZBERG I JONES.
LAYERED AIRED BY SCANNER STERN
WHY CAL SKI. YOU HAVE FORTY
ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL ALL RIGHT NEXT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CORREO. AB.
ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU-MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TEN OH
SEVEN A MEASURE THAT WILL
RIGHTFULLY COMPENSATE PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN WHO WERE
INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS. AND
EGREGIOUS EUGENICS LAWSON
THEREAFTER BY CREATING THE
FORCED STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM EUGENICS
PRACTICES HAVE A LONG SHAMEFUL
HISTORY IN OUR COUNTRY
INCLUDING INVOLUNTARY AND
FORCED STERILIZATIONS. BETWEEN
NINETEEN OH NINE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE AT LEAST TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE STERILIZED
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S EUGENICS
LAWS MAKING IT UP MAKING UP ONE
THIRD OF STERILIZATIONS
NATIONWIDE. ONE OF THE MOST
COMPELLING CASES OF FORCED AN
UNKNOWN STERILIZATION HAPPENED
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES
AND EARLY COUNTY HOSPITAL IN
DISTRICT. WHICH I AM PROUD TO
REPRESENT IN WHICH MEXICAN
AMERICAN AND MEXICAN WOMEN AND
IMMIGRANT LATINO WOMEN WERE
STERILIZED WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT POST LABOR. THESE WOMEN
THESE WOMEN NEVER KNEW WHY THEY
CAN NEVER HAVE ADDITIONAL
CHILDREN THE PAIN CONFUSION
ANGER DEPRESSION. AND MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THESE WOMEN
FACE IS DOCUMENTED IN THE FILM
NO MY HUSBAND IS NO MORE
BABIES. THESE WOMEN ARE NOW
ELDERLY. AND LEAVING OUR WORLD
EVERY DAY. ALTHOUGH THIS
HORRIFIC LAW WAS REPEALED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. A LATER
STATE AUDIT REVEALED A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR WOMEN WERE
STERILIZED DURING LABOR AND
DELIVERY WITHOUT PROPER CONSENT
WHILE INCARCERATED FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIX. TO TWO THOUSAND
TEN. IT WASN'T SO LONG AGO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. DATING TO THE
LATE NINETEEN NINETIES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED WOMEN
WERE INVOLUNTARILY STERILIZED
IN PRISON DURING LABOR AND
DELIVERY AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
FOUR STERILIZATIONS WERE
PERFORMED. DURING OTHER
SURGERIES. IT IS CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED THERE ARE ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
SURVIVING INDIVIDUALS
STERILIZED UNDER THE LAW. IN
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
SURVIVORS OF PRISON
STERILIZATION ABUSE. THESE
ABUSES ARE ALSO REFLECTED IN
THE FILM. BELLY OF THE BEAST.
INVOLUNTARY FOR STERILIZATION
HAS HISTORICALLY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INCARCERATED WOMEN OF COLOR
WITH 65% OF SURVIVORS IDENTIFY
AS BLACK. LATINO MEXICAN OR
OTHER. IT IS SHAMEFUL TO KNOW
THAT EVEN TO THIS DAY MANY MANY
SURVIVORS STILL DO NOT KNOW.
THAT THE REPRODUCTIVE CAPACITY
WAS VIOLENTLY STOLEN FROM THEM.
FORCED AN INVALID INVOLUNTARY
STERILIZATION HAS IMPACTED MORE
THAN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IN
SOME CASES THERE WERE EXTREME
SIDE EFFECTS LIFELONG HEALTH
COMPLICATIONS. SOCIAL
ISOLATION. AND EVEN DEATH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE FORCED
STERILIZATION COMPENSATION
PROGRAM IS MORE THAN MONETARY
COMPENSATION IT PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR OUTREACH
IDENTIFICATION AN APPEALS
PROCESS AND PAYMENT.
REPARATIONS MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
OFFERS A SEMBLANCE OF JUSTICE
BY CONFRONTING CALIFORNIA'S
SHAMEFUL PAST. AB TUNNEL SEVEN
WILL PROVIDE SOME CLOSURES TO
THOSE HARMED UNDER GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED STERILIZATION
PRACTICES AND ENSURE THAT IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN. THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP IN HEALING
COMMUNITY AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND ENDING THE
PERPETRATION OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH INEQUALITIES. THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE INCLUDES THE RIGHT TO
BE A PARENT TO BE A MOTHER AND
TO BE A FATHER. AND NO AMOUNT
OF COMPENSATION WILL EVER MAKE
THAT RIGHT BUT THIS IS ANOTHER
STEP TOWARDS JUSTICE. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS THAT I HAVE CARRIED THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN THE
FOUR YEARS THAT I HAVE BEEN
HONORED TO SERVE AND THE
DECADES LONG PROCESS. THAT THIS
ENTIRE CONVERSATION HAS TAKEN
FROM THE REPEAL OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE TO THE APOLOGY IN
THE IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
BY GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS TO THIS
MOMENT WHERE WE FIND OURSELVES
IN. TO GOD WILLING TO MOVE IT
FORWARD ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
THE WOMEN WHOSE RIGHTS TO
BECOME PARENTS AND MOTHERS WERE
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM. I THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NO VOTE. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WE I SEE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT LET'S
LET'S TURN TO THE GALLERY NO
WITNESSES THE GALLERY NONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- ON THE PHONE
LINE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF. AB ONE ZERO
ZERO SEVEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE INTO PART
OF EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN
IN THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHTY WE WILL START OFF WITH
LINE. FOUR OH TWO. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS REBECCA FROM BOTH OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE FIVE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF MEHRAN PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER THREE FORTY. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE V. TEN ZERO
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER. FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FILL THE
INCLUDES SHANTI HAPPENED
THIRTEEN POUNDS AFTER GROWING
UP NEAR FREEDOM PARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WINDS. FIVE FORTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NOT A
NEGATIVE THAT MIGNOLET
CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE THE
CHRONICLE FUNKIER AND EASY TEN
ZERO TEN DEAL SEVEN AND THE
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FIFTY ONE.
GOOD EVENING JENNIFER AFTER THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE SIXTY.
GOOD EVENING WITH THE ETHICS OF
STATUS ON BEHALF OF LA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR HELD THE LEASE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE. FIVE THIRTY SIX. GOOD
EVENING THE CAL PARLBY HACKERS
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
AREN'T A PART OF P. P. ZERO
SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YEAH
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY GET IN
THEIR LINE NUMBER HERE IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF FIVE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
CURRENTLY MIRED WITH THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION AND
DEFENSE FUND ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB ONE ZERO ZERO
SEVEN IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE JUST ONE MORE LEFT IN
THE QUEUE HERE AND THAT IS LINE
NUMBER. FIVE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CYNTHIA
CHANDLER AN ATTORNEY I'VE
WORKED TO UNCOVER THE
REALIZATION THAT YOU CAN
CALIFORNIA THEN IT'S WRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
OKAY AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE. TURNED
OPPOSITION- I SEE NO PRINCIPAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION KNOWN
TO GARY KNOWN ROOM ONE TWELVE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN. YOU ARE AN
APPLICATION OF ABC. TEN OH
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
OUR POSITION OF ABC TEN OR
SEVEN. ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP
RESEARCH THERE ALREADY- BRING
IT BACK TO THE FLOOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS I SEE NO QUESTIONS
I SEE NO COMMENTS IS THERE A
MOTION SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES
THE BILL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KRILL FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
HIGHLIGHTING THIS HORRIBLE
HORRIBLE EVENT THIS HORRIBLE
SERIES OF EVENTS. IN THIS
EPISODE IN OUR HISTORY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO REMEMBER
ALL RIGHT IF YOU'RE CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR. CALIFORNIA
JANICE LAWS WERE SO EGREGIOUS.
THAT THEY MADE THEIR WAY TO
**** GERMANY. AND WE'RE PART OF
HITLER'S PLAN TO. CREATE HIS
PERFECT RACE. CALIFORNIA IN
MANY WAYS LEAD IN THAT EFFORT.
IF THIS BECOMES LAW WE WILL BE
THE THIRD STATE IN THE COUNTRY
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER REPARATIONS
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE FIRST STATE IN THE NATION
TO OFFER REPARATIONS FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLYINCARCERATED. AS MARTIN LUTHER
KING SAID THE ARC OF THE MORAL
UNIVERSE IS LONG BUT IT DOES
INDEED BEND TOWARD JUSTICE AND
WE HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THIS
FIGHT FOR DECADES. AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE THAT IS A SURVIVOR OF
CALIFORNIA- GEN X. LAWS. IS
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD IS ABLE TO
HAVE CLOSURE IS ABLE TO RECEIVE
A SENSE OF DIGNITY AT THE END
OF THE DAY AND THAT THE STATE
NOT ONLY APOLOGIZES FOR IT. BUT
IT TRIES TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO DO WHAT IS JUST
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS
NECESSARY AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I BOTH
THINK ALRIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL YES THIS IS AB. ONE EIGHT
ZERO ZERO SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO. WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS BUT THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. AMBER GUY BURGESS.
THAT WAY AT ALL. THE RUSSELL
THE RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG HERZBERG HI JONES.
LAYERED BAIRD HI SKINNER. STERN
WHY CASKEY I'M GONNA GO BACK
THROUGH GORGEOUS HEAVY AT ALL.
HI GONZALEZ JONES SKINNER STERN
WHAT KASKY. YEP FIVE ZERO WITH
MEMBERS MISSING SORRY WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
SEVEN MEMBER GIBSON THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO
SIMPLY BILL EIGHT EIGHT NINE
WHICH SEEKS TO REQUIRE ALL
CORPORATE LANDLORDS WHO HAVE A
25% OR MORE EQUITY STAKE TO
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE'S. THIS
SIMPLE REQUIREMENT LOL REQUIRES
LLC'S TO REPORT INFORMATION TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. THAT
THEY ARE AUTHORIZED TO COLLECT
BUT LLC'S FAILED TO SUBMIT. I
AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE MY
CONCERN IS THAT WORKING
FAMILIES IN MY DISTRICT AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE BEING
DEPRIVED BEING DEPRIVED OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM. THERE IS AN
ALARMING THERE IS AN ALARMING
INCREASE OF CORPORATE LANDLORDS
PURCHASING HOMES ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA BUT THEIR NAMES ARE
NEVER RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC.
UNIDENTIFIED BUYERS HIDE BEHIND
THEIR LLCS BUYING GENERATIONAL
HOMES ACROSS THE STATE
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
RESERVE INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS
OFTEN BIT HIGHER THAN
CONVENTIONAL BUYERS. BUY A
MONOPOLIZING THE MARKET THESE
CORPORATE INVESTORS HAVE DRIVEN
UP HOME VALUES AND HAVE
CONTRIBUTE TO HOUSING THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE OF NEARLY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOMES.
THIS MAKES IT HARD FOR LOW
INCOME AND MEDIUM- INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES TO PURCHASE A HOME AND
BUILD GENERATIONAL WEALTH A. B.
EIGHT EIGHT NINE WILL PROVIDE A
NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY. TO KNOW
WHO IS BEHIND THESE L. L. C.'S
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS TO REPORT
THE BENEFACTOR OWNERS OF THE
CORPORATIONS OR- OR THE LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES. OF RENTERS
OUT OF THEIR OF PROPERTY
JOINING ME HERE TO SET TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION AND A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY LAW
CENTER. THEY WILL SELL PRODUCE.
THANK YOU- FIRST UP. KATIE PARK
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF LAW
PROPERTY LAW AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY LAW CENTER- THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME TODAY-
BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP OF
PROPERTY INFORMATION ABOUT WHO
OWNS PROPERTY INFORMATION THAT
HAS BEEN PUBLICLY AVAILABLE TO
THE TITLE REGISTRY IN AMERICA
FOR ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED YEARS-
THIS TITLE REGISTRY HAS BEEN
THE HALLMARK OF THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY SYSTEM. AND IF MARKET
IT'S A MAJOR INNOVATION FROM
ENGLISH LAW THAT HAVE BEEN
CELEBRATED AND ADOPTED ALL OVER
THE WORLD FOR A BENEFIT TO THE
MARKET AND SOCIETY WHICH
INCLUDE PREVENTING FRAUD
CORRUPTION DECREASING
LITIGATION PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
AS WELL AS THE COST OF
LITIGATION. YOU ALWAYS KNEW WHO
OWNS WHAT HOW TO FIND THEM THE
LAWSUIT THE FEDERAL. ENERGY
STILL AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION
NURSES. MUCH LITIGATION OVER
PROPERTY AS EVER. BUT THE
RECENT USE OF LLC. TO PURCHASE
PROPERTY HAS CHANGED A LONG
STANDING STATUS QUO- THIS NEW
PRACTICE- CHANGING THE STATUS
QUO CENTURIES REALLY TOOK OFF
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES INTO
THE TWO THOUSAND. THE LLC WAS
ORIGINALLY CREATED TO PROVIDE A
TAX BENEFIT NOT TO SHIELD
IDENTITY THE PROPERTY OWNERS.
IT HAS ACQUIRED THAT FUNCTION
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS OR
SO AND IT ISN'T UNINTENDED AND
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION BUT THE
USE OF LLC IS TO PURCHASE
PROPERTY. HAVE GUARDED THE
TITLE REGISTRY OF INFORMATION
ABOUT BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP.
THERE WAS NO GOVERNMENTAL
DESIGNED A PLAN THERE AND
PREDICTABLY IT IS GIVING RISE
TO ALL THE PROBLEM TITLE
REGISTRY WAS DESIGNED TO
PREVENT. FRAUD MONEY LAUNDERING
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO
NEIGHBORS TENANTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND RIGHT NOW WHAT
WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IF THE PIECEMEAL ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BY STATE.
HOW DO YOU- TO THE WEST COAST
AND KEEP OF THESE EFFORTS IF
THE COLLECTION OF INFORMATION
ABOUT BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP FROM
WHERE- THIS IS NOT A
COORDINATED EFFORT COLLECTION
OF THIS INFORMATION BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T FALL
STATE YOUR CITY PROBLEM REALLY
THERE SHOULD BE SOMETHING MORE
COMPREHENSIVE BUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S EACH GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
FOR ITSELF. BENEFICIAL
OWNERSHIP IS THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE
OBTAINED IN LITIGATION ONE
THERE ARE PROBLEMS THROUGH
DISCOVERY. BUT WHAT THE ABSENCE
OF A PUBLIC RECORD DOES IS
PROFOUNDLY RAISE THE COST FOR
OTHER PARTIES I'M TRYING TO
SETTLE A DISPUTE. THE COST
PREMEDICATION AND DURING
LITIGATION THE SUSPECTS
NEIGHBORS. AND CITY EXCUSE THE
ADVANTAGES- OF LITIGATION IT
COULD ENCOURAGE BAD BEHAVIOR IT
MAKES IT HARDER FOR CITIES TO
MAKE POLICY CHOICES ABOUT THEIR
HOUSING MARKET. BY RAISING THE
COST OF ENFORCEMENT. IT IS
SIMPLY THE CASE THAT NATURAL
PERSONS IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
PROPERTY INTEREST. ALWAYS HAS
BEEN A NOMINALLY THEY STILL ARE
EVEN IF THIS INFORMATION IS
STRICTLY THE REGISTRY BUT NOT
HAVING BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP IN
THE PUBLIC RECORD MAKES IT MUCH
HARDER FOR THAT SYSTEM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO WORK. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY. THANK YOU PROFESSOR NEXT
WITNESS. HI ANGELA TRIP FOLLOW
THE CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION AND TRANSPARENCY OF
CORPORATE AND ARGUMENTS URGENT
AND IMPORTANT MATTER TO US
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
IN MAY IT WAS REVEALED THAT
PRIVATE EQUITY GIANT THE
BLACKSTONE GROUP HAD PURCHASED
SIX THOUSAND APARTMENT UNITS IN
SAN DIEGO FOR NEARLY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. WE WERE NOT
SURPRISED AS A REPORT EARLIER
IN THE YEAR SHOW THAT JOHN
HAMMOND OF THE LARGEST
CORPORATE LANDLORDS HAD AMASSED
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE BILLION
CASH ON HAND DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND WE'RE READY FOR A
BUYING FRENZY. IN A HAD ALREADY
STRESSED BY HOUSING
UNAFFORDABILITY FURTHER
CONSOLIDATION UNDER LARGE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS. WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY MAKE THINGS WORSE
FOR TENANTS AND HOMEBUYERS
HOWEVER NOT HAVING SPECIFIC
DATA FOR CITIES COUNTIES AND
ELECTORAL DISTRICT IS A BARRIER
TO DESIGNING. AND MOVING POLICY
THAT ADDRESSES ALL THESE
HOUSING ISSUES EFFECTIVELY.
LACK OF OWNER INFORMATION IS
ALSO PROBLEMATIC AS YOU
CONSIDER THAT THE STATE IS
EXPECTING TO GRANT EIGHTY
MILLION IN RENT- TO LANDLORDS.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEY ARE STRUGGLING WITHOUT
THAT THEY NEED HOWEVER WITHOUT
EIGHTY EIGHT NINE RELATED
TRANSPARENCY THIS TIME NEXT
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE WILL NOT
KNOW HOW MUCH WHAT AND BAILING
OUT THE DESERVING MIGRANT
POPULATION. FIRST OF BAILING
OUT YOUR OLYMPIC STAR THAN
BUILDING IN NEW. YORK SLUMLORDS
LIKE VERITATIS. THE FACT THAT
BIG COAL ARE DRIVING IS ALSO
VISIBLE WATCH FIVE NUMBER OF
WORKERS WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
THIS YEAR. AS PART OF ONE OF
THE MURDERS RELATED. WE ARE
IMPACTING THE LENDING PROCESS
AS A BANK IN CALIFORNIA WHOSE
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT PROGRAM
RELIES HEAVILY ON LANDING THE
PERFECTLY TO LANDLORDS AND
WORKING CLASS EITHER. I THINK
IT MIGHT BE GETTING COMMUNITY
REINVESTMENT CREDIT FOR THE
LOAN. WE HAVE A PARTNERSHIP
WITH A TENANTS RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IN THE REGION AND
BE IDENTIFIED DOZENS THEM WON'T
CONNECT THE TWO LONG ALREADY
THANK YOU BUT ALL THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE. WRAPPED
UP. THANK YOU. YEAH THANK YOU
CAPITAL NOTICEABLE TO BE SERVED
COMMUNITY NEEDS IN THIS CASE
AND HELPING. GROW THEIR
OPERATION. AND LARGER THAN WE
ARE THE KIND OF INTEL IS NOT
REALLY THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE JUST LEARNING.
THANK YOU. OKAY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. IN THE GALLERY SEEING
THE WINDOWS OF THE GALLERY ROOM
ONE TWELVE SAYING NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ON THE PHONE
LINE OTHERS IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU AREN'T
REPORTED. EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
IN Q. RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT JUST
TO REVIEW THE BIDDING HERE-
WITH RESPECT TO THE GROUND
RULES ANNOUNCED- AT THE OUTSET
OF THE HEARING EACH SIDE WILL
PROVIDE EQUAL TIME EACH SIDE-
IS PROVIDED FOR MINUTES I
REALIZE THAT THAT WE'VE
EXTENDED THAT BEYOND FOUR
MINUTES. FOR THE PROPONENTS AND
SO WILL EXTEND IT BEYOND FOUR
MINUTES- UP TO FOUR AND A HALF
MINUTES FOR THE OPPONENTS- THAT
EACH SIDE WILL BE REMITTED OUT
TEN MINUTES OF WHAT ARE KNOWN
AS ME TOOS WHERE FOLKS IDENTIFY
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. SO
METAMATERIAL SCHOOL FOR NINE.
WE START WITH FIVE EIGHTY THREE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER. FIVE
EIGHTY THREE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
PEDRO CHROME THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE BACK OF THE
HOUSE IN A LION IN SHOCK. LINE
NUMBER FOUR FORTY SIX. I'M MARC
SUMMERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER FIVE FIFTY
ONE THE FOREHEAD GOOD EVENING
THIS IS A PROFIT FROM UNFOLD ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CRUZ
GAMBIAN OF STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER FIVE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IGOR TRACKER. ON BEHALF
OF THE BARCLAY CAN INFLUENCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
WINTRICH COUNCIL INTO THE
ASPECTS APART THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MY NUMBER FIVE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
ON ADAM BOOKBINDER CAMPBELL
REPRESENTING THAT THEY GIVE ME
PROPS FOR EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE
LENDING IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ECONOMIC JUSTICE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI THIS IS JOHN MINER
THAT WOULD BE SENDING YOU TO
PAY FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER HE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING HENRY HOOKER ON
BEHALF OF SENATE GMB IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK
WE'LL GO TO LINE. FIVE EIGHTY
NINE. DAVID WALKING REMEMBERED
MOM YOU CAN BE- IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER FIVE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WITH MICHAEL
TRUJILLO CALLING FROM THE LATIN
NATIONS TO AKON BALANCE IN A
DAY. KIND OF STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE AND-
THANK YOU EXCELLENT- TWO LINE
NUMBER FIVE FIFTY SEVEN. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
TRACY MALIK ALI AND I REPRESENT
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ENVY OR DMB
AND ABUNDANT HOUSING LA AND WE
ARE IN TERMS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER FIVE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
DANIEL CANDOR CARTER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ONE NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KEVIN MA WITH
NINETY EIGHT MILLION STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FIVE
NINETY SEVEN WE'VE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN PARKER
CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA IN AFFILIATION WITH
SOUTH BAY U. M. B. I SUPPORT
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINE. THANK
YOU THAT'S THE FINE NUMBER TWO
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER TO LET ME KNOW YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CONSTANTINE HATCHER
HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY EVER
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THREE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REPAIRING THE PUBLIC. EDT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER. FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS BRANDON
HEY I'LL BE HALF OF PUBLIC
COUNCIL CALLING SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER FIVE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARAFAT RAHMAN
I AM A HOMEOWNER AND LANDLORD
IN SAN BRUNO CALIFORNIA ON YOU
CAN ON BEHALF URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN SUPPORT OF
ANYTHING ANYTIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FIVE SIXTY HUGH. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ERIC I'M A
RENTER HERE IN OXNARD VENTURA
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER FIVE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SPEAKING CALLING
FROM UNION CITY THE WHOLE STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RENEE MORAN WITH ONE OF
THE BILL'S CO SPONSORS THE
STATEWIDE COMMUNITY GROUP EIGHT
THE ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER FIVE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
PAUL PICK MORE- CALLING FROM
OAKLAND AND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FIVE TWENTY THREE. HI THIS
IS FRANCISCO DOING YET FROM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
NOW THE WHITE HOUSE INJECTED
ADVOCACY COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT- HOTEL NUMBER
THAT HAVE MUST BE NINETY WITH
INNER CITY LAW CENTER BASED
CARE AND CONTROL MY FANS LOOK
VERIFY THE FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. FIVE NINETY PEOPLE
HAD. YOU CAN SEE BASED ON
TEMPERATURE SO REPRESENTING
SENTENCE THE NBA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THE BABY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE. LINE NUMBER FIVE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
ALLISON SCHALLERT IN LOS
ANGELES A HOME OWNER AND
REPRESENTING STORIES FROM THE
FRONT LINE AND HOLLYWOOD
FORWARD IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LIE NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTEEN. GOOD EVENING
SEVEN NINE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF TRANSPARENCY
IN EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
FIVE NINETY TWO. BY THE TIME
THE APPALACHIAN BEAUTIFUL
EIGHTY FIFTY THREE IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER FIVE NINETY
FOUR THE SCHOOL HAD. HI THIS IS
KIM CALLING FROM THE CITY OF
SANTA BARBARA AND I'M CALLING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIVE NINETY
ONE. HI WHENEVER DATA LOSS
AUGUST REFLECTED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE STILL HAVE
ABOUT TWELVE IN Q. WITH A VOCAL
LINE NUMBER FIVE SEVENTY ONE.
THIS IS MEGAN WITH THE BERKELEY
TENANTS UNION AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU. ONE NINETY
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS CAITLYN
QUACKENBUSH AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF STRATEGIC ACTIONS ARE
JUST THE KIND OF MEAT AND LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINE. THANK
YOU. FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING SURE NUMBERS STORED IN
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF AN INSULT
FOR EVERYONE IN SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINE. THANKS
SO MUCH. SIX HUNDRED. MY NUMBER.
SIX HUNDRED. I. IN THE BACK
HERE. OKAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SIX HUNDRED. HE HEAR ME NOW
YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU. SORRY
WITH THE HELP FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA. IN THE- STRONG
SUPPORT. EIGHT THANK YOU.
REPORTER FIVE FIFTY EIGHT. HI
THIS IS HANNAH HLLOWAY WITH
TECH EQUITY COOPERATIVE CALLING
INSURANCE COURT. THANK YOU.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN- MEHRABAD
UNION WITH AN EQUITY
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORTING AV
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU.
FIVE THIRTY SIX. MY NUMBER FIVE
THIRTY SIX- LINE IS OPEN.
THANKS WELL THE NEXT LINE OF
SIX OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THOUGHT THE THING LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR TALENTS TOGETHER
ON BEHALF OF OUR OUR FORTY
EIGHT MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS ARE
STRONG ARE YOUR STRONG WORK ON
THE CELL. IN Q. ONE NUMBER FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS SUZANNE
ALDRICH CALLING IN FROM SANDRA
FELL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU. SIX OH SIX. HI THIS IS
LAMAR HIGH TECH PRESIDENT OF
THE ASIAN INK WITH OFFICES IN
SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND SAN JOSE
AND FRESNO ALSO THE MANAGING
MEMBER REPRESENTATIVE OF ELEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN MISSION STREET L.
L. C. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TRANSPARENCY AND EIGHTY EIGHT.
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THEY HAVE MY NUMBER. SIX
OH SEVEN- HENRY FONG
REPRESENTING ABOUT HELPING LA
AND PEOPLE WERE HELD WARS
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER SIX OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALBERT WORK
FLOOR YOU'LL REACH COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF DELANO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE A.
B. EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN Q. AS OF RIGHT NOW MR
ZAHIR ALRIGHTY LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION- ARE THERE ANY
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. EIGHT EIGHT
NINE. EIGHT NINE. ONE NINE ZERO
TO GET IN THE QUEUE. YES SIR
YEAH AS WELL ALL RIGHT SO LET
ME LET ME- LATE STRIKING THE
ICT MR KINGSTON- KAREEM GREASY
AND TONY- WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
YOU HAVE FORTY FIVE MINUTES
BETWEEN YOU. I APOLOGIZE HELLO
OKAY- J. O. FIRST THIS COMING
WEEK YES GO AHEAD SIMPLY. THANK
YOU SURE- THANK YOU SIR BUT
AGAIN IT'S TWENTY BELOW THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION- RESPECTIVELY IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE IS. THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE NOT COINCIDE WITH THE
LETTERS OF SOME OF THE
SUPPORTERS WE- BE RECEIVING.
SOME SPONSORS INDICATE THAT
IT'S ABOUT UNDERSTANDING WHO'S
BUYING HEALTHY. TRANSPARENCY
BUT ONCE IT'S LIKE COUPLE
YOU'LL BE DROPPED THE NAME
BLACK ROCK- AND- TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF. THE AND AGAIN THE
CORE KNOWLEDGE THIS WOULD NOT
COVER PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES
LIKE BLACKWATER. AND TO BE
CLEAR THEY ALL DETECTION
COMPANY OWNED VERY LITTLE
HOUSING- CALIFORNIA- ACCORDING
TO THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK.
IT'S UP TO THE LAST 1% AND FOR
CORPORATE AND LIMIT LIABILITY
COMPANIES ALREADY HAVE TO
REGISTER- I'VE BEEN THIS BIG-
CURRENTLY. MOSTLY TO PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE ORGANIZED AS
CORPORATIONS AND LLCS THE POINT
OF THE LARGE COMPANIES AND IN
CORPORATIONS EVEN MOM HOPS
REGISTER AS CORPORATIONS AND
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANY. AND
THIS BILL WILL TREAT THE
LANDLORDS DIFFERENTLY THAN
OTHER SIMILAR BUSINESS OWNERS
THAT ARE USING THE LLC
INCORPORATION FALL. AND BUST
HOW CAN MANAGEMENT AND AN
OWNERSHIP- IS HIGHLY RATED
ALREADY HIGHLY RATED BY FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL. GOVERNMENT IN
ADDITION TO COURT SOON-
INCLUDING THE BUILD OF
REALISTIC GET TWENTY BOOK OR-
HELPING AGENCY AND THE U. S. OF
HEALTH AND URBAN. WE BELIEVE
THIS BUILDING UNNECESSARY
MANDATE ON THE RENTAL HOUSING
INDUSTRY MOST OF THE MOM AND
POP OWNERS THAT THE BILL WOULD
EXPECT HAVE NOT RECEIVED. OVER
AND WHAT STATES LIKE THAT AT
THE TURNER CENTER REPORTED
TODAY. RECORDING THESE SMALL
MOM PA OWNERS TO GET OUT OF THE
RENTAL HOUSING- BUSINESS AND
ADDED MILLION OUNCES MARKING
YOU CORRECTLY POINTS OUT. THIS
BILL IS NOT NECESSARY THIS YEAR
AND INCONSISTENT WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE OPERATIONAL
AND FISCALPROCEDURES AND
PRESENTED MULTIPLE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
ACCORDING TO THE ACTUAL WORK-
AND FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WE'RE NOBLE
AND WE UNDERSTAND. THE NEED TO
HELP BRANCH AND SO FORTH THAT'S
WHEN THE COUPLE APARTMENTS SO
SHE'S ALWAYS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT THE LAST FEW YEARS IN
REACHING A COMPROMISE ON BILLS
LIKE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE WENT.
ALONG WITH IT JUST BECAUSE
THANK YOU MR AND ACTION SPORTS.
NIGHT THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN A MEMBER CAN DO
PRIME TEN AND ARMOR. FIVE OF IS
SO. OR COUNTY PART OF RIVERSIDE
WATCHING. AND THE BEAR. AND ALL
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
HAVING SAID THAT LET ME REVIEW
A FEW THINGS. WE HAVE. BUT
STILL DEALT WITH GROCERY STORES
AND FOOD ACCESS UP UNTIL THREE
JUST THREE WEEKS AGO. THERE'S
BEEN NO STAKEHOLDER MEETING
ABOUT THIS. THERE WAS A BIT
OLDER THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY VOTED
DOWN- BY BUFFY WICKS SHE TRIED
GETTING IT OUT OF- THE HOUSE IS
SIMPLY HOUSING COMMITTEE- IN A
SIMILAR MEASURES SIMILAR
DIRECTION SHE COULDN'T SHE
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED. AND
STILL COULDN'T GET IT OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY. NEXT THURSDAY IN
A RAFFLE TO BAD BEHAVIOR
SLUMLORDS THE LAW IS COVERED IN
IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH LOG IN
NOW LET'S TACKLE. LET'S TACKLE-
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO HAVE MORE
INSPECTION PROGRAMS ARE THERE
WAS A REFERENCE ABOUT BANK
MERGERS I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND
THE RELEVANCE TO THAT- THAT
QUITE FRANKLY THE AREA- SO WE
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS IT THAT YOU'RE AFTER YOU
WANT TO BUY HOUSING. IT'S OPEN
AND IT'S ALWAYS FOR SALE FOR
CLOSURES. IS TA MEMBER-
TESTIFYING THAT IS REALLY
REALLY RELEVANT THEY BOUGHT.
BLACKSTONE BOUGHT THOUSANDS OF
HOMES THAT WORK IN FORECLOSURE
THEY WERE JUST OUT THERE FOR
SALE. AND THEN THEY TURNED HIM
INTO RENTALS SO AND NOW WE HAVE
GREAT MASSIVE RENT. TOWER THANK
YOU MISTER KING SO. LOCATES BUT
ARE YOU STILL BETTER GERMAN
KARIM THREES. YES GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR JOHN BERTIE SEVEN
THREE ON BEHALF. OF ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I'LL JUST DIVE RIGH
INTO IT- AT THE BACK OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE- EIGHTY
EIGHTY NINE HARMS SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS TO SCREEN GREASING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS SMALL HASN'T WRITERS
WERE UP IN JUNIORS INDIVIDUALS
OF COLOR WHO FORMED LLCS MADE
UP ENTIRELY OF INDIVIDUALS
USUALLY FAMILY MEMBERS FOR TAX
RELATED PURPOSES. EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE IMPOSES ONEROUS
REQUIREMENTS ON THE SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS AT A CRITICAL
TIME IN THE JUST BEGINNING TO
RECOVER FROM THE HARDSHIP
CAUSED THAT AND TEN. HE R. CAN
CURSE WITH MANY OF THE POINTS
RAISED IN THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS WHICH STOCKS WE
SUGGEST MEASURES IN OUR FULLY
DRAFTED AN ILL TIMED FOR THESE
AND OTHER REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
WHICH UTTERLY FAIL TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THANK YOU FOR
CONSECUTIVE MONTHS. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN THE OTHER CHEEK
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE OF THE
GALLERY NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
LET'S GO THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO. A. B.
EIGHT EIGHT NINE. YOU'RE NOT.
OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. THANKS AGAIN AS
ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE'LL START
WITH ONE SIX OH TWO AND HOW
MANY HOW MANY DO WE- I'M SORRY
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR. FOUR NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. UP FROM A
DOCTOR SANDRA DAY AND APOLOGIES
I'M ACTUALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
AGAIN APOLOGIES AND STRONG
SUPPORT ALL RIGHTY THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CRIPPLING
POPULAR WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
AND A LOT OF QUESTIONS THE BILL
THANK YOU. ALREADY THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER SIX SIXTEEN. HI THERE
BIANCA BLANC QUEST WITH SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ALREADY THANK
YOU OTHERS. NO HELLO THANK YOU
HERE IS FIVE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LITERATURE MEMBERS PAT
MORAN WITH ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ALREADY
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINE. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. OKAY WELL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. NOT SEEING
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUST A FEW
QUESTIONS- WHILE I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT. THE THRUST OF THE BILL
IDENTIFYING PROPERTY OWNERS-
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS THOUGH
THAT STILL EXIST ON THE BILL'S
BEEN IN PRINT NOW FOR TWENTY
ONE DAYS I BELIEVE IT IS. AND
THIS IS OUR FIRST OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY REVIEW THE BILL IN
THE LEGISLATURE. SO WHILE I
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE IDENTIFY THOSE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROPERTY
OWNERSHIP SOME QUESTIONS SO IT
WAS IT WAS MENTIONED BY ONE OF
THE WITNESSES WHAT WOULD
BLACKSTONE HAVE TO REVEAL.
UNDER THIS BILL IN TERMS OF THE
BENEFICIAL OWNERS. SURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE HAVE
OUR- THE INDIVIDUAL FROM-
GEORGETOWN. TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. ALL RIGHT
I THINK THAT'S PROFESSOR PARK
WHAT WOULD BLACKSTONE HAVE TO
REVEAL. WHAT WOULD LASH DON'T
HAVE TO REVEAL I MEAN ISN'T
THAT BILL JUST 25% BENEFICIAL
OWNERSHIP INTEREST I DON'T KNOW
WHO BLACKS DON'T HAVE 25%
BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP INTEREST.
SO BLACKSTONE WOULDN'T REVEAL
ANYTHING IS THAT RIGHT. I DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THE-
THE INTEREST THAT BLACKSTONE TONOTE THAT SOMEBODY HAD 25%
BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP INTEREST
OUT BLACKSTONE THEN THAT PERSON
WOULD HAVE TO DISCLOSE WHICH
SEEMS REASONABLE RIGHT HOWEVER
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROPERTY INSURANCE. ANALYTICS
AND MATTER OF LITIGATION OVER A
PROPERTY INTEREST WOULD HAVE TO
SHOW UP TO COURT WHOEVER THAT
PERSON WOULD BE ULTIMATELY
WOULD BE THE PERSON I WOULD
HAVE TO REPORT. ALL RIGHT SO.
TRUST. WHAT WOULD THAT BE FOR
REAL ESTATE INVESTMENT TRUSTS
WOULD BE THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
A PARTNER WOULD BE SOMEONE WHO.
HAS AND THEN I'M GONNA ASK A
SECOND WHAT WHAT A SUBSTANTIAL
INTEREST IT IS OURS I'M SORRY
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC BENEFITS.
WHO WOULD SHOW UP FOR A MINUTE
BUT- PETER COMPLICATED
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING
DETERMINED BY COURTS OF LAW IT
WILL BE DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS BUT THIS IS THE
QUESTION THAT COURTS ARE
DEALING WITH IT BECAUSE IT
ARISES- BECAUSE- SUCH FIGURES
AND ENTITIES. ARE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN COURT FOR THEIR
PROPERTY INTERESTS. ALL THE
TIME THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO MAKE IT BEAT. TO
BRING THEM INTO COURT IN THE
FIRST PLACE THAT'S REALLY THE
QUESTION HERE BUT THEN WHAT
WOULD THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
BE. IMPORTANT MECHANISM FOR
ENSURING THAT- INSURING THAT
THE INFORMATION REQUESTED IT
ACTUALLY REPORTED IT BUT THE
QUESTION SIR WELL FOR VIOLATION
OF SHOULD THIS LAW BE ENACTED
WHAT WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM BE. IT WELL I THINK
THAT THEY'RE WHATEVER-
MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE REPORTING OF OTHER KINDS
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ALREADY BUSINESS ENTITIES ARE
REQUIRED AND YOU KNOW- TO
REGISTER AND PROVIDE ALL KINDS
OF INFORMATION JUST NOT
BENEFICIAL OWNERSHIP WITH THE
SIMPLY JUST ADDING ONE MORE
LINE. TO AN EXISTING PRACTICE
AN EXISTING KIND OF FORM- AND
SO IT WOULD UPDATE REGULARLY
ADDS FILING WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ARE SUPPOSED TO-
REGULARLY BE UPDATED AND
REFRESHED. BUT SO IF FOR
EXAMPLE A CORPORATION- WITH.
SAY TWENTY OWNERS OR TWENTY
SHAREHOLDERS- THEY NEED ONLY
LIST THE NAME OF THE
CORPORATION ASSUMING EACH OF
EQUAL SHARE IS THAT RIGHT. IT
SOUNDS THAT WAY THE LAN I.
PRESENTS BUDGETS BY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT- INTEREST HOLDING
BENEFICIAL OWNERS. BUT IF MY
WIFE AND I BOUGHT- FORMED AN
LLC AND BOUGHT A UNIT THEN WE
WOULD NEED TO NAME OUR
INDIVIDUAL NAMES IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT'S CORRECT I SEE. OKAY IN
WHAT. I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL.
IT SAYS UNIVERSITY. WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFIT I SEE THAT
SOMEONE WHO RECEIVES
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC BENEFITS
MUST ALSO BE LISTED AS A
BENEFICIAL OWNER WHAT WHAT'S
THE DEFINITION OF SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFIT IS AGAIN LIKE
I SAID SOMETHING THAT BEING
DETERMINED BY THE COURT I MEAN
IT'S GING TO DIFFER A LITTLE
BIT JERK DICTION TO
JURISDICTION SO I WOULD
HESITATE TO SAY EXACTLY. I'M
NOT EVEN SURE WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING YOU'RE THINKING OF
RIGHT NOW- BYE YOU KNOW IT'S
FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD RICH
WRIST THE INCOME STREAM THAT IS
SUBSTANTIAL RELIED YOU KNOW
SOME QUANTITY THAT- IT'S
SIZEABLE- IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF ECONOMICS- BENEFIT FROM THE
PROPERTY ITSELF FROM THE
OWNERSHIP- THAT SORT OF THING
THAT PROBABLY THE MOST OBVIOUS
EXAMPLE. SO IF THIS LET'S
ASSUME THIS IS A CIVIL
VIOLATION. AND IF A JUDGE WOULD
INSTRUCT THE JURY HOW WOULD
THAT JUDGE HOW WOULD SHE
INSTRUCTS THE JURY AS TO WHAT A
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC BENEFIT
IS. FOR PURPOSES OF ISOLATION
ALONG. IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE JUST
REFERRING TO CALIFORNIA LAW AT
THIS POINT. I'M ACTUALLY IN
WASHINGTON DC IF I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT CALIFORNIA
LAW SAYS ABOUT THIS BUT IT'S A
FAIRLY INTUITIVE DEFINITION YOU
KNOW IT'S A FAIRLY
COMMONSENSICAL IDEA THAT IF
SOMEONE GETS A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF INCOME- FROM. SOME
KIND OF PROPERTY HOLDINGS- THAT
THAT WILL BE A SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFITS- YOU KNOW I
THINK. I DON'T KNOW TO TELL YOU
WHAT IT REALLY COMMONSENSICAL
IF YOU'RE ASKING EXACTLY WHERE
THE LINE IS I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT WILL DEPEND ON LOTS OF-
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES IN THE
CASE- BUT THE FAIRLY AGAIN
INTUITIVE STRAIGHTFORWARD. FIVE
OF- TYPE OF PROVISION SO WOULD
THAT BE THE JURY INSTRUCTION
THAT A JUDGE WOULD GIVE TO A
JURY THAT YOU ARE TO JUST.
ASSUME WHAT A SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BENEFIT IS THAT WOULD
BE THIS THAT WOULD BE THE
DEFINITION FOR I HAVE. YOU KNOW
WHAT I WOULD HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
ANY PARTICULAR DAY MY
EXPERIENCE IS THAT JUDGES GIVE
ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF JURY
JUDGE. THERE IS NO WAY TO
GENERALIZE ABOUT SUCH A THING.
BUT I SEE ALL RIGHT WELL I'M
GONNA LET THAT GO ALL RIGHT SO-
CENTER WHITE HOUSE GIVE A
QUESTION. NO NO NO ALL RIGHT-
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES SENATOR RUSSELL- YES I
UNDERSTAND THERE WERE- CONCERNS
RAISED RAISED BY THE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND I'M NOT SURE THERE
WAS ANOTHER AGENCY- BUT I'M
JUST MY QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
IS THE- ISSUES OR CONCERNS
RAISED BY RAISED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE- HAVE YOU OR
WILL YOU CONTINUE TO BE WORKING
TO- THE SATISFACTION OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ON THE
ISSUES THAT. THE SECRETARY HAS
RAISED ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR- AND
ABSOLUTELY I WAS ON THE PHONE
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TODAY- SHE'S PROVIDED AN
ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
THIS WOULD COST IF IT MEANS
UPGRADING THEIR SYSTEM- SHE
THINK THAT SHE COULD ALSO GET-
THE COST DOWN- BASED ON ANOTHER
MATTER. AND SO WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
TALKING ABOUT IT I JUST BLEW
THIS UP FOR YOU HAD OCCASION WE
TALK THIS IS SECRETARY OF STATE
FOR WE'RE TALKING ABOUT D.
BEING REMOVED WHERE IT SAYS-
LIST ADDITIONAL MANAGERS OR
MEMBERS AND WE JUST WANT
INCLUDE BENEFACTOR OWNER. THERE
AND THAT'S THE FORM THAT NEEDS
TO BE CHANGED- PEOPLE ALREADY
WITH A FILE LOC THAT
INFORMATION IS SENT TO THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE
ALREADY BY LAW AND WE'RE WE'RE-
ATTEMPTING TO DO IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. IT'S JUST LIKE
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WHO
OWNS PROPERTY. YOUR INFORMATION
IS MADE PUBLIC PEOPLE CAN FIND
OUT WHO OWNS THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
MARKING BARREL LANE WELL WHEN
IT WHEN IT COMES TO L. L. C. NO
ONE KNOWS AND WE WANT TO- IT
THROUGH THIS BILL TO CREATE
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY KNOW WHO IS BEHIND THE
L. L. C. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
FORM WILL MODIFY. AND SO MY
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE-
SECRETARY OF STATE AS WELL AS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE-
IN THIS REGARD THAT IS WHAT ASK
THE DEBT IS BODY ALLOW THIS
BILL TO MOVE FORWARD SO WE CAN
GET. I WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER IN
ORDER TO GET- THIS BO- ON THE
FLOOR AND PASSED. THANK YOU FOR
THE SUMMER GIVES IT WHAT WHAT
WHAT IS WHAT WHAT'S THE SECTOR
STATES POSITION ON THE BILL THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAS NO
POSITION AVAILABLE ALL RIGHT AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER ALL RIGHT- ANY
OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS.
ANYTHING. FOR THE MOTION. I'M
SORRY. SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE
BILL ALL RIGHT MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE BOTH WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO JUST APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
WHEN WE ASK THE QUESTION I JUST
WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME CLARITY
TO MY UNDERSTANDING MY- HE
BEING HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SUBSTANTIAL AND
THAT'S 25% OF THE EQUITY
INTEREST IN A QUALIFIED
ENTITLEMENT- THAT'S WHERE THE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD IN FACT BE A
DISCLOSE IF THERE'S THAT MUCH
OF YOUR INTEREST AS A
STAKEHOLDER INTO A PIECE OF
PROPERTY OR THE L. L. C. THAT
INFORMATION WILL BE IN FACT.
DISCLOSED IN ADDITION TO THE S.
MEMBERS I THINK THE OPPOSITION
WERE TALKING ABOUT. WHAT
INDIVIDUALS- STATING WHEN THEY
WERE UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- I DIDN'T
MENTION BLACKSTONE OR ANYONE
ELSE- DO WHAT I SHARE WITH YOU
IS WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO DO
AND THAT IS TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY. THIS BILL IS TO
MAKING SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANT TO. KNOW WHO THEY'RE
ALL WHO THE NEIGHBORS ARE-
WHETHER IT'S A CORPORATION
WHOSE BEHIND CORPORATION. AND
THAT INFORMATION SHOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC- MY PROPERTY IS MADE
PUBLIC AND WHY SHOULD SOMEONE
HIDE BEHIND LOC THE PROFESSOR
FROM GEORGETOWN INDICATING-
THAT LOC WAS NOT CREATED TO
HIDE THE INDIVIDUAL'S IDENTITY.
BUT IT'S BECOME THAT AND SO
THIS BILL EIGHT EIGHT NINE SIX
TWO ONE PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY-
WE CANNOT TO EIGHT NINE TO STOP
A CORPORATION FROM PURCHASING
PROPERTY OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
BUT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO KNOW.
WHO'S BEHIND THESE CORPORATIONS
LLCS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE. ALL RIGHTY THEN SHE
CANCELED THE CALL THE ROLL YES
THIS IS EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER. GIPSON WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR DID OFF
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG ABILITY. AMBERG NOT
VOTING. BOARD YES. ZERO THE
REST. THE REST SO I CONSIDER
THIS. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG NOT
VOTING JONES. LAYERED BLARED
NOT VOTING SKINNER STERN WHITE
HOUSE SKI WHITE HOUSE GATE NOT
VOTING THERE IS A ONE TO ZERO
SO FAR WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
PARTY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
NEXT- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONSOLIDATES AB. SEVEN OH ONE.
THANK YOU. MY TALKING POINTS A
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD EVENING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT FIRST OFF
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING CLOSELY WITH US
ON THIS LANGUAGE WHICH RESPONSE
TO MANY OF THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS TO MAKE NEXT DAY
DELIVERY POSSIBLE CORPORATIONS
LIKE AMAZON HAVE FORCED
WAREHOUSE WORKERS TO MOVE
FASTER SERVICE MORE CUSTOMERS
IN RECORD AMOUNTS OF TIME AND
RISK THEIR OWN BODIES IN THE
PROCESS. EVERY DAY THEY FACE
INCREASING WORK SPEEDS TO MEET
RELENTLESS PRODUCTIVE
PRODUCTIVITY QUOTAS THEIR TIME
MOMENTS AND HOW QUICKLY THEY
CAN PACKAGE UP TO FOUR HUNDRED
ITEMS IN OUR OFFICE IN REGARDS
TO SIZE OR WEIGHT OF THE ITEM
IS STRICTLY MONITORED BY ALL
THE RHYTHM. AI MINUTES BETWEEN
SCANNING PACKAGES WHERE THE
SYSTEM DETECTS THE WORKERS OFF
TASK CAN RESULT IN AUTOMATIC
DISCIPLINE AND EVEN
TERMINATION. CORPORATIONS LIKE
AMAZON OR SETTING THE INDICES
INDUSTRY STANDARD OF WHAT'S
CONSIDERED COMPETITIVE AMONG
THE MOST PHYSICALLY DANGEROUS
JOBS IN PRIVATE SECTOR AND THE
NUMBERS DON'T LOOK GOOD. AMAZON
WORKERS ARE INJURED ON THE JOB
TWICE THE AVERAGE RATE OF THE
OVERALL WE'RE HOUSING INDUSTRY
AND THREE TIMES THE AVERAGE
RATE ACROSS ALL PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS. DURING THE PANDEMIC
AMAZON SERIOUS INJURY RATE WAS
80% HIGHER THAN THE RATE FOR
ALL OTHER WAREHOUSE EMPLOYERS.
ALMOST 89% OF THOSE INJURED
WORKERS HAD TO MISS WORK THE
EXPERIENCE LONGER RECOVERY
PERIODS AND OTHER WORKERS
WAREHOUSE WORKERS. WHERE
WORKERS HAVE REPEATEDLY GOTTEN
INJURED ON THE JOB BECAUSE THEY
WERE FORCED TO RUSH THROUGH
SAFETY PROTOCOLS TO TRY TO MEET.
THE RATE YET MOST STILL CANNOT
SPEAK OUT FOR FEAR OF LOSING
THEIR JOB THESE DANGEROUS
PRACTICES ARE CAUSING AMAZON TO
TURN THREE WORKERS AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED RATE AND IT'S
SIMPLY UNSUSTAINABLE. THE
ANNUAL TURNOVER RATE FOR
WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES WITH AMAZON
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS HAS SHOT
UP TO OVER A 100% PER YEAR.
THEY'RE REPLACING THEIR ENTIRE
WORK FORCE A 100% OF THE TIME
EACH YEAR. WE SHOULD HAVE TO
SPECIFY LAW THAT WORKERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO USE THE BATHROOM DRINK
WATER OR THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TO WASH THEIR HANDS AND
SANITIZER APPOINTMENT DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WE CANNOT STAND
BY AND ACCEPT THESE UNDIGNIFIED
IN UNSAFE CONDITIONS AS THE NEW
FUTURE OF WORK. EIGHTY SEVEN NO
ONE WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR WORKERS
CANNOT BE DISCIPLINED FOR
FAILING TO MEET A QUOTA THAT
DIDN'T ALLOW THEM TO COMPLY
WITH EXISTING HEALTH AND SAFETY
LAWS NO LABOR CODE OR CAL OSHA
STANDARDS. THAT COMPLIANCE
COULD NOT BE COUNTED AGAINST
THEM AS BEING OFF TASK IF A
WORKER FACES DISCIPLINE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS DAYS AFTER THEY
FILED A COMPLAINT ABOUT HEALTH
AND SAFETY CONCERNS RELATED TO
QUOTA. AB SEVEN OH ONE WOULD
CREATE EVERY BOTTLE FULL
PERCEPTION THAT THE AD ADVERSE
ACTION TAKEN BY THE COMPANIES
WAS RETALIATORY. EIGHTY SEVEN
OH ONE WOULD ALSO DIRECT HELLO
SHOULDDEVELOP A WAREHOUSE
SPECIFIC SAFETY STANDARDS. THAT
MINIMIZE WORKER INJURIES IN
WAREHOUSES THAT USE PRODUCTION
QUOTAS. AFTER TAKING AMENDMENTS
AND SENATE LABOR WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
THIS COMMITTEE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS. THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS INCLUDING LIMITING
FORMER EMPLOYEES ABILITY
REQUEST QUOTE INFORMATION AND
PERSONAL WORKS B. DATA.
LIMITING THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION SO CONFUSE
REPETITIVELY BY CURRENT
EMPLOYEES. IN NARROWING THE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF ONLY TO
ADDRESS UNSAFE QUOTAS AMONG
OTHER CHANGES. THE PAGA.
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL ARE
ALL CURABLE WE MADE SURE THAT
THE LANGUAGE WAS VERY CLEAR ON
THAT SO THEY ALWAYS HAVE THIRTY
DAYS THEY ALWAYS HAVE DAYS TO
CURE. AND THIS IS IMPORTANT
BILL FOR ALL OF OUR WORKFORCE
BUT ESPECIALLY WAREHOUSE
WORKERS. I DON'T KNOW IF HE'S
STILL AVAILABLE I KNOW HE HAD
TIME CONSTRAINTS BUT I DID HAVE
RON FERRER THE PRESENTLY LA
LABOR FED. AS THE LEAD- WITNESS
ALL RIGHT MISS. MR ERA ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES GERMAN NUMBER
ALL RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU DISTINGUISHED
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RON FERRER
AS YOU HEARD ON THE PRESIDENT
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR AND
INTERNATIONAL VICE PRESIDENT
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF TEAMSTERS I'M
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS WHO WORK IN THE
WAREHOUSE IN CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE. IT IS AN URGENT
PRIORITY IS IT SEEKS TO CREATE
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
SAFETY PROTECTION FOR WORKERS
WHO ARE WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
GIVE US A GOOD IN RECORD TIME.
THE WAREHOUSING INDUSTRY IS
GROWING IT HAS TRIPLED IN SIZE
IN LOS ANGELES WE WELCOME THIS
GIRL BUT WE MUST PROTECT THE
WORK FORCE AND THE INDUSTRY AND
SHARE THIS IT HAS NOT BEEN
EXPANDED BY BREAKING THE BACKS
OF WORKERS AND MOSTLY YOUNG
WORKERS OF COLOR. IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WORKERS ARE
REPORTING HAVING TO WORK ON
YOUR QUOTE IS THAT ARE
IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET THAT WORKERS
ARE FORGOING BASIC HUMAN NEEDS
SUCH AS USING THE RESTROOM SO
THAT THEY CAN MEET THE BRUTAL
QUOTAS WAREHOUSES. THAT WORKERS
IN THEIR EARLY TWENTIES ARE
SUFFERING FROM TORN LIGAMENTS
BRANDON SERIOUS INJURIES IN
INJURIES THAT LEAVE THEM OUT OF
WORK FOR MONTHS AT A TIME THESE
JOBS ARE MORE DANGEROUS THAN
CONSTRUCTION. AND EVEN COAL
MINE. HUNDREDS OF I HAD HELPED
CREATE WHERE HOW ALLOWS WORKERS
TO MEET CODE. STANDARDS WILL
NOT ROCKING THEM. OF THE RIGHT
TO SAFETY MINE MEMBERS WORK
HARD AND WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
GETTING GETTING FIRED FOR
SPEAKING UP AGAINST WORKING
CONDITIONS. THESE ARE THE
STANDARDS WE ARE RECREATING
WITH A. B. SEVEN OH ONE
STANDARDS THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR THIS INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE
TO GROW AND THRIVE STANDARDS
THAT CAN PREVENT THE HUNDRED
AND 50% TURNOVER RATE WE SEE IN
THE WAREHOUSES LIKE AMAZON. I
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO LOOK AT THE
CORE FUNCTIONS OF THIS BILL AND
SEE HOW ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS CREATE BASIC PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS IN AN INDUSTRY. THAT IS
AT THE CENTER OF OUR ECONOMY
FOR THE SAKE OF WORKERS AND-WAREHOUSES. WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO LEGISLATE THE
STRONGEST STANDARDS POSSIBLE I
URGE YOU TO VOTE FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE TODAY AND ON THE
SENATE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MR
ERA. OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NOT AWARE
OF ANY WELL LET'S TURN TO THE
GALLERY NONE IN THE GALLERY
NONE IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE. MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD UP THOSE AND OF A. B.
SEVEN OH ONE WE'D BE GRATEFUL.
IT CURRENTLY IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE.
AND WE HAVE ROUGHLY ABOUT FIVE
IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHTY THEN
WE WILL START WITH. FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND- MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A RAMBLE AND SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THREE SEVENTY FOUR.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS KEEP IN
DATA ON BEHALF OF UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIRMAN
ABORTION GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
SIX TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACQUIRED A
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION A TRUNK
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER.
TWO EIGHTY TWO. DANIEL GOOD
CARE ABOUT HALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER. SIX OH NINE. MY NUMBER
SIX OH NINE YOUR PHONE IS OPEN.
VERY FEW ARMED SUPPORTERS ABC.
SEVEN OH ONE FIVE ONE AND THEN
ZERO. OKAY FINE. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING PUSHING THE BUTTONS
THERE. NINE SIX OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. ALL RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY BODY ELSE
IN HUE- THEY'RE NOT ANSWERING
ALL RIGHT SIR OKAY LET'S LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION NOW I SEE MR
ROBERT MOULTRIE IS OPPOSED MR
MOULTRIE ARE YOU ONLINE. YES
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME AT
THAT TIME ALL RIGHT ALREADY YES
WE CAN GO AHEAD. PERFECT THANK
YOU I WOULD RATHER LUCKY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE. NOT
PRISONERS LIKELY OPPOSED TO
BECAUSE I WANTED A JOB KILLER-
I WANT TO COMMENT ON THE YOUNG
MAN FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
LABOR COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL
JUST REPEAT THAT FOR THEIR
EFFORTS AND THE AUTHORS WALTER
FOR A- CONSIDERABLE ENGAGEMENT
ON SOME SIGNIFICANT EVENTS IN
THAT SHORT TIME PERIOD- THE
TYPICALLY I'D LIKE TO CALL OUT
AT THE AUTHOR DID. WE
APPRECIATE THE MOMENTS RELATED
TO LIMITING THE PREVIEW THAT
THE PRIOR PAGA EXPANSIONISM
THAT FELL OFF OF THE UNLIMITED
SUMS RETALIATION AND A FEW
OTHER POINT. AS A RESULT WE
EXPECT THE DOWNGRADED FELL OFF
OUR JOB KILLER LIST WITH THOSE
DEMANDS ARE IN PRINT FROM THE
COMMITTEE WHICH WE SHOULD BE
SHORTLY- AND CONGRATULATE OUR
I'LL JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE
REMAINING ISSUES- PERSON
FOREMOST YOU REMAIN CONCERNED
THE BILL WILL COMPEL CAL OSHA
DROP THAT REGULATION THAT HAS A
SIGNIFICANT OVERLAP WITH PRE
EXISTING REGULATIONS. ON
SECTION FIFTY ONE TEN RELATED
TO REPETITIVE INJURY ABOUT
EMOTION YOU QUEUED ME- I KNOW
WHO ARE GONNA COME AROUND THE
OTHER WE HAVE DISCUSSED IT AND
WE REMAIN CONCERNED THEIR BILLS
REMAIN CONCERNED WITH A COUPLE
OF REASONS OTHER PROVISIONS BUT
I WON'T BE LISTENING IN DUE TO
THE LATE HOUR. AGAIN FOR
HEATING GATEMAN AND- THE POINT
THOUGH HOWEVER WE REMAIN
OPPOSED AB SEVEN WALK. THANK
YOU MR MOULTRIE OF OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. A MODERATE F YOU
WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN OH ONE.
WOULD BE GRATEFUL. IF YOU ARE
AN POSITION OF EIGHTY. SEVEN OH
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN.
THERE THE POPULATION. EIGHTY
SEVEN OH ONE ONE TEN ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP
HERE IT'LL TAKE JUST A MOMENT
TO GET THEIR NUMBERS. AND ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS THE POSITION OF
THE A. B. SEVEN OH ONE. THAT'S
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
THROUGH THE LINE OF SIX TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS STEVE MCCARTNEY ON BASS
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE WILL CLOSE THE
LINE NUMBER FIVE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING-
BY LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR METRIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND MY
NUMBER. SIX TWENTY TWO. GOOD
EVENING RETURN EMERGING HELP ON
BEHALF OF CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE MORE LEFT THANK YOU HERE IS
SIX TWENTY FOUR. WHO ARE YOU
GETTING THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES THE TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE
AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN ONE. IF YOU ARE IN THE
CAR UP DIVISION OF ABC SEVEN OH
ONE WOULD PUSH ONE TEN ZERO.
AND I DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP AS OF RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHT- I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- IS THERE A MOTION. WELL
I'M SO OKAY NOT ALL AT ONCE
THERE'S FOUR THERE WERE FOUR
HANDS RAISED- ALL RIGHT IT IS
THERE ANYONE HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT YES SIR WHAT KOWSKI I
KNOW YOU'RE MOVING THE BILL
SAID A WHITE HOUSE HE MOVES THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES WILL.
ALL RIGHT- IS THAT A GOOD
SOLACE EXCUSE ME BUT REMEMBER
GOOD SELFLESS IT'S LATE AND I'M
TIRED IT'S OKAY IT'S OKAY I'M
JUST GOING TO AGAIN WARN PEOPLE
BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENED DO NOT
TEXT ME ABOUT MY BILLS THINK
YOU'RE TEXTING CENTER GONZALEZ
BAD NOW THERE MIGHT BE A GOOD
THING THE SIX LIMIT LET ME A
LOT HAS HAPPENED AMID A LOT
JUST A MOMENT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE BUT FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK YOU- I ADDRESSED WE
ADDRESS SEVERAL PRIMARY
CONCERNS YOU WORK VERY HARD. TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS I
REALIZE THERE'S STILL SOME
OTHER WORK TO BE DONE BUT I
APPRECIATE BOTH YOUR DEDICATION
AND YOUR- INTERESTED IN
RECREATING A POINT OF
COMPROMISE SO THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WOULD YOU CARE CLOSE
THANK YOU AM I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE MR HERTZBERG. DIDN'T HAVE
A QUESTION. BUT ALL RIGHT- IT'S
BERKELEY WE DON'T WANT TO CUT
THE MAJORITY LEADER ALSO GO
AHEAD. I DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS RESPECT TO CERTAIN
CROSS REFERENCES IN THE MEASURE
TO FIND OUT. HOW SHE HAS TO
HANDLE THOSE THINGS WITH
RESPECT TO SECTION FOUR NINE
THREE ONE OH ONE ONE. IN
SECTION FORTY THREE LED TO
MERCHANTS- WHOLESALERS DURABLE
CODE'S PROVISION AND I WANT TO
ASK HER THAT CROSS REFERENCES
TO THE ELECTRONIC SHOPPING AND
MAIL ORDER HOUSE PROVISIONS OF
THIS MEASURE. KNOWING THE STEAM
SHIP- SURE APPROPRIATIONS I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A REALLY
GOOD ANSWER SO WITH THAT HAPPY
DAY IF MISTER CHAIR THREE YOU
ARE LIKE TWO ADS AS THE
QUESTION. ASIA FIVE OF THE
MEASURE YES THERE'S A LINE OR
TWO LATER AFTER- AFTER EIGHT
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. ANY SMART
**** SIRI IS SERVED TO THE
CHAIR SO ALL RIGHT THAT'S
ALRIGHT APPROPRIATIONS IS
COMING RIGHT UP ALL RIGHT. YOU
CARE TO CLOSE SURE CROSS
REFERENCE I IT I ASSURE YOU I
DO WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN-
AND YOUR STAFF ESPECIALLY TAM
WHO WE WORKED HARD AND WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE. THIS BILL WORKS- WE
WILL NEVER GET THE OPPOSITION
OFF BUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
LAWYERS GETTING RICH THIS IS
ABOUT WORKERS BEING SAFE AND
BEING ABLE TO USE THEIR OWN
AGENCY TO USE A LOT TO MAKE THE
WORKPLACE SAFER. WE KNOW
THERE'S A PROBLEM WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE CHARGING INTO
NEW TERRITORY HERE WHAT YOUR
MANAGER IS BASICALLY AND ALL
THE RHYTHM AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE WORKERS CAN STILL
PRESERVE. THE BASIC HUMAN
FUNCTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO GO
TO THE BATHROOM TO WASH THEIR
HANDS TO GET AT THE WATER WHEN
IT'S SO HOT INSIDE THESE
WAREHOUSES SO. THANK YOU FOR
INDULGING ME AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I. VOTE AND- THANK
YOU. PLEASE LISTEN TO WHAT
KOWSKI THE MOVE THE BILL-
MANAGE ACCOUNTS THE
CONFIGURATION ARM WRESTLING AN
ACTOR ALL RIGHT. RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN A WHITE COLOR SCHEME
ALL RIGHT MAN AND CHIEF COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES THIS
IS EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER ON SATURDAY WITH-
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG OUR
NUMBER FIVE BARGES. CARRY IT
ALL ZERO I DID I SO. DID I SO
I. GONZALEZ. HER HURTS BERG I
JONES LAYERED LAYERED ICE
SKINNER STERN EASTERN I WAKE
HOUSEKI WHITE KATHY I'D- YOU
HAVE SEVENTY THERE WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL NEXT I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN WHO'S
ALSO BEEN WAITING VERY
PATIENTLY FOR QUITE SOME TIME-
FIRST UP IS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR A. B. ONE ZERO FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLD. FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THAT'S
HERE. AND THE CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHAIRS
CONCERNS WHILE KEEPING THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT I'M TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN TACT. WHICH IS TO
SEE UPWARD MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM. MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING A B. ONE OH FIVE A
BILL THAT IDENTIFIES AND
REFORMS PROCESSES THAT HINDER
UPWARD MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM. OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS THE SACRAMENTO BEE HAS
PUBLISHED A SERIES OF LETTERS
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN EMPLOYEES WORKING AT
ORGANIZATIONS. SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
OUR CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM
AND THE OFFICE OF STATE
PUBLISHING. ALL OF THESE
INSTANCES HAVE A COMMON
DENOMINATOR. THERE ARE BARRIERS
TO UPWARD MOBILITY AND
INCLUSION. LAST YEAR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TOOK A BOLD STEP FORWARD
BY SIGNING MY BILL AB NINE
SEVEN NINE WHICH REQUIRES EACH
PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATION WHOSE
PRINCIPAL. EXECUTIVE OFFICES
ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
HAVE A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
DIRECTORS FROM UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ON ITS
BOARDS OF DIRECTORS. THE GOAL
WAS PLAIN AND SIMPLE WE NEED TO
INCREASE UPWARD MOBILITY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THIS WAS A PRAISE WORTHY
STEP FOR EMPLOYEES IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. HOWEVER THERE
ARE PERPETUAL BARRIERS TO
UPWARD MOBILITY THAT EXIST IN
OUR PUBLIC SECTOR SERVICE CIVIL
SERVICE SYSTEM. IT IS IN THIS
SPIRIT THAT I HAVE PUT FORWARD
A NUMBER OF CIVIL SERVICE
REFORMS. THAT ARE REFLECTED IN
A B. ONE OH FIVE. FOR STARTERS
AB ONE OF FIVE CALLS FOR
DIVERSITY ON THE STATE'S BOARD
AND COMMISSIONS THAT HAVE
VOLUNTEERS AS YOU KNOW THE
CONSTITUTION DID NOT ALLOW
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT BASED ON
RACE GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. AND THE OPERATION
OF PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. EDUCATION
AND CONTRACTING THEREFORE THE
LEGISLATURE CANNOT REQUIRE
DIVERSITY RECORD REGARDING
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. THAT
SOLELY HAVE STATE EMPLOYEES.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALLOWED TO REQUIRE DIVERSITY ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS WERE THE
BOARD MEMBER COMMISSIONER IS A
VOLUNTEER. MAYBE ONE OF FIVE
SIX TO DIVERSIFY THE POSITIONS
OF VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBERS AND
COMMISSIONERS AS VACANCIES
OCCUR. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD ESTABLISHED A
PROCESS THAT INCLUDES DIVERSITY
AND BEST PRACTICES IN EACH
ASPECT OF THE DESIGN.
ANNOUNCEMENT AND ADMINISTRATION
OF EXAMINATIONS FOR THIS
TALISMAN OF EMPLOYMENT LISTS.
THE DIVERSE PERSPECTIVE ON ALL
ASPECTS OF THE HIRING PROCESS
PROVIDES FOR A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE AND BETTER OUTCOMES.
EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE PROVIDES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES MAY DEVELOP MODEL
UPWARD MOBILITY GOALS. TO
INCLUDE RACE GENDER AND LGBT Q.
AS FACTORS TO EXTENT POSSIBLE
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL EQUAL
PROTECTION LAWS. MEMBERS THE
INCLUSION OF THESE FACTORS ARE
SIMPLY MEANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR DIVERSITY. I'M AWARE
OF THE PROVISIONS OF PROP TWO
OH NINE AND I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
VIOLATE THE CONSTITUTION. OVER
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS. THE
COLLEGE OUR WORKFORCE ANALYSIS
INSTANCES REPORTS INDICATE
CONSISTENTLY THAT OVER SIXTY
PERCENT. OF THOSE IN MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS ARE WHITE ALE AND
FEMALE. ON THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM OVER 60% OF THOSE
MAKING LESS THAN FORTY THOUSAND
OR PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR IMPLICIT BIAS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED. FINALLY
A. B. ONE OH FIVE REQUIRES THAT
COLLEGE ARE SUBMITTED WITHIN
ITS ANNUAL WORKFORCE ANALYSIS
AND CENSUS REPORT ALL OF THE
ADVERSE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
DEPARTMENTS AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
THE CALLS FOR THE REPORTS TO
INCLUDE THE TYPE OF ADVERSE
ACTION THAT THIS CITY GENDER
AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION IF
AVAILABLE. THE GOAL IS TO SEE
THAT. THERE IS A IF SEE IF
THERE'S A PATTERN OF
DISCRIMINATION IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S. MEMBERS OVER THE
PAST YEAR ISSUES OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION HAVE BEEN. TOP AREAS
OF CONCERN NATIONALLY AND HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT
HAS BEEN NEARLY EIGHT YEARS
SINCE GOVERNOR BROWN'S
REORGANIZATION PLAN FOR CIVIL
SERVICE. COLLEGE R. HAS
PROVIDED US OVER SEVEN YEARS OF
DATA. THAT HIGHLIGHTS THAT
THERE ARE PROCESSES IN PLACE
THAT HINDER UPWARD MOBILITY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS BILL
REPRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FINE TUNE OUR CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEM. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. IS A MANUAL AMOR FOR
CO FOUNDER DIRECTOR ABOUT REACH
COALITION OF BLACK EMPLOYEES.
AND CHRIS LOXTON WITH THE
COALITION FOR JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU- MR ALMOST FOUR OR CHRIS
LARSEN ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YEAH
I'M ALL RIGHT AND WHO IS THAT
SAID MR ALMOST OR GO AHEAD. THE
MAN OFF SORRY GO AHEAD. OKAY
GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING SHARE
NUMBERS MY NAME IS AMAN AMAN
FOR AND I REPRESENT THE
COALITION OF BLACK EMPLOYEES. A
RESPECTED MEMBER SINCE THE
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES I'LL BE
READING SOME OF THE COMMENTS
SHARED BY. I'M CONSTANTLY
PASSED OVER FOR PROMOTION I DO
NOT SEE ENOUGH OF MY FACE IS
REPRESENTED IN THE HIGHET
LEVEL OF OUR LEADERS. ARE NOT
BEING UTILIZED RESPECTIVELY
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE THE MOST
QUALIFICATIONS AND EXPERIENCE.
THESE ARE THESE ARE SOME OF THE
COMMENTS HE SAID AND I'VE HEARD
FROM MANY STATE EMPLOYEES OF
COLORS. THEY DID THE DAMAGE
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY SHOWN
ITSELF TO BE THE LEADER OF
NATIONAL CHANGE BUT REPARATIONS
PLANTS FOR DESCENDANTS OF
SLAVES. WHERE THE MOST
CONSCIENTIOUS STATE IN THE
COUNTRY AND ALWAYS WANT TO
WRITE LONG. I AND MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE WORK WITH THE
STATE FROM WORK FROM THREE TO
THIRTY YEARS AND THE MOST
DISHEARTENING EXPERIENCE WE
SHARED. IN QUALITY THE
PROMOTION ABUSE OF POWER AND
MISTREATMENT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND ALL STATE DEPARTMENT. THIS
IS LIKE EIGHTY ONE OF FIVE IT
WAS VERY PERSONAL TO US BECAUSE
IT AFFECTS ALL OF US DIRECTLY.
WE CRIED OUT TO OUR DEPARTMENT
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY AND ACTING
BUT OUR CRIES WERE DAMPENED BY
THEIR LACK OF INTEREST. TO MAKE
A CHANGE. EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE IS
THE FIRST STEP TO WRITING
PRACTICES THAT ARE WRONG. WE'RE
FATHERS MOTHERS SONS SISTERS
DAUGHTERS VOTERS AND LEADERS.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR EQUALITY
IN STATE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPS
FOR THE PEOPLE. WE ALL KNOW
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG.
I DIDN'T GET MANY BY BOATING
FOR EIGHTY ONE OF FIVE YOUR
SIGNING YOUR NAME INTO THE
HISTORY BOOKS. CHANGE THIS BILL
WILL BE SUPPORTING SPOT WILL BE
A SUPPORTERS SHIELD FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN MISTREATED. DUE
TO THE CULTURAL BACKGROUND OF
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN. FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- CHRIS LARSEN. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE EMMANUEL GREAT
WORDS THAT AFTERNOON SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO
BEGIN BIRDS OF SUPPORT FOR THE
UPWARD MOBILITY ACT ON WHAT I
MIGHT CALL YOU IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MY NAME AGAIN IS
BECAUSE LAUNCHED IN PUBLIC
FOLDERS AND WAIT THAT EQUITABLE
CALIFORNIA WHAT HE GAVE ME THE
I'M AN AFRICAN AMERICAN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL DEPEND FROM
PERSON COMPLETE IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND I LIVE WITH THE
CURRENT IMPACT ON THAT HISTORY
WHICH INCLUDES UNFORTUNATELY
DISCRIMINATION IN STATE
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING STATE
BOARD AND COMMISSIONS BY VOTING
IN FAVOR OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE YOU ARE MADE TODAY YOU HAVE
A CHANCE TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
THE CONCERNS BEFORE THE
COMMISSION THAT AWKWARD
MOBILITY IS A REALITY FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND PEOPLE LIKE
EMMANUEL ARE BETTER RECENT
EVIDENCE TELLS US THIS ONE. JOB
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS IS THAT BAD NOW HAVE
THAT ONE FACTOR AT LEAST THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES TO APPLE
AFRICAN AMERICAN BORN COURT ARE
STILL FOUR BY EIGHT FORTY THREE
A POLL 70% OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN BORN INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS WILL FALL OUT OF THE
MIDDLE PLAN AT ADULT IN OTHER
WORDS MY COMMUNITY IS
EXPERIENCING DOWNWARD MOBILITY.
THEREFORE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YOU WILL MAKE
IT NECESSARY TO RESTORE UPWARD
MOBILITY AND CONFRONT RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN STATE EMPLOYMENT
CURRENTLY IT THE POLICY OF
MARKET RIGHT NOW THAT THE
COMPOSITION OF OUR BOARD AND
OUR COMMISSION BEFORE AL THE
REFLECTIVE OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC INCLUDING MINORITIES AND
WOMEN AND BE BASED ON MERIT AND
FITNESS LAST YEAR EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY NOT REQUIRED TO FIRST ON
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE BOARD IT
IS WELL TIME THAT ARE SPACED UP
STEP UP AS WELL BUT YESTERDAY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY WHEN YOU
ARE MATE BY DOING SO YOU ALSO
HAVE THE CHANCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE COMMITMENTS OF UPWARD
MOBILITY AREN'T JUST WORDS ON A
PIECE OF PAPER BUT THAT THERE
IS REAL ACCOUNTABILITY REAL
OVERSIGHT AND REAL MESSED UP
PROGRESS TOWARD OUR GOAL AND
LASTLY THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
YOU WOULD MAY ALSO REQUIRE THAT
UP WITH DIFFERENT BLACK OR
AFRICAN AMERICAN AFRICAN
AMERICAN GROUPS TO BE
DISAGGREGATED SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE DO NOW. APR BROTHER AND
SISTER THIS BIT. HELP OF GET
BETTER. MORE CLEAR DOWN. ON
DIFFERENT NEEDS OF OUR- THIS
MEANS MORE EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES
THAT. CAN IMPROVE LIFE ACTORS
YOUR SUPPORT BUT IT'S- TWENTY.
YOU MAY TODAY. THANK THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OTHER IN SUPPORT
SAYING ONE OF THE GALLERIES NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE. ON THE PHONE
LINE MODERATE OR DO WE HAVE.
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
THEIR POSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE OH FIVE. ONE NINE ZERO.
THAT DIDN'T SUPPORT AB. ONE OH
FIVE ONE NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE IN YOU ARE RIGHT AND
WE CAN START WITH WINE FOR
FORTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANGELA NIRVANA WITH THE
COALITION FOR A JOB AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A. B. ONE OH FIVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
NEXT THANK YOU. I APOLOGIZE. WE
HAVE MY NUMBER. THREE SEVENTY
SIX. HI THIS IS FROM THE JOHN
MUHAMMAD I AM A MEMBER OF THE
COALITION FOR JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
THE NATIONAL ASSEMBLY OF
AMERICAN SLAVERY DEFENDANT BY
ANGELA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AB ONE OH FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE SIX THIRTY
SIX. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
TIFFANY QUARREL NOT WITH THE
COALITION FOR JACKSON AT LITTLE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER. SIX THIRTY EIGHT. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GO AHEAD
HELLO. YES THIS IS MARTIN
CHECKING IN WITH THE NATIONAL
CINEMAX WHERE DISTANCE LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE COALITION FOR JOBS GOOGLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A B. ONE OH FIVE. THANK
YOU. NEXT IN HEADLINE FORM.
SIXTY FIVE. THE COALITION. AND
I DO SUPPORT IT MORE THAN FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND IF WE
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE OH FIVE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHTY- IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
PRINCIPAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WELL KNOWN LET ME
STRIKE THAT DR WEI YANG WU IS
pIN OPPOSITION- DOCTOR WU ARE
YOU AVAILABLE. CAN THANK YOU
I'M ONE OF OUR LAND THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRACTICE FINE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA W. QUIET
FOUNDATION I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
YOU CANNOT ISSUE A B. WHILE
FIVE FIFTY- PROPOSES SETTING UP
ANNUAL GOALS AND TIMETABLES
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN MAKE
DECISIONSWHICH WILL INCLUDE
YOUR RACE AND GENDER EXACTLY.
TRANSLATE YOU. IN RACHEL CRAFT.
BY RACE OF COLOR COMPLICATION
PRINCIPLE OF EQUAL TREATMENT
CODIFIED IN ARTICLE ONE SECTION
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SIX PRINCIPAL
WOULD ALLOW ME TO MAKE SURE
YOUR FRIENDS LAST NOVEMBER. AND
SEVEN POINT 2% OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS REJECTED PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHTY WHILE CLAD
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD NEED TO BE
FACT QUOTAS WHICH VIOLATE.
FEDERAL LEGISLATION
COMPLICATIONS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO ACCORDING AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION THE SEVEN
OR THE PEOPLE THAT ACT OF.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR AND YOU CAN
CALL. BECAUSE HE CAN YEAH THANK
THE FINAL. RECALLING SPEAKING
EIGHT ONE OH FIVE IF THEY FOUND
A MISGUIDED. THAT THAT HELLO A
PATH FOR COMMOTION OVER WHY
PEOPLE USE ON THEIR CALIFORNIA
GUARANTEE OF EQUALITY BEFORE
THE LAW WORKS WHAT'S THAT MIGHT
BE COOKING FOR CALLING YOU HAVE
A COMPLAINT THAT YOU CREATE
THEY CAN TAKE SIGNIFICANTLY
MINORITY CIVIL SERVANTS ROSE
FROM THIRTY EIGHT POINT NINETY
NINE OVER FIFTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY WOMEN MAKE UP
ABOUT FORTY SIX POINT 5% OF THE
TOTAL SEVEN POINT FOUR. IN
ADDITION A PORCH AND IT'S NOT
LIMITED TO LOCATING POSITIONS
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT WHAT
SHOULD EDUCATE OUR WORKING
EFFECTIVELY WITH REASONABLE
ASSISTANCE FOR DISADVANTAGED
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF RACE
OR SEX WE SHOULD ALSO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT PROVIDING
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT
ENCOURAGES INDIVIDUAL MERIT.
THEREFORE I URGE AUTHENTIC
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
VOTE NO. ON EIGHTEEN ONE OH
FIVE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES ABOUT
THE SAYING NONE OF THE GALLERY
NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE ON THE
PHONE LINE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP.
IF YOU ARE IN A POSITION OF AB
ONE OH FIVE PLEASE. ONE ONE
ZERO. THE OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE
OH FIVE ONE ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE ONE IN Q. IT IS ONE OF SIX
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
IN FAVOR. ALL RIGHTY ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
QUEUE ARE A GREAT THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER- QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SIX SENATOR- SENT A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. YES MISTER CHAIR
AND- THE I HAVE A QUESTION AS
TO WHY- WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
STRIPPING AS P. B. AT THE AT
THIRTY TO CONDUCT INDEPENDENT
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS. A
PERSONAL PRACTICES IT JUST
SEEMS COUNTER INTUITIVE TO ME
AND I IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
WHY YOU TAKE IT AWAY FROM AN
INDEPENDENT ORGANIZATION AND
PUT IT SOMEWHERE WHERE. THEY DO
ALL THE HIRING AND THE FIRING.
SEVEN NUMBER HOLD. I THINK THE
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS OPPORTUNITY FOR TRANSPARENCY
AND FOR THERE TO BE- A PROCESS
IN PLACE TO ALLOW FOR THE KIND
OF ACCOUNTABILITY WHERE- THOSE
WHO ARE SEEKING TO HAVE THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROMOTION
EVALUATED CAN BE EVALUATED IN A
WAY THAT THERE WAS CLARITY AND
TRANSPARENCY TO THE TO THE
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT WAS
ESSENTIALLY THE- THE THINKING
BEHIND. OKAY THE PROBE. SO MY
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
THINK IT'S- MAKE IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE I SEE WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO WITH IT BUT SBB
WAS SET UP AS AN INDEPENDENT.
ENTITY TO DO AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATION OF PERSONNEL
PRACTICES SO IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO ME JUST TO SEND
THAT OVER TO KELLY CHAR- WHEN
THIS IS REALLY A- A BODY THAT
WAS SPECIFICALLY SET UP TO LOOK
AT- AND HOW OUR SYSTEMS WORK
SO- I'M JUST GONNA. I'LL LAVE
THAT THERE- AND- AND I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL- DELIVERY HOLD
YOU WISH ADDRESS THE POINTER IN
YOUR CLOTHES WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS IT. WELL I APPRECIATE
THE POINT AND I'M HAPPY TO-
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE DROVE ON TO
REACH THAT CONCLUSION BECAUSE I
THINK IT WAS AFTER HAVING-
REVIEWED THE CALLOUS OUR
REPORTS AND HOW- THE- THE
ISSUES THAT WERE. IMPEDING THE
UPWARD MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT WE WERE SEEN NOT. THE
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROCESS THAT
WAS IN PLACE AT THE ESPYS WERE
IN PLACE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S- SOME CLARITY TO
THIS AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND I
THINK THAT. THERE MAY BE SOME
OTHER ELEMENTS THAT I'M LEAVING
OUT TODAY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH YOU TO. ADDRESS
FURTHER YOU'RE CONCERNED. PARTY
THANK YOU CENTERS FOR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I HOLD THIS AUTHOR IN
HIGH REGARD HE'S BEEN A FRIEND
OF MINE FOR DECADES BUT I HAVE
A BONE TO PICK WITH THEM WITH
RESPECT TO THIS MEASURE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN I
INTRODUCE. THE UPWARD MOBILITY
ACT. AND I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
SOME INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY-
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO THIS
MEASURE. FORTUNATELY MY UPWARD
MOBILITY ACT HAD TO DO WITH MY
SERVICE TAX THAT NEVER MADE IT
ANYWHERE IN. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO NOTE FOR
THE RECORD THAT THE UPWARD
MOBILITY ACT WAS THE SERVICE
TAX THAT NEVER WENT ANYWHERE
AND I OPEN MY FRIENDS GOOD WILL
THAT HIS UPWARD MOBILITY ACT
DOES IT BETTER THAN BY UPWARD
MOBILITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ALSO HAD ONE IN
TRANSPORTATION CALLED UPWARD
MOBILITY THANK YOU SENATOR HERS
FOR AGAIN. FOR EITHER OF YOU
TWO ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- IT IS-
YOU KNOW SIMPLY MEMBER HOLDING-
I THINK THIS IS A LAUDABLE GOAL
I THINK YOU'VE LEFT OUT TWO
VERY IMPORTANT CATEGORIES OF
THOSE WHO ARE PROTECTED.
PERSONS UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW A
DISABLED AS WELL AS VETERANS I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
TO CONSIDER INCLUDING A MORE
COMPLETE LIST OF THOSE WHO
SHOULD BE- NOT JUST CONSIDERED
BUT ALSO FOCUSED UPON FOR
PURPOSES OF BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE THE SUGGESTION AND
CERTAINLY- MISTER CHAIRMAN- I
TAKE YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS A VERY
SERIOUSLY AND AS WE REFLECTED
BACK AFTER OUR CONVERSATION IT
BECAME. JUST TO REITERATE THAT
UNDER NINE SEVEN NINE IT WAS
REALLY ESTABLISHING WHAT UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES- WHO
ARE NOT EVIDENTLY- ON THESE
BOARDS- IN A WAY THAT SHOWS
REPRESENTATION. THAT DATA
REPORTS THAT WERE IN PLACE THEY
WERE COULD JUSTIFY EACH GROUP
WHO FALLS UNDER THE UNDER
REPRESENTED CATEGORIES- WHY
THERE IS AN ISSUE THERE AND
WHERE THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE THEIR
REPRESENTATION ON THESE BOARDS.
AND AS I. WAS NOTING- THE S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO. A LOW MOAN
ESTABLISHES REALLY BACK DATA
WHICH I THINK IS VERY CRITICAL
TO THE NEXT STEP SO IT'S THE
DATA IN THE MANDATE AND WITHIN
HER BILL THERE'S A CALLS OUT
WITHIN SECTION THIRTEEN OH FIVE
B. THE COLLECTION OF DATA ON
DISABLED DISABILITY STATUS AND
VETERAN STATUS. AS IT RELATES
TO THE STATE BOARD MEMBERS AND
COMMISSIONS AND SINCE THAT'S
CALLED OUT CURRENTLY IN ER
BILL WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED IT IS THE WHAT I WOULD
CALL THE PRECURSOR TO THE NEXT
STEP WHICH WOULD BE THE MANDATE
WHICH THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
DO AND I'M VERY HAPPY. TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT- AS WE GO
FORWARD HOW THAT CAN BE
ADDRESSED IN FUTURE BILLS
ALREADY THANKS VERY MUCH- I
WAS- OUR MOTION YES CENTER THE
RUSSELL MOVES I'M SORRY. I'M%
SORRY WE HAD HIRED AS THE FIRST
MOVER OF THE MOTION SO- THE
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED-
WOULD LIKE CLOSE. ACTUALLY
AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU. THIS IS
A B. ONE OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. HI AMBER
I. GORGEOUS KELLY IT'LL- CAREER
HIGHS GOOD AAL. THE RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ. HERZBERG PRINTS
BURGER I JONES. LAYERED LAYERED
ICE SKINNER STERN STERN I WAKE
HOUSE SKI BIKE HOUSE SKI I HAVE
SEVEN TO ZERO SO FAR WITH
EMBERS MISSING ALREADY WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT THE
FOLLOWING NUMBER. TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY NINE FOUR EIGHT SOMEONE
NUMBER HOLD CLOSURES. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
STATE THAT I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THAT'S
HERE AND HIS CONSULTANT FOR
WORKING WITH MY TAFF TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE TEACHERS
CONCERNS. BOB TURN MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT IN A. B. NINE
FORTY EIGHT A BILL THAT
REQUIRES THAT EVERY CONTRACT
FOR THE SALE OF REAL PROPERTY.
CONTAIN A NOTICE INFORMING THE
BUYER AND SELLER OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPORT ANY
SUSPICION OF DISCRIMINATORY
APPRAISAL. BY A REAL ESTATE
APPRAISER THROUGH THE BUREAU OF
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS INTERNET
WEBSITE OR TELEPHONE NUMBER.
FOR THOSE THAT SEEK TO
REFINANCE THEIR PROPERTY THE
NOTICE WILL BE PROVIDED IN THE
LOAN MATERIAL. MEMBERS THE FAIR
HOUSING ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PROHIBITS HOME APPRAISERS
FROM DISCRIMINATING BASED ON
RACE RELIGION NATIONAL ORIGIN
OR GENDER. HOWEVER OVER FIFTY
YEARS AFTER THE ACT WAS PUT IN
PLACE THE HOMES OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE STILL BEING
UNDERVALUED. RECENTLY THERE
HAVE BEEN A SERIES OF
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES WHERE THE
HOMES OF PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
BEING UNDERESTIMATED. FOR
EXAMPLE IN MARIN CITY AN
APPRAISER S. UNDERESTIMATED A
BLACK COUPLES HOME BY NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND. IN
OAKLAND AN APPRAISER LOWBALL
THE VALUE OF A BLACK AND PORTER
RICAN COUPLE'S HOME BY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND. THERE HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONAL HEADLINES IN NEWS
REPORTS OF RACIAL BIAS IN REAL
ESTATE APPRAISALS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES. MAYBE NINE
FORTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE THE
BUREAU REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS
TO PLACE ON ITS EXISTING
COMPLAINT FORM. A PLACE FOR
BUYERS AND SELLERS OR WITH
PERMISSION THE REAL ESTATE OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO VOLUNTARILY
PROVIDE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION. NINE FOUR EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE THE BUREAU TO
COMPILE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION. AND SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON OR
BEFORE. JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. IN TERMS OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE AN APPLICANT. FOR
APPRAISAL LICENSE INTO A
COMPLETE CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND ELIMINATION. OF BIAS
TRAINING FINALLY THIS BILL ADDS
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES TO THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT
REGARDING DISCRIMINATION AND
THE PROVISIONS OF APPRAISAL
SERVICES. MEMBERS FOR MANY
CALIFORNIA IS THEIR HOME IS
CONSIDERED TO BE THE GREATEST
ASSET. THE EQUITY IN THEIR HOME
ALLOWS THEM TO FIND CONTINUING
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILDREN
RETIREMENT AND HEALTH EXPENSES.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A TIMELY
BILL AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. TONIGHT FOR THOSE OF
THOSE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OUR OUT OF BOX WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND MIKE BELOW WITH
THE APPRAISALINSTITUTE. ALL
RIGHTY MR BELOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AS NOTED I AM MIKE
BELOW MY CLIENT IS CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS COMMITTEE
OF THE APPRAISAL INSTITUTE. THE
NATION'S LARGEST REAL ESTATE
APPRAISER ORGANIZATION. GIVEN
THE HOUR I'LL BE LEADING THE
FREE- THESE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
REPORTS ARE VERY VERY
CONCERNING OUR HEARTS HOPE THAT
THERE WERE SOME EXPLANATION
OTHER THAN RACE. BETTER HEAD
SUGGESTS THAT WE DON'T KNOW AND
IT'S VERY SIMPLE- REAL ESTATE
APPRAISING SHOULD ESTIMATE THE
VALUE OF A PIECE OF REAL
PROPERTY AT A GIVEN POINT OF
TIME. IN THE RACE NATIONALITY
ETHNICITY. SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
ETCETERA SHOULD HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH VALUE SO WE THINK THAT-
MR HOLDEN IS PUT TOGETHER
THOUGHTFUL PACKAGE HERE IT'S
NOT JUST CONTINUING EDUCATION
IT'S DISCLOSURE IT'S A PLACE TO
COMPLAIN. IT'S A START START
STRAIGHT OUT OF PROHIBITION IN
THE FIGURE APPOINTMENT AND
HOUSING LAWS WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR I. THANK YOU MR BELOW. ALL
RIGHT ON A BOOK. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- ANNA
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE A DIVERSE
NATION OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND REALTORS WHO ARE
EXTREMELY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL- AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS EIGHTY NINE FOUR
EIGHT REQUIRED ELIMINATION OF
BIAS TRAINING FOR ALL REAL
ESTATE APPRAISER AND- I REQUIRE
THAT EVERY REAL PROPERTY
AGREEMENT CONTAINED A NOTICE
STATING THAT THE BUYER AND
SELLER. ARE ENTITLED TO AN
UNBIASED APPRAISAL IS COMPLETED
ONE NATION TO THE PARTIES AND
ALSO INJURED NOTICES ARE
INCLUDED IN THE MATERIAL SHOULD
THE CONSUMER TO BE INVOLVED IN
A REFINANCE. OF THE PROPERTY
THAT REQUIRED AN APPRAISAL.
HOME IS. THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT TRANSACTIONS BASSMAN
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WILL
EVER MAKE MAKE NO MISTAKE THERE
IS A HUGE SOCIETAL CAUGHT THE
DEVALUATION OF PROPERTY EITHER
FROM BIAS OR FROM SOME OTHER
MEANS THE VALUE PROPERTY IS AN
OBSTACLE TO BUILDING EQUITY
WHICH WORKS TO BRING PETS AWAY
INCOME INEQUALITY IN OUR STATE
REDUCED PROPERTY VALUES ALSO
DESTABILIZED COMMUNITIES AND
REDUCING EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
THERE IS SO VITAL TO OUR
COMMUNITIES- AS THAT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IN THE ALL CLEAR BOTH
POINTED OUT OVER THE PAST YEAR
ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
HEADLINE MAKING STORY THE COAL
MINERS BEING LOW BALLED BY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. IN THE APPRAISAL
PROCESS THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
IN PREDOMINATELY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THE LEGACY
OF REDLINING SO WE FOUND IN
THIS IS. SIMPLY A POLY. EIGHTY
NINE FOUR EIGHT CERTAINLY DOES
ACCOMPLISH THEIR GARGANTUAN
TASK OF ELIMINATING BIAS IN THE
APPRAISAL INDUSTRY BUT THROUGH
A SERIES OF BOTTLED BEVERAGES
IMPROVED EXISTING LAW. AND WILL
MOST DEFINITELY HAVE THE EFFORT
EVERY. EFFECT OF REDUCING BIAS
IN THE INDUSTRY AGAIN WE ARE SO
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND. ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OTHER WITNESSES
SPORTS SING ON THE GALLERY NINE
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ON THE PHONE
WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE THEM UP.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IT
ISN'T SUPPORTED. EIGHTY NINE
FOUR EIGHT. AND WE HAVE
CURRENTLY QUEUE IN THE QUEUE
ALREADY. MY NUMBER SIX THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR KERRY
SANDERS KEVIN GOULD WITH
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE FORTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER FOUR
FORTY Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
AND YOUR PARTNER VON- WITH THE
COALITION FOR A JOB AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE HERE AS
LINE NUMBER. THREE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
COUNTED JOHN MUHAMMAD- FROM
JUSTIN EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. I APOLOGIZE WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN A PLAN NUMBER.
FOUR SIXTY FIVE. MAJOR
CORPORATION WE'RE JUST
CONNECTED WITH ALEX LANDED IN
FAVOR. THANK YOU. WE HAD ANYONE
ELSE WORKS IN SUPPORT OF.
THIRTY OF THEM SO I JUST ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE PHONE.
NO I DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE OUR LIST TURNED
OPPOSITION I SEE NO WITNESSES
LISTED IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THE GARY SAYING
pNONE. ON THE PHONE LINE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE TO A. B. NINE FOUR
EIGHT. ANY ACCUSATIONS OF
EIGHTEEN NINE FOUR EIGHT. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP HERE IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT WHILE I THINK IT'S YOUR
NUMBER AGAIN IT IS A POSITION
OF EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT ACCUSED SO THERE
IS NOBODY IN Q. AS OF RIGHT NOW
ALL RIGHT- BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS I
SEE NO MICROPHONES UP IS THERE
A MOTION CENTERS WERE MOSTLY
BUILT. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN TO CARE TO CLOSE- VERY
QUICKLY SIR I JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOUR STAFF- AND THANK YOU
FOR NOT ONLY. THE EXPERT.
ANALYSIS QUITE FRANKLY NOT ON
THIS BILL NINE FOUR EIGHT BUT
ALSO IN THE PREVIOUS BILL ONE
OH FIVE. YOUR YOUR TEAM- TOOK
NOT ONLY THE SPIRIT AND INTENT
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE. BUT ALSO WENT TO THE
NUANCES OF WHAT IT WAS
REPRESENTING AND FOR SO MANY
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR. THE LIGHT
TO SHINE IN SOME OF THESE DARK
PLACES- THAT KIND OF- DETAILED
ANALYSIS I JUST WANT TO KNOW
HOW MUCH I PERSONALLY
APPRECIATE THE CARE AND WHICH-
ARE YOU GAVE BOTH OF THESE
BILLS AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON A. B. NINE
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NO ONE APPRECIATES THAT MORE
THAN I- ALL RIGHT. BANNON CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YES THIS IS THE A. B. NINE FOUR
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG. AMBERG
I. BARGES. CARRY AT ALL. YET
ALL I DID I SAW. THE DRESS SO
I. GONZALEZ. HURTS BERG.
PITTSBURGH I JONES. LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SKINNER STERN. MR
AND I Y. CASKEY Y. CASKEY I.
THAT SEVEN TWO ZERO EIGHT
MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT ON CALL NEXT WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA. THE FLOOR
IS USED AS SOON AS WE CLEAN THE
PODIUM. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ALL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENT AS DESCRIBED IN
THE KIDNEY DIALYSIS. AND I
REALLY WANNA THANK YOUR STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AS
A BILL THREE TWO THREE LOS
TABLETS TO CLEANER STANDARD
NECESSARY TO HOLD LICENSE LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DEATHS BECAUSE
UNDER THE REGULATORY DUTY OF
CARE. ADDITIONALLY UNCHANGED
FOR TWENTY YEARS. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE ADULTS A STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATION TO
INCREASE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PENALTY
AMOUNTS. MOVING FORWARD ROBUST
AND CLEAR NURSING HOME
OVERSIGHT BY CITY PH WILL BE
CRITICAL THE RETURN OF BURKE
FURTHER CHARGES THAT I'VE ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED. BY THE COLD
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. CLASS W.
CITATIONS OF THE MOST SERIOUS
AND ONLY ISSUE THE CDPH PROVES
THAT THE FACILITIES ACTIONS IN
THE JURY TO REGULATIONS WAS THE
CAUSE. FOR RESIDENTS TO. THE
CURRENT DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE
LEGAL STANDARD IS STATUTE HAS
CREATED INCONSISTENCY WHEN
APPLYING CLASS W. CITATIONS IN
OUR STATE'S NURSING HOMES.
BECAUSE COURTS HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE IS
CONFUSING. AND UNCLEAR. IN FACT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
HAS SINCE REJECTED THE
APPLICATION APPROXIMATE CAUSE
AND PORTS OF CENTRALIZED ON THE
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR TEST. THE
CHANGE TO SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR
PROPOSE UNDER EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WHEN NURSING HOMES
AND FACILITIES APPEAL CLASS
DOUBLE A CITATION AND A
SUPERIOR COURT. THE STATE HAS
THE BURDEN OF PROOF FROM THE
JUDGE MUST APPLY THAT CAUSATION
STANDARD INSTRUCTION.
ADDITIONALLY COUNTY MILES
CREATED DISINCENTIVES FOR
FACILITIES TO VIOLATE HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND THESE AMOUNTS
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH INFLATION
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE
CRUISES AND REVISES THOSE
TREACHERY AMOUNTS. OF
POSITIONAL SAY THERE NEEDS TO
BE A SECOND FORESEEABILITY TEST
INCLUDED WAS A CENTRAL FACTOR.
THIS HAS BEEN REJECTED BY CITY
PH THE CONCERN AND I AGREE IT'S
FORESEEABILITY IN THE PRESENCE
OF A RESIDENT WITH THE COAL
MORBID MORBIDITY. COULD RESOLVE
THE FACILITY FROM THEIR DUTY OF
CARE. ADDITIONALLY UNDER
CURRENT LAW CPA STILL NEEDS A
SHOW OF THE DEATH RESULTED FROM
A VIOLATION IN REGULATION.
DESIGNED TO PREVENT THE DEATH.
C. PH FOUR SORRY NINETY IS NOT
A DISK. AFFECTING YOUR HOME. IT
IS REVEALED FLAWS IN OUR
REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT. EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY THREE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ABLE TO PROPERLY APPLY
OVERSIGHT TO LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES. AND HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FOR BROWN TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR RESIDENCE
HALL RESIDENTS HARM OR DEATH.
BY THIS DOING SO CITY PH CAN
ALSO IDENTIFY AND CORRECT A BAD
PERFORMANCE FACILITIES OF THE
QUALITY CARE. IS IMPROVED FOR
FUTURE RESIDENTS. PUT ME OVER
THE PHONE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY HIS GRAMMAR GRAMMAR
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. TEN TWENTY CHICKEN
TELL CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES. FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHTY MISTER
KRAMER YOU AVAILABLE. AND IF
YOUR CHAIR. GO AHEAD MISTER
KRAMER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- THIS IS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. LAST MONTH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL RELEASED-
DATASYNAPSE OUT WITH FINDINGS
THAT WERE ALARMING BUT NOT
SURPRISING THEY FOUND THE
OVERALL MORTALITY RATE IN
NURSING HOMES ROSE OVER 32% AND
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE PRESIDENT
OF COLOR WERE MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME INFECTED WITH COPA
NINETEEN THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. BUT NOT ALL
NURSING HOME STATES CUPBOARDS
DEVASTATION EQUALLY NURSING
HOMES THAT WERE PROBLEMATIC
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WERE MORE
LIKELY TO SUFFER OUTBREAKS WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE A REPEAT
OF THE UNNECESSARY DEATHS. AND
SUFFERING THAT WE WITNESSED
LAST YEAR. DISABILITY RIGHTS
ITS RECORD KEEPING ARCING HOME
RESIDENTS SAVE EXPLAINS WHY THE
CURRENT LAW FALLS SHORT OF
PROVIDING ADEQUATE GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT. IN A REPORT WE
DETAIL HUNDREDS OF INCONSISTENT
RESULTS AND LICENSING CITATIONS
OF NURSING HOME DEATHS. AND
THAT THE CURRENT LEGAL STANDARD
GOVERNING CITATIONS FOR NURSING
HOME DEATHS IS FLAWED AND
CONFUSING AND LEADS TO AN
UNEVEN AND INSUFFICIENT
PROTECTION OF RESIDENTS. EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY THREE ADOPTS A
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR STANDARD A
TERM USED AND UNDERSTOOD BY THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY AND WHICH WILL
HELP PROVIDE CLARITY AND IN
TURN MORE CONSISTENT AND BETTER
LICENSING OVERSIGHT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. FOR THE
SAKE OF OUR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS THE FACILITIES THAT
TAKE CARE OF THEM AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I ASK. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF BABY THREE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. MR THE ONLY
ONE YEAH HI GOOD EVENING- THIS
IS TONY TICKET TO- A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. YOU KNOW NURSING
RESIDENCE SUFFERED IMMEASURABLY
LAST YEAR AND WE OWE IT TO THEM
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
NURSING HOME CARE. OUR LAWS AND
REGULATIONS REGARDING CARE
STANDARDS ARE PRETTY GOOD AND
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN. ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY ENFORCEMENT. WHICH
HAS RANGED FROM LACKLUSTER TO
ABYSMAL FOR DECADES. SIMPLY
BILL THREE TWENTY THREE WILL
ENHANCE THE CARE PROVIDED IN
NURSING HOMES THE BILL
CLARIFIES THE CRITERIA FOR
DOUBLY CITATION SO THAT WE
BETTER DETER THE CONDUCT THAT
CAUSES THE DEATH OF PRESIDENT.
IN THE BILL GIVES A LONG
OVERDUE INFLATIONARY BUMP TO
PENALTY AMOUNTS TO ENSURE THAT
DETERRENCE IS NOT ERODED BY
DEPRECIATING DOLLARS. OUR
CITATION SYSTEM IS VERY.
COMPLAINTS AGAINST NURSING
HOMES CONTINUE TO RISE EVERY
YEAR BUT THE ACTIONS TO ADDRESS
THOSE COMPLAINTS REMAIN FLAT
AND LETHARGIC JUST ABOUT EVERY
DAY I SPEAK TO RESIDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WERE BEYOND
FRUSTRATED BE IT BY THE STATE'S
FAILURE TO MEANINGFULLY ENFORCE
THE RULES MEANT TO PROTECT
THEM. EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE
WILL UPDATE A LOT OF BRING MORE
CONSISTENCY IN MORE JUSTICE TO
ENFORCEMENT. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE IS ALSO PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA PROTECT PLAN A
PACKAGE OF BILLS. AIMING TO
REPAIR BREAKDOWNS IN LONG TERM
CARE EXPOSED. DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND PROTECTING
FACILITY RESIDENT RESIDENTS.
FROM ANY MORE PREVENTABLE HARM.
PLEASE VOTE I AM EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR TRICKETT TELL OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SAYING NONE OF THE
GALLERY NOT A ROOM ONE TWELVE.
BUT IF YOU DO THOSE UP WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE TWO
THREE. WE WOULD BE GRATEFUL. IF
YOU AREN'T A PART OF A. B.
THREE TWO THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT ISN'T
SUPPORTED. EIGHTY THREE TWO
THREE ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE QUEUE UP WE DO HAVE
ONE CUED UP HERE. WE HAVE ONE
REPLY NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY TWO.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
HELP AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THERE ARE NON OWNERS IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE WILL
TURNED OPPOSITION MR SHANE
LEVIN- LEVIN ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. IBM GOOD EVENING THE
CHARTER MEMBERS I THINK SHE
WILL BE IN ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HELP
FACILITIES REGRETTABLY WE ARE
POST EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AGAIN ALL
THE WORK MR CALLER THE STAFF
DOWN TO TRY TO RESOLVE THEIR
DIFFERENCES- WE SEE PH
PROPORTIONALLY UP TO THIS POINT
THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN.
UNFRUITFUL WE CONTINUE TO FIND
OURSELVES AT LOGGER HEADS HE PH
OF A NEW STANDARD IN WHICH THEY
WOULD LIKE TO PROVE A DOUBLE I
DOUBLE A VIOLATION. THE P. H.
TAKEN POSITION THAT NO LONGER
SHOULD DIRECT PROXY PROXY
BECAUSE THE STANDARD BUT JUST
INTRACTABLE. WE'VE TRIED TO
MAKE THE CASE THAT PERCY
ABILITY OR A REASONABLE
CONNECTION BE CLARIFYING FACTOR
IN THE CAUSATION ELEMENT
BECAUSE IT BROUGHT THE SCOPE OF
THE SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR TEST.
THIS IS BAMBI REJECTED MANY
TIMES. ELDER PERCY ABILITY
SEEMS EMINENTLY REASONABLE
GIVEN THE IMPACT OF THE DOUBLE
I TATIAN. BUT WHEN THE IMPACT
WITH A VOICE LIKE ANGEL HAVE
UNOFFICIALLY SUCH AS- THE
FEDERAL AND STATE PENALTIES
LOSS OF CORAL INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. POSSIBLY THE REST
BEFORE CLOSURE SO WE HAD A
DOUBLE EIGHT CITATION BECOMES
SCARLET LETTER FOR FACILITY.
THE REASON WE ASK YOUR MOBILE
THANK YOU- FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE OF THE
GALLERY NUMBER ONE TWELVE
MODERATOR IF THEIR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP.
A. B. THREE TWO THREE AND IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
THREE TWO THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE A LINE
NUMBER SIX SIX ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING I'M
ACTUALLY HERE AND OF COURSE ALL
THE THREE TWENTY THREE I'M IN
THE WHY THE HARDBALL WITH A. R.
P. CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU. EARLY
NEXT TIME LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
AS A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIX FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS
WITH READING EACH CALIFORNIA-
WHAT IF WE- RICHARD PRYOR. EACH
COMPANY IN THE- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX
FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARBARA PLAYED HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY THREE
TO THREE. THANK YOU. NEXT IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHTY LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE FLOOR
OTHER. ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS-
I SEE NO MICROPHONES RAISED. UP
ALL RIGHT. YES- SIR RUSSELL
MOVES THE BILL SO REMEMBER CARL
DO YOU CARE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MR SURE THIS IS THE
FIFTH YEAR. OF THE LAB
INTRODUCED THIS BILL OF MY
STAFF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
A LOT OF TIME INTO THIS WORK
WITH ADMINISTRATION WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE STAFFERS
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES STUFF. THEM
WITH OPPOSITION WHO TRULY IN
GOOD FAITH WE BID FROM REAL
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TRY TO COME
TO RESOLUTION WE TRY TO THREAD
THE NEEDLE ON THIS ISSUE I FEEL
CONFIDENT WITH THE INPUT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT. AND THE FAIR
THOROUGH REVIEW FROM THIS
COMMITTEE YOU CAN FIND THE
ADDRESS A VERY FLAWED LEGAL
STANDARD IN LAW LIVES HAMPERED
OUR STATE'S ABILITY TO ENFORCE
HEALTH AND SAFETY REGULATIONS
ON TO KEEP RESIDENTS HEALTHY
ALIGNED WITH THAT. RESPECT WE
ASCRIBE IT TO TORY BUT SHE CAN
ALSO BE CALLED ROLE THIS IS
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR DID OFF SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI AMBER
I BOARD YES. GOT A LITTLE CUBBY
AT ALL I DID ALSO THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI HURTS BERG
HURTS BURGER I. ATE JONES.
LAYERED LEE ICE. STIR THIS I
WAKE HOUSE SKI Y. CASKEY I.
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL ON THE NEXT
CERTAINLY MEMBER CARLOS A. B.
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SURE I'M PROUD OF IS
THAT MAYBE A FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THANKS TO A
DECENT EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE ALL
AGE WAY FARMWORKERS WITH
WRITTEN NOTICE OF KEY STATE AND
FEDERAL EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS
INCLUDING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS DURING FEDERAL
STATE EMERGENIES. AND
DISASTERS. LAST YEAR MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FORM FOR
THE FOREIGN FARM WORKERS WERE
IMPORTED. BY ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA GROWERS AND
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS UNDER
THE H. TWO A. FEDERAL VISA
PROGRAM. THIS NUMBER HAS BEEN
INCREASING ANNUALLY. THE THREE
FORMER BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA-
LARGELY RECRUITED IN MEXICO ARE
TIED TO A SINGLE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYER PROVIDES THEM WITH
HOUSING. MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY H. TWO A. WORKERS HAVE
NEVER BEEN TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE
THE NEITHER SPEAK NOR READ
ENGLISH. IF YOU'RE FIRED FOR
ANY REASON THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
IMMEDIATE DEPORTATION WHICH IS
A POWERFUL DISINCENTIVE TO
REPORT ANY ABUSE OF WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS THEY ARE SUBJECTED
TO. A EIGHT FIFTY SIX SEVEN
SIMPLY REQUIRES H. AWAY
EMPLOYERS. PROVIDE A SWEET FARM
WORKERS ON THEIR FIRST DAY OF
WORK. A SHORT COPPER HAS A
WRITTEN SUMMARY OF KEY LABOR
TRANSPORTATION RELATED HOUSING
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS THE
SPANISH. AND REQUESTED IN
ENGLISH. THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER DEVELOP
A TEMPLATE CONTAINING THE
SUMMARY AND THE POST ON THE
WEBSITE. FOR EXTRA EMPLOYERS TO
USE TO COMPLY WITH THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT. EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN CREATES A SAFER
LEGALLY COMPLIANT WORKPLACE FOR
A CENTURY FARM WORKERS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS MARGE SCHOTT THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA RULE
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
AND CYNTHIA RICE DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION A PROUD OF
LITIGATION ADVOCACY AND
TRAINING. FOR CALIFORNIA. RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU- MR SHAD OR
MISS RICE. YES MEMBERS- I'M
MARK SCHECTER CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION FOR
THE SPONSORS OF EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN THIS BILL AN ACT
THE CALIFORNIA LEGAL RIGHTS
DISCLOSURE ACT FOR H. TWO EIGHT
FARMWORKERS AND ADDRESSES THE
THING YOUR PROBLEM FACED BY
FLOORING CONTRACTOR CONTRACT
WORKERS WHO ENTER CALIFORNIA
UNDER FEDERALLY APPROVED JOB
OFFERS THAT OFTEN INCLUDE TERMS
THAT UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW. ARE FALSE OR MISLEADING OR
INACCURATE WITH NO STATE OR
FEDERAL AGENCY CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING THE FALL OF THE GAS
WORKERS WITH CORRECT
INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE IN
ROUGHLY 50% OF THE NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED H. TWO EIGHT JOB OFFERS
WE ANALYZED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA H.
TWO A. IMPORTERS FALSELY STATED
THAT RESIDING IN EMPLOYER
HOUSING CREATED NO TENANT
THINK. THEY MISLEADINGLY STATED
THAT RIDING ON THE EMPLOYER'S
BOSS FROM HIS HOUSING THROUGH
ITS FIELD IS VOLUNTARY IMPLYING
THAT IS NOT COMPENSABLE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW WHILE MANY OTHER
EMPLOYERS FAILED TO DISCLOSE
THAT OVERTIME PAY IS REQUIRED
AND OTHERS INACCURATELY STATED
WHEN OVERTIME PAY APPLIANCE. IT
IS- ASSEMBLYMEMBER CONGRESS AT
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN IS A
FUNDAMENTAL H. TWO A.
FARMWORKER RIGHT CAN NO STATUTE
THAT PULLS TOGETHER INTO A
SINGLE CRITICAL NOTICE- KEY
SALINE FORMATION. CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL SERVICES OFFICES
HAVE REPRESENTED H. AWAY FARM
WORKERS FOR ROUGHLY TWENTY
YEARS IN CIVIL MATTERS RELATING
TO WAIT STAFF FAILURE TO
PROVIDE MEAL AND REST PERIODS
FAILURE TO PAY OVERTIME PAY
REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA BUT NOT
FEDERAL LAW. AND OTHER LABOR
LAW VIOLATIONS THESE WORKER
GENTLE COME IN OUR OFF ONLY
AFTER THEIR CON IS ENDED FOR
HIS TURNED- THERE ARE SOME
HELLO. THAT OF THE EXCEL. BODY
OF LAY HOUSE HEALTH SAFETY THAT
PROTECT. THEM THAT WERE NEVER
JUST GO WELL TO THEM BY THEIR
EMPLOYER. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIFTY SEVEN WILL THIS MY CAL
LAW. INFORMATION IS THAT OF
THEIR FARM FOR ONE THEY WORKED.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL AS FOR
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS UNION AND
THE CONSUMER JOURNEYS- WHO ARE
UNABLE TO BE HERE TONIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THOMAS
RICE. MISTRY'S THE ONLINE. FIVE
LET'S TURN TO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF MISS RICE COMES
BACK WE WILL Q. HER IN- NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE TEN ZERO. TO
BE JUST A MOMENT. WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER SIX SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A READING.
ABOUT THIS REPORT THANK YOU IF
YOU COULD JUST HAVE REPEAT YOUR
NAME WE MAY HAVE NOT HEARD THE
FIRST PART OF IT. GOOD JOB ON
BEHALF OF UNITED FARM WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. GIVE. AND EIGHT IF YOU
WISH TO QUEUE UP YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE ALREADY LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION WE HAVE
MATTHEW ALLEN IN ROB ROY IN
OPPOSITION. MR ALLEN YOU ON THE
LINE. I AM ALIGNED I MISSED
YOUR- GOOD EVENING MR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON MAPPING
AROUND WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION I WILL. KEEP MY
ASSETS WHEN YOU BREATHE DUE TO
THE LATE HOUR. A WESTERN
GROWERS IS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
EIGHTEEN EIGHT FIVE SEVEN- THE
BILL REPRESENTS FAR MORE THAN A
SIMPLE NOTIFICATION. A
PROCEDURE THAT IN FACT. CHANGE
IS THAT A LOCK ON A TRAVEL
TIME- BY- EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT VOLUNTARY
AND MANDATED TRAVEL TIME. AS
PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. IN
THE EARLY IN PERSON WHILE
PACKERS NUMBER YOU CAN GET IN
THE QUEUE. HELLO BUT THEREFORE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
AT NEW SITUATIONS WHEREBY
TRAVEL TIME WOULD BE REQUIRED
H. U. H. TWO EIGHT EMPLOYEE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL GOES
WELL BEYOND EXISTING COURT
STATIONS BY REQUIRING THAT THE
TRAVEL TWENTY EIGHT AT THE
REGULAR RATE OF PAY. THIS IS
NOT A NOTICE OF EXISTING RIGHT
SINCE CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A
TRAVEL TWENTY COMPLICATED AT NO
LESS THAN THE- MINIMUM WAGE.
FINALLY THEY'RE STILL
SIGNIFICANTLY MAYORS AT ELEVEN
OH JUNE WHICH WAS VETOED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM LAST YEAR. AND
IS IT A MESSAGE THE GOVERNOR
DIRECTED THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY TO DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN.
THE EMPLOYEE NOTIFICATION
TEMPLATE THAT WAS CONTEMPLATED
IN AT ELEVEN A JUNIOR. STUDENT
THAT IS A PROCESS THAT CAN MORE
READILY TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
CHANGES IN H. TWO EIGHT
GOVERNING LAW. AND ANY FUTURE
COURT DECISIONS. WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
DIRECTION OUTLINED IF YOU DON'T
MATCH IT SHOULD PROCEED FORWARD
WITHOUT THE INTERFERENCE OF
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE SEVEN.
IT'S FOR THOSE REASONS AND
OTHERS. THAT WE ARE CLOSE TO
THE- THANK YOU MR ROBERT. IF
YOU CURRENTLY DROP. HE. YEAH
THIS. HELLO THIS IS WHICH
REPORTER FIRST NAME YEAH SHE
COULD BRING THE- THIS.
PUBLISHED BY THE STATE WHAT
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT. WE SHOULD
ENCOURAGE. AND EXACTLY BUT-
FIVE SEVEN FOUR TWO COMPELLING
REASONS FOR CLOSE LIFE THE
RECORD THAT THIS. BUT THIS BUT
IT WILL NOT BE ACTIONABLE IN
GENERAL BECAUSE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT IS REQUIRED IN
THIS WILL BE THE SECOND
ALREADY. IN THE FEDERAL BUDGET
TO REGULATIONS. AND IMPOSE ON
AN OLDER. YOU'RE KIDDING. IS
THAT HE IS A RENOWNED GIN OF
TRANSPORTATION AND
CONSIDERATION OF TRANSPORTATION
TIME MAPPING TO WORK AND BACK
NOW. THIS WOULD BE COMPENSABLE
WORK TIME WHEN THERE'S- A CLEAR
MAJORITY OF THIS ALL THE
GENERAL RULING CALIFORNIA'S.
TRANSPORTATION THE WAR IS.
STUPID UNLESS SPECIFICALLY.
THAT DID NOT APPLY HERE HM
SUPREME COURT DECISION MR ALLEN
NOTED MARTY ON VIRTUALLY ALL
PACKED IN TWENTY YEARS AGO ST
PAUL MINN CHESS MOREOVER. HE
EMPHASIZED AND IT. S. WHAT WE-
TRAVEL TIME BY PROVIDING. IT'S
CALL IS IN TROUBLE NO
TRANSPORTATION WELL YOUR
PROVIDE BUT THIS IS NOT
REQUIRED IT EMPLOYS JUNIORS AND
NOT COMPENSABLE HOURS WORKED
PROPOSITION FOR THIS BILL IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT BREAST
PLATE- WALKER TOLD ME THAT THE
EMPLOYER PROVIDED
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS TO BE
WORKERS WITHOUT COMPENSATION
BUT WE'RE EXAMPLE
TRANSPORTATION THAT THEY WORK
WITH THIS LITTLE BIG BAND BUT
THE BROKERS IN THE AREA.
BOLLINGER TRANSPORTATION.
BUDGET BY MANY OF THE HONEY.
ALL HAVE MANY OF THE DOMESTIC
US PREFERS TO WORK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ROY IF YOU WRAP IT UP
FOR. YEAH I SUPPORT THIS IS THE
POSITION. L. M. D. THE LANGUAGE
IN SECTION. TWENTY EIGHT. PARTY
THANK YOU SIR BUT- THANK YOU
ARE THE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT- MISS RICE'S BEEN FOUND SO
WE WLL COME BACK TO HER AFTER
WE'VE HEARD FROM OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE OF THE
GALLERY SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
E. B. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER SIX FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX FOUR
TWO. GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MEDICAL GOING ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE OUR NEXT LINE SIX SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY HOPPING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER SIX FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
WORLD WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO BACK TO MISS RICE MISTRY'S
AVAILABLE. YES GOOD EVENING CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MY NAME ISN'T DERIVED
FROM A DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION
FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE WE CURRENTLY
REPRESENT HAPPENED THE PAST RED
RECOVERED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR H. TWO A. WORKERS ON ISSUES
LIKE THIS EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN DOES NOT CHANGE THE CASE
ODD DEFINITION OF COMPENSABLE
TRAVEL TIME FOR H. TWO A.
WORKERS. IN CALIFORNIA ALL TIME
SPENT UNDER THE CONTROL OF AN
EMPLOYER MUST BE COMPENSATED.
IN COURT AND MARIO MAKE CLEAR
THAT EXTENDS TO TRAVEL TIME AND
CASES LIKE THOSE REFERENCING
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. SDLC
AND AL CONTAR REJECT THE NOTION
THAT IS THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
THAT TIME IS CHARACTERIZED AS
MANAGER MANDATORY OR VOLUNTARY.
AND RECOGNIZE THAT AND ILLUSORY
CHOICE IS NO CHOICE AT ALL.
THAT COMPATIBILITY TURNS ON
WHETHER THE EMPLOYER CONTROLS
WHEN WHERE AND HOW THE EMPLOYEE
GETS TO WORK. H. TWO A. WORKERS
ARE BROUGHT INTO THE COUNTRY BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS AND ARE
ASSIGNED TO SPECIFIC HOUSING
SITE THEY HAVE NO CARS NO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS
AVAILABLE. AND THEIR ACCESS TO
OTHERS IS LIMITED. EMPLOYERS
CONTROL THEIR H. TO A CRUISE BY
TELLING THEM WHEN AND WHERE TO
REPORT NOT TO A FIELD OF WORK-LOCATION BUT TWELVE BUSTER VAN
AFTER HOUSING SITE. WORKERS
ADVANTECH INTO THE WORK SITE
SOMETIMES AN HOUR AWAY. AFTER
THE FIELD WORK AND THEY WAIT
FOR THE. EMPLOYER TO SEND THE
BUS TO COME AND PICK THEM UP.
THEY ARE UNDER THE CONTROL OF
THE EMPLOYER AND MUST BE PAID
FOR THAT TIME AT THE REGULAR
RATE OF PAY. WHICH FOR H. TWO
A. WORKERS IS GENERALLY BE A
WERE A HIGHER RATE OF PAY SET
BY FEDERAL H. TWO A. LAW. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO REPLACE
U. S. WORKERS WITH H. TWO WAY.
THE OPPONENTS OF THE BILL SEIZE
UPON THE VOLUNTARY LANGUAGE OF
MARIANE. AND IGNORE ITS
ANALYSIS AND THE TWENTY YEARS
OF CASE LAW APPLYING IT TO THE
BALDING SITUATIONS. THEY DO SO
TO PROTECT EMPLOYERS WHO
CURRENTLY UNDER CONTRACT AND ON
PLACARDS IN THE BOXES. PRESENT
AN ILLUSORY CHOICE BY STATING
THAT TRANSPORTATION IS
VOLUNTARY WHEN WORKERS HAVE NO
REAL ALTERNATIVE. TO GET TO THE
WORK SITE. CURRENTLY AND UNDER
PROPOSED SECTION. TWENTY EIGHT
TEN POINT SIXTY FIVE OF THE
BILL. WORKERS H. TWO A. WORKERS
WHO HAVE A REAL ALTERNATIVE TO
GET TO WORK AND ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO TAKE THE BUS. WILL
NOT BE ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTRY'S
WRAP IT UP RIGHT AND I'VE- YES
THEY ARE. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION SHARES THAT
WORKERS ARE ADVISED TO THESE
RIGHT AND OTHER WELL
ESTABLISHED RIGHT AND I WOULD
BE HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT I THINK THAT
EXHAUST WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
MODERATOR ANY OF THE WINDOWS ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- TO A. B. EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
I HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX SIX FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE NAVY. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN-
THIS IS KEITH TOMATO WITH-
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH READ NEXT
PLACE. TO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND HE
BEAT FIVE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE QUEUING
UP ON THE PHONE ALL RIGHT CAN
YOU LET'S COME BACK TO THE
FLOOR- QUESTIONS COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS YES CENTER BOARD JUST.
FIGURES FEATURE. DISTURB POINT
OF CLARIFICATION MAYBE I CAN
POSE A QUESTION TO THREE YOU
TOO THE AUTHOR- IF HE'S WILLING
TO ACCEPT MY QUESTION WOULD BE.
IT IS THERE ANY CASE LAW THAT.
THAT EXPLAINS IN DETAIL THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ENTITLED
TO PAY. WHILE IN TRANSIT AND WE
HEARD FROM SOMEONE THAT CALLED
IN IT SAYS WHEN YOU'RE UNDER
THE CONTROL THAT THAT BE THE
OPERATIVE- PART OF THE ANALYSIS
BUT WAS THIS RESOLVED IN THE
COURT SYSTEM. BUT SELLING
NUMBER CAR HERE SO THANK YOU
THE RESEARCHERS UNDER FARM THE
REALITY IS THAT. THE COURT
SYSTEM. MORE GENERALLY TALK
ABOUT MANITOBA SO VOLUNTARY
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
ACTUALLY A B. V. SEVEN IS
DECLARATORY OF EXISTING LAW.
AND ACTUALLY PUTS IN FACTORS TO
MAKE THE DETERMINATION BECAUSE
ONE CAN SAY VOLUNTARY. BUT AS
INDICATED BY THE BY THE WITNESS
OFTENTIMES A LOSER YOU SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF SOMEONE DOES NOT A
PERSONAL VEHICLE THEY CAN'T
TAKE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. TO
FROM THE WORK SITE YOU HAVE NO
REAL OTHER REAL OR TURNER TO
TAKE A TRANSPORTATION. PROBLEM
THE REQUIRED BY THE EMPLOYER
ASIA TAKE CHANCES PROVIDED FOR
BY THE EMPLOYER THESE ALL
FACTORS THAT ACTUALLY ALTHOUGH.
ON THE SURFACE MAYBE DIDN'T
MAYBE DEEMED VOLUNTARY IN
ACTUALITY IT'S MANDATED FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO PERFORM
THEIR DUTIES. R. M. THANK YOU
IT SEEMS AS IF THE BASED ON THE
REPRESENTATIONS BY AT LEAST ONE
OTHER CALLERS AT THIS WAS A
MATTER OF. LAW THAT HAD ALREADY
BEEN DETERMINED AND THIS WAS
SIMPLY EFFECTUATENG- YOU KNOW
SOME SORT OF- CASE LAW
DETERMINATION- IT I FIND IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO WRAP MY ARMS
AROUND THAT IF WE HAVE FEDERAL
LAW THAT'S REQUIRING
TRANSPORTATION. AND THEN FOLKS
ARE- OBLIGING- THAT SERVICE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES- THAT SEEMS
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE. BUT TO
PAY THEM I IN TRANSIT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A BIT MUCH WHEN I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT AN
AGRICULTURAL AREA AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THERE MIGHT BE
DISTANCES ON IT OTHER TIMES-
THE RELATIVELY CLOSE. THE
WAITING TIME IS THAT THE THRUST
OF WHY YOU'RE PROPOSING THIS
BILL THAT THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT
WAITING TIME EITHER AT THE
BEGINNING. OF THE DAY BEGINNING
IN A SHIFT TOWARD THE END OF
THE SHIFT. THE CENTER THE
REALITY IS THAT. THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE WORKING
WITH THESE CONTRACTORS ARE
UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
CONTRACTORS IN TERMS OF WHEN
THEIR SHIFT BEGINS AND WHERE
THEY GO EVERY DAY FOR THEIR
SHARE SO THE REALITY IS IT'S
NOT- OPTIONAL- THAT THEY STEP
ON THE BUS TO GO TO THE WORK
SITE. AND SO THEIR WORK DAY
STARTS WHEN THEIR EMPLOYER
TELLS THEM THE STARS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T STEP ON THE BUS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WORK. ALL
RIGHT. I THINK WE'RE GONNA HEAR
IS THAT I'M SORRY GO AHEAD AND
I DON'T THEY DON'T FINISH HERE-
I THINK I UNDERSTAND- WHAT THIS
ISSUE IS- WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
A PANDEMIC. WHERE AGRICULTURE
AS A WHOLE HAS SUFFERED
GREATLY- IN A IN WE SHOULD ALL
BE TERRIBLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THOSE THAT CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
WORK FORCE ESPECIALLY THROUGH
THE H. TWO A. VISA PROGRAMS
THAT WERE DESPERATELY RELIANT
UPON. WE'RE ALSO IN A SITUATION
WHERE WE ARE IN A DEVASTATING
DROUGHT IN THAT DROUGHT. HAS IS
PROBABLY GOING TO CONTINUE ON
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
SO WHEN YOU ADD NOT ONLY THE
ENORMOUS REGULATORY
OBLIGATIONS. THE DAD- ARE
IMPOSED UPON THE AGRICULTURE
SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE BAR
NONE THE GOLD STANDARD OF THE
WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO
AGRICULTURE. ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AS WELL AS LABOR
PROTECTION. THAT YOU THEN MOVE
INTO. OUR WHAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH IN THE PANDEMIC NOW
MOVING TO DROUGHT I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH YOU CAN MORE YOU CAN
IMPOSE UPON- IN INDUSTRY. AND
NOT EXPECTED TO BREAK- WITH
THAT I THINK. ALL ALL CONCLUDE
MY COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALREADY
THANK YOU SORT OF BORED JUST
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I
SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES RAISE
SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCHER-
AND THE REALITY IS THAT- YOU
KNOW IN IN RESPONSE OF THE
COMMISSAR POSITION- THAT. FIRST
OF ALL THE DETAILS THE ISSUE WE
WILL WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR IN
TERMS OF GIVING A MORE
DISCUSSION LABOR COMMISSIONER
AND THOSE WITH ISSUES HAVE BEEN
RESOLVED- AND- HIS DAUGHTERS.
THE REALITY IS FEDERAL LAW DOES
NOT MANDATE THESE RICE WE
NOTICED A FORMER OCCURS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD BE DOING.
AND ULTIMATELY THIS IS WELL
ESTABLISHED EMPLOYMENT LAW WHEN
IT COMES TO BEING UNDER CONTROL
THE EMPLOYER. HAS THE OPTION IS
OPPOSITE SHE INDICATED REFER TO
TECH WORKERS- FROM THE CAPITAL
SILICON VALLEY. THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN SOMEONE'S LIVING
IN SAN FRANCISCO MAKING A
CHOICE OF DRIVING THEIR TESLA
TAKING CALTRAIN OR STEPPING
INTO A BUS THAT HAS WIFI AND
COFFEE AND WENT ON TO WORK IN
SILICON VALLEY- AND A FARMER
OCCUR AS BEING TOLD WHERE TO
LIVE- EIGHT AND IS BEING KEPT
UNDER ALMOST COMPLETE CONTROL
THE EMPLOYER. AND SO WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A VERY
UNIQUE THIS IS A UNIQUE
SITUATION THAT IS EXPERIENCED
BY MANY THOUSANDS AND I'LL END
BY SAYING. THAT THE CALL THE
CRISIS HIT FARM WORKERS- AS BAD
AS ANYONE IN OURNATION AND OUR
STATE THEY'RE THE ONES DYING
THEY'RE THE ONES ALLOWING US TO
BE ABLE TO STAY AT HOME AND BE
WITH OUR FAMILIES AND BE SAFE
AND SECURE- AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS STAFF.
WERE PUTTING A LOT OF TIME INTO
THIS BILL A VALUE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT AND I'M. GRATEFUL
AND WITHOUT A RECIPIENT'S RIVAL.
ALL RIGHTY- BETTER CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
YES THIS IS EIGHT. EIGHT FIVE.
BUYS KALRA WITH A MOTION BY
SENATOR DO TO US SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BEAT RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BERG. HI AM
BERG I BARGES. GORGEOUS NO
CARRY IT ALL. DID ASAL THE REST
SO I A. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I.
PITTSBURGH HERTZBERG HI JONES
LAYERED LAYERED I SKINNER STERN
EASTERN I WAKE HOUSE SKI Y.
CASKEY I'D YOU HAVE SEVENTY ONE
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. ALREADY
GOES ON CALL- NEXT IS PHYLUM
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AB THREE
THREE NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVY SEVERAL MEMBERS LEAVE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD EVENING
SHARON SENATORS- TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB THREE THREE NINE
A BILL TO EXPAND AND PRESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE WITH
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. OUT OF
THE SEWER LINE DEPENDS ON MAKE
WE LEARNED THAT WE COULD ENGAGE
REMOTELY DIGITALLY AND
TELEPHONICALLY AND WE'RE
LOOKING TO RESERVE THAT FOR
LARGER SECTIONS THIS BILL ALSO
HAS- SOME RESIDENTS BECAUSE WE
LEARNED THAT IN NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE THE ORIGINAL BROWN ACT
WAS ALSO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THREE NINE GREAT COINCIDENCE.
THE NOW ALMOST SEVENTY YEARS
LATER WE'RE WORKING TO
MODERNIZE THE WAY GOVERNMENT
OPERATES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR CONSTITUENTS THIS BILL
REQUIRES CITY COUNCILS AND
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
MEETINGS IN JURISDICTIONS WITH
A POPULATION OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC TO RESPECT EITHER
THROUGH TELEPHONE OR INTERNET
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS POSSIBLE
AS LOW GOVERNMENTS HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED A
REMOTE PARTICIPATION OPTIONS
RUN PANDEMIC. TO ADDRESS COST
CONCERNS ARE TAKEN MANY
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS FOR FAR TOO LONG
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE BEEN
PRECLUDED FROM PURCHASING
GOVERNMENT DUE TO REQUIREMENTS
ATTEND IN PERSON THERE ARE MANY
REASONS WHY SOMEONE WOULD BE
UNABLE TO ATTEND SAY A TUESDAY
HEARING AT NINE PM. AND SAT
THERE FOR SEVERAL HOURS IN
ORDER TO MAKE A COMMENT SO
THEIR VOICES HEARD BUT AS LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE ALREADY HAD TO
IMPLEMENT WAYS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE OUR MULTI
WE WANT TO SEE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES CONTINUED AFTER
THE BAND THAT MAKE IN ORDER FOR
US TO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR THE VOICES OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND REDUCE
EXISTING BARRIERS IN PLACE THAT
STOP THE PURPOSE MAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON A. B. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THREE NINE AND WITH THAT
I HAVE HOPEFULLY
WHO ARE STILL ON THE LINE IT'S
DAVID SNYDER FROM THE EXECUTIVE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FIRST
MEDICAL MISSION AND BONNIE
LIEBERMAN FROM THE SANTA CLARA
UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD ALREADY.
THANK YOU MR LIEBERMAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. I AM ALL RIGHT.
CLOSE YOUR EYES THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS BONNIE LIEBERMAN I AM A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE JANITOR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'M SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT AND. EIGHTY THREE
THREE NINETY DAY- THE LOCAL.
ELECTED IN A DRASTIC INCREASE
IN PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND
ENGAGEMENT IN OUR MEETING THEM.
IT'S STILL A TIMELY AND VERY
MUCH NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. AFTER SCHOOL- NUMBER I
OFTEN WORK WITH PARENTS WHO ARE
NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
MEETING BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
TRAVEL WITH MY CHILD CARE
OPTIONS FOR MEETINGS THAT MAY
GO ON FOR SEVERAL HOURS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE BEEN REQUIRED
TO FIND ALTERNATIVE METHODS TO
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC. WHICH HAS
INCLUDED NEW MEETING. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC REGULAR IN PERSON
BOARD MEETINGS WITH A TRACKING
MAYBE A DOZEN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. DURING THE PENDENNIS
CAN BASE PANDEMIC THANKS TO THE
LIVE STREAM AND RELATED PUBLIC
ACCESS BE A WEAPON ARE AND
TELEPHONE. I'VE SEEN IT
EXPONENTIAL INCREASE IN
PARTICIPATION BECAUSE WE ALLOW
REMOTE PARTICIPATION THROUGH
OPTIONS LIKE BEER WHICH HAS
BEEN CRITICAL AND ENGAGING
PARENTS. AND DISCUSSING REMOTE
EDUCATION AND THE SAME PRE
OPENING UP OUR SCHOOL. I'VE
ALSO HEARD FEEDBACK ABOUT HOW
THE PUBLIC HAS SEEN A LOT OF
DOORS OPEN FOR THEM TO ENGAGE
YOU PHYSICALLY AND MAKE THEIR
VOICES HEARD THANK YOU BYE I
REALLY HOPE YOU CONTINUE
OFFERING VIRTUAL PARTICIPATION
IN BOARD MEETINGS BECAUSE I
CAN'T ATTEND IN PERSON. AND
BEING ABLE TO ATTEND MEETINGS
VIRTUALLY HAS HELPED ME BE
BETTER INFORMED ABOUT THE
GOINGS ON IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I KNOW A LOT OF LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST OF IMPLEMENTATION. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY FOUND WAYS TO
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY. AND THE
INCREASED AVENUES OF
PARTICIPATION ARE WELL WORTH
THAT. I'M DELIGHTED OFFICIALS
WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO INCREASE OUR OUTREACH
AND ENGAGEMENT WITH MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. AND THIS BILL IS A
GREAT STEP IN THAT DIRECTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AND THE
AUTHORS MISSION FOR INCREASING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISLI ROMAN MISTER SNYDER.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
DAVID SNYDER AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT COALITION WE ADVOCATE
FOR FREE SPEECH OPENING IT OPEN
AND ACCOUNTABLE GOVERNMENT AND
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION CIVIC
AFFAIRS WE HELP JOURNALISTS
ACTIVISTS ACADEMICS AND MANY
OTHERS ACCESS THE GOVERNMENT
AND WE DO SO BY PROVIDING
EDUCATION. ONE ON ONE LEGAL
COUNSELING LITIGATION AND MORE
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE THREE NINE WE
BELIEVE IN THE HEALTH OF ANY
DEMOCRACY DEPENDS ON THE
ABILITY OF THE PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY TO
OBSERVE IN INTERACT EACH
ELECTED AND APPOINTED OFFICIALS
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD. AT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL THIS
MEANS BEING ABLE TO SEE YOU IN
HERE IMPORTANTLY TO SPEAK AT
PUBLIC MEETINGS IN REAL TIME
BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC MEETINGS USED TO MEAN
HAVING TO RANGE CHILDCARE TAKE
TIME OFF WORK GETTING A RIDEOR
PAYING FOR TRANSIT TRAVELING
LONG DISTANCES WITHIN RURAL
COMMUNITIES OR WORSE BEING ABLE
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE DUE TO
HEALTH CONCERNS OR DISABILITY.
THAT'S A BURDEN SO HIGH THAT IT
MADE MEANINGFUL PARTICIPATION
OUT OF REACH FOR FAR TOO MANY
ANALYSTS GOVERNMENT'S FREE TO
MAKE. DECISIONS WITHOUT INPUT
FROM THE COMMUNITY. THERE'S ONE
SO LINING FROM PANDEMIC IT IS
AN AXIS TO GOVERNMENT DECISION
MAKING BECAME AVAILABLE TO A
BROADER RANGE OF PEOPLE THAT
WAS BEFORE. EIGHTY THREE THREE
NINE WOULD ENSURE THESE GAMES
ARE NOT LOST FOR CITY COUNCIL
AND COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISOR
MEETINGS. IN JURISDICTIONS WITH
POPULATIONS OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO PROVIDE
CONSTITUENTS OF EITHER CALL IN
OR INTERFACE INTERNET BASED
OPTION FOR PARTICIPATION. FOR
THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
AGENCIES DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY
COULD PROVIDE THIS KIND OF
ACCESS LOCAL DEMOCRACY IN
CALIFORNIA DEPENDS ON
TRANSPARENCY FOR ITSELF. IT'S
WHY ABILITY PARTICULARLY TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE
AND SO THE FIRST AMENDMENT
COALITION URGES THE COMMITTEE
TO ENSURE THIS LEVEL OF ACCESS
IS MAINTAINED AS PROVIDED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
OTHER WINNERS IN SUPPORT SAYING
NONE OF THE GALLERY SAYING NOT
A ROOM ONE TWELVE THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
THREE NINE- MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE PUT THEM UP. PUT THEM ON.
EIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICOLE WARD OPEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FOUR ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKER CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE SIX ZERO EIGHT YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FAMILY MEMBER AT LEAST
THIS IS TONY TOOK KERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORTED AB THREE THREE NINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SIX SEVEN SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER WHEN
WE SAW ON THE FASHION HOUSE
READ BACK WITH. FOR INSTANCE.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE MY
NUMBER SIX EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THE PRINTER
MEMBERS AREN'T THEY WOULD
CALIFORNIA BE HERE IN
STRASBOURG THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEETING IN
HERE NUMBERS BACK THEY'LL THINK
EVERY CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CAN WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FOUR SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS CAITLYN DEAN WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROPOSED
POINT EIGHTY THREE THREE NINE
READINGA LIST OF CONSOLIDATED
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO GIVING THEIR-
OUR SENIOR IN DISABILITY ACTION
NEXTGEN POLICY HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT ORANGE COUNTY
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA WHERE
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG TOGETHER WE WILL
INDIVISIBLE GATOS.
CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED FOR
PROPHETIC ENGAGEMENT PUBLIC
ADVOCATE THE SPACE FOR EVERYONE
IN CENTER FOR RACE POVERTY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CAN WE APPLY NUMBER
SIX FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR TURN MEMBERS MADISON DAHLIA
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
YEAH ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF E. B. THREE THREE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THANK YOU WE HAVE- BE JUST A
MOMENT WE HAVE ONE PERSON IN
THE QUEUE. I'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THEIR LINE UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD IT'S LINE SIX EIGHT THREE
WE HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS MAIN BEEN PLAYED WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE AND WE SUPPORT
A B. THREE THREE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE MODERATOR ANYONE
ELSE. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE AT THIS TIME IN CUBA
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION I SEE NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE BATTERY IF YOU WOULD Q.
THOSE UP WITH WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE THREE
NINE. AND FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF A. B. THREE THREE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE HAVE MY NUMBER FIVE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
CHECKED MEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- IF I COULD TAKE JUST
A MOMENT TO OUTLINE OUR
CONCERNS. EVEN GIVEN THE LATE
HOUR ALL RIGHT. I PROMISE TO BE
BRIEF- APPRECIATE THE WORK WITH
THE MEMBER WITH THE AUTHOR OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS ON
THIS BILL- BUT STILL HAVE SOME
CONCERNS- PUT IT ON BEHALF OF
THE AGENCIES THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED. WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO- YOU CAN
GAUGE THE PUBLIC MORE
EFFECTIVELY GIVEN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT INCLUDE SOME SOME
OF THE RESTRICTIONS OF THE
BROWN ACT I WOULD NOTE THAT NOT
ALL OF THOSE. LISTINGS ARE IN
THE FIELD ONLY THE REQUIREMENT-
THAT MEETINGS START REMOTE
PARTICIPATION BE MADE OPENTO
THE PUBLIC SO IMAGINE. IF YOU
WILL- HEARING THAT GOES LATE
INTO THE NIGHT BUT WHERE YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACTIVELY MANAGE THE
PARTICIPANTS AND ARE REQUIRED
TO INSTEAD. OF EVERYBODY WHO
WISHES TO CALL AND- A COUPLE OF
MINUTES OF TIME WORRIED THAT
WITHOUT THAT KIND OF-
FLEXIBILITY WELL WHICH WE- DO
ENJOY UNDER THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MEETINGS SUBJECT TO THESE
REQUIREMENTS WILL BECOME
UNMANAGEABLE AS I THINK. YOU
CAN IDENTIFY WITH SO. GIVEN
THOSE CONCERNS I DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR BUT-
WOULD LIKE TO- STILL OPPOSED TO
POLITICIZING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR.
ALREADY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION PHONE LINES. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIVE
FOURTEEN WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND OUT
WHY MORE CHILDREN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH
MEMBERS JOHN PENA A CALIFORNIA
CITY RESPECTS THAN OPPOSITION
OUT OF THE LIKE THE ECHO OF THE
COMPANIES ACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I THINK HE'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT STEP PERSON
THANK YOU. BUT A MODERATE TO
TELL ME HOW MANY ARE STILL IN
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
FOUR IN Q. FRATERNIZATION THANK
YOU. I WE DO HAVE ONE NUMBER
SIX THIRTY ONE A LINE SIX
THIRTY ONE WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. ONE SIX THREE ONE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THIS IS JEAN HURST
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TODAY- WANT TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT HE THOUGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR SEVEN
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
COMMENT. ONE FOUR SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU LANE FOR SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. ALKALINE FOR SEVENTY
FOUR WE'LL GO AHEAD AND RELEASE
THE LINE. WE DO HAVE LINES SIX
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. NINE SIX
EIGHT FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIX EIGHT SIX THE
LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE NEXT LINE IN THE QUEUE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT'LL BE JUST
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE LINE NUMBER. FOUR SEVEN
ZERO ONE FOUR SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE COMMITTEE SAFETY
HEATON WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH FEEDBACK AND IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ON THE PHONE
PLEASE ALL WRITING YOU THANK
YOU- LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS SITTING
YES- JONES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR A SWIMMINGLY. I'M I'M
INTRIGUED BY A COUPLE OF
ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THAT I AGREE WITH- I DO
BELIEVE THAT- HAVING THIS
ABILITY TO ACCESS OUR MEETINGS
HAS. INCREASED DEMOCRACY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SURE SO I HAVE
ONE QUESTION AND ONE CONCERN
THAT MAYBE YOU COULD DRESS- WHY
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND-
NUMBER- WHY NOT JUST MAKE IT
ACROSS THE BOARD. AND THEN
NUMBER TWO I NOTICED THAT YOU
TOOK. AMENDMENTS AT SOME POINT
IN TIME THAT REMOVED- THE
STATE. LEGISLATURE AND THE
STATE AGENCIES FROM THE SAME
REQUIREMENT- WHY EXEMPT WHAT
RIGHT WHY REQUIRE THIS ON
LOCALITIES BUT NOT THE STATE
PLAN I THINK THE ARGUMENT CAN
BE MADE. SACRAMENTO AND
WHEREVER THE STATE AGENCIES
MEET IS ACTUALLY HARDER TO GET
TO. THEN THE LOCALITIES THAT
WERE REQUIRING- THESE EFFORTS
ON. THANK YOU SIR JOHN'S I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY GREAT
QUESTION WHEN I BEGAN THE BILL
IT DID APPLY TO ALMOST EVERY
AGENCY AND BODY INCLUDING US IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE- BUT-
GOING TO IT IS A PROCESS I
CERTAINLY HAD TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS THAT I DID NOT
ENVISION TAKING. WHEN WE
ARRIVED AT THIS THRESHOLD FOR
LARGE COUNTIES IN LARGE CITIES-
NOT IDEAL BUT I DO AGREE WITH
YOU I THINK IT SHOULD BE
APPLICABLE IN FACT ACTUALLY
ADMINISTRATION HAS A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGEOUT THERE FOR
STATE AGENCIES RIGHT NOW. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW OUR
HOUSES WILL CONCUR WITH THAT
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
SOMETHING I'M INTERESTED IN AND
BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS A SUNSET
IN TWENTY EIGHT DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIS IS AN
ISSUE WE'RE GONNA KEEP WORKING
ON. SHOULD THE GOVERNOR SIGNED-IT BUT I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN AS
EXPENSIVE AS POSSIBLE. YOU'RE
IN YOUR INITIAL. A PROPOSAL
WHEN YOU STARTED THE BILL WHAT
IT DIDN'T HAVE THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT. OF
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE. I
GOT TO READ DOES NOT. TURN
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IT DIDN'T
HAVE THAT LIMIT. OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR JOHNSON A COUPLE
EURO. MISTER CHAIR- I THINK
MIKE MY QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH- WHAT IS THE CONSEQUENCE
OF A FAILURE OF THE SYSTEM IS
IT THAT. THE THE BOARD OR THE
COUNCIL HAS TO IMMEDIATELY
CEASE THE MEETING AND- AND
RESCHEDULE IT. I HEARD OF THAT
CONCERN VIA THE OPPOSITION BUT
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT CONCERN
I MEAN IT'S THE SAME CASE IF
YOU'RE HAVING A PUBLIC MEETING
IN THE ALL THE POWER WENT OFF.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
CONSTITUTES A COMPLETE SHUTDOWN
OF THE MEETING I DON'T KNOW IF
MY WITNESS FROM THE FIRST OF A
COLLISION WITH THE COMMENT ON
THAT BUT I DON'T. READ A SUCH.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT. WELL
I AM CERTAINLY WILLING TO
LISTEN TO WHAT YOUR- EX. EXPERT
HAS TO SAY BUT- THE BROWN ACT
REQUIRES. ACCESS AND IF YOU IF
FOR SOME REASON YOU HAVE A
FAILURE OF THE SYSTEM YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT DISRUPTS- A GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
CALL IN AND TOTALLY DISRUPT THE
MEETING I MEAN I WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED IN OUR CITY IS WHEN
PEOPLE SHOWED UP AND THEY
DISRUPTED THE MEETING. WE
RECESS UNTIL WE CAN GET CONTROL
OF THE MEETING BACK AGAIN AND
IF WE COULDN'T CONTINUE BECAUSE
THERE WAS TOO MUCH OF A
DISRUPTION WE HAD TO. CANCEL
THE REST OF THE MEETING AND
LEAVE WE DIDN'T HAVE TO DO THAT
THANKFULLY BUT I AM. I LIKE TO
BUILD. THE CONCERN I HAVE IS
THAT THERE ARE. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT A SYSTEM
CAN FAIL. AND IF IT MEANS THAT
THE MEETING HAS TO BE CANCELED
THEN YOU END UP WITH TIMELINE
CONSTRAINTS THAT REQUIRE YOU TO
DO THINGS BY A CERTAIN DATE
LIKE PASS A BUDGET BY A CERTAIN
DATE- POOR FINISH- IF YOU'RE
DOING BOND WORK THERE'S USUALLY
DEADLINES THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH THAT. THEY'RE JUST A LOT
OF TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT COULD
ARISE AND FOR US TO TELL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND FRANKLY I DON'T
HAVE VERY MANY I HAVE NO CITIES.
BUT A COUPLE OF COUNTIES IF
THIS WOULD APPLY TO- THAT. SO
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT IT IT
DOESN'T APPLY IN MY AREA BUT I
AM CONCERNED WITH THAT WITH THE
CONSTRAINTS. THAT DISAPPEARS TO
PUT. ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PARTICIPATION AND IT'S FOR THE
NEXT TWO AND A HALF YEARS. AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE THROUGH
WITH COVERT- I JUST WORRY ABOUT
THAT TIMELINE AND I WORRY
ABOUT. BURDENING IS THAT IT AND
NOT HAVING A AN ESCAPE HATCH.
OR IF YOUR LINE GOES AND I AND
I AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. THIS
ACCESS IS ILLUSORY. BECAUSE I
HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO MOVE
GO OVER TO A PARK. OR A LIBRARY
IN ORDER TO GET INTERNET
ACCESS. AND SO IT'S IT MAY WORK
IN- BRILL URBANIZED CENTERS BUT
IT IT DOESN'T WORK QUITE AS
WELL IN RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE
INTERNET ACCESS IS. IS NOT
AVAILABLE SO I AM CONCERNED
WITH THE- END RESULT AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I PROBABLY
WON'T END UP SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. UNLESS I GET AN
ASSURANCE THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ESCAPE HATCH FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT- BUT FOR SOME
REASON LOSE ACCESS TO THEIR
INTERNET THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
WITH THEIR MEETING AND- AND
TELL PEOPLE YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO COME DOWN TO THE
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE. THE SENATE CAREER
I THINK YOU BRING UP THREE GOOD
POINTS- THE FIRST I'LL JUST SAY
ABOUT THE DISRUPTION IS YOU
KNOW I THINK BECAUSE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED HERE IT'S MUCH
EASIER TO CONTROL MAYBE A
HUNDRED ROWDY GUESTS-
VIRTUALLY. THAT A HUNDRED ROWDY
GUESTS IN YOUR CHAMBER SURFACE
GIVEN DOWN TO THE OPTION OF.
ONE OR THE OTHER I THINK WE
BUSINESS'S SAKE CHOOSE TO HAVE
A VIRTUAL OPTION. AND IT'S
AGAIN REMEMBER IS HAVING
ADDITIONAL THE OPTION OF
TELEPHONIC. OR VIRTUAL SO
PEOPLE IN RURAL COUNTIES WHICH
OF COURSE WE HAVE A REAL
DIGITAL VIBE WHICH IS A REAL
PROBLEM- STILL PEOPLE HAVE THE
OPTION TO CALL IN OR- ZOOM IN
OR WHATEVER ONLINE PLATFORM
JURISDICTION CHOOSES TO DO SO.
SO I'M HOPING THAT RATHER THAN
HAVING TO DRIVE TO YOUR SKIN
YOU SEE. IN A RURAL DISTRICT
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO SAY DRIVE
TO PARK OR GET ON THE PHONE AND
CALL IN A PRESCRIPTION. FOR
YOUR FIVE MINUTES OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY PROBABLY MORE. MORE
EFFICIENT AND THEN I WOULD SAY
THE THIRD THING TO THAT POINT
IS. TO MY KNOWLEDGE DURING THE
YEAR PLUS THEM ENDEMIC I DON'T
KNOW OF ANY JURISDICTION WHICH-
AND KEEP IN MIND. YOU NEVER IT
HAS UNIVERSAL EXISTED BEYOND OR
SIX JUST TO UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND. I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
FAILURES AND OUTAGES THAT EVER
EXISTED. SO I DON'T KNOW THAT
IN THE CASE OF THIS JUST BEING
EDITION WITH THAT ALSO EXISTS
SO I. I GENERALLY DON'T KNOW IF
THAT HAS ALSO BEEN A PROBLEM
BUT I'VE NOT HEARD OF THIS IS
AN ISSUE. AND I WOULD AM
ASSUMING THAT YOU KNOW WITH A
MODERN TECHNOLOGY MODERN. POWER
GRIDTHAT I THINK WE WOULD BE
PRETTY DURABLE WITH OUR-
TELEPHONIC AND DIGITAL SYSTEM
SO I'M I'M SAYING THAT. I JUST
DON'T THINK IT NECESSARILY IN
REALITY IT'S GOING TO BE AS
DESTRUCTIVE AS IT IS- YEAH. BUT
THIS WOULD BE A GREAT ADDITION
FOR RURAL AND URBAN COUNTIES
LIKE TO HAVE MORE MORE. OPTIONS
ULTIMATELY. YOU CAN. PLEASE
CHAIRMAN I MIGHT. ALL RIGHT MY
BIGGEST ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH
WHETHER YOU PUT THIS IN THE
BROWN ACT. SUCH THAT IT IS
REQUIRED TO BE PROVIDED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND AS A
CONDITION OF THE BROWN ACT THAT
IF. THERE'S ANY PROBLEM WITH
THE SERVICE. THAT THEY HAVE TO
TERMINATE THE MEETING THAT'S MY
ISSUE. ON WHETHER YOU AGREE
WITH WHETHER IT'S- A- PHONE
LINES AND- INTERNET IS. IS
FAULTY IN RURAL CALIFORNIA. I
MEAN I DID COME OUT AND I'LL
SHOW YOU HOW IT'S FAULTY BUT-
BUT THE REAL ISSUE HAS TO DO
WITH. THE BROWN ACT
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRE CERTAIN
THINGS AND IF THIS IS IN THE
BROWN ACT AND MY READING OF IT.
IS SUCH THAT YOU'D HAVE TO STOP.
YOUR MEETING IF YOU HAVE A
FAILURE OF THE SYSTEM AND IF
I'M WRONG THAT'S THE QUESTION
IS AM I WRONG. IF IT NOBODY CAN
TELL ME THEN I'M NOT GING TO
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO PUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN THAT
POSITION SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
ONE ISSUE THAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. SORRY THANK YOU- SEVERAL
MEMBERS LEADING CARRIERS FONT.
OR IN YOUR CLOTHES AND CLOTHES.
ARE ALWAYS ON MY CLOTHES RIGHT.
IN YOUR CLOSER NOW- IN MY
CLOTHES ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT A
SINISTER. THANK YOU MR- THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I YOU KNOW I THINK
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC WE'VE
ACTUALLY FOUND INCREASED
PARTICIPATION IN SOMEONE IN
GOVERNMENT. AND ESPECIALLY FOR
RURAL- CONSTITUENTS FOR FOLKS
FROM SAY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO CAN'T GET UP TO SACRAMENTO.
MMHM EITHER BECAUSE OF A
PANDEMIC OR FRANKLY BECAUSE OF
MANY FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
THIS PLACE IS INHERENTLY
LIMITING TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE THE MEANS EITHER TO HIRE A
LOBBYIST OR TAKE A SOUTHWEST
FLIGHT UP TO SACRAMENTO- I'M
DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF YOUR
LEGISLATION- THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FIX OFF IT TO
EXEMPT ITSELF. FROM THIS BILL
AND I THINK I HOPE IT'S NOT A
FATAL FLAW ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
I WANT TO SEE THIS BECOME LAW
BUT- I DON'T THINK THAT
REFLECTS VERY WELL ON ON THIS
BODY- AND I'M I'M I'M PLEASED
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
THIS HEARING RIGHT NOW- IN
ALLOWING REMOTE PARTICIPATION-
NOT FROM MEMBERS BUT CERTAINLY
FROM THE PUBLIC. I THINK IT'S
ENABLED THE GREATER EXPANSION
OF DEMOCRACY AND I HOPE THAT
CONTINUES BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S AT
THE DISCRETION OF OUR
LEADERSHIP I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
THE IN LAW SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
HAVING ISSUES RETAINING THE
STATE LEGISLATURE'S. ROLE IN
THIS- AND SO YOU'RE LIMITED NOT
JUST A LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT TO
LARGER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- SO
ANOTHER CONCERN I HAVE IS THAT.
YOU KNOW THE SMALLER
GOVERNMENTS THE SMALLER CITIES
THE SMALLER COUNTIES THOSE THE
PLACES THAT IT'S EVEN HARDER TO
PARTICIPATE SOMETIMES THOSE
ALSO DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT
THAT TWENTY FIFTY THOUSAND
PERSON LIMITATION WAS ADDED
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY
GONNA HURT- THOSE WITHOUT
ACCESS- I HOPE GOING FORWARD
YOU'LL FIND SOME OPPORTUNITY OR
MAYBE THIS BODY WILL FIND
OPPORTUNITY TO STRENGTHEN THIS
MEASURE. I THINK SENATOR JONES
BROUGHT UP VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS AND I THINK THERE'S IT'S
ACTUALLY A REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR SOME BI
PARTISAN- AGREEMENT- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO SEE. THE ELEMENTS OF
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER. THAT ALLOW
FOR MEMBER PARTICIPATION- FROM
IN IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES- TO
PERMIT IT TO PERSIST. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW I CREATE
WE DON'T LOSE ANYTHING WHEN I
WAS. QUARANTINING AT HOME
DURING THIS PANDEMIC IN
PARTICIPATING THESE PROCEEDINGS
FROM ZOOM- I HAD EVERY BIT AS
MUCH STANDING AS ANY OTHER
MEMBER. AND I THINK THAT THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES CAN BE SOLVED
HERE SO I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER BOTH SUBJECTING THE
MEMBERS THEMSELVES OF THESE
BODIES NOT JUST THE PUBLIC TO
THIS TO THIS BILL. I HOPE
YOU'LL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND WHATEVER
WHOEVER IS EXEMPTED US HOPE
THEY RECONSIDER THAT PROVISION.
AND I HAVE TO SAY LASTLY VERY
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THE URBAN
COUNTIES TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION I ASSUME THAT MEANS
INCLUDE MY OWN COUNTY IN LA-
WE'VE WE'VE THRIVED WITH
MAXIMUM PARTICIPATION IN LOS
ANGELES. AND WE'RE
TECHNOLOGICALLY CAPABLE PLACE-
THAT YOU CAN CALL ON THE PHONE
OR YOU CAN ZOOM IN THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF OPTIONSBUT- THAT
RESISTANCE TO ME IS- ALLIES ARE
ARE ARE UNDERLYING- ETHOS IS AS
BOTH THE COUNTY AND- AND AS A
STATE SO. I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE MEASURE TODAY. RECEIVE YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND I KNOW YOU'RE
SORT OF YOU'RE UP AGAINST
FORCES BIGGER THAN YOURSELF BUT
I HOPE THAT- WE ALL KIND OF
RECONSIDER. OUR TREPIDATION
HERE AND- REALIZE THAT- AS I
SEE MYSELF STREAMING LIVE ON A
SCREEN BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT
SCARY ABOUT STREAMING PUBLIC
SEARCH PUBLIC PROCEEDINGS LIKE
THIS AND- THIS IS FRANKLY THE
FUTURE. SO. ALTHOUGH I'VE MOVED
THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. ALL RIGHTY- OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS YES THERE
WERE KELSEY. LISTEN TO MY
COLLEAGUES WERE STUCK WITH THE
FACT THAT THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PUT A 210050% CAP ON
IT BECAUSE OF I GUESS POTENTIAL
FINANCIAL BURDEN SOME OF THIS
MANDATE OULD HAVE A SMALLER
COMMUNITIES BUT WE HAVE A TWO
YEAR SON SAID IN THAT ALLOWS US
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ASSESS THIS
POPULATION FLOOR. AND ALSO THE
BILLS OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS AND
I GUESS WE'LL HAVE INFORMATION
HOW PEOPLE. WILL DO IT WILL
PARTICIPATE HOW. THIS IS THE
AUTHOR OF ANY IDEA OF HOW WE
WILL ASSESS THE POPULATION
FLOOR IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY HERE
TO REMOTE HEARINGS GOING ON IN
THESE SALLER COMMUNITIES LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY. HAVE
THERE WERE SOMETHING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY. WHEN THEY PUT THE
AMENDMENT ON YOU THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT SENATOR AND I
VALUE I APPRECIATE THE POINT-
YES YOU KNOW NOTHING IN THIS
BILL OR EVEN EXISTING LAW NOW
PRECLUDES JURISDICTIONS OF ANY
SIZE OR TYPE FROM HAVING THE
REMOTE OPTION I KNOW
ANECDOTALLY EVEN FROM OUR
DISTRICT THERE WILL BE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE SMALL CITY
THAT CONTINUE TO INTEGRATE.
ONLINE OR VIRTUAL POSITIONS
SOME FORM SO YES THE ACCESSING
OF THE DATA WILL PROBABLY NOT
BE A PERFECT COMPARISON BUT THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
ACTUALLY DID A REPORT I THINK
LAST WEEK. AND THEY ALSO DID
TALK ABOUT HOW THE ECSTASY OF
VIRTUAL MEETINGS ALSO EXPANDED
ACCESS SO I THINK THERE WILL BE
MORE DATA POINTS I THINK SO
LONG AS THEY WERE STILL LIVING
IN THIS CURRENT SAID EMERGENCE
WE SEE IF WE STILL AT LEAST
HAVE THAT DATA POINT WHERE.
IT'S MORE UNIVERSAL VIRTUAL
VIRTUAL POSITION. AND THEN
THERE'S THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
AN EMERGENCY MORE HAVE A COVERT
HEALTH SITUATION AND THEN WHEN
WE DON'T WE JUST GO ON AND WE
DO THIS. AND I WHEN I WAS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I HAD SOME
ISSUES WITH THE BROWN ACT
PARTICULARLY WHEN. NOW I THINK
WE'RE MORE SOPHISTICATED WHEN
WE POST IF A MEMBER IS GOING TO
PARTICIPATE TELECOMMUNICATION
OR TELEPHONE NOT TELEPHONICALLY
REMOTELY. WE NOTICE IT THE
PERSON IN THEIR HOTEL ROOM HAS
TO PUT A SIGN UP THAT SAYS I'M
PARTICIPATING THIS LITTLE CITY
COUNCIL MEETING AND THEN THE
PUBLIC IS ABLE TO GO IN. TO
YOUR ROOM SINCE IT'S NOW AN
OFFICIAL AREA AND I'M WONDERING
IF WE MAKE A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN I MEAN. IF WE HAVE A
HEALTH. PROBLEM OR HEALTH- I.
WHY IN THE WORLD SOMEBODY COULD
COME INTO MY HOUSE SO I GUESS
IF I WAS PARTICIPATING I JUST
WOULD ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT THAT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T CLEAR TO ME
IF THAT LITTLE WRINKLE
CONTINUES AND IT WAS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS AS WE GO INTO THE
BROWN ACT HE THINKING AS WE'RE
MORE SOPHISTICATED NOW THAT
SEEMS STRANGE THAT WE WOULD
STILL DO THAT IT'S NOT NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ANYMORE SO I'LL
JUST. LEAVE THAT AS A
pRHETORICAL QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR AND I'LL JUST SAY YOU
KNOW AND TO YOUR POINT SENATOR
AND SENATOR STARNES POINT I
THINK THERE IS MUCH TO BE
MODERNIZING THE BROWN ACT
EXECUTIVE ORDER BY THE GOVERNOR
WAS MODERNIZATIONS DEPEND OF
COURSE FOR THE PUBLIC AND THE
OFFICIAL SIDE AND I INTEND TO
KEEP WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- CONSTITUENCIES TO
KEEP MODERNIZING THAT HOPEFULLY
WE WILL SEE SOME SORT OF CHANGE
ON THAT FRONT. THE SORRY.
FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SAYING NONE OF THEIR MOTION. OH
I'M SORRY CENTER MORICHES.
THANK YOU CHAIR. THIS IS A
GREAT CONVERSATION I'VE LEARNED
A LOT FROM MY COLLEAGUES- IN
THE COURSE OF- I WAS REVIEWING
THIS MATTER HAVING SERVED IN. A
CITY COUNCIL AS WELL AS A-
SUPERVISOR OREO CAPACITY- THE
BROWN ACT IS A VERY REAL- SET
OF OBLIGATIONS. AND NOT ONLY IS
A VIOLATION. READ HAVOC IN
CONSEQUENCE OF FOR THE BODY IT
CAN ALSO UNDO ALL OF THE POLICY
OR LEGISLATION OR DECISION
MAKING THAT WAS DONE BY THAT
BOARD THE CONSEQUENCES ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN EXPECTATION
OBLIGATIONS ARE VERY REAL- I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE THAT I
THINK. WE SHOULD HAVE THIS
ATTACHED TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT IRRESPECTIVE OF THE SIZE
OF THE CITY. NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TECHNOLOGICAL. ISSUES
TECH ISSUES THAT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE IN A POSITION IF IT
CANNOT BE ACCOMMODATED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OR AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL THE STEP IN AND PROVIDE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
POSSIBLY EVEN THE EQUIPMENT
SPECIALLY IN THESE RURAL.
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
RELATIVELY SMALL BUDGETS SO I
GUESS AS I'VE HEARD MY COMMENT
READ THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ESPECIALLY GREW WITH
THE IDEA THAT INDIVIDUALS NOT
JUST FROM THE PUBLIC BUT THOSE
WHO SERVE ON A BOARD OR
COMMISSION FOR A MUNICIPALITY
OR COUNTY BE IN A POSITION TO
PARTICIPATE AS WELL. BUT UNLESS
YOU FIGURE OUT HOW THE BROWN
ACT. THE UPON THIS IN THE
CONSEQUENCES OF IT. MY CONCERN
IS THAT. WE COULD BE OPENING UP
A PANDORA'S BOX WITHOUT ANY
REAL- SOLUTIONS. AT OUR
DISPOSAL SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY YOU KNOW JUST
THROW THIS OUT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. WOULD THIS NOT
BE A SITUATION THAT. MORE CAN
BE DONE TO SEE IF WHETHER THEY
BE- MORE SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONS
TO THE LEGISLATION AS WELL AS A
BETTER ON THE SET OF
DISCUSSIONS THROUGH BOTH
HOUSES. TO BRING EVERYONE EXIT
SIDE THIS HAS THE THIS HAS THE
KERNEL OF A SIGNIFICANT
BROWNBACK REFORM ACT. MAYBE
MAKE THIS A TWO YEAR BILL. IS
WHAT I'M ULTIMATELY GOING TO
THROW OUT THERE BECAUSE IF WE
CAN ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE FINAL.
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE OF THIS
HOUSE THIS IS GOING TO A FLOOR
VOTE IF IT PASSES TODAY AND
IT'S MOVING FORWARD. I MEAN SO
THIS IS I DON'T THINK THE RIGHT
AND THE MISSILE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE FOR US TO BE THROWING OUT
TRULY SUBSTANTIVE. ABSENCES IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS
MERITORIOUS I WANT TO GIVE YOU
ABSOLUTE CREDIT. AS A FORMER
LOCAL OFFICIAL THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT ESPECIALLY
LEARNING LESSONS FROM THE
PANDEMIC. I THINK MORE TIME FOR
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT EVEN
BETTER. I'LL JUST SAY SENATOR-
THE I HAVE  LISTING THE
CONVERSATION TODAY SOMETIMES I
WISH I WAS ABLE TO START MY
BILL IN THIS COMMITTEE OR THIS
HOUSE- BUT I'D APPRECIATE ALL
YOU DO IS YES I'M FOR IT BUT
SINCE THIS IS HAS A SUNSET OF
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE IN
EFFECT YOU KNOW WE WILL BE BACK
HERE AGAIN NEXT YEAR. IF THE
BILL IS SIGNED- AND WE WILL
KEEP WORKING AT IT AND I DO
BELIEVE IT IS THE CEILING OF A
GREATER PRODUCT REFORM
HOPEFULLY IS I THINK TO MY
KNOWLEDGE ONE OF THE FEW BROWN
ACTIVE REFORM BILLS THAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW AND- WE'RE HOPING TO
KEEP ENGAGING ALL STAKEHOLDERS
LOCAL GOV AD ACTIVISTS ALL
WHOLE LIFE FOR DOWNSTATE.
ALREADY FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS HENRY STERN SENATOR
HENRY STERN MOVES THE BILL.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SOME OF THE
BILLS NO ASSEMBLY EMBER
LANGUAGE LIKE LOS RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL AND VERY APPRECIATE
THIS CONVERSATION THIS LATE
HOUR THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU COUNSEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THIS AB THREE
THREE NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEAVE WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
STERN THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
BUT FIRST TO BE RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI. AMBER I BOARD YES.
FOR JUST NOT VOTING. AT ALL.
COPYRIGHT NOT VOTING DID ASAL
DRESSEL I. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG PITTSBURGH I JONES
JONES HI LAYERED LAYER DIE
SKINNER. STERN STERN I WACO SKI
Y. CASKEY II. THAT'S EIGHT ZERO
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL NEXT
FILING NUMBER THIRTY SIX AJ R.
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY. MEMBER RAYOS
MAJORITY LEADER RAY THIS IS
ABOUT TO APPROACH THE PODIUM
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- MEMBERS WE ARE ON A
ROLL IT IS. IT'S ONLY NINE
FIFTY SIX AND WE'VE GOT JUST
FIVE BILLS LEFT SO. ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AN AJ ARE
AFTER ALL THESE A POLICY- BILLS
A. J. R. SIXTEEN CALLS ON THE
U. S. CONGRESS AND BIDEN
HARRISON MINISTRATION TO PASS
SENSIBLE IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR
THE ELEVEN MILLION IMMIGRANTS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AS A AS A BORDER STATE
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST IMMIGRANT POPULATION
THE US. APPROXIMATELY 27% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION IS
FOREIGN BORN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS HAVE AT LEAST
ONE IMMIGRANT PARENT AND ONE IN
EVERY TEN WORKERS IS
UNDOCUMENTED. THESE ARE OUR
FRIENDS OUR FAMILY ARE SO
CENTRAL WORKERS. IT'S BEEN OVER
THIRTY YEARS SINCE THE LAST
IMMIGRATION REFORM THE SYSTEM
IS OUTDATED BROKEN HAS NOT
ADEQUATELY MEET MAPPED PRESENT
DAY CHALLENGES. AN OUTDATED
SYSTEM CANNOT AND DOES NOT
PROPERLY SERVE THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA NOR OF THE U. S.
WELL REMEMBER THAT DURING THE
CALL WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC OUR
CENTRAL WORKFORCE CONSISTED OF
MANY IMMIGRANTS WHO RISK
CONTRACTING CODE NINETEEN
BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS.
BECAUSE OF THEIR STATUS
IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN THE
CONSTANT STRESS AND FEAR OF
DEPORTATION OF BEING SEPARATED
FROM THEIR FAMILY. THE HUMANE
THING TO DO IS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION IMMIGRANTS THE
HUMANE THING TO DO IS TO
PROVIDE IMMIGRANTS WITH A
PATHWAY TO LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENCY AND TO CITIZENSHIP.
THERE'S NO BETTER TIME TO PASS
IMMIGRATION REFORM THE NOW AND
THEY J. R. SIXTEEN CALLS ON
CONGRESS TO TAKE ACTION ON
COMMON SENSE IMMIGRATION REFORM.
EARLIER AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY ARE AVAILABLE BUT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A J. R.
SIXTEEN WORD JOSEPH THE LET
ALONE. ACHIEVE LONG AND IS
MEADOW THE LOPEZ WITH ONLY
THOSE US. ALL RIGHTY- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE- ARE THE
WITNESSES AVAILABLE. ON THE
PHONE. IT'S RATHER LATE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AGE ARE
SIXTEEN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF TO THE MODERATOR.
WE'LL WE'LL MOVE ON AND THEN IF
EITHER IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WE
WILL COME BACK- ABSOLUTELY
TAKES OTHER SUPPORT NO OTHER
WITNESSES AND IN THE GALLERY
NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WITNESSES OF SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO I
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP ON THE
pCONTINUE ALL RIGHT LISTER THE
OPPOSITION- SINGLE AND IN
OPPOSITION THE GALLERY NORTH
ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AJ ARE.
SIXTEEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR ELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT IS. ONE ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP ON THE
PHONE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL ALL RIGHT-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
CHAMBER SO THE RUSSELL SENATE
RESOLUTION ALL. IT THROUGH THE
ETHICALLY MOVES THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NONE OF LIKE TO CLOSE
A SIMILAR NUMBER S. R.
SPECTRALLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TEXAN CLOSE ALL RIGHT.
THE MAN TO COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS A DARE SIXTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAJORITY
LEADER ADVANCE. THE MOTION BY
SENATOR DID US SO THE MOTION IS
TO BE ADOPTED UMBERG BY NUMBER
I BURGESS. MERGES I HAVE A
LITTLE. HEAVIER I THAT I SO DID
I SO I'VE GONE SLAS GONZALEZ I
HEARD SOME BURG. PITTSBURGH I
JONES. JONES OCCASIONALLY HERE
LAYERED- LAYERED ICE SKINNER
CERN STERN I WACO SKI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I'VE THAT'S NINE ZERO
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL MOVE CALL THANK YOU
MAJORITY LEADER S. ALL NEXT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOSE THREE OF
US A. B. NINE EIGHT FOUR FIVE
AM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN A. B.
NINE EIGHT FOUR. SOME REMEMBER
REAVIS. DO YOU ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I DO YEAH ALL RIGHT
SO- THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
SENATORS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH EVALUATION AND FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THE
AMENDMENTS I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE OPPOSITION- THE ACLU FOR IN
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS BILL
WHILE WE WERE UNABLE TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THEIR CONCERNS I BELIEVE
WE WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR PRIVACY
CONCERNS. AND THAT ARE THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE AMENDMENTS AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS IN ADDITION THE
CONCERNS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- WERE BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION LATE LAST WEEK
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS I'M
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THEM TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AS THE
MAYOR BILL. MOVES THROUGH THE
PROCESS- EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR CONTAINS LANGUAGE TO
SPECIFY THAT THE PROGRAM IS
SUBJECT TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PROTECTION ACT AND
PROHIBITS THE SALE OF DATA BY
PARTICIPATING VENDORS IN THE
CASE OF DIGITAL PLATES
CONSUMERS HAVE A CHOICE OF
DEVICES THAT ARE EQUIPPED WITH
GPS OR NOT WITH THE NON GPS
PLATE CARRYING A LOWER PRICE
POINT. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
CARRIES A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
GPS MODEL BE VISUALLY
DISTINGUISHED FROM THE NON GPS
VERSION DIGITAL PLATES ARE NOT
MANDATORY AND SHOULD THE DEVICE
FAILED THE VENDOR IS OBLIGATED
TO REPLACE IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. SO NOW I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF. OF THESE PROGRAMS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN S. B. EIGHT OH SIX
AUTHORIZE THE DMV TO CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION ALTERNATIVES AND
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE RESULTS OF THIS PILOT
PROGRAM THE PILOT PROGRAM
ALLOWED SPECIALTY PLATE OWNERS.
TO RENEW THE REGISTRATION
ELECTRONICALLY THROUGH DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATES AND ALLOWED
INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS THE
REGISTRATION INFORMATION. FROM
THE LICENSE PLATES APP
ESTABLISHED BY THE PROVIDER.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM FOUND THAT
THESE ALTERNATIVE REGISTRATION.
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AT THE DMV
BY ALLOWING SPECIALTY PLATE
OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION VIA AN MOBILE APP
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO INTO
THE DMV. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
FOUR WILL IMPLEMENT THE
FINDINGS FOR THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION ALTERNATIVE PILOT
PROGRAM BY AUTHORIZING THE DMB
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP. TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION CARDS
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES AND
LICENSE PLATE WRAPS. TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I HAVE GYM LIGHTS
REPRESENTING REVIVER. MR LIGHTS
YOU'RE BUILDING YOUR NAME. YES
GOOD EVENING- GERMAN NUMBER
AGAIN MEMBERS- JIM WHITE'S
REPRESENTING BOTH WERE FIBER
ONE OF THE THREE DEVICES THAT
ARE- YOU WOULD EVALUATED DURING
THE PILOT PROGRAM- BY THE DMV
AS A FAMILY MEMBER REVERSE
DESCRIBES THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION PROVISIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDED TO THE BILL THROUGH
A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS ARE
ABSOLUTELY MANAGEABLE FOR US AS
A VENDOR THAT ALLOWS US TO
CARRY FORWARD WITH THE PROGRAM
AS THE DMV WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED. WHILE PROVIDING
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF PROTECTION
FOR CONSUMERS AND I JUST WANTED
TO INSURE THAT THE COMMITTEE
KNOWS- THIS IS- THE DIGITAL
LICENSE PLATE TECHNOLOGY WAS
INVENTED BY AND THE COMPANY WAS
FOUNDED BY- CALIFORNIA AFRICAN
AMERICAN ENTREPRENEURS SO WHEN
IT COMES TO SURVEILLANCE AND
TRACKING CONCERNS WE'RE
UNIQUELY SENSITIVE TO THAT AND
WE STAND WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALREADY THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SAYING NONE OF THE GALLERY NOT
A ROOM ONE TWELVE ON THE PHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF A.
B. NINE EIGHT FOUR WE. WOULD BE
REALLY GRATEFUL. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. NINE EIGHT
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE SIX NINE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JUSTIN
HIERARCHICAL COME OUT OF YOUR
SHIP GROUP AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIX NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR NUMBER THIS IS A LOT
BETTER LUCK WITH THE WORD ADMIN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF B. TWO AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER SIX NINE SIX IT'LL
BE JUST ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU
LINE SIX NINE SIX WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. THE SHARE
MARKET THE PART OF THE FILE
THANK YOU. AND THAT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE QUEUING UP ON THE PHONE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALREADY LISTED
IN THE OPPOSITION I SEE THERE
ARE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO A. B. NINE EIGHT
FOUR EDUARDO MARTINEZ AND BECCA
KRAMER MILDER- MISS KRAMER
MILDER WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
FIRST. SURE AFTER KRAMERMATTER
WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY FOUR UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. THERE'S A LADY WHO
PLAY AN ADDITIONAL VEHICLE
REGISTRATION CARD GREAT HI THIS
SEQUEL USING AN EQUITY CONCERNS
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED PRIOR TO
MAKING THE PROGRAM PERMANENT.
WELL WE APPRECIATE OTHERS
WILLINGNESS TO ACCEPT ANOTHER
SUBJECT AMENDMENT YEAH MY
MISTAKE AND DO NOT ADDRESS OUR.
CONCERNS WITH THE PROGRAM.
HELLO ALLOWS DIGITAL PLATE AND
THE RIGHT CARD YOU CAN TRY
DEVICES. ELECTRONIC DEVICES CAN
GATHER EXTENSIVE IMPLICATION
INFORMATION ON EIGHTY EIGHT
NINE THREE NINE EIGHT FOUR BUT
NOT PROHIBIT UPS TRACKING WHAT
THESE DEVICES NOR DOES IT
REQUIRE DRIVER CONSENT TO THIS
TRACKING. ONLY THAT VEHICLE
OWNERS CONSENT. FOR YOU COULD
BE TRACKED OR NOT AT WORK
PEOPLE ARE BEATING THE MATH AND
VIOLENT COULD BE TRACKED
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE. BUT HE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS BASED
ON THE TRACKING DEVICE IN THEIR
LICENSE PLATE OR CR
REGISTRATION. RECENT AMENDMENTS
YOU'RE NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED
WE THINK VERY. ADDITIONALLY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CAR
REGISTRATIONS COULD BE IN THE
FORM OF THE MOBILE APPS THERE'S
A POTENTIAL THAT THESE DIGITAL
TRACKER COULD OFTEN TRACK WHERE
A PERSON IS AT ALL TIMES EVEN
THOUGH I'M NOT DRIVING. AS WELL
AS THEIR CONTACT WHICH WEBSITES
THEY VISIT AND MORE. EIGHTY
EIGHT NINE EIGHT FOUR OPERATED.
VERY OFTEN REQUIRES THAT THE
LICENSE PLATE TO BE MORE
TRACTABLE. THAN THE CURRENT
MODEL LICENSE PLATE. I A BABY
L. P. R. READER. MADELEINE
PLATE DO NOT HAVE THAT RIGHT.
AND I SHOULD. LIFE GREAT.
FINALLY EIGHTY NINE EIGHT ON
ALLOWED FOR. WHO HAVE PROPERLY
THEIR CAR BECAUSE IF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE YEAH. POLITICS
WOULD BE A IT TICKET BUT IT'S
KNOW HOW PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
CALIFORNIANS IN FAVOR OF THE
PROBLEMATIC ACTUAL FOB AND
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE FULL TICKET
**** IF THE DRIVER IS TAKEN AT
THE VEHICLE OWNER REFUSES TO
FIX THE ISSUE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE REMAIN HELLO UNLIKE
THE MANDATES EIGHTY NINE EIGHT
BARKLEY YEAH THANK YOU RIGHT AT
THE WIRE- NEXT DOOR THE
MARTINEZ. I THANK YOU MR IN
MARCH WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR-
WE'RE HERE WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON A.
B. NINETY FOUR. I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPOSITION.
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING
EXPANDED IN THE CELL AND
SPECIFICALLY WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT THE DEVICES THAT ISSUE.
ALLOW FOR WORKERS TO BE TRACKED
OR MONITORED ON THEIR OWN TIME.
AWAY FROM WORK. TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY AND TRANSMIT THAT
INFORMATION TO THEIR EMPLOYERS
OR THIRD PARTY. ATTENTION
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE. WE'VE
MET WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS AND BELIEVE THERE'S A
SINCERE DESIRE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU AND THE AUTHORSHIP
THAT THEY'LL MOVE OUT OF
COMMITTEE. THANKS MUCH. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT OTHERS- IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE OF THE
GALLERY NONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
ON THE PHONE LINE MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT FOUR. AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF A BEAT NINE EIGHT
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE NINE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING THAT TERROR MEMBERS
DANIELLE KENDO CARTER ON BEHALF
OF THE PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
WE WOULD ALIGN OURS. ARE A
POSITION WITH THE ACLU AND
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU NEXT.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO THAT FLYING TO EIGHT
TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HM YOUR
I'M SORRY AT LINE TO REACH YOU
IF YOU CAN JUST REPEAT THAT
THANK YOU. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA WITH
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU NEXT. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO ENTER THE QUEUE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY
PAD. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER I SEES THAT HER
SPURS MIKE'S UP AND HE'S
STANDING. MUST BE IMPORTANT IN
HER SPORT. INDEED IT IS MISTER
CHAIRMAN BECAUSE I WANT TO
ADDRESS THE POINTS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION IN THE
LATE OPPOSITION HERE BECAUSE
ICE WE SPENT HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF HOURS
GOING THROUGH THE DETAILS ON A.
B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND ALSO
WITH RESPECT TO PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR WHEN WAS THE CCPA
THE ONE C. P. R. A. PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR WHICH WAS APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS. WE SPENT
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS CONSULTING
LABOR LAWYERS. TO DEAL WITH THE
PRECISE ISSUE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED. THE DEFINITION IN
THE C. P. R. A. WHICH IS
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR WHICH
WILL SOON BE THE LAW OF THE
LAND. IS THAT YOUR GEO LOCATION
IS SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS DEFINING YOUR
GEO LOCATION IS ANYWHERE WITHIN
TWO OR FIFTY YARDS THEY CANNOT
PINPOINT YOU. THAT MEANS THAT
IF YOU ORGANIZING FROM A LABOUR
POINT OF VIEW AND SOMEONE WANTS
TO FOLLOW YOU IN TRACK YOU THEY
CAN'T. BE SUBJECT TO INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF AND PENALTIES IT MEANS
THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO A
CLINIC TO DEAL WITH THE HEALTH
CARE PROBLEM ORDER BOOK CLUB OF
YOUR PARTICULAR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION YOU CAN'T BE
TRACKED IT IS DEFINED AS YOUR
SENSITIVE PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THE UNDERLYING ISSUES EXPRESSED
BY EACH OF THOSE THAT
ARTICULATED THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS MATTER HAVE BEEN TAKEN
CARE IN OUR PART OF THE LAW. TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS MEASURE
EVER BECOMES LAW IT WILL ALWAYS
BE SUBJECT TO. TITLE TO I MEAN
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR WHICH
CAN'T BE AMENDED OUTSIDE OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AT
BRIGHTS AND PRIVACY RIGHTS AS
SET FORTH IN SECTION THREE OF
THE MEASURE. SO I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THOSE WHO. PUT THEIR LATE
OPPOSITION TO TAKE A DEEP DIVE.
INTO THE HOMEWORK THAT WE DID
IN PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
BECAUSE THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
RAISED- WHICH I RESPECT
TREMENDOUSLY. AND THINK THEY'RE
A 100% RIGHT. HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY DIRECTED TO AND ARE
NOT IMPACTED BY THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALREADY PROTECTED THAT IN TERMS
OF DEFINING. YOUR GEOLOCATION
SENSITIVE PERSONAL INFORMATION.
AND THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN USE
UNDER THE LAW IS IF IT'S
SPECIFICALLY APPROVED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO ALLOWS
THEMSELVES TO. TO PROVIDE THAT
IF THEY PROVIDE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT SUBSEQUENTLY. TO
REMOVE THEIR APPROVAL- AND
THERE'S A SPECIFIC PROCESS TO
DO SO WELL I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH THE SENSITIVITY IS
REFLECTED. I WOULD SUGGEST AND
I ONLY DO SO BECAUSE I'VE PUT
JUST AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME
IN. PROTECTING EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT AND SO I
DON'T THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE
THE RACE THIS LATE TIME AT ALL
IMPACT THIS LEGISLATION ANYWAY.
I OUR LAST YEAR. THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS IS
THAT YES SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MR- VERY IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION APPRECIATE THAT
FROM- FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG I
JUST WANTED TO SEE IF I GET THE
AUTHOR JUST TO COMMENT ON SOME
OF THOSE. INTERIM CONCERNS
BEFORE IT IS VERY IN THAT IN
THAT INTERIM PERIOD BETWEEN THE
WIN WIN CCPA KICKS IN- THE
ANALYSIS SAYS THAT- THE
EXEMPTION EXPIRES AS OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'VE GOT A- YEAR
AND A HALF OR MAYBE A YEAR.
PERIOD WHERE THE TRACKING WOULD
BE ALLOWED- AND THEN WHEN THOSE
IN IN THOSE PROVISIONS WOULD
KICK IN. THEN IN JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO. I JUST
WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN GET SOME
JUST A RESPONSE TO I GUESS THE
LABOR FEDERATION'S CONCERNS ON
THAT IN TERMS THAT THAT ONE
YEAR PERIOD IF THERE'S SOME WAY
TO REMEDY THAT. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON LANGUAGE-
WITH LABOR FED AND OTHERS- TO
ADDRESS THAT. RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW LIKE I SAID IT WAS A LATE
OPPOSITION BUT I HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY. WITH
THEM- AND WE AGREED TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOGETHER ON THEIR
CONCERNS. THANK YOU BUT THERE
STANDING UP WE SUPPORT IN THE-
SORRY- CENTER HERZBERG MOVES
THE BILL I'M SORRY SENATOR
ALSO. OF CLIMBING- IDEA. I
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERTISE THAT
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES HAS ON THESE ISSUES
AND- I HAVE ENORMOUS RESPECT
FOR. HIS EXPERTISE ON THIS. I
STILL THINK. THAT IT'S WORTH IT
TO RAISE THESE ISSUES. BECAUSE
THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON SO MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE- AND WE
NEVER KNOW WHEN. AND HOW. THIS
KIND OF INFORMATION CAN BE USED
WITH WORKING PEOPLE SO I'D
RATHER ERR ON THE SIDE OF BEING
MORE CONSERVATIVE. AND FILLING
IN THESE- THESE HOLES THAN NOT
AND WITH THAT I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR- AND
WHEN SHE COMMITS TO WORKING ON
THIS I'M SURE SHE WILL AND FOR
THAT REASON. AND UNDERSTANDING
HI ALL THIS IS THE CORE ISSUE.
FOR WORKING PEOPLE HOW
EMPLOYERS AND BUSINESSES DO USE
INFORMATION THAT THEY GET
OUTSIDE OF THE WORKPLACE- YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES AGAINST THEM BUT
WITH THAT AND THOSE ASSURANCES
FROM THE OFFICE AUTHOR I WILL
BE SUPPORTING. PARTY THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE. SEVEN MEMBER REVIEWS DO
YOU CARE TO ADD TO- CENTER
THERE ALSO AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S CLOSE I WANT TO
THANK BOTH THE SENATORS FOR
THEIR COMMENTS- AND EDITION OF
COURSE- THE SENATOR. FROM THE
SOUTH WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY-
ALL OF THEM- FOR THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK- ITO BASED
ON MY DISCUSSIONS- WITH THE
OPPOSITION THEY HAVE BROUGHT A
LOT OF CONCERNS AND I HAVE
ASSURED THEM. YOU KNOW THAT I
AM FOR PROTECTING WORKERS RIGHT
I AM NOT- I WOULD NEVER
INTRODUCE A BILL THAT WOULD
AFFECT WORKER PROTECTIONS. I
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS I
KNOW THAT THAT THAT'S TRUE I'VE
ACCEPTED SIX OUT OF THE SEVEN
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE REQUESTED
BY THE ACLU PRIOR- TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND MY HOUSE THE ONLY
AMENDMENT THAT I HAVE NOT
ACCEPTED IS TO BAN. THE
MANUFACTURE OF AN ELECTRONIC
PLATE WITH GPS TECHNOLOGY- YOU
KNOW THERE ARE MANY DEVICES-
FOR CARS THAT HAVE GPS
TECHNOLOGY WE PROBABLY ALL HAVE
GPS. IN OUR CARS WHEN I WAS AN
ENGINEER THAT'S WHAT I WORKED
ON I WORKED ON NAVIGATION
SYSTEMS I DESIGNED NAVIGATE
TION SYSTEM. FOR CARS AND SO I
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE USED
EFFECTIVELY. AND WHILE THERE
ARE MANY PRIVACY CONCERNS OF
THIS BILL DOES CONTAIN LANGUAGE
THAT SPECIFIES THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS SUBJECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT AND LIKE SENATOR HERTZBERG
MENTIONED- ALL HIS WORK ON THIS
THAT. IS WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN-
YOU KNOW THOUGHT OF IN TERMS OF
WORKER PROTECTIONS ARE JUST NOT
JUST WORKER BUT JUST ANYONE
THAT THAT IS USING ANY TYPE OF
TRACKING DEVICE. R. AND SO-
LIKE BUT I STILL HAVE COMMITTED
TO WORKING- WITH THE OPPOSITION
ON THIS- I FEEL IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SINCE IT IS. YOU KNOW
THEY ARE BRINGING LEGITIMATE
PRIVACY CONCERNS THAT I AGREE
WITH I WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THEY ARE PART OF THIS BILL OR
IT'S COVERED BY THE PRIVACY
ACT. AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND THE NEXT MONTH
WORKING ON TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ALL GOING TO WORK ON THIS
TOGETHER. I'M AND SO- AT TODAY
I'M REQUESTING YOUR I. VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU COUNSEL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS.
IT WAS- CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK
YOU. OKAY THIS. HER FACE FAMILY
MEMBER LOOSE LEAVE US WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG AMBERG I.
BURGESS. ZERO ZERO I DID ALSO
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HURTS BERG HURTS BURGER I
JONES JONES I LAYERED. CLEARED
I SKINNER STERN STERN I WACO
SKI. I Y. CASKEY NOT VOTING-
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
ALL RIGHT NEXT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERT RIVAS A. B. THREE SIX
ONE PHYLUM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT.
FOUR GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS FOR THIS BILL
AND THEIR ENGAGEMENT. AS WE ALL
KNOW LAST YEAR AT THE BEGINNING
OF- THIS COVER NINETY PANDEMIC-
IT WAS GOVERNOR NEWSOM WHO
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT.
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED PORTIONS
OF THE BROWN ACT REQUIRING IN
PERSON MEETINGS AND ALLOWING
MEMBERS OF A LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO ATTEND
MEETINGS REMOTELY AND IN THIS
LEGISLATION HERE THIS EVENING.
WHICH HAS A SUNSET DATE OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. PROPOSES TO ENACT- SOME
SIMILAR- SOME PROVISIONS
ALLOWING BROWN OUT ACT
EXEMPTIONS FOR SOME
TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS- YOU
HAVE A MINUTE ANY FUTURE UP- SO
PRO CLAIM STATE EMERGENCIES IN
WHICH CERTAIN OFFICIALS HAVE
DETERMINED THAT IN PERSON-
MEETINGS. WOULD PRESENT AN
IMMINENT RISK TO THE HEALTH OR
SAFETY OF ATTENDEES AND SO
ADDITIONALLY IN AN EFFORT TO
PRESERVE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT
THE PUBLIC CAN JOIN THESE
MEETINGS VIA PHONE OR VIDEO
CONFERENCE. UNDER THIS BILL
LOCAL AGENCIES WILL NOT HAVE TO
RELY ON AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THAT TO HOLD FULLY REMOTE
MEETINGS- IF THERE'S AN
UNEXPECTED EMERGENCY EVENT
EMERGENCIES THAT COULD MAKE IT
PERSON MEETINGS VERY DANGEROUS
OR NEAR IMPOSSIBLE- THIS
LEGISLATION HAS ENJOYED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN I VOTED IN AND- I
HEAR. THE CV TO- PROVIDE SOME
ROOM TEST- IF HE'S STILL WITH
US IS MARCUS- DID DEBT WYLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SEVEN
MEMBER- MARK IS THAT WHETHER IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. YES MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS MARK MARKET
THAT WEILER I'M LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
THE FDA THE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE. EIGHTY THREE SIXTY ONE
OF THE NARROWLY CRAFTED
COMMONSENSE MEASURE TO CODIFY
SELECT PORTIONS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
EXECUTIVE ORDERS CONCERNING THE
BROWN ACT IN THE EVENT OF
FUTURE EMERGENCIES WHICH WOULD.
SPECIFICALLY PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM GATHERING IN PERSON. BACK
IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
GRANTED TARGETED RELIEF TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES OBLIGATED TO
FOLLOW THE BROWN ACT
RECOGNIZING THAT A SELECT FEW
OF THE SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSED BY THE ACT. WOULD
UNDERMINE EFFORTS TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS SAFE. THREE SIXTY
ONE SIX TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO USE THE MODIFIED
BROWN ACTIVE SHOOTERS USED OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS. IN THE
EVENT OF A SIMILAR FUTURE
EMERGENCY THAT IS AND I CANNOT
STRESS THIS ENOUGH. AN
EMERGENCY WHICH WOULD PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM. GATHERING IN
PERSON SAFELY. EIGHTY THREE ONE
OF NOT ONLY ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
WHAT ABOUT SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR EMERGENCIES FOR EXAMPLE
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE.
FOR THE CITY OF PARADISE WAS
DESTROYED BY WILDFIRE AND
RENDERED UNSAFE TO MEET WITH
THEM. THE TERMS OF THREE SIXTY
ONE WHAT IF ALLOWED AGENCIES
WITHIN THE CITY LIKE THE
PARADISE YOUR NATION DISTRICT.
TO MEET REMOTELY IN ORDER T
ENSURE THE CONTINUED DELIVERY
AND RESTORATION OF ESSENTIAL
LOCAL SERVICES. IMPORTANTLY
THIS BILL INCLUDES NUMEROUS
SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT OF ACCESS. THIS
MODEST MEASURE WAS MADE ALL THE
MORE MODEST Y AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE. NOW THE
BILL'S TERMS ARE OPERABLE ONLY
IN THE INSTANCES WHERE THE
STATE HAS DECLARED AN EMERGENCY
AS PPOSED TO INCLUDING BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION. THE BILL AS
PREVIOUSLY REFERENCED ALSO HAS
A TWO YEAR SUNSET PROVISION
MANY OF THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
WILL BE SUBJECT TO REFLECTION
AND EXAMINATION IN THE VERY
NEAR TERM. THE EXTENT OF THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN EXPLICITLY
REFERENCED AND PROTECTED WITHIN
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS. AND
TECHNOLOGICAL DISRUPTIONS
ARISING BEFORE OR DURING A
MEETING WHICH PRECLUDE WOULD
PRECLUDE LOCAL AGENCIES FROM
TAKING ACTION WITHOUT HAVING
FIRST RESOLVE THE DESTRUCTION.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR A B. THREE SIXTY
ONE. I WILL REMAIN ON THE LINE
AWAKE AND ALERT AND LISTENING
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT MAY
ARISE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MR
DETWEILER. YOU ARE WAY AHEAD OF
US ALL RIGHT- OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NONE IN THE GALLERY
NOT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. BUT IF
YOU TWO OF THOSE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY ONE.
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
NUMBER SIX SIX FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEETING HER MEMBERS
THEIR BRIDGE ON THE HELP OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT TRUMP OF
COURSE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIX SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SURE
MEMBERS CONTENTIONS WITH THE
BODY OF A POLICY GROUP CALLING
IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY CARLSBAD BUT BUT TO BE
FOSTER CITY. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILL BE ABLE TO REACH OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
IN STOCKPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SEVEN ZERO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN ZERO ONE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR ROSS BARKLEY ON
BEHALF OF INTER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
THAT'S FOR. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR TURN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER AND ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SEVEN ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE FUTURE MEMBERS ANSWERING
ANSWERING ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
RAIL AUTHORITY OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS BACKLINKS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE FIVE ONE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHURCH MEMBERS JOHNNY
BEING ABLE THE BIG CALIFORNIA
CITIES AT THE COURT. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING KAREN FOR THE COMPANY
WITH THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE TWENTY FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- RICHARD BILL
GATES I'LL BE HAPPY TO ATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES ON
BOARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO BE JUST A MOMENT
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON
IN THE QUEUE. WE'RE JUST
PROVIDING THEM A LINE NUMBER
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN JUST
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
GET INTO THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
ON E. P. THREE SIX ONE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER SEVEN ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MAY BEEN PLAYED WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
MOST AMENDED JP THREE SIX ONE
THANK YOU. ALREADY THANK YOU
MORGAN TURNED OPPOSITE NO ONE
ELSE SECOND Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN OPPOSITION. ANDRES ROM
ALSO ARE YOU AVAILABLE FOR.
KATHLEEN BURKE THE ISLAND DEAN.
MR AHMOSE YES GO AHEAD THANK
YOU. GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ON
THE S. ROMMEL'S LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL WITH PUBLIC AND
BECAUSE- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO TWO EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY ONE UNLESS AMENDED. AS A
NONPROFIT LAW FIRM AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORKS
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO CHALLENGE THE SYSTEMIC
CAUSES OF POVERTY AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN PUBLIC
POLICY. PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREAS OF EDUCATION HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY AND
CLIMATE JUSTICE WE KNOW VERY
WELL THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
BROWN ACT IN GUARANTEEING THAT
THE VOICES OF IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ARE. HURTING THE LOCAL DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. THAT'S WHY WE
RECKON THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THAT THE BUSINESS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN CONTINUE.
IN AN OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
MANNER DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS IN THIS AREA.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL GOES TOO FAR IN EXEMPTING
LOCALGOVERNMENTS FROM EXISTING
PRODUCT REQUIREMENTS. WHICH MAY
RESULT IN COMMUNITY MEMBERS NOT
BEING ABLE TO FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN THE LOCAL DECISION MAKING
PROCESS FOR OPENING THE DOOR
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES USING
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. TO
AVOID OUR OBLIGATION TO BE
FULLY PRESENT AND LISTEN TO THE
VOICES OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IS
ESSENTIAL TO PUBLIC POLICY
MAKING. TO THAT AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ANY CHANGES TO
THE BROWN ARE YOU SURE ABOUT
ALL COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND IN
PARTICULAR THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES WITH WHOM WE WORK.
CAN CONVENIENTLY ACCESS AND
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
MEETINGS IN AN EQUITABLE
MANNER. AGAIN WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS EFFORTS IN THIS
AREA WE KNOW THIS BILL IS WELL
INTENTIONED BUT ARE CONCERNED
THAT IT MAY HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON EIGHTY THREE SIXTY ONE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ROBERTS PRISTINE. THE
MILITARY MEMBERS CAME WHEN DEAN
BUT DEFENDED ADVOCATE WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. AS EXPECTED
THE OFFICE OPENS ON THURS IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE ARE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE EACH WEEK
ONE LUCKY WOMAN. FATHER GOAL OF
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES.
NEED TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES DURING TIMES OF CRISIS
OR EMERGENCY ABSOLUTELY
LAUDABLE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST
CONDUCT THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS.
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT MANNER.
THE LEADING FUNDING FROM.
PUBLIC PROTECTION SHOULD BE
EXTREMELY RARE AND HIGHLY
CERTIFIED. THE PREDICATE FOR
THE LOSER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL JUST OVER
THE LAST FIFTEEN LAST. FALL BUT
IT REQUIRES THE STATE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY SUCH
AS THE ONE WE'VE BEEN UNDER
SINCE MARCH AND WILL CONTINUE
TO BE UNDER FOR SOMETIME IN A
RECOMMENDATION BY A LOCAL
OFFICIAL BUT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME KIND OF SOCIAL DIFFERENT
THINGS I'VE SEEN IN SECTION ONE
SUBDIVISION ONE WAY. EACH TERMS
ARE UNDEFINED UNDEFINED AND
QUITE VAGUE AND WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO INVOKE THE
EXCEPTION TO THE BROWN ACT.
WITH VERY LITTLE JUSTIFICATION.
ONE DIRECTION THE X. AXIS
EXCEPTION IS INVOKED THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COULD CONDUCT
BUSINESS WITHOUT BEING REQUIRED
TO DO SO IN PUBLIC WHICH IS ONE
OF THE KEY REQUIREMENTS OF
DEMOCRACY. UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTY
THREE FOR TWENTY TWO FAR RIGHT
SENDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
THE OBLIGATION THE BROWN ACT.
AGAIN TO FIND A LOCATION EACH
TELECONFERENCE OCCASION. IN
FROM THE REQUIREMENT THAT
TELECONFERENCE LOCATIONS BE
ACCEPTABLE TO THE PUBLIC. A
WELL INFORMED AND ENGAGED
COMMUNITY IS CRITICAL TO
BUILDING TRUST AND REBUILDING
BETTER AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BROWN ACT ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN ATTEND
MEETINGS IN PERSON I CAN
DIRECTLY ADDRESSED MEMBERS OF
GOVERNING BODY. WHAT THE
REMOVING THE ABILITY IS
CONTRARY TO THE BASIC TENANTS
OF A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
AND FOR THESE REASONS PLEASE
TELL YOUR CALIFORNIA ACCENT
IT'S A CODE EIGHTY THREE SIX
ONE. THE NUMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE OF THE
GALLERY SEEING NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON THE PHONE LINE OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE EP THREE
SIXTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN IT IS
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO JOIN THE
QUEUE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS A LIVIA SIDEMEN
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY I'M
CALLING WITH A CONSOLIDATED
LIST OF ME TOOS INCLUDING FIRST
AMENDMENT COALITION. ACT FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS CALIFORNIANS
AWARE PEOPLE BACK IN ORANGE
COUNTY HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA THE
COALITION TOGETHER WE WILL
INDIVISIBLE LOS GATOS AND MARK
MERION GROWTH THERE I'M
ACTUALLY JUST EIGHT INCHES MADE
PICKING AND I'VE HEARD A. LOT
MAN CONDITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BUT ISN'T. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO QUEUE
UP ON THE PHONE AT THIS TIME
FOR OPPOSITION ON AB THREE SIX
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP
ON THE PHONE PLEASE CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT- LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE CHAMBER I SEE N
MICROPHONES EXCEPT FOR SENATOR
STERN CENTER THERE ALSO IS IN
CENTER GONZALEZ IS MICROPHONE
SENATOR STERN. I SPOKE TO SOON
MISTER CHAIR- OKAY A BRIEF JUST
A BRIEF. COMMENT I GUESS NOT SO
MUCH FOR THE AUTHOR MAYBE MORE
FOR THE SPONSORS OF THE
SUPPORTERS I JUST. CAN'T HELP
BUT NOTE. THE SEEMING
DISCONNECT HERE WE JUST HEARD A
MEASURE TRY TO EXPAND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION REMOTELY THAT WAS
ROUNDLY OPPOSED BY EVERYONE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
THINKING OF OUR URBAN COUNTIES
AND- VARIOUS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TOURS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. SO I'M- I'M CURIOUS
FOR- AND MAYBE EXPERT- THE
SPONSORS- IF IT'S GOOD ENOUGH
FOR AN EMERGENCY WHY ISN'T IT.
WHY ARE WE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
EXTEND PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
UNDER THE SORT OF BROADER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE
OPPOSITION- IS ASKING FOR
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
RELUCTANCE TO HAVE THOSE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS OR-
AND- RESOLVE SOME OF THOSE
VAGARIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED HERE. I DON'T FOR THE
AUTHOR MAYBE TO. THE SPONSOR ON
THE LINE. I ALL RIGHT SURE THIS
DO YOU CARE TO TAKE THE
QUESTION SURE- YOU KNOW- I DO
HAVE A PATH TO THE SPONSOR ALL
RIGHT. IF YOU LIKE TO WEIGH ON
IT BE GREAT. THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OF ACTUALLY NOT AFFECTED BY
THREE THIRTY NINE. AND FOR THAT
REASON WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
NEUTRAL POSITION ON THAT BILL-
I WILL NOTE HOWEVER- THE POINTS
RAISED BY SENATOR CAFIERO
RELATING TO. REIMBURSEMENT AND
MANDATES THAT ARE CONTAINED
WITHIN THE WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF THE BROWN ACT. YOU CREATE
THOSE. NON REIMBURSABLE
MANDATES ON LOCAL AGENCIES- IT
DOES- MAKES SENSE GIVEN THAT IN
THE- POLICY COMMITTEE THAT IS
THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. FOR THREE
THIRTY NINE- IT HAD REMARKED
THAT THE- TELECONFERENCING THAT
WE'VE SEEN HAS NEVER BEEN
BEFORE REQUIRED OF LOCAL
AGENCIES OF ALWAYS BEEN
PERMISSIVE. AND MANY AGENCIES
STILL LACK THE EQUIPMENT STAFF
AND INTERNET ACCESS ANOTHER
TECHNICAL SUPPORT NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THAT TECHNO TELEPHONIC
AND INTERNET ACCESS TO THEIR
MEETINGS. TO INTERPRETIVE
REQUIREMENT ON TOP OF THAT
WOULD POSE A PARTICULARLY
COSTLY MANDATES ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. YES SENATOR STERN
IF I MAY UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL. HOW WOULD YOU
AVOID THAT WHAT YOU'RE CALLING
A COSTLY MANDATE. HE WOULD HE
WOULD NOT HAVE INTERPRETERS
THEN IN THESE EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCES OR WOULD NOT.
HAVE THOSE SORT OF
TELECONFERENCING SERVICES. OR
THAT FOR YOU WHAT IS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. A
TAKE ON THAT COST YOU JUST WANT
THE STATE TO REIMBURSE YOU FOR.
SO I WOULDN'T BE ABLE
NECESSARILY TO COMMENT ON WHAT
WE WOULD WANT AGAIN WERE NOT.
AFFECTED BY THAT BE A TERM OF
THREE THREE NINE BUT YES THE
MAJOR FACTOR OF A MAJOR FACTOR
OF THE OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITY IN OPPOSITION
THREE THREE NINE- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT DOES CENTER ON
BE. A MANDATORY PROVISIONS OF
THAT BILL VERSES THIS BILL
WHICH HIS PERMISSION- IN NATURE.
BUT WHAT I'M ASKING IS YOU
WOULD YOU WOULD DEPLOY
INTERPRETIVE SERVICES. IF THE
IF THOSE OPTIONS WERE EXERCISED
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION OR OTHER
ACCOMMODATIONS TO. IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IS THAT LAID
OUT OR IS THAT ALL PERMISSIVE
THAT'S ALL THE OPTION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UNDER THREE SIX ONE.
THREE ONE DOESN'T SPEAK TO
TRANSLATION SERVICES- AS FOR
THE TRANSLATION SERVICES AS
THEY EXIST AND FINALLY ALATORRE
ACT THAT MAY CREATE OBLIGATIONS
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- WHICH
OPERATE GENERALLY. WHICH IS.
INCLUDING THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
ACCORDING TO THE MERGER
PHYSICAL SAMPLES. SIR SIR ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- JUST ADJUSTED
A NOTE OF THAT WE'VE BEEN HERE
SO LONG THAT CENTER BOARD IS
ACTUALLY CROSS THE ISLAND ALIGN
HIMSELF WITH SENATOR SKINNER
THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF HOW LONG
WE'VE BEEN HERE AND HOW WE WARN
CENTER BOARD JUST DOWN. ALL
RIGHT- SIR THERE ALSO. IF I
COULD JUST AS THE- THE AUTHOR
TO RESPOND TO THOSE I I'M SURE
IT'S BEEN MIXED UP IN THE
ANSWERS BUT THE- OPPOSITION I
THINK THERE WERE FOUR. FOR
CONCERNS YEAH I'D BE HAPPY ON I
APPRECIATE THE LOVE ENGAGING
WE'VE HAD WITH OPPOSITION YOU
KNOW WE'VE- THE GAUGE OF THEM
SINCE THE TIME WE INTRODUCE THE
BILL WHEN THEY RAISED. THEIR
CONCERNS AND WE'VE TAKEN.
NUMEROUS ROUNDS OF AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND
YOU KNOW AND I THINK SOME OF
THE REMAINING CONCERNS OR
SPECIFICALLY THE REQUEST TO
MANDY BOTH PHONE AND VIDEO
COMMENTS OPTION. IT'S ACTUALLY
A PROVISION- THAT WAS REMOVED
FROM THEIR OWN SPONSORED BILL
IN A. B. THREE THREE NINE AND
THE SEMI LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE BROADBAND
DISCREPANCIES THAT WE KNOW
EXIST THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND
THE IMPACT IT'S HAVING TO RULE
RESIDENCE- AND- THESE SMALLER-
THESE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
SO UNFORTUNATELY REQUIRING BOTH
PHONE AND THESE VIDEO
CONFERENCING FOR ALL MEETINGS
IS NOT. TECHNOLOGICALLY
FEASIBLE- FOR MANY OF THESE A
SMALLER AREAS AND SO YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. TRYING TO FORCE
THESE TOUGH REQUIREMENTS IN
ARBIL- IS- THE- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. YOU KNOW A VERY
CHALLENGING- KNOWING THAT IT'S
BEEN AMENDED OUT OF THEIR BILL
AND SO CERTAINLY JUST. YOU KNOW
AS WAS MENTIONED HI THIS IS A
BILL THAT HAS. BEEN YOU KNOW
NARROWLY TAILORED- IN THE SENSE
THAT. IN ORDER FOR. THIS TO BE
UTILIZED THERE HAS TO BE ONE A
PROCLAMATION OF A STATE
EMERGENCY. AND THEN- FURTHER A
LOCAL- A DETERMINATION BY A
MAJORITY VOTE. TWO TWO THAT
THAT THAT. SPECIFICALLY STATES
THE OTHER RESULT OF THIS
EMERGENCY. THAT A MEETING A
PERSON WILL PRESENT AN IMMINENT
RISK TO HEALTH OR SAFETY OF
ATTENDEES AND SO IT'S EXTREMELY
NARROW. IN SCOPE- TO REALLY
FOCUS ON- YOU KNOW A LOCAL
EMERGENCY AS WE EXPERIENCE AMID
THIS PANDEMIC. THANK YOU ON THE
SECOND HOUSE. YES THANK YOU- TO
THE AUTHOR AND MAY I HAVE THE
SAME QUESTIONS AS US SENATOR
ASAL- YOU KNOW MAYBE SOME
SOMETHING TO ADD THAT COULD SAY
THAT YOU KNOW BEST EFFORTS
COULD BE MADE IF SOMEONE DOES
HAVE GOOD BROADBAND BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW THE
CONCEPT OF NOT HAVING THAT
ACCESS. FOR PHONE AND VIDEO BUT
IF YOU DO HAVE THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE THAT AVAILABLE TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE PUBLIC- SO
JUST YOU KNOW SOMETHING ELSE TO
THINK ABOUT THE OTHER-
COMPONENT WHICH I DON'T KNOW
HAD BEEN ADDRESSED BUT IT WAS-
IN THE BILL HAD MENTIONED THAT
THIS PROVISION WILL ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE BODY TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY HAVING.
WITHOUT HAVING TO POST OUR HOME
ADDRESS WHICH I CAN UNDERSTAND.
OR AT THE ADDRESS OF WHATEVER
LOCATION FROM WHICH THEY ARE
PARTICIPATING SO. I CAN SEE
WHERE MAYBE THERE'S SOME
DISTRUST AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S
AN EMERGENCY SITUATION WHERE
THE PUBLIC MAY THINK YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SOMEWHERE ELSE THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW ARE NOT IN THE
JURISDICTION THAT USE. SHOULD
BE IN- THE WHILE VOTING
REQUIRED TO HAVE A QUORUM IN
THE JURISDICTION SO JUST
SOMETHING ELSE I'M THINKING
ABOUT BUT I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- YOU
KNOW OPPOSITION ON THIS AND-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS IS
A VERY NARROW SCOPE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YO.
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- SEEING NONE IS OUR
MOTION. SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES
THE BILL- WE CARE CLOSE. I'M
SORRY. HELLO AND THANK HER FOR
IT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BENCI
COUNSEL TO CALL THE ROLL YEAH
THIS IS AB THREE SIX ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT EVERY OF
US WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
COVEY IT'LL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS- BURKE HI AMBER I BURGESS
BURGESS I ECHO ZERO. HEAVY AT
ALL I DID ALSO. THE SO I'VE
GONE SILAS GONZALEZ I A HERTZ
BERG. HURTS BURGER I JONES
JONES I LAYERED. LAYERED I
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN. STERN
NOT VOTING WHITE HOUSE SKI. BUT
WHITE HOUSE SKI I OKAY SO YOU
HAVE TEN TO ZERO ALL MEMBERS
HAVING VOTED. ALL RIGHT THE
BILL IS OUT. IT'S THE FIRST
BILL IT'S GOTTEN OUT. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROD REGUS
ITEM NUMBER. FORTY EIGHTY THREE
SIX FOUR THANK YOU FOR STAYING
UP LATE WITH US. SO REMEMBER
RODRIGUEZ FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
AB THREE SIXTY FOUR THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT ALL OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND TEMPORARY VISA
HOLDERS. WHO COME TO CALIFORNIA
TO WORK RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE
PROTECTIONS FROM WELL
DOCUMENTED DECEITFUL PRACTICES
OF THIRD PARTY FOREIGN LABOR
RECRUITERS. AB THREE SIXTY FORT
WORTH CORRECT A DRAFTING ERROR
MADE AN SP FOUR SEVEN SEVEN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT CREATED
THE FIRST FRAMEWORK OF
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
TEMPORARY VISA HOLDERS BY
pAGRICULTURAL WORKERS. AMONG ALL
TYPES OF BASES THE H. TWO A.
PROGRAM VISA PROGRAM THE
TEMPORARY VISA CALORIE LINK TO
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE UNITED
STATES. NEWLY RELEASED DATA
FROM THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE SHOWS THAT
OUR CULTURE WORKERS WITH H. TWO
A. VISA REPORTED 70% MORE CASES
OF TRAFFICKING. AND
EXPLOITATION DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND AT LEAST ONE THIRD
OF THESE WORKERS ALSO REPORTED
BEING DENIED MEDICAL ATTENTION
AMONG OTHER USES WHAT THEY WERE
DEEMED ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES BY
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENTS.
THESE ARE JUST TOOK JUMP
EXAMPLES OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
OUR CURRENT SYSTEMS BOTH
FEDERALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA. DO
NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT THESE
WONDERFUL TEMPORARY MIGRANT
WORKERS ENTERING CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE SERVICES OF FOREIGN
LABOR RECRUITERS. THE BILLS
INCREASE PROTECTION WOULD JUST
DO THAT FOLLOWING THE LAST
COMMITTEE'S HEARING. OPPONENTS
SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE WILLING
TO WORK WITH US TO FIND A
COMPROMISE. MY OFFICE REACH OUT
BUT THEY REFUSED TO OFFER
LANGUAGE. I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY ONLINE HOPEFULLY
STILL THERE STEPHANIE RICHARD
REPRESENTING THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
WHO CAN SPEAK. TO YOUR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ALSO SHE'S
THEY'RE A VICTIM OF FOREIGN
LABOR RECRUITER PRACTICES. ON
THIS BUILD THIS WOULD ADDRESS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SOME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I SEE- TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANGELA.
GOINGS ON AND STEPHANIE RICHARD.
MISS SAIGON'S ON. GO AHEAD.
THERE YEAH GOOD EVENING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR IT SO LATE AND I'M SORRY
THAT IT ENDED HERE FRIDAY-
MEANING CENTER THE GOINGS ON I
AM NEIGHBOR TRAFFICKING
SURVIVOR ORIGIN FROM THE
PHILIPPINES- I DON'T KNOW IF E.
R. ANY OF YOU HEARD ME SPEAK ON
OUR S. BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN
NATIONAL DOESN'T FOURTEEN I
WANTED WHEN I WENT IN FRONT OF
YOU LEFT. BEHIND BY- EVERY
MEMBER. I REMEMBER HOW EXCITED
I WANT THEY THOUGHT HE WOULD.
HAVE REALLY HELPED ME AND WOULD
PROTECT. ARE THERE ANY DIDN'T
WORKERS LIKE ME I WAS
DEVASTATED WHEN I HEARD THAT.
THE DEAL WOULD ONLY COVER EACH
TO BE WORKERS BECAUSE OF
INTERESTING A. R. I DIDN'T COME
TO THE UNITED STATES ON H. TWO
B. VISAS. I CAME IN AND P. ONE
VISA AN IT WAS BECAUSE OF HOW
CONFUSING DEFEATS THE PROCESS
WAS THAT THEY ENDED UP TRAFFIC.
I NEED TO THE UNITED STATES AND
THE LENGTH THE STORE WITH THE
PROMISE OF A GOOD CHAT. IN THE
PHILIPPINES IS LIKE WINNING THE
LOTTERY. AND I GET MY VISA. I
WAS EXCITED AND I DIDN'T ASK
MANY QUESTIONS. I CAME TO
CALIFORNIA WITH A RECRUITER BUT
MORE THAN HALF THE PEOPLE. THE
E. ONE VISAS. AND WE BELIEVE.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO LEGALLY
WORK IN THE UNITED STATES. WHEN
I ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES
MY PASSPORT WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM
ME. AND I WASN'T GIVEN A
CONTRACT OR THE TERMS OF MY
EMPLOYMENT BEFORE I LEFT MY
HOME COUNTRY. I WAS TOLD A-
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR MY
TRANSPORTATION. THE UNITED
STATES AND IF HE'S- SUPPOSED TO
HAVE TO WAIT TEN YEARS. AT A
TIME AND HOPEFULLY EARLY
EDUCATED IN LOS ANGELES AT THE
OFFICE THAT. I WORKED. EIGHTEEN
HOURS A DAY WITH NO DAY OFF. I
HAD TO SLEEP ON THE FLOOR IN
THE HALLWAY EIGHT PEOPLE
SCRATCH. MY TRAFFICKER OVER
STRICKEN THAT. SHE TOLD ME THAT.
IS THIS POLICE TOLD ME THEY
COULD TAKE IT SLOWLY AND PUT US
IN JAIL. THIS WENT ON FOR TWO
YEARS FINALLY I WAS HELPED BY
THE F. B. I. ACTUALLY NEED WE
NOTICED. THAT I NEVER HAD A DAY
OFF I SPOKE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME DID THE FBI. AND
EVENTUALLY TESTIFIED AGAINST MY
TRAFFICKER IN THE CRIMINAL
COURT. I KNOW THAT I AM VERY
FEW LABOR TRAFFICKING CASES ARE
PROSECUTED. UNDER EIGHTY THREE
SIX FOUR HELP US GROW OUR
STELLAR. TRAFFICKERS AND
PROTECT TRAFFICKING. I AM NOW
WORKING WITH SCHOOLS AND BILL
AND CODING AND A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE GOING TO SET CASH AT
LEAST IN PART OF A NETWORK.
TYPE OF ABUSE THAT HAPPENED TO
ME AND MY COWORKERS HAPPENING
TO OTHER PEOPLE. BASED ON MY
OWN EXPERIENCE OF OTHER
SURVIVORS IN MY NETWORK. F. B.
FOR SEVEN SEVEN SHOULD COVER MY
TEMPORARY VISA CATEGORIES ADDED
THAT EACH TO THIRTY MISSED
CALLS ON FOR IF. YOU COULD
REFERENCE THE EXCLUDED. I KNOW
WHEN BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO WORK
FOR AN EMPLOYER AND DATE AND BE
TAKEN THANK YOU. JENNIFER FOR
THE THANK YOU VISITORS ON WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE ALLOWING EACH
WITNESS TESTIFY FOR TWO
MINUTES- IF YOU COULD WRAP IT
UP THANK YOU. YEAH I HOPE ARE
YOU WHAT ARE YOU IN EIGHTY
THREE SIX FOUR THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NEXT. STEPHANIE RICHARD.
STEPHANIE RICHARD I'M
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING THE
SPONSOR MAYBE THREE SIX FOUR
CASTLE THE LARGEST LEGAL AND
SOCIAL SERVICE PRIOR FOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS AND UNITED
STATES. BASED ON FORECAST
MODELS WRITERS APPEARANCE
WORKING A TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
YOU LEARN THAT ONE OF THE BEST
WAY TO PREVENT TRAFFICKING
BEFORE IT. WAS TO LIMIT THE
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES A THIRD
PARTY FOR LABOR CONTRACTORS AT
THE TIME OF WORKER RECRUITMENT.
TRAFFICKING IS THE DIFFICULT
CRIME TO VENT BUT THE DAY WE
CAN PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
WORKERS AT THE PORT SEVEN SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS AS CLARIFIED BY
EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR OR CRIME
SO PROTECTING ALL TEMPORARY
WORKERS COMING TO CALIFORNIA.
MUCH OF THE DEBATE AROUND
EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR FOCUSES
ON THE H. TWO A. AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ONLY ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND OF THE WORKERS- THE
BILL WAS DESIGNED FOR THAT SO
WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THE
OTHER VISA CATEGORIES THE BILL
COVERS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS. EVIDENCE
SHOWS. THAT HOUSTON SUFFERED BY
WORKERS RECRUITED BY FOREIGN
LABOR CONTRACTORS AT THE SCENE
YOU REGARDLESS OF THE CATEGORY
FOR THAT REASON THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED BY EIGHTY THREE SIX
FOUR. THE WHOLE WAY BEYOND
THOSE EXISTING IN CALIFORNIA OR
FEDERAL LAW THEY PROVIDE A
SORELY NEEDED ASSISTANCE
FRAMEWORK COVERING ALL THE
THREE CATEGORIES ONE THAT
MATCHES WELL BUT DOES NOT
OVERLAP WITH EXISTING
PROTECTIONS. THE BILL
PROVISIONS ARE ALSO GOOD FOR
BUSINESS EMPLOYERS WILL NOT
HAVE A VETTED LIST OF
LEGITIMATE RECRUITERS THAT THEY
CHOOSE NOT TO DIRECTLY RECRUIT
THEIR OWN TEMPORARY WORKERS.
AND UNFAIR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES THE BUSINESSES USING
RECRUITING UNDERPAY WORKERS
WILL BE ELIMINATED. THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENT THIS IS
DOUBLE LIFE CONVENIENTLY THANK
YOU MR. CHIDED WRAP IT UP YOU
KNOW MARK. SO WE URGE I'VE-
IRAN. USES WE SEE IN OUR WELL.
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- OTHERS SUPPORT. NO ONE
IN THE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE. OF
ON THE PHONE LINE. MODERATE IF
YOU QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. THREE SIX FOUR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE SIX
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
WE GO TO LINE SIX FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLINE STAPLETON ON THE
PUBLIC POLICY OFFICER. FOR THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
WOMEN- IN STRONG SUPPORT I ALSO
AM AN ELECTED DELEGATE. AT
FORTY SIX THERE'S A LOT OF
FINANCIAL AID- COUNT COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE. VOTED
EARLIER THIS EVENING ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS FOR
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIX EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ON HAVE A LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI INTO COURT
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVEN
ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS JEREMY KERR. BECAUSE
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVEN ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS KAELIN DEAN WERE
DISPLAYED ADVOCATE WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE SIX
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. SIX FOUR
ZERO. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
ACROSS THE LEVEL OF LEO ON
BEHALF OF CSA'S ANNUAL COUNTY I
WILL NOT EXECUTION. FOUR EIGHT
THREE THREE SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIX EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SIX ONE EACH. GOOD
EVENING HERE IN MEMBER MICHELLE
THOMAS SHOP REPRESENTING THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSORS AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE MY NUMBER SEVEN ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS THERESA
RODRIGUEZ AND I'M CALLING FROM
THE NORTH THE CALIFORNIA CINEMA
COUNTY- ON BEHALF OF VERITY- WE
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTING AB
THREE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SIX FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR FIVE.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS CLEAR LIP
SCHULZ FROM THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. AND IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL- WELL THAT WOULD
LIKE TO GET INTO THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT AN EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD.
I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
ON THE PHONE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT LET'S TRY THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MATTHEW ALLEN AND BRIAN LITTLE.
MISTER ALAN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR- THIS IS MATTHEW
ALLEN WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION I WILL KEEP MY
SYSTEM WHEN YOU BREATHE IN A
LATE HOUR. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY AT THREE FIFTY FOUR-
SIMPLY DUE TO THE FACT THAT WE
FIND IT A DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING LAW- BONIVA
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA IN.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAVE TO BE
REGISTERED UNDER THE- FARM
LABOR CONTRACTOR LOG THAT IS
THROUGH THE LABOR COPPER LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. AND
THIS- REGULATION WOULD BE
DUPLICATIVE TO THAT IT WOULD
SUBJECT- ARE POSTED TO
LICENSING RESTRICTIONS- THAT-
THE JUDGE WILL BE COVERING THE
SAME THING AND SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ALSO BRIAN
LITTLE. BEING A TEACHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M QUITE A
LITTLE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST ORGANIZATION OF FARMERS
AND RANCHERS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
BECAUSE ALL OPPOSED TO CLICK A
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ON FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS TO
PARTICIPATE WITH FEDERAL H. TWO
A. TEMPORARY CULTURAL WORKER
VISA PROGRAM AND FURNITURE
CULTURAL PULLEYS ON MANY
CALIFORNIA FARMS THE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS HAVE FOR DECADES
BEEN REQUIRED TO CLEAN AND
MAINTAIN. THE STATE FARM LABOR
CONTRACTORS LICENSE WHICH
REQUIRES FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
TO DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE AND
SATISFACTION BUT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WITH NUMEROUS
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING FOR THEIR
PERSONNEL PUT YOU AWAY TO BOND
FOR CONTRACTORS SEEKING INITIAL
LICENSES EXPECTED IT'S CRUCIAL
ACQUIREMENT CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROPEL SEES SEEK
RENEWAL OF THEIR LICENCES
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY FOUR IS AN
UNNECESSARY EXPANSION THE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT THE
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS ALREADY
LICENSED BONDED AND SUBJECT TO
EXTENSIVE EDUCATION ON THE
COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
MONITORING BY THE OFFICE. OF
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OTHERS
IN. ON THE GO NONE OF ONE TWO.
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO. AB
THREE SIX FOUR. HE WOULD LIKE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY THREE
SIX FOUR YOU MAY ENTER THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE MY NUMBER SIX
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN BREAST
MEDICAL DIO THEY HAVE THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF
CALIFORNIAN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COULD BE
BOILED ME HALFPENNY SAY
FORMERLY AN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND IF ANYONE
ELSE IS IN OPPOSITION OF E. B.
THREE SIX FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK
TO THE FLOOR IF THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE PHONE CALL RIGHT I SEE
SO THE BOARD JUST AT OUR
BORDERS. THANK YOU CHAIR BOY IT
HAS BEEN ONE HECK OF A DAY- THE
GROUP THAT THAT WOULD NINE HOUR
MARKER SO- FIVE RISE. IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ONLY BECAUSE AND I THINK
SOME FOLKS THAT ARE YOUR TICKET
LATER SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
THE- THE MOTIVATION BEHIND THIS
BILL SEEMS MERITORIOUS I MEAN
WHO WOULDN'T WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE REDUCE OR
IDEALLY ELIMINATE TRAFFICKING-
IN ORGANIZED CRIME THAT GOES
ALONG WITH- THAT ELICIT-
ENTERPRISE. THE ISSUE IS WHAT
EXACTLY IS NOT WORKING WITH THE
TWO OTHER EXISTING REGISTRATION
AND COMPLIANCE. OUR REGION IS
THAT WE HAVE BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE RIGHT NOW. IN ADDING THAT
THIRD. YOU'RE WELCOME CLIENTS-
I THINK WE WOULD BE BETTER
SERVED IF WE IMPROVED IF
NECESSARY. THE EXISTING STATE
REGISTRATION AND COMPLIANCE-
REGIME RATHER THAN CREATE A
THIRD ONE SO I DON'T DISAGREE
THAT THERE CAN BE IMPROVEMENTS
IN WAYS THAT WE CAN LOOK AFTER
THE WELFARE OF THOSE THAT ARE
WORKING IN THIS COUNTRY-
BECAUSE WE RELY ON THEM SO MUCH
APPRECIATE WHAT THEY CONTRIBUTE
TO. OUR INDUSTRY. BUT AT SOME
POINT I MEAN. WHEN YOU HAVE
THREE SEPARATE REGIMES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IN MANY
RESPECTS THE SAME THING- I
DON'T SEE. WHY IT COULD BE
TERRIBLY USEFUL. AND I THINK
WITH THAT I WOULD- RESPECTFULLY
LET THE AUTHOR KNOW THAT I
APPRECIATE WHAT HE'S DONE BUT-
WE TALK ABOUT THE REGULATORY.
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL ARE IN
POSITIONS ON ENTERPRISE WE ALSO
TALK ABOUT THE DROUGHT AND
DISEASE THE OVERALL CONDITIONS
WE'VE EXPERIENCED RECOVERED-
AND WHAT HAVOC THAT IS READ ON
OUR AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION WE
ARE HELD TO HIGHER STANDARDS IN
THE WORLD. IN THESE AREAS OF
REGULATION AND WELFARE AND
LABOR- I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
NECESSARILY LOOK UPON WHAT IS
OCCURRING AS SOMETHING THAT IS
INHERENTLY FAULTY ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE HAVE FEDERAL AND STATE.
REGISTRATION REGIMES THAT CAN
SATISFY THESE CONCERNS SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- CENTER MORICHES
ALL RIGHT. OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES RAISED- IS THERE A
MOTION. YES SIR WHY CAL SKI
MOVES THE BILL. THERE GOES ALL
RIGHT- SIMPLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
DO YOU CARE TO CLOSE YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MARTIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGING
COUNSEL TO CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR BY A
FAMILY MEMBER OVER THE WEEKEND
WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GIVE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. NUMBER NINE. A
FIVE GORGEOUS GORGEOUS NOBODY
IT'LL CARRY IT ALL I DID. THE
REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
HERZ BERG. FOR THIS BURGER I
ATE JONES JONES KNOWS LAYERED
LAYERED ICE SKINNER. SKINNER I
STERN STERN I WACO SKI. WHY
KELSEY I YOU HAVE A NINETY TWO
ALL SENATORS HAVING VOTED THE
BILL IS OUT ALL RIGHT NEXT.
SIMPLY MEMBER RUBIO I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW HAPPY WE ARE TO
SEE YOU YOU ARE CLEARLY OUR
FAVORITE MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
TUESDAY ALL RIGHT. A. B. FOUR
NINE NINE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
GOOD AFTERNOON OH WAIT GOOD
EVENING MISTER TURNED SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETY NINE LEGISLATION WHICH
WILL CREATE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR FAMILIES USING
REFERRAL AGENCIES FOR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXPENSIVE AND I DO MEAN
EXTENSIVE WORK ON THIS MEASURE.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES OR
RCF VI'S FOR THE ELDERLY ARE
NON MEDICAL FACILITIES THAT
SPECIALIZE IN HOUSING-
PERSONALIZED SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND ASSISTANCE IN THE
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING SUCH
AS GETTING DRESSED EATING
WALKING AND SO ON DURING COVERT
NINETEEN REFERRAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN A CRUCIAL PART OF
PLACEMENT DECISIONS FOR HELD UP
FOR ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT
AS THEY VISITED AS A VISITATION
IS EITHER NOT AN OPTION OR
INFREQUENT TO LIMIT THE
EXPOSURE OF. OF RESIDENTS AND
STAFF THIS LEGISLATION IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY WOULD ALLOW FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY AND AXIS OF
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS
SEEKING PLACEMENT AT THE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY OR A
REFERRAL AGENCY IT BEFORE
NINETY NINE SEEKS TO PROTECT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES BY
CODIFYING A NUMBER OF OUR
REGULATIONS DURING A REFERRAL
SOURCES. INTERACTION WITH THE
CLIENT AND INCREASED
REGULATIONS ON REFERRALS FROM
SOURCES EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE
ALSO OUTLINES CRITERIA OF ABUSE
AND OR POOR QUALITY OF-
TREATMENT- FOUND WITHIN AN R.
C. F. E. BY REFERRAL SOURCES
NEEDING TO BE REPORTED TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING AGENCY
THE BILL ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND ON THE- ON THE
LINE WITH TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF A. BEFORE NINETY NINE IS
MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF OF- ACT
EIGHT AND CLIFF BURKE ON.
BEHALF OF A PLACE FOR MOM THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT MISS MILLER YOU
AVAILABLE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD.
PERFECT PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH ON THE GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING AT EIGHT AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO GET HER CONTOUR- AT
THIS LEGISLATION ALONG WITH A
PICTURE MONITORING .COM. IT'S
STILL A LONG TIME COMING IT'S
BEEN OVER SEVEN YEARS THAT
LEGISLATION I CAN JUST MILK.
I'M BUT NOW FINALLY BOTH THE
INDUSTRY AND THE CONSUMER ON
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COME
TOGETHER TO REACH A COMPROMISE
PACKAGE. AND HAVING SAID THAT
WITHOUT THIS LEGISLATION THERE
IS NOTHING ON THE BOOKS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS WHEN THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR A RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVED ONES.
WE REALLY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION IS RIGHT IT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN PARTICULARLY DURING
COLD IT WOULD BE ONLY MEMBERS
DID NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TWERK ABILITIES. STATE WORK
FORCE TO TAKE ADVICE FROM I'M
NOT FORCED HEATING THE TICKET
BY- I'M COMPLACENT AGENCIES
WHICH WORKS BUT I KNOW WITH THE
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT HAD TO
PLACE SOMEONE IN A FACILITY
IT'S NICE TO BE ABLE TO TELL
THE DEATH IF YOU LOOK AT
GETTING A DEAL. WANT TO SEE
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEIR LOVED.
ONE AND POTENTIALLY PROVIDE ALL
OF THOSE. ACTION ON IT
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDE INCREASED.
FOR THE RESIDENTS AND THEREFORE.
WHEN THEY ARE YOU CAN YOU.
CAROUSEL ON. AND PETER PEARL H.
AND A HOTEL WITH COULD BUY
INCREASE CREEK. FOR BECAUSE
APART SOURCES BE SUBJECT TO
MANDATORY LIABILITY INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS. ALONG WITH
OTHER ON. ETHICS REQUIREMENT
AND AGAIN IT SHOULD BE INDUSTRY
AND THE CONSUMERS COMING
TOGETHER TO REACH A COMPROMISE.
DEPUTIES READING. THE- JOB
YOU'RE EITHER ON THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU MISS
MILLER ALL RIGHT MISTER BERG
WAKE UP TIME YOU TESTIFIED. MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR WAKING
ME UP APPRECIATE IT IT'S- CLICK
BERGEN WITH GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATES HERE IN BEHALF OF A
CLIENTOUR CLIENT A PLACE FOR
MOM- WHICH IS PLEASED TO BE A
CO SPONSOR- WITH MONICA MILLER
CLIENT. OF EIGHTY FOUR NINE
NINE AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
EIGHTY FOUR NINE NINE CREATE A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION AS THEY FIND
THE RIGHT FACILITY FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS. A PLACE FOR MOM IS THE
LARGEST NATIONAL ONLINE SENIOR
LIVING REFERRAL AGENCY WITH
HUNDREDS OF HIGHLY TRAINED
EXPERIENCED AND COMPASSIONATE
SENIOR LIVING ADVISORS LOCATED
IN CITIES ACROSS NORTH AMERICA
INCLUDING CITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
A PLACE FOR MOM IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FAMILY MEMBERS THE
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
AND FINDING THE RIGHT THIS IS A
LIVING FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES. OFTEN AT A TIME OF CRISIS
BASED ON YOUR UNIQUE NEEDS AND
BUDGET. A PLACE FOR MOM IS PAID
BY THE SIZZLING DISABILITIES
CARE PROVIDERS IN THE NETWORK
SO THE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED O
FAMILIES AT NO CHARGE. EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY NINE IS THE RESULT
OF SIXTY YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSIONS CONTEMPLATING HOW
TO PRICE CONSUMER BENEFIT
ORIENTED NOTICE TO FAMILIES
WITHOUT COST TO THE STATE AND
WITHOUT UNDUE BURDEN TO THE
INDUSTRY WILL POSITIVELY
CHANGING THE PLAYING FIELD
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY. AFTER SIX
MONTHS OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR OUR SEAT
AT THE REFORM AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THE AMENDED
VERSION STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE
BETWEEN CONSUMER NOTICE AND
PROTECTIONS FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
FOR DISCLOSURES TO FAMILIES
WILL MAKE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AND PROVIDE BACKGROUND CHECKS
IN INSURANCE COVERAGE MINIMUMS
SPECIFICALLY BEFORE NINE NINE
WOULD ENACT THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT PROVIDING FAMILIES
THE FOLLOWING INFORMATION PRIOR
TO A REFERRAL. THE DESCRIPTION
OF THE REFERRAL AGENCY SERVICES
THE REFERRAL AGENCIES CONTACT
INFORMATION INCLUDING EMAIL
ADDRESS. MAILING ADDRESS AND
TELEPHONE NUMBER YOUR FOR ALL
AGES PRIVATE PA. EARLY PRIME
POLICY. THE STATEMENT THAT THE
REFERRAL AGENCY WILL BE PAID A
REFERRAL FEE BY THE ASSISTED
OF THE FAMILY MAY REQUEST A
REFERRAL AGENCY CEASE CONTACT
WITH THE FAMILY. INFORMATION ON
THE AVAILABILITY OF STATE
INSPECTION COMPLAINTS REGARDING
FACILITIES PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT. DURING A PANDEMIC IN
COVE IT. IN ADDITION THE BILL
PROVIDES FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES EMPLOYEES
HAVE DIRECT CONTACT WITH
SENIORS REQUIRES LIABILITY
INSURANCE COVERAGE LIMITS ANY
BACK CHANNEL REMUNERATION FOR
pALL YOUR- IN GAME PLEASE PLEASE
WRAP IT UP FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
BURKE ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT NONE OF THE GALLERY
NINE ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATORS
TO QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTY FOUR NINE NINE OUR
LAST BILL TO BE HEARD THIS
EVENING. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU I WOULD LIKE TO GET INTO
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ON E. B.
FOUR NINE NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR
ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THAT I'M SO SORRY WHAT
THAT MR BURKE. MY NAME IS.
REPRESENTING SIX BED.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED ORGANIZATION. WE WERE
INITIALLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNLESS AMENDED BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T THINK IT WENT FAR ENOUGH
PROJECTOR TEEN YEARS. THEY HAVE
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
THANK YOU. THE CARD THAT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER FIVE FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD FIVE FOUR FOUR.
HELLO THIS IS LINDA HONEST
REPRESENTING NATIONAL PLACEMENT
AND REFERRAL ALLIANCE THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL REFERRAL AGENCY WHICH IS
CONNECTED THANK ASSEMBLYWOMAN
RUBIO. AND CARING DOT COM AND A
PLACE FOR MOM AND EVERYONE WHO
WORKED SO HARD TO MAKE IT RIGHT
HERE IN BANGOR SPENDABLE BUILT
A SIMULATION COURT COURT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE SEVEN LEVIN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EENING PATRICK
CHAN AND- PRESENTING CO SPONSOR
CARING DOT COM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF COURSE THANK YOU.
NEXT AND IF YOU WISH TO JOIN
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT ON A. B.
FOUR NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE PHONE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT NEXT LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE JODY
SPIEGEL. IN OPPOSITION. DIRTY
SPIEGEL ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I
AM LAST BUT NOT LEAST ALL
RIGHTY THANK YOU FOR CARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I UNDERSTAND
THAT I'M THE ONLY WITNESS
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE AND I
KNOW IT'S LATE BUT I HOPE THAT
YOUR OWN TOLD ME IN A LOT WE DO
USE THE ENTIRE TIME SLOT
WRISTER PROPOSITION. HI MY
NAME'S JOE YOU SEE GOING ON THE
STOP ATTORNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN BUYER ACRONYM
CANNER. GENEROUSLY STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS WE'VE BEEN DEDICATED TO
HELPING CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
CARE CONSUMERS AND THAT'S WHY I
AM TESTIFYING TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT YOU HEAR THE VOICES AND
CONCERNS OF THESE CONSUMERS.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE AND IT STOPPED FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS WORKING
IMPROVING EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
NINE WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND AGREED TO BY THE
AUTHOR I BELIEVE THAT THE BILL
IS FINALLY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THANKS TO YOUR
EFFORTS. WE ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ADDING
PROTECTIONS AROUND CONSENT TO
PRIVACY WHICH PROTECTION SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FUNDAMENTAL TO ANY
BILL PURPORTING TO HELP
CONSUMERS HOWEVER WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS AND ARE STILL
EVALUATING. OUR POSITION
REGARDING THE BILL. WHERE I
DISCUSSED THE- I'D LIKE TO.
TOUCH ON THE- OF THIS BILL A
CONSUMER LAND. 849950% SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO REGULATE
PLACEMENT AGENCIES. THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD AND PASSED TO
WITH THE BUILT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH BUILDS ESTABLISH
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
SCHEMES AND NUMEROUS CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. WERE OPPOSED BY
PLACEMENT AGENCIES. UNLIKE THE
PREVIOUS BILLS APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
NINE- SPONSORED BY PLACEMENT
AGENCIES AND PROVIDES FOR NO-OVERSIGHT WHATSOEVER. AND WHILE
THAT DOES INCLUDE A HANDFUL OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE MAJORITY OF
SAFEGUARDS IN THE PREVIOUS
BILL. EIGHTY FOUR NINETY NINE
IS NOT A CONSENSUS BILL NOR A
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL. WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS RABBIT REMEDY
SOME KEY PROBLEMS DIRECT YOU
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT STILL NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED. FIRST EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY NINE OUT OF TEN
REQUIREMENT TO HOLD REFERAL
SORTERS SERVER EXCUSE RESOURCES
ACCOUNTABLE. THAT DOESN'T EXIST
IN CURRENT LAW. UNNECESSARY
DETRIMENTAL. SO SHORT HE CANNOT
CONSUMERS WITH FACILITIES AND
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ESCAPE
LIABILITY BY ARGUING THAT THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT DISABILITY BUT
UNLICENSED. ESPECIALLY WHEN
SUCH INFORMATION IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE WITH THE ONE MINUTE
INTERNET SEARCH. SECOND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY NINE AND TO BE BURDENS
CONSUMERS FOR EXAMPLE. THE BILL
AS AMENDED ALLOWS PLACEMENT
AGENCIES UP TO TEN DAYS TO
PLEASE CONTACT THE REFERRALS.
CONSUMERS NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
ABOUT PLACEMENT AGENCIES THAT
SET. UP A BARGAIN BY COLTON
PACKED UP AFTER REQUESTING THAT
SUCH CONTACTS AND- IT SHOULDN'T
TAKE ANAGENCY CAN DAZE CONFUSE
REFERRALS WHEN IT TAKES ONLY A
FEW HOURS TO INITIATE THEM.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE TYPE EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY NINE REQUIRES
CONCERTED. SEPARATELY REQUEST A
HARD COPY OF THE DISCLOSURES
THAT ARE SUCH A PIECE OF THE
BILL. OFF AND OLDER ADULTS ARE
VICTIMIZED BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE
AND. LACK OF DIGITAL
SOPHISTICATION CONSUMERS SHOULD
BE WITH WRITTEN. OF THE
REQUIRED DISCLOSURE TO THE OF
COURSE YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
REQUIRE THEM. ARE TRYING
CONCERNS BABY NINETY NINE. IN
PLACEMENT FROM WIDE. BY FAILING
TO PROVIDE FOR- AND CODIFYING
PENALTIES AND ILLUSORY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS CANTOR
PLEASE THAT CALIFORNIANS WOULD
BEST BE SERVED A PLACEMENT
AGENCIES WERE SUBJECT TO
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
SCHEMES. SUCH AS THOSE SET
FORTH IN THE PREVIOUS BILLS
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE. ANY
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS. GOOD TO
HAVE ROBUST PENALTY ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE AND THAT STUFF
FOR HEARING OUR CONCERNS AND
BEING TRUE CONSUMER CHAMPIONS
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR GREAT
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND CO
SPONSORS UNDER. TRACKING OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS. THANK YOU
SPIEGEL R. I. OTHERS IN OP.
SAYING NONE THE GALLERY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE ON THE PHONE LINE.
THOSE ARE NOT. WITNESSES IT UP
ON THE PHONE LINE NAME.
AFFILIATION PLEASE TELL ME IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP ON
THE PHONE AT THIS TIME FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR NINE
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
I HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP ON THE
PHONE ALL RIGHT JUST BRING IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I SEE
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS. IS GIVING
US A THUMBS UP DOES THAT MEAN
YOU'RE MOVING THE BILL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR EXPERT OKAY. SENATOR
STERN. VERY BRIEFLY I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THESE AMENDMENTS- WITH THIS
COMMITTEE HERE AT. SERIOUS
CONCERNS COMING INTO THIS BUT I
APPRECIATE THE WORK- GOING.
PHYSICIAN TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE OUTSTANDING ISSUES IN
TERMS OF THE TEN DAY. TIME
FRAME AS WELL AS- SOME KIND OF.
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM ALTHOUGH
I DO SEE THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAWS BEEN APPLIED BY THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES AND
AMENDMENTS SO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING A MEASURE TODAY BUT
I HOPE YOU'LL- KEEP WORKING AS
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OF CENTER WHITE HOUSE
SKI. MISTER CHAIR I WOULD. LIKE
TO GO ON RECORD YET. I'M NOT
QUITE THERE ON THIS BUILD YET I
SEE THE WORK I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR IN ALL THE ADVOCATES.
ARE THERE SOME THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY- I SHOULD THAT
KANTER'S RAISED TO SO- WISH
EVERYBODY GOOD LUCK. WE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OTHERS ANYONE
ELSE ALL RIGHT LET LASTLY
BEFORE WE TURN TO SELLING A
ROUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
NOT GONNA GO THROUGH ALL THE
AMENDMENTS. YOU WORK VERY HARD
COMMITTEE WORKED VERY HARD WITH
YOU- TO GET TO PLACES OF
COMPROMISE AND I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD
YOU CARE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS ALL RIGHT. BEN CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS A. B. FOUR NINE NINE.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
WITH A- MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE.
ON APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG.
BAMBERG BY BURGESS BURGESS I
GOT VIETTEL. VIETTEL I DID I
SAW. THAT I SAW I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ BYE HERTZBERG.
HERZBERG I JONES JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED I SKINNER.
SKINNER. I STERN STERN I HOUSE.
WHY BECAUSE YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT
TEN TO ALL MEN HAVING VOTED THE
IS OUT ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE
ONE WE'VE GOT A FULL COMPLEMENT
OF MEMBERS HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION YOUR
DILIGENCE YOU'RE ALL GREAT
PEOPLE THANKS OKAY NOW LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE TIME AND
ONE TIME ONLY I SEE SAID A
COUPLE YEARS GOT A QUESTION.
MISTER CHAIR I'VE BEEN ASKED
BY- ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON TO
REQUEST THAT HIS. BAIL A. B.
EIGHT EIGHT NINE- BEES ARE
CONSIDERED FOR RECONSIDERATION
TO BE MADE INTO A TWO YEAR
ABOUT. BUT ONCE YOU OPEN THE
ROOM. I SEE YEAH I WENT OVER
THE RIGHT OKAY. WHEN WE OPEN I
THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE TO
TAKE AVOTE AND THEN IF IT
FAILS TO PASS THEM WILL PROVIDE
RECONSIDERATION THAT'S FINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ROLE- OKAY. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. HERTZBERG
HURTS BURGER I JONES JONES I.
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN STERN I
THAT'S ELEVEN TO ZERO MEMBERS
VOTED INSTANT COUNTERS OUT. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. FOURTEEN OH FIVE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER WICKS. CHAIR
VOTING BY VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
FIRST TIME AROUND- BURGESS. NOT
VOTING HERTZBERG HERZBERG HI
JONES JONES NO. SKINNER SKINNER
I STERN. STERN I. THAT'S NINE
TWO ONE ALL MEMBERS HAVING
VOTED ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. K.
S. THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO S. J. R. SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD- AMBERG THANK
AMBERG HI. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
JONES JONES I. SKINNER SKINNER
I STERN STERN HI THAT'S TEN TO
ONE ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
BILLS OUT- THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED YEAH- THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
ELEVEN HUNDRED BY FAMILY MEMBER
I AGREE ARE CURRY. AT WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI BOARD YES.
GORGEOUS NOT VOTING JONES JONES
NO SKINNER SKINNER I STERN
STERN I THAT'S NINETY ONE ALL
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED THOSE OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. SIX NINE FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ITEM BLACK.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
PORGES. GORGEOUS HI SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN STERN I ELEVEN
TWO ZERO MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
THOSE OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY BAUER
KAHAN. WITH SORRY. THE CHAIR
VOTING HI BOARD YES. GORGEOUS
NOPE COLORADO ABIERTO HI IT
ALSO. THE REST SO I HURTS BERG
HERZBERG I LAYERED. LAYERED BY
SKINNER. SKINNER HI YOU HAVE.
EIGHT TWO THREE WITH ALL
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT BILL. IS FILE ITEM
SEVEN A. B. SEVEN ONE SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI GORGEOUS
GORGEOUS I CAN BE AT ALL
COPYRIGHT I A. SKINNER. SKINNER
I STERN STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI.
WHITE HOUSE SKI NOT VOTING THAT
TEND TO ZERO ALL MEMBERS HAVING
VOTED THOSE OUT. THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN TWO ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. SHARE
VOTING I GOT IT OKAY CARRY IT
OFF I DID ALSO. THE REST SO I.
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN. STERN
HI WAY CASKEY WHITE HOUSE SKIN
NOT VOTING THAT. EIGHT TWO TWO.
WITH ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
THOSE OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY B.
NINE ONE SEVEN THE PROPER
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED. I
WOULD THE CHAIR VOTING I AND- I
DID ALSO. NOT VOTING SKINNER
SKINNER I STERN STIR NOT VOTING
WAY CASKEY BY CASKEY NOT VOTING.
THAT'S EIGHT ZERO ALL MEMBERS
HAVING VOTED BILLS OUT. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN A. B. ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO. THE
CHAIR VOTING I BOARD YES MORE
JUST HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
JONES. JONES I. SKINNER SKINNER
I STERN STERN IOWA KATHY WHAT
KATHY I THAT'S ELEVEN TO ZERO
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED TO CLOSE
OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS- FOLLOWED
HIM NUMBER ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD THAT
SHARE VOTING I. GORGEOUS NOT
VOTING BOARDS NOT VOTING AT ALL.
GOT ME INTO NOT VOTING
HERTZBERG. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN- VOTING I'D.
BY A FAMILY MEMBER CHILD.
HERTZBERG HURTS BERG I SCANNER
SKINNER I. THAT'S EIGHT TO ONE
ALL MEMBERS VOTING BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TISSUE THIS IS A B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR AT THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D GORGEOUS. PORGES NO.
SKINNER. SKINNER ICE STERN.
STERN BY THAT'S NINE TWO TO ALL
MEMBERS VOTING THOSE OUT. THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB THREE EIGHT SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WITH THAT
SHARE VOTING. HI. SEVEN ZERO.
HAVE IT OR NOT VOTING DID ASAL.
THE REST SO HI GONZALEZ. ONE
SILAS NOT VOTING HERTZBERG. FOR
ITS BERG I LAYERED. LAYERED NO
SCANNER. SKINNER BY STERN STERN
NOT VOTING. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
THIS IS FORTY THREE ALL MEMBERS
HAVING VOTED. THE BILL FAILS
BILL FAILS RECONSIDERATION OF.
YES CENTER SKINNER MOST
RECONSIDERATION. OKADA JUNCTION
RECONSIDERATION GRANTED ALL
RIGHT. R. EIGHT THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEMS NUMBER. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES. AT THE
CHAIR VOTING I PORGES GORGEOUS
HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ NOT
VOTING HERTZBERG HERTZBERG BY
SKINNER. A LOT OF SKINNER I
STERN- STERN HI THAT IS TEN TO
ZERO ALL MEMBERS HAVING VOTED
THOSE OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NINETEEN AB FOUR SIX
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE CHAIR READING HI.
FORGES GORGEOUS HI DID I SELL
THE RUSSELL I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HI SKINNER SKINNER I STERN.
STERN I Y. CASKEY. HEY KATY I
ELEVEN TWO ZERO. ELEVEN TWO
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTING BILLS
OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS FOR ITEM
TWENTY MAYBE TEN TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI GORGEOUS.
WE'RE JUST NOT VOTING THE
RUSSELL RUSSELL I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT JONES. JONES
NOT VOTING. SKINNER SKINNER I
STERN STERN I A WACO SKI. WHY
CASKEY HI THAT'S NINE ZERO ALL
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED BILLS OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO A. B. EIGHT EIGHT
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON.
THE CHAIR ABSTAINING DURING THE
FIRST ROUND AMBER THAT BUILDING
NOT VOTING MEMBERS NOT VOTING
PORGES. GORGEOUS NO CAPITAL.
HAVE YET OR NOT VOTING DID I
SELL I'M SORRY THE REST WITH
THE NINE. I TAKE THAT BACK ONCE
I LIST. GONZALEZ HI HERZ BERG.
HERTZ FOR NOT VOTING JONES
JONES NO LAYERED. THEY'RE NOT
VOTING SKINNER SKINNER I STERN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON. A. B.
EIGHT EIGHT NINE THE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. STERN. STERN NOT VOTING.
YOU HAVE THREE DATES YOU ARE
AND EVERYONE HAS VOTED BILL
SALES CENTER TO COVER EURO
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION THAT
OBJECTION RECONSIDERATION
GRANTED. THE NEXT ITEM IS
EIGHTY SEVEN OH ONE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE BY-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOAD AND I'VE
GOTTEN GONZALEZ- AND THE CHAIR
VOTING I. PORGES BORDERS NO
ONES ARE LESS CONCERNED LESS HI
JONES JONES KNOW SKINNER.
SKINNER I THAT'S NINETY TWO ALL
MEMBERS HAVING VOTED THOSE OUT.
ARE THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY ONE OH FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN WITH
FED CHAIR VOTING ALL RIGHT
BURGESS. GORGEOUS NOW GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI JONES JON SNOW
SKINNER. SKINNER II THAT'S
NINETY TWO ALL MEMBERS HAVE
VOTED THOSE OUT. THE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN NINE FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I BORJAS. BRIDGES
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES.
JONES NO SCANNER. SKINNER HI.
THAT'S TEN TO ONE ALL MEMBERS
HAVE VOTED BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
ITEM FILE IN. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN. I'M BURKE
BY AMBERG FIVE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING. THAT'S
OKAY. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. OKAY
GONZALEZ NOT VOTING HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I'D JONES JONES ICE
SKINNER. THIS FILE ITEM. TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE.
SKINNER. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX WE HAVE
SEVEN TO ONE SO FAR AND THEN WE
HAVE YOUR VOTE AND SENATOR
STERN'S. I'M SORRY HI OKAY
SKINNER I STERN EASTERN HI.
THAT'S NINE TWO ONE ALL MEMBERS
HAVE VOTED BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
ITEM FOR ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY FAMILY
MEMBER- WHEN. AMBERG HI AMBERG
HI GORGEOUS NOT VOTING FOR JUST
NOT VOTING HERTZBERG HERZBERG
HI JONES. JONES NOT VOTING.
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN STERN
HI THAT'S NINE ZERO ALL MEMBERS
HAVE VOTED. NINE TWO ZERO ALL
MEMBERS HAVE VOTED. BOTTLES OUT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT AB THREE
TWO THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
BOARD YES. WE'RE JUST NOT
VOTING JONES JONES NO SKINNER.
SKINNER BY SO THAT'S NINE TWO
ONE ALL MEMBERS HAVE VOTED
THOSE OUT THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM. TWENTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA THE CHAIR VOTING I'D
PROBABLY IT'LL. W. DON'T NOT
VOTING JONES JON SNOW SKINNER
SKINNER HI. THAT'S EIGHT TO ALL
MEMBERS HAVE VOTED BILLS OUT
THE NEXT ITEM BY ITEM THIRTY AB
THREE THREE NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE- WITH THAT
SHARE VOTING HI. ABOARD THIS.
NOT. PREVIOUSLY YOU HAD NOT
VOTED. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB THREE THREE NINE BURGESS.
WE'RE JUST NOT VOTING COVEY
IT'LL COVER YET OR NOT VOTING
SKINNER. SKINNER I BUY THAT.
NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT THREE ONE
TWO. NINETY ZERO ALL MEMBERS
HAVE VOTED BILLS OUT NEXT ITEM
BY ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW CHAIR VOTING I HAVE YET-
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW. WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. OKAY AKEBIA
DON'T I DID ALSO THE REST SO I
HURTS BERG HURTS BERG I LAYERED.
WHERE'D I SKINNER. SKINNER I
STERN STERN I WAKE HOUSE SKI.
WHY CASKEY I. THAT'S NINETY
TWO. ALL MEMBERS HAVE VOTED
BILLS OUT. THE NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM THIRTY SIX AJ R. SIXTEEN
BY A FAMILY MEMBER AS WITH THAT
YOU'RE VOTING I JONES. JONES
NOT VOTING. SKINNER SKINNER I
SAT TEN TWO ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTED A RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
OKAY THE NEXT ITEM IS- FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB NINE EIGHT
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBERS LOSE
THREE OF US WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING II FOR JESS. WE'RE JUST
NOT VOTING SCANNER. HE SAYS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB.
EIGHT NINE EIGHT FOUR. SKINNER
I. WHITE HOUSE SKI.
DISCOMFORTING OKAY. THAT'S NINE
ZERO ALL MEMBERS HAVE VOTED OUT
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE- BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING THIS IS A. B. I'M SORRY
FIVE IN FORTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
TAKING CARE OF ADDING I
PROBABLY IT'LL- KAYNE HAIR.
HURTS BERG HURTS BURGER I A.
JONES JONES NOW. SKINNER
SKINNER I STERN STERN I.
SEVENTY EIGHT THAT'S EIGHT TO
ALL MEMBERS HAVE VOTED FOR THE
BILL IS OUT WE ARE ADJOURNED.
THE ONLY ELEVEN THIRTY FOUR PM.
DO YOU WANT.